Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
So
now
[Music]
Red
and red
and break room
[Music]
and break room.
Heat.
[Music]
Everything.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat.
Hey. Hey. Hey.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
[Music]
I hope you're ready for action because
today we're going into the rift. That's
right. I'm going to teach you how to
play Riftbound, the new collectible
trading card game inspired by the world
of League of Legends. We'll be talking
about the game with help from Proving
Grounds, a box set for two to four
players containing ready toplay decks
featuring some of our favorite League
champs. We've got Annie, Master Yi,
Garen, and Lux. This game was designed
to be played one-on-one and multiplayer
in Proving Grounds. These champs were
carefully balanced to be played against
and with one another in 1v on's, three
and four person free-for-alls, or 2v2s.
Additionally, it was designed with newer
players in mind, so anyone can jump
right into the game. And that makes it
the perfect subject for this learn to
play video. So, let's go.
The goal of Riftbound is to fight for
control of battlefields, iconic
locations from around the world of Rune
Terra. You'll do so with a deck of
units, spells, and gear cards. You'll
draw those cards to your hand and spend
resources, runes to play them. Once
they're on the board, you'll use those
cards to buy for control of
battlefields. That's called conquering.
And when you do it, you score a point.
You might conquer a battlefield by
moving a unit to an unoccupied one, or
you might send a unit to one that your
opponent holds. Then you'll battle for
control. If you manage to conquer a
battlefield and you still control that
battlefield at the start of your next
turn, that's called holding. And guess
what? That gets you a point, too. When
you get to eight points, you win. Like
all great games, there's more detail and
nuance when it comes to scoring and
winning, but we can worry about that
later. For now, let's just remember that
the goal is to conquer and hold
battlefields in order to score enough
points to win. Now, let's talk about the
cards, runes, and battlefields that will
define every game you play. When you
play Ripbound, you'll pick up a deck of
cards inspired by a champion from the
world of League of Legends. That deck is
going to be filled with a variety of
different cards, and you'll use that
deck to fight your friends for control
of battlefields, scoring points, and
hopefully be the first person to score
enough points to win the game. As a very
competitive person, that's my favorite
part. In this section, you'll learn
about units, the little fighters you'll
send to battlefields. Units are
essential to winning the game, so every
deck will have a diverse array of them.
We'll also learn about spells, which are
cards that are played once per splashy
effect. There's also gear, the cards
that live in your base and give you
interesting recurring benefits. Finally,
we'll talk about champion legend cards,
the very special cards that your decks
are built around that are always in
play. Speaking of, every deck starts
with a champion legend card that will
define the overall theme and strategies
for your deck. So, let's go over the
anatomy of a champion legend card.
First, let's look at Master Yi's
champion legend card, the Wuju
Bladesman. You can tell it's a legend
because it says it right there. In the
top left, you can see Master Yi's
domains, calm and body, represented by
green and orange. These represent the
colors of cards that you'll find in his
deck. And in the lower third, you'll
find his ability. This is a defining
part of the Champion Legend. Let's go
into greater detail using Garen's
Champion Legend card. Champion Legends
and Proven Grounds have two domains
associated with them and each has a
different color. Garren's Champion
Legend card is the might of Damasia. In
the top left, you can see his two
domains, orange and yellow. Each domain
has a theme that inspires the cards of
its color. Garin's domains represent
body and order. Cards in the orange
domain, body, are all about strength,
agility, and the force required to take
what is rightfully yours. While yellow
cards representing order are about
loyalty, community, and the dedication
to give yourself up for the good of the
group. Your champion legend card will
always be on your board, which means you
will always benefit from his ability.
Garren's ability reads, "When you
conquer, if you have four or more units
in that battlefield, draw two." You can
see how he benefits from playing
aggressively with lots of units on the
board. Let's look at Master Y again.
When a friendly unit defends alone, it
gets plus two might. might is a number
that represents how strong and durable a
unit is. It's both your attack and your
defense stat at the same time. When you
play Master Yi, your units will benefit
from his ability that adds might. Now,
let's look at Lux. When you play a spell
that costs five or more, draw one, a
very different ability, and right away
you can tell that Master Yi wants to
send strong solitary units to battle,
while Lux wants to play big spells. This
is true for each champion legend. They
all combine two domains which create
interesting synergies. And as a result,
Garin's deck will play very differently
than Lux's even if they have some of the
same cards. You can see how they
significantly influence your deck and
play experience. Next, we have units.
These are the little warriors you're
going to use to conquer and hold
battlefields, which is the way to score
points and win the game. Let's have a
look at Stalwart Porro to go over the
anatomy of a unit card. In the top left,
you can see the number two. That's the
amount of energy it costs to play. Some
cards will have a little symbol beneath
the energy cost, which means it also
costs power to play. We'll return to
energy and power later. In the top
right, by the little sword and shield is
another two. That's this card's might,
how strong and tough it is. Finally, in
the lower third, you can see that like
champion legend cards, units also have
abilities. Stalwart Porros is shield
plus one might while I'm a defender. If
this little guy is at a battlefield and
one of your opponents attacks him, he'll
have plus one might for that combat.
Units enter your base exhausted. And so
when I play a unit, I can't use it till
the start of my next turn when it
readies. If I move a unit or use its
ability, it will exhaust again and I'll
have to wait another turn. I'll do a
deep dive on these concepts like
exhausting, energy, and might a little
bit later. Until then, let's take a look
at a different type of unit. So, you
already know each deck has a champion
legend associated with it that starts on
the board when you begin a game. But
there's also another card that starts on
the table as well, and that's your
chosen champion card. These cards are
also units, just a special type. So,
their energy and power cost, their
might, and their abilities will all be
arranged on the card in the same way as
other units. Let's take a look at Lux
Illuminated. You can see she costs six
energy, and because of this little blue
and white symbol, she also costs one
power. She's got five might and an
ability. When you play a spell that
costs five or more, give me plus three
might this turn. Remember Lux's champion
legend cards ability? It also benefits
when you play spells that cost five or
more. So you can see how these work well
together. When you play Lux's proving
grounds deck, her champion legend card
will start on the board and the chosen
champion card starts on the table next
to it. I'm saying board and table for a
reason. Your champion legend is on the
board, and that term typically means
that it's in play, which it is. However,
this chosen champion isn't in play yet.
Think of your chosen champion as an
extra card that you can use as soon as
you can pay for it, like any other card
in your starting hand. Whenever you can
pay her cost, you can play her and then
she's on the board. Every deck has a
different chosen champion card designed
to work with the strengths of that deck.
There's another powerful card type
you'll find in your deck that isn't a
unit. I'm talking about spells. With
spells, you pay their cost and get an
immediate one-time effect. Then you put
that spell in your trash. You're done
with it. Let's have a look at Annie's
incinerate to go over the anatomy of a
spell. In the top left, we have the
energy cost two. Spells don't have
might, so we can forget about that. And
below we see the ability deal two to a
unit on a battlefield. You could use
this spell to damage an enemy unit on a
battlefield on your turn or use it in a
showdown. A showdown is a special time
when both players can play spells or
abilities, even if it's not their turn.
More on that later. For now, let's show
a spell in action. I'm playing Lux, and
Matt, where's Matt?
>> I'm playing Garen, my heart and sword
always for Damasia.
>> Okay. Uh, so let's say Matt played a
Vanguard attendant on his turn, which is
five might, and that's too much for my
units to do anything about.
>> Victory awaits. Not so fast because I
have a spell called blast of power which
lets me kill a unit on a battlefield.
Boom. I chose your vanguard attendant.
>> The mafia.
>> And that's spells. Finally, we have
gear. These are utility cards with
useful recurring benefits. Even though
they're not units, unlike spells, they
don't go away once you've used them.
They'll just sit in your base until you
need them again. Take a look at
Ravenborn Tone. In the top left is its
energy cost three. Like spells, gear
cards don't have might. And like spells,
the most important thing to look at is
the ability. Ravenborn toms is exhaust.
The next spell you play deals one bonus
damage. Unlike units, gear cards don't
enter your base exhausted. So, I could
use this immediately to deal some
damage. Now, here's a fun fact about
Riftbound. Did you know that when you
play this game, you actually use two
decks? You'll shuffle up your units,
spells, and gear into your main deck. To
pay for their energy and power costs,
you're going to use cards from your rune
deck. The first thing to know is at the
start of your turn, you'll take the top
two runes of your rune deck and put them
onto the board. This is called
channeling. Anytime you're asked to
channel rune cards, take them from the
top of your rune deck and place them on
your board. You might remember me saying
there's two costs: energy and power.
Even though you pay both costs with
runes, they work a little differently.
Let's talk about energy first. Energy
costs are represented as a number, often
in a gray circle. This Vanguard
sergeant's energy cost is four. On my
board, I have six runes, so I'll turn
four of them sideways, exhausting them
to play a Vanguard sergeant. When a rune
is exhausted, you can't use it for its
energy until it becomes ready again. And
you turn it sideways to symbolize that
it's done for now. You can exhaust runes
to pay energy costs, even if its domain
or color doesn't match that of the cards
you're paying for. Vanguard sergeant is
yellow, but I can exhaust four blue
runes to pay for him. That's exhausting.
Now, let's talk about recycling. Let's
have a look at this Vanguard attendant.
Right below the energy cost of six,
there's a little symbol. That's this
guy's power cost. If there's one symbol,
that costs one power. Two symbols means
two power, and so on. To pay a power
cost, I have to take a rune of the same
color, in this case yellow, and recycle
it by placing it on the bottom of my
rune deck. Now, I only have five rune
cards, but Vanguard attendant is so
powerful, it's worth the hit to my pool
of rune cards to play them. If you see
this symbol, you can recycle a rune of
any color to pay its cost. And something
very important to remember, you can
recycle a rune that's exhausted. That
means when I exhausted six runes to pay
Vanguard attendants energy cost, I could
recycle one of these very same runes to
pay his power cost. Pretty neat, right?
Guess what? There's another type of card
you need that you won't find in either
your main deck or your rune deck. In
fact, we've already seen it, and that's
your battlefield. You'll send your units
to fight for control of these exotic
loces in order to win the game. If
you're playing 1v one, each player
places a battlefield on the board. Each
battlefield is unique and adds some
dynamic variables to your game, meaning
no matchup will be the same. Take a look
at the battlefield that comes with
Annie's deck, Voidgate. It reads,
"Spells and abilities affecting units
here each deal one bonus damage. That
means if you have a card like Annie's
Incinerate, which deals two damage to a
unit on a battlefield, you can use it to
kill a unit with three might, like a
Crackshot Corsair. You never know what
battlefield your opponent will bring,
ensuring enough variability that you'll
always be on your toes. All of these
cards have card text that will do their
best to explain to you what the card
does, but we sometimes use a little
shortorthhand to tell you a lot of info
in a little space, and these are called
keywords. Let's take a look at the
chosen champion, Master Yi, honed. He's
got the keyword ganking. Most units can
only move from your base to a
battlefield, but then back to your base.
But this guy, he can move from one
battlefield to another because of that
ganking keyword. On this card, you can
see there's a little explanation of what
ganking means. But sometimes you might
see a card that has a keyword like
ganking with no explanation. If you
don't know what the keyword's meaning or
effect is, that's okay because you can
always peep the rule book or reference
card to double check.
Now that you know about champion
legends, chosen champions, spells, gear,
and runes, let's set up a game. When we
play Riftbound, the space our cards go
in is called the board. To help organize
your board, you'll play your cards onto
these playmats. Your champion legend
goes right here in the top right. Beside
it is your chosen champion card, and in
the middle of your board is your base,
where you place units and gear. Below
that is your rune deck and a space for
your runes. To the right of that is your
trash, and then a space for your main
deck. In between this board and your
opponent's board is where your
battlefields go. Let's dive deeper. I am
playing Lux, so I'll place her champion
legend, Lady of Luminosity, right here.
I'll put Lux illuminated, her chosen
champion, to the right of that. Your
deck might have multiple different
champions that could be your chosen
champion. And at the start of your game,
you can choose which one to play here.
Next is the base, where you can play
your units and gear. Strategy tip. You
don't have to be as ruthless as I am and
immediately send your units into battle
as soon as they're ready. You might want
to build up an army in your base over a
few turns before you go in to do some
conquering.
Below my champion legend card, I'll
place my main deck. And below it is my
trash. Your trash is where cards go when
you're done with them. When units are
killed, they go here. Or after you've
cast a spell, it goes here, too. And
over here, I'll place my rune deck. And
this space in between my rune deck and
my trash is where my channeled runes
will be. Across from me, Matt's Garen
board is ready to go. In one v one, each
player places a battlefield down in the
space between our bases.
Then we separately shuffle our main
decks and our rune decks.
This is what our boards look like before
battle begins. I did a Garen thing.
To start, choose who goes first. Matt
and I are going to shuffle up our
battlefields, and he's going to pick
randomly, but you can choose however you
like.
It me. All right. I played the Star Tip
Peak Battlefield, so that means I go
first. We each draw four cards from our
main deck. And if we want, we can
mulligan up to two of them. That means
if there's one or two cards I don't
like, I can recycle them to the bottom
of my deck and draw that many more.
After we've mulliganed, we're ready to
play. Let's recap a couple key terms
before we jump in. Ready. When a card is
upright, it's ready and that means you
can use it. Like this eager apprentice.
If it's in my base vertically like this,
that means it's ready. Exhaust. When you
use a card's ability or if you move a
unit to or from a battlefield, you often
exhaust it. That means it's turned to
the side. Usually, you can't use it
again that turn. Some cards and effects
will ready an exhausted card, meaning
you can use it again. Most units enter
your base exhausted.
Not so eager, are we? Move. That's what
it's called when a unit travels from
your base to a battlefield, from one
battlefield to another, or from a
battlefield back to your base. If my
eager apprentice is ready, I can exhaust
it to move it to an unoccupied
battlefield and conquer it.
Recycle. That's when you take a card and
put it at the bottom of that card's
deck. We've already done it with runes,
but we can do it with main deck cards,
too, like we did when mulligan. Card. I
bet you're like, "Wait, Becca, I know
what a card is." Well, in this context,
card refers to a card from your main
deck. For example, this rune for our
purposes, not a card. This battlefield,
not a card. This eager apprentice,
totally a card. Tokens. I haven't
mentioned these yet, but these are units
that get created during play rather than
coming from your deck. See this recruit?
He's a token. You don't need a physical
card to represent a token. And if you
run out of these token units, you can
use whatever you have that is handy to
represent them. beads, pennies, bottle
caps, what have you. Running out of the
recruit tokens that come with the game
does not mean you've hit your limit.
That's it. We're ready to play. You
ready, Matt?
>> Yes.
>> Always in character. Our board is set up
and we've drawn our cards. So, what
happens next? At the start of your turn,
you'll follow a series of steps. Awaken,
beginning, channel, draw, A, B, C, D.
Awakening means reading cards that
started your turn exhausted. Beginning
means activating any effects that happen
at the start of your turn, like scoring
points for holding battlefields.
Channeling means taking and playing rune
cards from your rune deck. And drawing
means taking a card from your main deck.
After you've done those steps, you're
free to use your cards in whatever order
you want. Playing units, spells, and
gear, moving units to battlefields,
taking part in combat and showdowns, and
more. Let me show you some examples.
First, a awaken. Because it's my first
turn, I don't have any cards to awaken,
readying them for this turn. But let me
show you an example of awakening.
Anyway, let's say this was the middle of
a game and this daring porro was here in
my base. At the start of my turn, I
would awaken it and return it to
vertical. That means it's ready to be
used. For now, I'll put it back in my
hand. Next up is B beginning. Check if
any cards have any effects that happen
at the start of your turn. Take a look
at Jinx's champion legend card, Loose
Cannon. Her card text reads, "At the
start of your beginning phase, draw one
if you have one or fewer cards in your
hand." Jinx isn't actually in Proving
Grounds, but we're sneaking her into
this video to give you the best
explanation of the mechanic.
During this phase, you also check to see
if you are holding any battlefields.
Using my friend the daring porro as an
example, let's say I begin my turn and
he was here on this star tipped peak.
That means I'm holding this battlefield
and I would score a point. But I'm not.
So this little guy is going back in my
hand for now. As we all know, after B
come see, which stands for channel. In
the channel phase of your turn, take two
runes from your rune deck and place them
on their section of your board.
Finally, D stands for draw. I draw a
card from my main deck. Oo, a stupify.
This spell will come in handy later. Now
that I'm done with the start of turn
steps, I'm ready for the action phase.
That's when I can play cards and use
card abilities in any order I choose.
Now I've got these two runes and this
Raven Bloom student in my hand. This
card costs two energy, so I'm going to
exhaust both of these runes and place
her in my base. Unless they say
otherwise, all units enter your base
exhausted. That means I won't be able to
use Raven Bloom Student until my next
turn. Looks like I'm out of runes and
can't take any more actions. So, that's
the end of my turn. The only thing left
to do is check for end of turn effects.
There aren't any on the board, so I'll
show you one. Take a look at Annie's
Champion Legend card, the Dark Child.
Her ability reads, "At the end of your
turn, ready two runes." If I were
playing Annie, I would ready my two
exhausted runes at the end of this turn.
All right, that's my turn. You're up,
Maddie.
>> Prepare to face Damasian justice. Okay,
this is my first turn. I have nothing to
awaken. I have no cards with start of
turn effects. I'm not holding any
battlefields, so I can jump straight
past the A and B steps and go right to
see channel. Because I'm going second on
my first turn, I get to channel three
runes. This only happens during my first
turn. Next turn and every turn after,
I'll only channel two runes. After
channeling, I'll draw a card. Perfect. A
first mate. This card costs three energy
and I have three runes. I'll exhaust
those and play this first mate exhausted
to my base with nothing else I want to
do. That's my turn.
>> All right. A time to awaken. My Raven
Bloom student is no longer exhausted. B.
Beginning. I had no beginning of turn
effects and I'm not holding any
battlefield, so I'm good there. C.
Channel. I'll channel two more runes. D.
Draw. I'll draw another card from my
main deck. Time for my action phase.
With three of my four runes, I'm going
to play this lecturing yortle exhausted
to my base. I draw a card. Since my
Raven Bloom student is ready, I'm going
to move her to this battlefield. Star
Tipped Peak. Moving exhausts a unit, so
I turn her sideways. Now, I've just
moved my Raven Bloom student to this
battlefield, and Matt has no units there
to stop me. So, I've successfully
conquered this battlefield. That means I
get a point.
Nice. Finally, I've got no end of turn
effects, so I end my turn.
>> First, I'll awaken my first mate and my
runes. I have nothing for the beginning
step, so I'll channel two runes this
turn and draw a card. Now, I know if I
end my turn and Becca's Raven Bloom
student is still on that battlefield,
she's going to score a point.
>> That's holding,
>> right? And I don't want that to happen.
But because my first mate is ready, I'm
going to move it to start to peak where
Becca's Raven Bloom student is.
>> How dare you? I will fight for as long
as I stand.
>> Okay, Matt's move is looking pretty
strong. His first mate has three might,
while my Raven Bloom student only has
two might. In combat, that means his
mate will kill my student while only
taking two damage from my student. All
damage is healed at the end of combat.
So, if I do nothing, he's going to
easily win.
>> That's what's going to happen, right?
>> Not so fast. Remember, last turn I drew
this Stupify card. It says I can play it
at any time, even during Matt's turn. I
have one rune left over for my turn, so
I'm going to exhaust it. And stupify
lets me give any unit minus one might
for a turn. Playing it also lets me draw
one, so I'll do that, too. Now, your
first mate has two might. Take a look at
my Raven Bloom student. Her ability
says, "When you play a spell, give me
plus one might this turn." That means
she has three might, which beats first
mates two. The tables have turned. Your
Raven Bloom student beats my first mate
and I lose this combat.
>> That's right. Also, no point for you. I
don't gain a point for defending this
battlefield, but I have denied Matt a
point when I kept him from conquering.
>> Well, that is a bummer. But there's
still a lot of game left. I'm going to
exhaust my five runes to play Dune Drake
at my base and then end my turn.
>> My two units awaken as do my runes. And
now that I'm beginning a turn with my
Raven Bloom student at a battlefield,
that's a great example of holding. So I
score another point. Also, Star Tipped
Peak has a hold effect. When you hold
here, you may channel one rune
exhausted. So I do that as well as
channeling two more runes for the turn
and drawing a card. And you know what?
I'm just going to end my turn there. To
demonstrate some other parts of the
game, let's jump forward in time a
little bit. Imagine a little time has
passed and a few more rounds have passed
and now our boards look like this. Let's
have a look at a more complicated
version of combat, including a showdown.
Remember when we played Stupify earlier?
That was a showdown. A showdown begins
whenever a player moves a unit to a
battlefield they don't control. A
showdown is the name for the sequence of
events that happens when players play
spells or abilities during combat. Most
cards are only played on your turn, but
many cards, especially spells, can be
played on your opponent's turn when they
move a unit to conquer an unoccupied
battlefield or when they initiate combat
by moving a unit to a battlefield
controlled by opposing units. There's
two types of showdowns: open showdowns
and combat showdowns. Take a look at
this eager apprentice.
Let's say it's my turn and this unit is
readied. When I move it to an open
unoccupied battlefield, there won't be a
combat because there's no enemy units to
fight. But that doesn't mean I'm free
and clear. An open showdown happens when
a player moves a unit to an unoccupied
battlefield. Any player here can use
spells or abilities on this unit and
then a showdown begins.
>> Playing as Garen, I don't have any
spells that could stop her from moving
that unit. Let's look at Annie's
Incinerate as an example. If I were
playing Annie and cast two of these at
her eager apprentice, I could stop her
cold.
>> That's an open showdown. Let's look at a
combat showdown and show off the way
actions and reactions work. Remember
Matt's Dune Drake? It's now on the
Trifarian War Camp battlefield alongside
a faithful manufacturer and a token card
that Matt got by playing manufacturer
because of its ability. Dune Drake has
five might, faithful manufacturer has
two, and the token has one. That's a
total of eight might, meaning I have to
arrive with a unit or multiple units
with more than eight might to beat it.
or I need to find a way to reduce how
much might you have there if I want to
conquer that battlefield.
>> It gets worse. Trifarian War Camp's
ability adds one might to each unit who
is on or attacking this battlefield.
>> Wow. I definitely won't be able to bring
that much might to the battle, but that
means I need to reduce that number or
take some of your units out with spells.
The only card in my base right now is
Lux Illuminated. You might remember she
began the game as my chosen champion
right here on my board. Last turn, I
exhausted six runes and recycled another
to move her from her starting position,
the chosen champion zone, all the way
here to my base. Now that it's my turn
again, I've readied her, and I think
she's the perfect unit to conquer the
Trifarian War Camp. First, I'm going to
move Lux Illuminated to your Trifarian
War Camp. This starts a combat.
>> Right now, my units have a combined 11
might, while your Lux only has six,
counting the bonus she gets from the war
camp.
>> That's right. But now I'm going to play
Blast of Power and kill a unit on a
battlefield. And I choose your Dune
Drake.
>> Sorry, little guy. But wait, part of a
showdown is that players can use cards
with a reaction tag.
>> That's right. Lots of spells have the
action and reaction tag. This means you
can play them during showdowns, which
can happen on your opponent's turn.
Right now, it's my turn, but because
we're in a showdown, that means Matt can
play cards that say action or reaction
on them. And I'm going to do just that
by playing the card back to back, which
lets me add plus two might to two units.
Since doing that won't save my Dune
Drake, I'm going to give this card's
bonus to my faithful manufacturer and
the token at this battlefield. Thanks to
the Trifarian War Camp's ability, they
already had five might and now they have
nine. That's still more than enough to
defend from your Lux Illuminated.
>> Uhhuh. You forgot about Lux
Illuminated's ability. When you play a
spell that costs five energy or more,
give me plus three might this turn. And
blast of power does just that. That
means she has nine might this turn. And
I am going to exhaust one more rune in
order to play another stupify. This is a
reaction on a reaction. And it gives a
unit minus one might this turn to a
minimum of one might. And I'm going to
play it on your faithful manufacturer.
And then I'm going to draw one card. So
that leaves Lux with a total of nine
might and your units with a total of
eight.
>> Well, I don't have any cards in my hand
that have the reaction or action tag on
them. So I guess I lose this one.
>> That's going to be another point for me.
Feels good. If Matt had another card
with the action tag, he could have
played it, but it would mean I could
play any cards with the reaction tag.
And this is known as the chain. Either
player can use a spell or ability that
says action on it, and the other player
may play a card that says reaction on
it. The reactions card effects may occur
first, so they might disrupt the plans
of the person who played the action
card. Let's show an example of all this.
Remember Annie's incinerate? It deals
two damage to a unit on the battlefield.
Let's say Matt had a daring porro on the
battlefield and it was being targeted by
this spell. Right now, Daring Porro has
two might and incinerate deals two
damage. So, in theory, Daring Porro is
toast.
>> If I play backtoback right now, Daring
Porro would get plus two might and Becca
doesn't get to take back her move, so
she still has to play incinerate.
>> Yep, that's right. Both the spell with
the action tag, Incinerate, and the
spell with the reaction tag backtoback
go off. Daring Porro is still on the
field, and this interaction is now
resolved. Now, either Matt or I could
play a spell or ability with the action
tag, and the other one of us could reply
with a spell or ability with the
reaction tag.
>> And as you just saw, you can cast
reactions on other reactions. You're not
limited to reacting to actions.
>> Reactions can be used to react to any
spell or ability. They can't be used to
react to units or gear, but they can be
used to react to abilities of units or
gear, including when I'm played
abilities. This goes back and forth
until neither player has any abilities
or cards they can play or want to play
during that showdown.
>> Once you've resolved the effects of the
spells and abilities played during the
showdown, you resolve combat like we
just did. Fun fact about showdowns. In
multiplayer formats, like with three or
four players, all participants at the
table can potentially participate in a
showdown. We'll show you an example of
that a little bit later. Now, we keep
saying spells and abilities, so let's
show an example of an ability. Here's
another Lux Champion card. Lux
Crownguard. Her card reads, "Exhaust
reaction, add two energy, use only to
play spells." Even though she's not a
spell, her ability still has the
reaction tag. Let's say that during a
combat, this Lux crown guard was readied
and not in the combat already. And I
wanted to play Blast of Power, but I
didn't have enough energy. After Matt
played a card with the action tag, I
could exhaust this Lux Crown Guard as a
reaction, add two energy, then as an
action, I could play Blast of Power.
Lots of cards have abilities like that
that cause the card to exhaust. And as
we've mentioned before, some have
passive abilities, which means they're
always on. Remember Master Yi's Champion
Legend card? It reads, "While a friendly
unit defends alone, it gets plus two
might." That's considered a passive
ability. You don't have to exhaust
anything to take advantage of it. Simply
have a friendly unit defend a
battlefield alone and you get the
benefit. Now, just to make sure all your
combats go exactly as planned, let's
take a deeper look at might. Let's show
another example of combat at this Star
Tipp Peak battlefield. Matt controls it
with a petty officer and a daring porro.
The petty officer has five might while
the porro has two. I have two vanguard
sergeants in my base and they each have
four might. That's eight against seven,
so I'm going to attack. Even though
Becca is going to win this combat, I can
still make trouble for her. That's
because I get to decide where the damage
from my units is distributed. I'm going
to send four might at one Vanguard
sergeant.
>> Ouch. Off to the trash with you.
>> And I'm going to send the remaining
three at the other one.
>> Even though this Vanguard sergeant has
taken three damage, that doesn't reduce
his might. He still has four might for
the purposes of this combat. But if he
had taken one more damage, he'd be in
the trash tube. Once combat is resolved
and at the end of each turn, all damage
is healed. On Matt's next turn, if he
wants to defeat this sergeant, he's
gonna have to deal at least four damage
to him. And these go to your trash.
They trashy.
Because damage is healed at the end of a
turn or the end of combat, you can kill
a unit outside of combat by casting
multiple spells. If two of Annie's
incinerates are cast on a unit with four
might, send it to the trash. that unit
won't heal in between two casts of that
spell. Fun fact, even though we didn't
play any spells or abilities with the
action or reaction tag during this lost
combat, technically a showdown still
happened. It was just one where zero
cards were played. Every combat has a
showdown in it, whether it's one where
dozens of cards are played or zero
cards. Ending a game. Let's have a look
at how games end. In a one-on-one, you
play to eight points. During the game,
you score points by conquering and
holding battlefields. But to win the
game, the rules are a little bit
different. You can win the game by
scoring your eighth point, holding one
or more battlefields at the start of the
turn. But if you want to score your
winning point by conquering a
battlefield, then you need to have
already scored a point on the other
battlefield by either holding or
conquering it that same turn. Let's say
I need to score one point to win, and
Matt controls both battlefields. If I
conquer just one of those battlefields,
I won't score a point. Instead, I'll
draw a card for the first battlefield I
conquer. If I conquer the second one,
then I score a point and win the game.
Check out the board now. I'm one point
away from victory, but Matt controls
both battlefields. Luckily, he only has
a token on each battlefield. I have two
daring porros ready in my base. So,
first I'll conquer one battlefield,
killing that token. Since I need one
point to win, I don't score a point by
just conquering this one battlefield.
Instead, I draw a card. Now, with my
second daring porro, I'll attack this
second battlefield.
And I win.
>> Good game.
>> I'd love a second chance to take you on,
but I know we have some friends who want
to jump in.
>> Let's use this as an opportunity to talk
about the different ways we can all play
together. So far, we've mostly talked
about 1v one, but Riftbound supports a
lot more ways to play. We've got
threeperson free-for-alls, fourperson
free-for-alls, plus 2v2s for those of
you that want to play with a buddy on
your side. Let me break down the
differences for you. One v one. A 1v one
battle, like this one between Matt and
I, is called a duel. Remember, when you
duel, you can use two random
battlefields, and the second player
channels an additional rune on their
first turn, and the first person to
score eight points wins. Another type of
one v one game is a match. That's a best
of three game where you play three games
and the first person to win two of those
games is the winner. The only difference
is instead of using random battlefields,
each player chooses a battlefield for
each game. And in subsequent rounds, you
had to choose a different battlefield.
No repeats. Now, let's talk about
multiplayer. Ripbound was designed with
multiplayer in mind. In Proving Grounds,
that means you don't always play with
just one other person. This game is
built for two, three, or even four
players. Now, let's see what a table
looks like with more than two players.
The first multiplayer mode we're going
to talk about is called skirmish. That's
what we call a three-person
free-for-all. Across from me is Matt.
>> I bring justice.
>> And we're also joined by a third player,
Olivia. Oh, hello. I'm playing Annie.
And all I can say is try to keep up.
Were you there the whole time? Yep.
You can see three boards set up between
us and there are three battlefields. To
win a skirmish by conquering a
battlefield, you must have already held
or conquered the other two battlefields
that same turn. Otherwise, the rules are
the same except for one big one,
showdowns. Let's talk showdowns in
multiplayer. There's two types of
showdowns: open showdowns and combat
showdowns. An open showdown happens when
a player moves a unit to an unoccupied
battlefield. Any player here can use
spells or abilities on this unit and
then a showdown begins. Say it's my turn
and I want to move this daring porro to
a battlefield.
>> Well, I don't want you to score, so I'm
going to incinerate your daring porro.
>> I'm not happy about that, but it's well
within your rights. If I wanted to, I
could play a spell with the reaction
tag, but I don't think I want to, but
Matt could also.
>> I'm good, actually.
>> Okay. Well, then I guess my porro goes
to the trash. Fine. That's fine. Now,
let's talk about combat showdowns. In
multiplayer showdowns, all the players
can get in on the action. Take a look at
the board here. Matty controls this star
tipped peak battlefield, and it's got
three units on it. Crackshot Corsair, an
Noxian drummer, and a token. Matt is
also only one point away from victory,
and it's his turn next. We must stop
him.
>> Mhm.
>> In my base, I only have my old friend
Raven Bloom student readied. She has way
less might than I need to take that
battlefield from Matt.
>> Haha. Victory awaits.
>> Hold on. I'm still going to attack with
Raven Bloom student and initiate a
showdown. That's because in Showdowns,
anyone at the table can be invited to
play cards. Olivia isn't part of this
combat. It's between me and Matt. But
I'm going to invite Olivia to join since
she doesn't want Matt to win either. So,
Olivia,
can you help me out?
>> I'm happy to help. And I think I have
the perfect spell for this situation.
>> Oh, hell yeah.
>> Oh, hell yeah. Oh, hell yeah.
>> Oh, hell no.
>> For this showdown, since I'm playing
Annie, got a lot of destructive spells.
So, I will join the fun
and play a Firestorm. I'll deal three
damage to all enemy units at a
battlefield.
>> Okay, I don't like that because that
also hurts my Raven Bloom student, which
would be destroyed.
>> Correct. I don't want Matt to win, but I
also don't want you to conquer it and
take a point. Becca may have invited me
to join the showdown, but it's still up
to me who I help and what spells I play.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Got him.
>> Okay. Yeah, that's that's Thank you.
>> Mhm. No problem.
>> Something to keep in mind about
multiplayer combat. Even if everyone is
involved in the showdown, combat can
only ever involve units from two
players. Ripbound also thrives on four
players. Sephi is joining us to round
out the table.
>> Doubt is the greatest enemy. That's
Master Yo.
I'm playing Master Y.
>> Oh, okay. Well, if we want to play a
four-person free-for-all, that's called
war mode. In war, the first player skips
their first draw. The player going first
also removes their battlefield. Even
though we have four players, we only use
three battlefields. The player going
last channels an extra rune, and it
still just takes eight points to win.
But what we want right now is a 2v2
player game. You may be used to seeing
Matt as my opponent, but today we will
be playing for the same team as allies.
>> We are the Vanguard.
>> He always talks like this. Anyway,
together we need to score 11 points to
win. Just like in war mode, the first
player does not draw on their first turn
and they discard their battlefield. The
way it works is a player on the first
team takes their turn.
>> I'll go first. I will channel two runes,
but because I'm going first in a
four-player game, I won't draw. With
those two runes, I'll play this daring
porro exhausted into my base and then
end my turn.
>> Great. Now, a player on the other team
will go.
>> I will go second. I'll channel two
runes. I'll draw, which is great because
I picked up this traveling merchant. I
will play him into my base and pass the
turn. Great. Now it's back to us since
Matt went first. Now it's my turn. I
will channel two runes.
draw. And I will also play a daring
porro exhausted to my base. And now it's
E's turn.
>> Since I'm going last, I will channel
three runes like in all other formats.
And then I will draw a card. In future
turns, I will just channel two runes.
Since I have three runes, I will play
the wielder of water
and pass my turn.
>> Now it's back to us. Since Matt went
first, it begins this cycle again and
it's his turn. We'll continue in this
order until either side wins the game,
which will be us, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Our courage must never waver.
>> He's always like this.
>> Becca, even you aren't good enough to
overcome Matt as a teammate.
>> I know.
>> Mhm. You should.
>> Anyway, before we jump in, there are a
few more specifics that only apply to
2v2 games. Everyone can now participate
in showdowns. No invitation needed.
>> You and your ally cannot have units at
the same battlefield. The two-player per
battlefield rule still applies.
>> And the word friendly on cards applies
to you and your allies. Take a look at
Wu Bladesman. His card says, "While a
friendly unit spends alone, it gains
plus two might. If I were using Master
Yi's deck and I played this card,
Olivia's units would also benefit from
this ability."
>> Speaking of allies, your ally can also
play spells on your turn without having
to wait for a showdown to start.
>> Helpful. And that's Riftbound by way of
proving grounds. If you like this video
or have taken Proving Grounds for a spin
and you're hungry for more, this is just
the tip of the iceberg. Until then,
remember your turn starts with ABC D.
Either player in 1v one can play actions
and reactions during showdowns. Damage
to might is healed after combat. And you
can exhaust and recycle a rune on the
same turn. Say that every night before
you go to bed.
>> I will thrice. You can find Proving
Grounds and other Ripbound products at
your local game stores starting October
2025. If you want to expand your
experience beyond Proving Grounds, there
will be lots of champions launching with
Ripbound Set One Origins. Some classic
champs like Victor Leon or my favorite,
Jinx will be hitting shelves alongside
booster packs that let you tweak and
modify these decks to make them play
exactly the way you want.
>> Proving Grounds was specifically crafted
for trading card game beginners.
Combining these pre-made decks with
boosters will allow you to play even
more competitive games than those you
saw here today.
>> When you've got your decks and you're
ready to play, check out your local game
store for new friends, new opponents,
and plenty of weekly Riftbound events.
All right, I think they know everything
they need to know. Until then, see you
on the rift. Bye-bye, Toddles. You all
want to play again?
>> Yeah. Oh, yeah. Okay, let's
>> Damasian warriors.
>> What are they going to do?
>> Yeah. What are they going to do?
>> Fight with heart and courage.
>> Beautiful.
I got order in.
>> Oh no, but he can leave anytime.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
We will
be
[Music]
down
with your heart.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Hallelujah.
[Music]
Oh,
I
heal.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Happy
birthday.
[Music]
Oh,
what can you do?
[Music]
Wow. Wow. Heat. Heat.
It's finally here. Hello, Riffbounders
from across the world. Welcome to
Houston, Texas for the first ever
English regional qualifier for
Riftbound.
My name is Barrett Bryant and I'll be
your guide this weekend through the tour
of competitive Riftbound here in
Houston, Texas, where almost 1300
players will be competing for $25,000
worth of prizing, exclusive promos, and
of course, the coveted Metallic Best of
Legends.
So, lock in and get ready for the
falling stars, well disciplined units,
and the brightest dazzling auroras
you've ever seen here at the Riftbound
Regional Qualifier.
Over a thousand players have descended
upon Houston, Texas for the first
regional qualifier for the English
language out here in the West. I'm
Casanova joined by Frank Scarren for the
call on the first few rounds of today.
And Frank, what are you looking for in
this very first qualifier that we've
got?
>> Yeah, hey Cass. Uh, super excited to be
here. Uh, I mean, I'm mostly just
looking to see some great games of
Riftbound. kind of want to see how this
meta has been developing. You know,
there's a lot of a lot of cool decks out
there, a couple decks maybe stronger
than others, but I think people are
really starting to adapt and I'm I'm
just excited to see what people bring to
the table and what people have cooked
up.
>> Yeah, of course. Like when we looked at
the Chinese events, we saw a lot of
Kai'Sa and Yei domination, but even in
the first few kind of smaller events
that we've had in the West, we've had uh
some Annie in set resurgence to join
that Kai'Sa and Yi. And I'm wondering,
are there any other decks that you're on
the lookout that maybe, hey, we haven't
seen that big success yet, but might
have their breakout performance here in
Houston? Yeah. So, you know, I'm
actually a really big fan of uh Teemo. I
think that he's like, you know, a little
sleeper. I know we had like prismaticism
over in Vegas. Had a really good showing
with Teemo. And I think the deck just
has a ton of play to it. There are kind
of things you can do to adapt against
the meta. You know, Mundo is a really
great answer to Kai'Sa if you kind of
just reach a stage in the game where
he's big enough, they just can't deal
with it. And um yeah, I'm just really
excited to see the next evolution of
that deck and maybe see it make a deep
run again here. Yeah, I think the big
one that you know we mentioned how Annie
had that good run, but it's been that
big surge in the west of Annie being
this really really kind of dominant
force and it feels very interesting that
when we walk around the room there's a
lot of Kaiser as we expect but then you
would think oh a lot of Yi but really
what I've been seeing personally when
I'm walking around is more Annie than Yi
even which is quite surprising and also
way less Victor than we had seen you
know with the Chinese tournaments and
I'm wondering do you think Victor just
that conversion rate in China affected a
lot of players mindset tier or do you
think maybe uh just in general it's
slowly fallen out of popularity?
>> Yeah. No, that's uh really interesting.
I think Victor definitely kind of
started out a little more hype. You
know, people were maybe coming from
other games were like, "Oh, this is like
my typical control deck. I'm going to
play a lot of removal. I'm going to draw
a lot of cards." And people are sort of
starting to learn that Riftbound is
maybe a little more tempo driven than
other card games they might be used to.
And it's really interesting with Annie
because I do feel like Annie first
started to rise as like a Kai'Sa counter
and then people are sort of like wait
this deck's kind of just great. It's not
just a Kai'Sa answer. It's a deck that's
going to let me get on the table, score
some points and really put anyone in a
pinch.
>> Yeah, there's been these like new
sideboard options cuz previously I think
one of the the big gatekeepers of Annie
was Master Yi, but we've seen a lot more
of these sideboarded rebukes and even
mainboarded rebukes that have kind of
helped that match up quite a bit. And
I've talked to a lot of the Annie
players out on the floor and they don't
feel like they're unfavored into this
Master E deck that has been kind of that
gatekeeper. We had this meta where it
was like Kai'Sa gatekeep some decks, but
then the decks that maybe could sneak in
get gatekeep by Yei. And we just don't
have that here.
>> Yeah. I mean, at the end of the day,
like I think the real kind of like heart
and soul of the Annie deck is the buy
ride the wind combo. And at some point,
you're just going to have so many stats
that even Ye with, you know, the
defensive uh stats from the legend,
you're just going to go over the top of
them. And if they don't have the counter
for the ride, the wind, you're just
going to end the game in a way that they
really just can't handle. So I think
that's the the real strength is Annie
has that sort of explosive early game.
I'm going to cheese out some points and
then this really robust sort of two card
combination and you know they have so
much filtering that they're going to
find it against you eventually.
>> And and that's the really funny thing.
We we start to have this meta develop
and then I wonder if there's anybody on
that kind of like level three where now
hey Annie is so popular in the room.
Maybe I need to find a deck that's order
so that I've got you know the hidden
blade to kind of answer this buy ride
the win. And that's where the Victor
comes back around or maybe Darius shows
up or even the set that had found some
success maybe has a little bit more room
to play.
>> Yeah. No, I mean that's one thing that
I've really been impressed with by
players is like, you know, it's only one
set. It's not a ton of cards out right
now, but players have really been able
to kind of like adapt and just keep
taking that meta one step forward and
one step forward. And that's really
awesome to see. Um, but one thing I do
want to make sure we don't forget to
mention is like yes, people are trying
to be Kai'Sa, but Kai'Sa is still pretty
great. There's going to be a lot of
Kai'Sa out there. There will be a lot of
Kai'Sa. I'm actually I'm looking forward
to seeing how the different Kais have
decided to tech their deck. We saw a lot
of players leaning towards this triple
rain strategy, but I've also seen other
players go for zero main deck rain.
They'll still have some on the side, but
zero main deck raid versus three main
deck rain. And both of these players,
you know, both of these uh groups of
Kais are saying, "Yeah, I think this is
better for the mirror." Someone has to
be wrong, right?
>> Yeah. No, it's really interesting. I've
got like a lot of a lot of friends in
the community and like a lot of them are
on Kai'Sa and I walk around I talk to
them and like the first person will be
like time warp's broken you guys going
to ban it best card in the game it
crushes the kaismir and then I'll go to
the next person they'll be like time
warp's unplayable I don't know what all
these other Kais are doing and it's
going to be it's going to be interesting
to see the theologies crash well we will
see who is right as the day progresses
but reminder that these players are
playing for a prize pool of $25,000
with first place taking home that line
share that $6,000 as as well as the
champion prize card of this Misfortune
Buccaneer with that prestige treatment.
It looks beautiful. They're also going
to take home that playmat and you know
top eight still getting that foil that
that top eight card. It is so
prestigious to be able to grab one of
these.
>> Yeah, for sure. And the thing that I'm
really excited about is kind of the best
of metal legends that the people with
each legend uh who does the best with
each is going to get this really special
prize tailored just to them. And you
know, I think that's really cool cuz it
incentivizes people to maybe play some
of the less popular decks so they can go
after that really unique prize. Yeah,
everybody's kind of got their favorites.
And also, you know, a great place to
play your favorite regardless of the
stakes is at your Nexus Knights locally.
You should go and check out if you've
got a game store running Nexus Knights
every single week at
locator.ribbound.uvsgames.com/events
where you can jump in the action and
start playing some Riftbound with your
locals. And if you want to take things a
step further, you can see if you have
any summoner skirmishes around that can
get you a round one buy at a regional
qualifier just like this one. Go check
out uvsgames.com/ribbound-organize-play
in order to find out more about the
summoners skirmish. Frank, this is a
great way for players to jump in. They
can try and earn these round one buys.
You saw a lot of players out there
already with their round one buys happy
to be like, you know what, I don't need
to win seven rounds today. I only need
to win six.
>> Yeah, for sure, Cass. I mean, I think
it's just pretty great. You know, local
stores really are the lifeblood of any
trading card game. And, you know, that's
where you go. You find your community.
You start to figure out what type of
player you are and, you know, you can
really just like take slow steps up
until you're ready for the big stage.
Maybe you get that by and it convinces
you to come out and play in a great
event like this.
>> All right. Well, we talked about a lot
of different decks, but one that we
didn't mention was Leona. However,
luckily I got to catch up with Frodan
and talk to him a little bit about the
deck he decided to bring.
I'm here with Frodan at the Houston
Regional Qualifier. Dan, uh, can you go
ahead and introduce the audience uh,
yourself for anybody who maybe doesn't
know where they know you from?
>> Yeah, my name is Frodan. I am a TFT
content creator, streamer, and I used to
be a commentator. I actually used to
cast TFT main broadcast events with Cast
Nova once upon a time, but these days
I'm sort of a washed up dad gamer
playing some strategy games.
>> All right. Well, speaking of what uh
what deck have you decided to bring to
the uh regional qualifier and and why
did you decide on it?
>> I decided to bring Leona. I think Leona
has been one of my favorite champions in
League for a long time and I also find
her play pattern really fun. I also want
to go a little bit off meta. I think a
lot of people are going to be playing
Kai'Sa and Mastery Annie, those kinds of
decks. So, I felt like I want to go a
little bit against the grain. I'm a big
proponent of trying to beat the meta,
not necessarily just conform to it. So,
I'm going to try to roll the dice this
weekend with Leona.
>> Look, as a Leon enjoyer, I'm excited to
see that as well. But, uh, Dan, I also,
you know, we we talked about TFT, we
mentioned TFT. I got to ask, are there
any transferable skills from TFT coming
over into Riftbound?
>> Yeah, there's many transferable skills
from TFT to Riftbound. If you view it
both as strategy games where you have to
kind of play around variance and manage
risk versus reward, there's a ton of
overlap. And perhaps the most important
skill for TFT and card games is reading.
That is something that most TFT players
struggle with, but from time to time I
like to finish my sentences. Uh so I
think that's going to be one of the most
important transferable skills from TFT
to Rickbell.
>> All right, Dan. Well, let's go ahead and
take a quick look at your Leona list and
see what you're bringing to the
tournament.
>> All right, I'm here with Frodan and
we're gonna kind of talk a little bit
about this Leona deck that you've
brought to the Houston Regional
Qualifier. Uh why don't you go ahead and
just kind of break down a little bit of
the overarching strategy for what you're
looking to do?
>> Yeah, absolutely. So the main legend I
play around is Radiant Don Leona, which
is whenever you stun one or more enemy
units, you get to buff a friendly unit.
And from there, you get to leverage a
bunch of buffs to either draw cards or
just to attack. But the most important
thing is stunning prevents that unit
from dealing damage that turn, which
allows you a lot of different combat
trick potential, which is really fun.
And to make matters even more
complicated, Leona, this is the
alternate version of her card, Leon
Determined, whenever she attacks, gets
to stun an enemy unit here. And so you
basically are able to get those stuns a
lot and actually trigger the buffs and
then make your army really strugg.
And then to make matters even more
complicated is once Leon gets to the
battlefield, she also has shield. So she
can even hold the point a little bit
better. And then you combine the fact
with there's some yellow and green
spells. Green spells are really good at
small buffs. You're talking about like
ong guard, you're talking about
discipline, maybe even a defy to help
protect her. It could be a very very
sticky champion to deal with.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Let's go ahead and
take a look through some of the other
kind of key pieces of this deck as to uh
maybe that you're looking to buff or
looking to kind of use to push onto
these battlefields.
>> Yeah, so the first card that I love
playing a lot is Solari Shield Bearer.
When you play me, you stun a unit. And
it's a pretty basic effect, but once you
get Leona out, you can actually go for
the slower shield barrier to
preemptively stun. And then Leona
attacks, that allows you to double stun
a double buff and leverage both of those
to take down even the the very pesky
double holes. If you're going up against
a Teemo deck that likes to hide cards,
maybe go for the double, you actually
have different ways you can manipulate
that. So, this is a really simple card,
but a pretty big staple uh in the deck.
Uh and then of course uh one of the
cards that I really like to play around
as well is set kingpin. I think this is
one of the departures from the usual
Leona deck. I think a lot of people like
to play like Fiora for example or some
of the other four costs. But I really
like Kingpin because I just think this
card it's actually kind of broken. I
think he has so much stats for four and
if you have even a buff onset himself he
gets plus one for each buff friendly
unit that counts himself. So he goes up
to a seven might unit for for mana and
you have to recycle a power but
ultimately I think it's worthwhile.
>> Yeah, one one stun gets him to seven. I
think that that ends up being really
really good. Well, I mean this this
seems like a nice like core strategy.
Just get a lot of really stat big stats
out there. Stun so your unit opponent's
units can't kind of trade back. What are
some of the like ace in the whole card?
Some of the these spells that you may
have to help uh deal with maybe threats
that you can't deal with with just
stuns.
>> Yeah, the big one I think is the big
reason why you want to play Leona is
Zenith Blade. This is her signature
spell that stuns an enemy at the
battlefield and then you get to move
into that battlefield and challenge it
for either a showdown. But the cool
thing about Zenith Blade is that you
have so many lateral movements as well.
So let's say I attack Leo to battlefield
one and I can use Zenith Blade. It's
pretty expensive, but it's worthwhile. I
can actually move this Leona to the
other battlefield and that's also a stun
as well. So Leona can attack. She
triggers her own stun. Zenith's Blade
stuns and you have a lot of control. And
here's the kicker. Zenith Blade is an
action spell. Unlike something playing
around set, for example, set
showstopper, you have to play on your
turn. Even though it's cheaper, you
don't get to play on your opponent's
turn. Zenith Blade has some really cool
things that you can do because a lot of
people traditionally think of trying to
get rip out in points of two, right? You
try to go from like six to eight points
to double conquer and try to go for the
win. But on your opponent's turn, if
you're at five points, you can do some
pretty tricky stuff having Leona
Zenith's blade in and try to steal a
point and that puts you at the really
crucial interval of being at six points
trying to get the win. And so I really
like some of this interaction and it's
always really scary because if you leave
three mana open, is it just for simple
combat tricks like uh defy and
discipline or they trying to zen this
blade me or maybe I just didn't really
have anything. So it kind of creates a
bunch of layers of mind games that just
frustrate a lot of opponents.
>> Really cool bluffs opportunity, right?
And then this sometimes just being two
points cuz you get in, you steal their
conquer, and then you hold because they
don't have enough gas. Definitely makes
a lot of sense. Well, let's talk a
little bit. I know you have a couple
sideboard cards here that you wanted to
mention. Let's let's bring those out.
Let's talk about what they're in the uh
the side for.
>> So, one of the things about Leona is
that if you stun, it stops them from
doing damage, but you still have to
present the might to actually kill them.
So, one card that's pretty problematic
that I think is on a lot of people's
mind is can you deal with mastery's big
threats or can you deal with Dr. Mundo
and say a Teemo list? And so one of the
important cards to play in yellow is
that you have a lot of ability to just
kill units. And I think hidden blade is
really strong because there's also a
couple of other hidden cards you like to
work with Leona. I think hidden cards
are pretty underrated with Leona. You
have zas, you have things like the
hidden blade and so working that into
the sideboard to deal with big threats
feels pretty good.
>> Uh the second card that I think is also
pretty fun to play is the other version
of Leona, which is Leona Zealot, which
is a really good comeback card. If your
opponent's within three points of
winning, Leona gets to enter ready and
immediately get to attack. And then when
units are stunned, when enemy units are
stunned, they get minus eight. So
basically, they're going to go down to
one. Uh and you get to have an
opportunity to deal with the super big
chunky minions. Talking about the dead
predator, the white flame protector,
things like that. So you protect the the
the zeal, and then you're able to kind
of win back the battlefield and swing
some of those really difficult, hard to
kill beefy units.
>> All right, it looks like a cool list. I
I've been no stranger to being a Leona
fan, so I'm I'm really rooting for you
to kind of bring this home with Leona.
Uh but uh thanks for doing this de tech
deck with us and uh Dan, good luck in
the tournament.
>> Appreciate it.
It
>> was great to hear from Dan about the
Leona. I mean, as I said in the video,
it is my favorite deck to play
personally as well, Frank. And uh really
cool to see his variation uh playing
around the set kingpin as like this big
unit that he gets to really beef up with
all these extra buffs from the stuns.
Yeah. No, it's really awesome. Dan seems
like he's kind of a man with a plan on
this one. You got to respect the like
I'm not going to do what everyone else
is doing. I think I maybe see a weakness
in the meta and he's going to come catch
people off guard.
>> Yeah, there are a lot of amazing legends
in Origins, but in fact, we've got even
more legends coming your way with Spirit
Forge coming out early next year.
Pre-orders should be available at your
LGS already or uh even online. You can
find it very different LGS's across the
country. You should be able to find some
pre-orders for Spirit Forge. So, go
check it out. see if you can find a
pre-order today and try and get Spirit
Forge coming in. A lot of really cool
legends come in. I'm personally really
looking forward to Azir and Rexi.
>> Yeah, I mean I'm I'm super excited to
see Spirit Forge in the hand of players.
You know, we're getting gold, we're
getting equipment, some really classic
League of Legends game pieces, and I
just think it's going to be really cool
to actually see what it does to the
meta.
>> Lot of fun. I mean, you know, we have a
a Kaisa dominant meta potentially now,
but gear and permanent stats that could
change the math on a lot of these like
backline access spells coming through
>> for sure.
>> All right, but without further ado, we
should have round one ready to go to get
our first match of the Houston regional
qualifier. And we got a treat. It's
going to be T on Garen going up against
Quincy on Yasuo to kick things off. So,
some uh uh off thebeaten path legends to
start our day.
>> Yeah. No, this is really exciting to
see. You know, both players kind of
taking a different take from what you
know, most might expect. Um I'm really
interested in this Garen. I want to ask
you, Cass, do you think this is like a,
you know, a true Garen deck where it's
like I'm going to play recruits, I'm
going to try to activate my legend, or
do you think this is what I would call
dirty Garen where it's like I'm going to
jam an Aurora and try to take home that
medal?
>> I can tell you for a fact it is dirty
Garen. I know T from, you know, from
another card game we play. Uh he's
playing on team PCG Invasion. This is a
flesh and blood team. There's a lot of
these guys that are at the event. Most
of them are actually on Annie, but T
decided, you know what, I would like to
play for a metal card, and he
specifically went in the Garen
direction, and he put together an Aurora
list. So, it is going to be an Aurora
Garen. No true Damasians here. This is a
just three Auroras in a trench coat. And
that trench coat happens to look like
the might of Damasia.
>> Yep. And you see that first turn
mobilize. I think that confirms your
theory. And it is indeed going to be an
Aurora strategy.
>> Yeah, this is really cool though. On the
other side, we've got Yasuo stack deck.
Immediately finds a Noctturn. And I know
you're a big fan of this card, Frank.
Yeah, you know, I love Nocturn. I think
it's a real a real cool way to go with
the Teemo deck, but it's awesome to see
these Yasuo decks start to adapt it and
they're playing like handle it Sanctums
and you see the stack deck here and
hitting it on turn one off the stack
deck. Pretty powerful. You know, you
might feel like in other games like you
put something that big in an early,
you're like, "Oh my god, that's
unbeatable." But here, you know, it's
only going to go score a point just as
any other unit would be. And sacking the
rune is actually pretty significant.
>> I think this is crazy, though, cuz Yasua
gets to push it in and then he has
ganking to move over. But T recognizes
that, hey, you're going to score way too
many points too fast with this uh with
this knock turn. So, I'm just going to
go ahead call the week, get rid of that.
I'll replace the rune with immobilize
and get through there. But real quick, I
wanted to go over our battlefields to
start this out. We do have Aspirin's
climb from T on Garen. That's going to
be We are playing to nine. We have got
one more point that everyone has to get
in this game. Whereas back alley bar for
Quincy, he is playing when you move from
that location, you get plus one might.
So very good for Yaso when he has all
this extra mobility. Kind of a one-sided
battlefield for him in a lot of
matchups.
>> Yeah, definitely two battlefields that
are really tailored to each deck. Um,
you know, T probably not going to get
much value off that bar himself, but I
will say really heads up play on that
call to just be like, you know, your
instinct in in like a dazzling war might
be like I don't want to stack my runes
early. I got to get this Aurora out as
fast as I can. But he did realize, as
you said, that that knock is really
going to threaten a lot of points and
he's probably going to have more time in
the long run if he just takes it off the
table.
>> Yeah, for sure. And I think one of the
big things that we can look at in this
match up is Yasuo tends to be really
good into these Auroralists because of
his ability to score points early. He
essentially just has this like two
energy pseudo accelerate with being able
to uh activate his uh his legend ability
and then push in that unit. And we see
that with the traveling merchant gets to
play it down and immediately move it in
and get a conquer and score there. But
on the other side, I think that call has
bought enough time that if T's got this
uh Aurora in hand, we see the sign come
down. He's going to have the runes next
turn to get there while Quincy is only
at three points
>> for sure. Yeah, I think it's going to
the roles are going to be pretty defined
here. It's really going to be on Quincy
to do the best he can to score those
early points, get in there and, you
know, just try to rack that score up so
high that once the Aurora hits from T
that he's still going to have a chance
to close out the game before the
inevitability overwhelms them.
>> Yeah, really cool. I love these kind of
Yasu lists that are playing around the
mask of foresight. They have a lot of
these kind of big units that get to
utilize the plus one when attacking or
defending alone. uh mostly within the
Kane or the Yasuo Remorseful where Kane,
you know, by not taking damage, just
being able to beef up that might helps
you deal with any of the bigger threats
whereas Yaso gets that on attack trigger
completely can blow out a lot of big
break points by having that additional
uh point of might.
>> Yeah, for sure. You know, at the end of
the day in Riftbound, you only need to
beat the other number by one. So Yaso is
going to use all these like little
tricks, maybe some disciplines to try to
just come over the edge of Te's giant
monsters once they start hitting the
field.
All right, couple move triggers from the
traveling merchant. Quincy's going to be
able to filter this hand quite a bit to
try and find what he needs to beat an a
lateg game Aurora. And then also, you
know, by having Yaso, it's nice. You
kind of have this pseudo ganking where
you get to move the traveling merchant
back and then just pay for Yaso to move
it back in and get those extra points.
>> Yeah, I think Quincy really just doing
kind of exactly what we're saying here.
He's getting his units in. He's scoring
points. He's trying to keep them safe
and kind of just build up enough
resources so when, you know, if the
Aurora hits the table here, he can go
over the top. All right, that's the big
question, though. We've got the runes.
Does he have the Aurora for this very
first game, or is he playing this kind
of poor Garen deck that has a lot of the
big threats that can't quite hit the
board? But I saw him kind of shuffle the
hand. And not only does he have the
Aurora, but he has the divine judgment
to follow it up.
>> Wow, that is a powerful combination. And
yeah, know it's cool cuz when they when
they have the Aurora, you know, T's
going to get to play kind of the
supercharged game other than the fair
game of just play one big thing a turn
and hope it's enough. But yeah, here we
see the Aurora and you know that's going
to start just putting some big threats
on the table.
>> Yeah, let's see what that first one is
as he passes the turn. Here's the first
trigger. Just an Ursa. So maybe not the
thing he was most excited to see,
especially because that Divine
Judgment's coming up. But realistically,
yeah, you're going to dramp yourself,
but you're going to have these two big
bodies and you're going to put Quincy on
the other side on just two runes and two
cards to try and deal with it. Yeah.
Know, there's a there's a really
interesting dynamic with the Aurora
decks where you kind of got to find that
sweet spot of like, do I only want to
play the insane flips or do I want to
play some of the more middle stuff so I
have a more reasonable game plan in the
games where I don't have Aurora or on
the turns getting there. Um, so you
know, I'm not the best hit that he could
have put out, but you know, it's still
pretty big. Yeah, I think I'm a fan of
Ursign in this version, right, where you
kind of need something to play if you
can't because one of the other big
threats that we see in this deck uh is
going to be commander Lros, which has
that like four recycle cost and really
you can't play that uh so effectively in
this list. You need it to come off of
the Aurora. So having some threats that
you actually can play out is really
helpful.
>> Here we see a accelerated tasty FA folk
coming to brawl with the signs. That
extra stat from the mask is going to
push it over the top to be able to kill
it cleanly and score a point.
>> All right, and there it goes. That's
going to be a little annoying for T
actually be able to deal with straight
away because this turn really wants to
be that divine judgment and then allow
the Aurora to start kind of acrruing
that value and uh that earth sign is a
little too small. They can't actually
deal with the tasty at seven.
>> Yeah. No, the mask playing both O and D
here uh really just lining up perfectly
against the numbers that T has right
now. It's going to be interesting to see
if he still thinks it's worth it to go
for the judgment or if he's going to try
to get some more on the table before
pulling that trigger.
Let's see. I mean, this is the decision
here. The question really becomes, does
he have maybe um like a uh a hidden
blade or any of the other potential
hiddens that he could have? And there is
a hidden blade, right? So, this is
pretty nice. You actually hidden blade.
Now, he's Quinc is going to draw three
cards here. He's draws two for the
hidden blade, one for the tasty, channel
two runes, and now boom, divine judgment
is going to take that all away.
>> Yeah, this lines up really perfectly for
T. Super heads up play. You know, you'll
obviously see him like tapping the
table. That's when you know like the
gears are turning. He's doing some math
and he's like, "Can I do this?" And he's
like, "Oh, I can. This is going to be
great for me."
>> Oh, yeah. He's like, "Yeah, draw that
draw those extra cards."
>> Go ahead. Uh, it doesn't matter. Well,
it it can matter, right? you get more
options to try choose when this divine
judgment is going to hit the table. Um
he's just trying to figure out how
legally to cast it as he's going through
uh the big recycle.
>> Yeah, definitely judgment not maybe not
a card that people are thinking about
most of the time and then your opponent
plays it and you kind of lean over the
table and you're like, "Oh, that's uh
>> that sucks for me." Yeah. uh especially
when you've got this grip of cards and
what I'm what I'm seeing right now is a
lot of very lowcosted cards, a lot of
spells, a lot of tricks. Uh and maybe
you know Quincy could try and use those
to help out with the remorseful actually
you know making something happen after
the fact. But the question is going to
be what are the big pulls that come from
the Aurora cuz now both of you are just
on this very low economy game except for
one of you has an Aurora in play,
>> right? You know, normally after the
judgment it's like oh yeah, this is
totally fair. We're both going down to
two of everything. We'll build back up
and see what happens. But when you have
an Aurora in play, you're going to come
out way faster than the opponent. And
it'll be it's really going to be on
Quincy to see if he could find a way out
of it. He does have a big point lead
right now.
>> Yeah, it is a big point lead. He's at
the the four to one, but because we're
on aspirin, it's not even on that point
cadence that we talk about in this game
all the time where it's like, you know,
2 4 6 and eight and try and score two
points per turn to win the game. Here,
you've got to get to nine. So, it breaks
that math quite a bit. as mountain drake
is going to be just that first thing
coming out and that is just a big 10
might body.
>> Yeah, you know, mountain drake it's not
it's not flashy but it is sure huge and
it is going to be way bigger than
anything I think Quincy is going to be
able to get on the table here.
>> Yeah, and you know I talked about
remorseful being a nice way that you can
kind of use the spells and start to
answer some of this. The problem is is
you go down to two runes with divine
judgments. You actually need two more
turns before you can actually even get
to the remorseful. I think a mask is
helpful to start things out, get the
ball rolling and maybe start to be able
to use this Yasuo. But if T's got an
answer, like another hidden blade if
he's got, you know, any other kill
spells in the deck ready to go, that's
going to be where things get really
tough for Quincy. And I think I saw him
just draw a blast of power
>> for sure. Yeah, that's kind of the
nightmare scenario. You're like, okay,
I'm kind of under the gun. I'm going to
go all in. and then you just get really
blown out by one of the removal spells,
especially with things like hidden blade
being so efficient that you could even
still have them ready to go even after
the divine judgment.
>> Yeah. And the pull from the Dazzling
Aurora this time is a snap bind. So you
you were talking about units that you
can kind of utilize if you don't find
that Aurora. I think Snap Vine being
that five cost kind of fits exactly in
there. Yes, off the Aurora, it does
impact the board immediately because you
can actually target something at the
battlefield, get that kind of clash to
come through, but also if you're missing
the Aurora, this is just kind of a more
efficient play that the Garen deck has
access to to slow down the game.
>> Yeah. Know, this is really cool to see
cuz, you know, I'm not I'm not as tuned
into the the specifics of the Garen
meta. So, I'm used to seeing Misfortune
just slamming in turbo chunguses, but
like seeing it really looks like this
Garen deck is kind of built on a much
more mid-range plan that is using the
Aurora as just like I'm going to grind
you to dust with value instead of lock
you out of the game with huge might
numbers.
>> Yeah, I mean, especially because you've
got Aurora DJ as that combo, which is
just like uh you know, DJ Aurora, my
favorite artist. It uh is completely
locks your opponent out of the game.
They're not dancing actually. It's a
it's an artist where you just kind of
stand still and actually don't have much
action.
But yeah, T just you know moving his
stats around scoring points and you know
just like that the point score has
shifted.
>> Yeah, as T now having that massive lead
and it feels like you know double mask
knockturn turn while it does allow you
to you know contest the snap vine is
just going to really struggle to kind of
keep pushing through. I wonder if the
harness dragons are in here cuz that's
another thing that you get access to by
being in order that you get to just kind
of rip that off the top and point at
their unit and say goodbye. And that is
really really tough for a lot of players
to be able to deal with. But we do see
the dead bloom. We're seeing dead bloom,
drake, snap vine, earth sign. I'm
wondering I, you know, when I was
talking to him yesterday, I saw some
lead roast in there. I'm curious if that
means there's no uh hearts dragon, which
would be I think interesting to me that
that, you know, because that's something
that can come off and immediately impact
the board. Often that's a popular
choice.
>> Yeah. No, that's interesting. I would be
surprised if he doesn't have it
somewhere. Maybe he's got some in the
sideboard for some of the bigger uh unit
matchups. I will say one thing uh that I
really respect from Quincy here is, you
know, sometimes in spots like this,
you'll just be like, "Oh, I'm
demoralized. There's nothing I can do.
I'm just going to concede." I think it's
really great that Quincy's kind of
sticking in here, especially because, as
you just saw when that Aurora triggered,
uh T had to flip over like 15 cards, and
that's really valuable information for
Quincy to have for the rest of the match
to kind of know uh what T's deck is
going to be capable of.
>> It's a great call out. really helps you
when you go into the sideboarded rounds
if he's got any tech in the board that
uh is maybe to target a different
matchup because I I'm assuming most
players don't have Garen tech in their
board. Uh but if he sees the cards and
he knows, oh, this is an effective card
uh to deal with something I saw from
those flips. It's going to be really
good as we see that blast of power come
out to deal with an Octturn, maybe
there's a wind wall in the board that
could potentially come in to help deal
with some of these bigger threats that
you can't defy.
>> Yeah. And you know, T just taking no
chances here. He's like, I know I'm I'm
ahead on points. I'm head board, but I'm
just going to kill that noturn. Kind of
crush any dreams that Quincy might have
of a comeback here. And yeah, just keep
just keep putting stats in play.
>> Yeah, and we've already we've made it
all the way to the I believe he's got
the runes for the second Aurora in hand.
Uh and if not, it would be next turn. I
can't it's I can't count. It's eight or
nine there. I think it's nine. Yeah. So,
he's got the Aurora if he wants it as
he's just able to push in for these last
couple points and he can look to either
full stack for a hold or doesn't even
really need to cuz he's been able to
keep Quincy off enough points that now
he gets to play that really slow game.
Look for the double conquer with all
these big units. And there's that second
Aurora hitting the board.
>> Yeah, now T really stunted on us with
his fancy alt art runes. If I look at
them too directly, I get I get a little
blinded, but yep, there's the second
Aurora.
>> Yeah, that makes sense.
>> And that's going to do it.
>> All right. All right. Well, that's a
Garen grabbing game one of the Houston
Regional Qualifier. Our first game of
the day and we get a Garen W on the
board. We'll see if you can actually
take this series down though as we'll
get towards game two. We'll see what the
uh battlefield change are. I'm I'm
curious about the Garen cuz usually MF
Aurora, you know, we get the obelisk is
maybe uh either a game two option where
your opponent wants to be on the play so
you kind of get those four uh runes or
uh often is sigil of the storm to try
and slow down your opponent. I wonder if
it'll be the same for Garen. Yeah. No,
that that'll be interesting. And
definitely like if you told me that I
was going to come in here in the first
match that game that I was going to see
is a a Garen dazzling Aurora master
class, I probably wouldn't have believed
you. But um the thing that I'm really
excited to see if Quincy has some
options to kind of deal with that
Aurora, you know, he could have
acceptable losses. He could have fading
memories, just ways to get a gear off
the table once it's hit.
>> Yeah. One of the other big things I
think the gear destruction is is huge,
especially because I actually think um
what is it? Adaptatron ends up being a
really good one uh in Yasua because you
can do that pseudo accelerate to push it
in and score on the turn that you play
it. You don't have to worry about
leaving it around letting them keep up
runes to try and deal with it. Uh but
the other side of it is we saw the knock
turns. Is this an aggressive enough
Yasuo that they might have something
like Arena's greatest and game two
arena's greatest might be really solid
for us to do. So let's go ahead and jump
into game two. Let's see what options
maybe Quincy has been able to bring in
to help deal with this Garen Menace as
we jump in. Candle it Sanctum that'll
kind of synergize with those Noctturns,
try and help find them. When you look at
those top two cards, you put him either
top or the bottom from there. And then
the oblisk of course from T. So it is
kind of similar to that Aurora MF. He is
going to go up to those initial uh big
four runes and we'll see if the catalyst
is there.
>> Yeah, definitely. One one of the things
I really love about Nocturn is just like
you conquer that Sanctum and it's just
such a sweat. You just peel one card,
two card, and you're like, is Noctturn
there? And sometimes you just get to put
a four might into play.
There is that catalyst for T. Everything
coming up T in this uh initial series. I
didn't get a glimpse of the hand fully.
I saw Divine Judgment, but I did not
catch if there was an Aurora or not in
that hand. But that's the big question
when you're on Obisk because he's on
pace for that turn three Aurora, which
is so devastating for any deck that's
trying to play against this.
>> Yeah, for sure. Really T kind of just
living the dream right now. He's going
second. The Obelisk is there to start
him on four runes. slams the catalyst up
to six and you know the Aurora is is is
probably well on its way
>> as we got the initial trigger from the
candle it looks at the top two that
looks like it's not an Octturn or we'd
probably see that slammed rather quickly
figuring out if he wants to just top or
bottom these cards it looks like one top
one bottom
>> yeah you know it's interesting we see
the the mask of foresight here for
Quincy again and although it did help
him out in the first game I'm curious if
that's still here because he's like he
thinks it's good in the matchup or if
it's just like a maybe he just doesn't
have the sideboard slots to deal with
what Garen's bringing to the table.
>> Yeah, I mean it's a match up you're not
prepared for. You might be prepare
prepared for misfortune. Um and it is
like similar in what you want to do.
However, realistically the defies kind
of help you in the green match up versus
it because you can deal with like bullet
time from Misfortune. But for Garen,
it's kind of just like, hey, like I'm
just going to slam an Aurora and then a
Divine Judgment, and you're just not
going to have the resources to even
attempt to put up the fight at the end
of the game as this time Aurora's
missed, but this is just a dead bloom
that's going to come out and slow down
the game quite a bit for T, right?
Right. And yeah, that's kind of the
interesting dynamic that Quincy's got to
keep his eye on because, you know, if he
like overboards and puts in like six
things to kill gear, all of a sudden
maybe he's just going to get run over by
dead blooms that he doesn't actually
have an answer for and have a handful of
gear removal.
>> Yeah. And we see top two from Candleit
and he's just going to put both to the
bottom. It was a divine judgment and a
hidden blade. And I think T seeing as
how he played this dead bloom, I assume
there's no Aurora. This feels like,
yeah, I get to conquer Sanctum. Look at
top two. Oh, no Aurora. Those go to the
bottom.
>> Yeah. And I I think you said you saw you
snuck a peek at a judgment in T's hand.
Probably not a card you need two of very
often.
>> No. And the the really neat thing though
for T is even if he keeps missing on the
Aurora. If he has something like a
second Dead Bloom, gets to get that onto
the board. You can consider just going
for the Divine Judgment saying, "I've
got these two big guys. How are you
going to deal with this?"
>> Yep. And uh big play coming in from
Quincy here. Going to accelerate that.
Oh no, not accelerate the Tasty Fay folk
this time.
Yeah, the mask not going to get you over
a dead bloom predator, but taking a
little glimpse at Quincy's hand. I I saw
an ong guard and a discipline kind of
push through. So going into the next
turn, there might be a nice easy way to
kind of push over this dead bloom if T
doesn't have an answer. Looking at the
hand though, I think I caught a glimpse
of a hidden blade from T. Uh so there is
going to be that answer if he decides to
hold it up. and he's got to think about
what he wants to do cuz I think most of
the hand doesn't do a ton just yet
because it the way this deck is
constructed lot of big units try and get
them out with dazzling and then lowc
cost spells that are mostly affecting
the battlefield. So it might even be
time that that rugged Garen might even
get deployed which uh is something that
I don't think this deck likes to do that
often.
>> Yeah. No, it's it's interesting. We kind
of haven't even talked about the Garen
chosen champion or the legend. It seems
like those are mostly just hanging out.
>> Kind of an emergency. Yeah. I mean, I I
so the the Garen Legend to trigger it,
you have to conquer a battlefield with
four units, which, you know, I feel like
if the way TE's got this deck set up, if
we've reached that point, he's probably
comically won the game. Um, but you
never know, maybe maybe he'll just need
a little two extra cards to push things
off.
>> All right, looks like a quick judge
question for T stepping away there
trying to figure out the rules. I do
like when the players are are are doing
this. The game is still, you know,
relatively new. A lot of people are
pretty comfortable with the rules, but
there's still some edge cases that
people have not figured out. And I think
this is always the way to do it. Call
the judge, ask them, try and figure it
out, and then just proceed from there.
And uh this is, you know, T's been been
around the block a lot of times with TCG
tournaments. He's played a lot of uh TCG
tournaments in the past. So, this is,
you know, you come in with something
new, you're really excited about
Riftbound, got to learn all the rules.
>> Yeah. And definitely just like really
want to reinforce like never be afraid
to call a judge. You're worried, you
need a clarification, you think
something sketchy is going on. I know a
lot of people like sometimes, like, oh,
I'm nervous. So, I don't want to I don't
want to slow the game down and then but
no, just like always call the judge.
Judges are great. They'll help you out
and make sure things are going the way
they should.
>> And thinking about what T could even be
wanting to do on this turn, we know the
Divine Judgments in hand. He's got some
spells. It really feels like an option
between keeping up most of your runes if
not all of them to just kind of deal
with whatever uh Quincy wants to do and
maybe it's just slamming a Garen and
actually just saying you know what uh
five might uh you know he also has
assault and shield two so kind of a
pseudo seven might unit just a little
weaker to spells um that you you can
just kind of get on the board and at a
certain point when you've got a dead
bloom you've got a decent position just
getting more might on the field might be
enough to actually kind push you over
the edge and actually score enough as
already this early game even without the
Aurora has been relatively successful in
keeping Quincy off of points.
>> Yeah, you know, I think if you just
showed me uh this match in a vacuum and
I knew nothing about Riftbound, I'd be
like, "Wow, this Garen deck is broken."
So, it's been really cool to see that
level of power come. Um, and I did think
I think I saw a peak of a call the weak
in uh T's hand, which is interesting
because I imagine a lot of the time he
wants to play that when he has no units
because, you know, right now if he
played it, he'd have to kill his own
dead bloom predator, which is a pretty
hefty cost to pay.
>> All right, so it looks like he'd have an
sign in hand. So preferable to playing
the Garen from the champ zone. You
actually get to uh ramp a rune as well.
Uh, and you're going to have that tank
keyword, which is quite nice. And it
looks like maybe just hiding the hidden
blade. So says, you know what, this uh
dead bloom's not moving. This is going
to stay here all game and uh unless
you've got a way to kind of move it
away. That what I will say is this a
little soft to something like a charm.
Uh being able to try and get that dead
bloom off there because you're not going
to want to hidden blade your own dead
bloom to uh just get value in that case.
Yeah, for sure. For those who don't
know, certain cards have the hidden
mechanic. When you hide it at a
battlefield, you can now only use it at
things at that battlefield. So if a
charm came out here, I kind of agree. I
don't think he'd be like, "Okay, I'm
going to kill my dead bloom to draw two
cards." You know, that would be a pretty
tough tempo loss for T. But, you know,
he wanted to get it in there and it
looks like he might get paid off here.
>> Yeah, looks like this will be good. I'm
I'm going to I I think Quincy, it's
possible, has a defy. I didn't see it in
hand, but I think going with this line.
Hey, this uh order deck has just hidden
a card and I'm going to send this in as
a nine might. Um I want to have some
backup to make sure I can deal with the
hidden blade, but we'll see if it's
actually there as that hidden blade gets
cast. And there's the five.
>> There it is. Great call, Cass. Yeah, I
mean, I think uh from Quincy's end,
especially after you got to see so many
cards uh from Te's deck in the first
game, you're probably not, you know,
going in there and just being like, "Oh,
I wonder what this hidden card is."
There's really really only a few things
it could be.
All right, still a lot of runes
available for Quincy as he does get this
conquer and he will get to take a look
at the top. Looks like it is going to be
the vision porro and a mask on the top
of the deck for Quincy. And we see once
again, it looked like he went top one,
bottom one. I'm surprised he actually
kept either of those cards.
>> Yeah, it's it's interesting. And it's
interesting to see kind of like some of
the concessions that this build of
Quincy's deck makes to be like, I just
want extra peaks at Nocturn cuz you
think maybe the vision pouro, you're
like some decks might not be excited to
do that, but when you have that extra
chance to hit Noctturn and put him into
play, the value goes way up. Makes a lot
of sense as we do finally see one of the
big units out of this Yasuo archetype.
It is Kane Unleashed. Usually uh Kane is
actually the main carry for this deck
and then Remorseful is just the
secondary option if you don't find your
Kanes. You've always got that kind of
six might abusable with movement uh unit
in your champion zone
>> for sure. And you know this game uh
definitely interesting compared to the
last to see what the game looks like
when there's not a dazzling Aurora in
play giving the Garen deck kind of that
extra juice. And you know Quincy is uh
starting to put a lot into play here.
>> Yeah. And that that call that you
mentioned, it keeps kind of coming up
where, hey, look, Kane is a problem when
Yaso has access to like a full grip of
runes and just kind of gets to go with
it. I might be willing to sacrifice a
unit in order to to deal with that maybe
after the conquer depending on what my
follow-up is, but you do still have this
tasty fay folk you've got to deal with.
You got, you know, a lot of things that
still have to be dealt with. There is a
harness dragon in fact in this deck and
so that can at least deal with the Kane
if that decides to be the choice as the
faith folk is the other option.
>> Yeah, interesting. I I wonder if that
did come out of the sideboard or if we
just didn't see it for the first game.
But I definitely agree. You know, Kane
um the Yasawa deck is really good at it
has these kind of few core cards that it
really tries to build its strategy
around. And there probably will come a
point where like if T can pick off a
Kane or something of that level with a
call, he might actually be willing to
sack one of his, you know, bigger units,
but it might not be better. So,
as we get the pass back over to Quincy,
I see yet another Tasty Fay Folk in the
hand. And that accelerated will actually
get over the top of this Earth sign as
we saw in the previous game. Having that
mass getting to that seven does does
kind of make these fay folks really
threatening accelerate units as that is
going to get sent in though T I think
does have a second hidden blade here. Uh
so it will come down to does Quincy have
yet another defy for that last rune and
it looks like not this time.
>> Yeah and I will say I was I was a bit of
a masked doubter here but it is you know
Quincy just showing us again and again
how just those stat points really matter
at every moment and even though he did
eat the hidden blade here he's going to
he's going to get a lot of cards and
runes and compensation. Yeah, draws up
quite a few cards. But now this opens up
what I was kind of mentioning earlier
where Divine Judgment when you've got a
couple of guys on the board could just
kind of crush that hand, get rid of the
runes, reset the game if you're still
not finding that Aurora becomes an
option. But this is a great kind of
hedge against that by hiding a card from
Quincy. He'll get to keep that. You get
to keep your hidden cards when that
Divine Judgment comes down.
>> Yeah. And it's interesting. Not super
familiar with Quincy's list, but I'm
guessing we might be looking at a
Zagna's Hourglass hidden there, which
will also, you know, Zas let you uh
protect a unit that would die, give him
a little bit of resiliency to kind of
fight through uh some of these two for
ones and removal threats that T keeps uh
playing against him.
>> Yeah. And let's see, is that Blast of
Power, which is just ripped off the top.
And it looks like T says, you know what,
Divine Judgment not needed. You got one
guy. Blast of Power seems pretty good at
dealing with one guy. As it looks like a
response, no, it's a fighter flight.
This could have been deployed in
response to the blast of power because
it was hidden and actually avoided
losing that Tasty Fay folk. I'm not sure
if Quincy decided because he wanted to
draw cards or if he didn't realize that
he had that opportunity for counterplay.
>> Yeah, interesting because you know kind
of a subtle nuance with hidden there.
Like normally fight or flight is an
action and you wouldn't be able to play
it in a spot like that. But once you hit
hide it, it actually upgrades to a
reaction. And since blast of power is
battlefield only, he could have gone for
a backout there, but you know,
definitely could see a world where he
just wants the cards and the runes
instead.
>> Yeah, and we'll see what the followup
ends up being from Quincy as he has now
been able to push up to five points.
He's going to move back the Earth sign
recognizing, you know what, these faolk
keep causing me a lot of problems with
my six might units. I'm willing to
sacrifice the dragon for the looks on
the the uh Kennellet Sanctum and to
score the point, but I want to make sure
I've got a little bit at the back row
safe, ready to go.
>> I really like what T does here where
he's just keeping his hand face down on
the table. He's kind of just being like,
"Yep, I got two cards. Do what you're
going to do." Um, no ambiguity here.
>> And you know, there is the Fay Folk in
hand once again looks like for Quincy.
So, we may just see kind of a repeat of
what we've seen time and time again of
that caster. No. Okay, that was a that
was a trigger from Oh, that was stack
deck. Okay, that's what that was. So,
he's looking to see what he can add to
this massive hand.
>> Yeah, Quincy Quincy doing the big thing
on stack deck. Seeing if he's can find
anything to kind of help him fight back
in. And let's see what he came up with.
>> That's two green runes going to the
bottom. I'm going to assume that's going
to be remorseful hitting the board.
Yeah, and that uh that attack trigger on
Yaso Remorseful. Really really
threatening. You know, he's a little
slow to come out. Cost you a lot of
power, but you you get what you paid
for. Yeah, very potent. The masks
helping buff this up. Doesn't matter in
this spot, right? Six would have gotten
the job done, but you do have that
seven, which may come into play later
on, especially if we can get a second
mask down. Then you can actually deal
with even, you know, in the deck. I was
talking about the Ledros if that ends up
actually being in there. We haven't seen
one yet, but having that big buff as he
does get to find a Noctturn off the
candle lit.
>> Yeah. Know, it's interesting at this
point like he's kind of dug through so
many cards. I was like, man, did he take
the Noctturns out? Is that not what this
game is about? But here we find one
later on. And you know, the the really
fun thing about playing Nocturn is like
if you haven't seen one yet, every time
you look, you're just more and more
likely and you could actually start to
start to bank on I'm going to hit a
Noctturn soon and swing the tempo back
in my favor.
>> Yeah. And now, you know, this game has
gone long enough where T kind of had
this like early advantage, but the
Aurora is still just not coming through.
And now we're at the point where it's
like, yeah, you kind of needed to find
that for this game to still get really
properly stabilized. Is finally, I think
Quincy has found his footing in this
game. He's got, you know, Yasu on board.
He's got the Noturn on board. He's got a
hidden card. So, he's even insulated
around the Divine Judgment. He's got a
really great board for if it if it were
to happen. And he's got this fistful of
cards that he can continue to enable the
Yasuo. Yeah, I definitely I don't think
I would not expect T fire off the
judgment here. I don't think this is
kind of the the game state you're
looking for, but we'll see what he has
to do because you know sometimes your
options are thin and he is running low
on cards in hand. Hasn't triggered that
Garen legend yet unfortunately.
>> No, see that would have helped with the
cards right if he could have gotten that
off. But at this point, uh yeah, I mean
he's just looking he's at six points so
he's at least, you know, approaching a
win. So now the question is is can you
actually maybe look for a hold even? But
he is just going to, you know, deploy
Garen Rugged in the uh the back row here
and then just catalyst up to I'm just
going to be at max runes next turn.
Hopefully he's hoping to find something
to do with them.
>> Oh, maybe Garen Rugged has hit the
table. It's not plan A, I don't think.
But
>> maybe not even plan B. Certainly plan
B, C through F.
>> Hey, I mean, he could he could he could
throw down with a knockturn. He could
take out a knockturn if he's got it.
Hey, we said, you know, this mask of
foresight makes these uh things seven.
Uh well, guess what? Garren rugged on
offense. That's a seven to try and get
through the oo as a mindspplitter is
going to come down from Quincy. And that
is going to allow this kind of look at
the hand, grab one of those cards, and
say goodbye, send it to the trash.
>> Yeah. And he's, you know, really kind of
just trying to back te in a corner, take
out all his resources, and just make
sure that he really has no way out. I
imagine he's probably thinking, how do I
lose at this point? Can I? and just make
sure that he can win even if T manages
to get an Aurora down at this stage of
the game.
>> Yeah, now he gets to push in that mind
spplitter with the Yasuo legend ability.
And that's going to be an eight going
into that six because of the mask, which
is massive. And now you even get to
reinforce with the noturn so that uh
Garen can't just run in and deal at
least trade with the Yasuo. So, we'll
see. It's just top decking for T.
Yeah, and for sure we talked about the
uh the Yasaw Legends ability to kind of
like rush points down early, but this is
actually where it really can shine is
later in the game where you've got a lot
of extra energy to use and then just
getting to like manipulate that movement
so much and always like everything you
play from your hand is immediately a
threat can be really hard to come back
from.
>> All right, so it is just going to be a
dead bloom going down. Is there an ong
guard for Quincy to deny this? There is.
>> Wow. Yep. And it looks like Yep. That's
enough for T. We're going to take it to
a third game here.
>> Yeah. So, this time, you know, look, you
get to see what the Garen deck can do
power level when it sees that Aurora,
when it gets to see the Aurora, Divine
Judgment. There's not a lot of decks
that can even manage that once that
happens. But when it misses, this Garen
deck really does struggle. It has a lot
of difficulty trying to piece together
these good enough turns. And we see
Quincy's able to punish. Yeah, I think
like one of the things that the Garren
deck seems to really struggle compared
to like the Misfortune Aurora variants
is like you don't have those cards like
stack deck that are going to help make
sure you find it every game and you're
kind of just putting your hope in the
heart of the cards and hope that you can
just find it naturally.
>> Yeah. And for this third and final game,
we are going to dreaming tree for Yaso.
So when those on guards and disciplines
are able to buff at least the first time
per turn onto Quincy's cards, he's going
to get to draw one. And then on the
other side, it is sigil of the storm. So
when Quincy's running in there to try
and conquer in the early stage of the
game, you are going to have to recycle a
rune.
>> Yep. And uh you know, no immediate start
from T. Quincy going to set things up a
little bit with a stack deck. And uh
let's see if we'll have a unit to add to
the board.
>> From uh from T's side.
>> Noturn.
>> Oh, a Noctturn. That is a unit to add to
the board. All right. And it's
interesting because it kind of we saw
this start from Quincy in the first game
and then he really wasn't able to
leverage it as well because that Aurora
came down quickly. But it'll be
interesting to see if T can deal with
the early knockturn the second time.
>> Yeah. And this time around I didn't see
an Aurora in T's hand, but the same way
he dealt with it last time is there.
There is just the call of the week.
>> Yeah, I'm getting I'm getting
flashbacks. Cass.
>> Oh yeah. Question from Quincy there is
uh when I choose my Noctturn, do I draw
for dreaming tree? And I believe the
answer is no for that one.
>> The answer is no. Yeah. So call doesn't
actually the spell isn't choosing. It
prompts the player to make a choice. And
Dreaming Tree specifically says when you
choose with a spell.
>> Oh, hey,
>> there it is.
>> I said it might be the good one for
Yasua to have. That gets really
difficult cuz it just sits back here and
it just says, "Hey, you can never play
you can never play this uh Aurora
because the second you do, I'll just
move this in and get the conquer." So
you have to be able to have Aurora up
with maybe the backup of a hidden blade,
but even then there could be a Defy. And
I see it at the corner of Quincy's hand.
>> Yeah. Really, really great thing for
Quincy to get on the table. Really heads
up to prioritize putting that down. And
you know, Adaptatron on the on the
design team. We lovingly refer to it as
French Fry Mdinger. So, you know, just a
just a real good guy to have on your
side.
>> That is so good. As we do have this
pickup from Quincy on the stack deck. It
looked like a a pair of mind spplitters.
wasn't sure what the last card was and
it looks like I think he's keeping one
of those splitters cuz I mean that's
also going to be good. You've got this
fork, right? You've got the adapatron
down and if T can't deal with it in the
next few turns, you just mind splitter
and you take the Aurora anyway and you
can have these different options in
stopping the Garen from getting online
>> for sure. Definitely not the ideal start
from T here. Not really using his early
energy very well. Kind of no no board
development and Quincy doing his best to
kind of capitalize on that and score
some of those early points.
Yeah, looks like they're just clarifying
that the the move trigger needs to
happen first and then the the conquer uh
can come from there. So, we'll see.
There's just going to be an ong guard
that gets stomped.
They'll draw a card, then the recycle
comes through.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah, I imagine Quincy's got to be
feeling pretty good about this one.
>> Okay. with the uh the adaptron moving in
though that does open up maybe the
potential
uh for T actually deal with this
adaptatron and then uh potentially from
there be able to play out in Aurora. So
we'll see if there is removal in T's
hand. I think there were blast of power
and honestly that that's kind of worth
it to say you know what get rid of this
adaptron don't have to worry about this
going forward. Yeah, there's a kind of
an interesting dynamic in Riftbound
where a lot of the removal is uh
battlefield restricted. So, you kind of
have those spots where you have to
choose, do I want to send my unit to a
battlefield, get that point, but then
put it at risk of dying to some of these
removal spells that it might be safe
from if I'm in the base. And Quincy
making the call to really value the
points here, which I think is pretty
smart.
>> Looking at this hand from T, I'm still
not seeing an Aurora. Couple divine
judgments, a lot of the early spells,
the ways that you can kind of deal with
some of the other decks, but not a great
way to deal with this as it is just
going to be a mindspplitter. Just take a
look at the hand. Not going to see an
Aurora, but going to see a lot of other
options to deal with. And it might even
just be something like the dead bloom.
Just getting rid of any units, any any
way for T meaningful meaningfully impact
the board.
>> Yeah, whether whether Garen Rugged is
plan B or C, I certainly don't think
it's the first unit you want to add to
the table. So T is got a bit of a clunky
draw here, but we're going to see if
he's going to can do anything about it.
>> Yeah, I I I like this from Quincy. Just
take the dead bloom and say, you know
what, your only unit right now is Garen.
That's fine. These spells are not that
threatening to what I'm currently doing
to the game.
>> It's interesting. I saw a uh unyielding
in Te's hand there. And I'm thinking
about what that interacts with in
Quincy's deck. I guess it's mainly
looking for some protection against
Yasawo.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I guess it does work against
Yasuo Remorseful. And I think that's
probably what T was thinking. maybe he
doesn't have any other cards that feel
especially useful and uh feels like hey
maybe I can actually get like a a pretty
big surprise into Quincy where he tries
to send in this Yasuo expecting it to
just be free like it has been in the
previous games and I get to kind of just
deny that away with the unyielding.
>> Yeah, especially cuz you can just hold
that up for one energy. So they're like
it's probably not going to be on their
radar cuz you know you're thinking like
oh I'm chaos I'm calm. I don't have
damage. They're probably not bringing
that card in against me and then it can
really catch you by surprise.
So now T is just going to have to blast
the power of a traveling merchant. That
can't feel good.
>> And you know, a pretty a pretty
reasonable turnaround for T here. Oh
>> yeah, just deal with everything, I
guess.
>> Yeah. And I mean, you know, you might
not want to sack a a dead bloom to a
call of the week, but Garren Rugged,
he'll he'll he'll go right to the trash.
>> Oh, he's expendable as now,
unfortunately, with those recycles for
T, he is now at uh six runes. So even if
he top decks that Aurora, it's not going
to be something he can actually play
out. Uh will be looking for something
like that dead bloom that was taken away
by the mind spplitter.
>> Yeah. Now, and now Quincy, he's like
he's probably feeling okay cuz he knows
there's no Aurora in the immediate
future, but he's got to feel that
pressure of like I just got to keep
doing what I can, keep scoring points
before the Aurora comes up cuz you know
he will draw it eventually.
>> Yeah, cuz being at five is great, right?
Like uh being able to push uh to that
six point break point where you can look
for that double conquer and end the game
is the big thing that Kuni is going to
look for. and just a pass coming out of
T. We know there's a blast of power
there, right? And so does Quincy because
he saw it with the mindslitter. And
that's exactly what you have to be
thinking about is do I just send this in
and say, you know what, I'll just take
my runes and my cards. You you and we'll
get through that blast of power cuz we
have to at some point anyway.
>> Yeah. And one great thing about Blast of
Power, you can't defy that.
>> Yeah.
>> Defy only let you hit things up to four
energy. Blast of Power sitting at six
energy. So that gets right through a
Defy, which I believe Quincy did have in
his hand,
>> but unable to use it to defend here.
just going to play out a knockturn as
that was drawn off the top. What I think
I saw in the hand, I'm not sure though.
I don't want to I don't want to say for
sure, but if it was the rebuke that I
thought I saw in Quincy's hand, that is
a massive threat to have for these
matchups where you're against all these
big units because if T finally gets a
chance to get on board and a rebuke is
there to answer it, this game's over
>> for sure. And you know, this is what I
would normally, at least from the from
the Teemo side, I would call the sad
knockturn cuz you really never want to
play your knockturns. But in Yasawo,
getting to move him in immediately and
then threaten that ganking is actually
like, you know, I' I'd pay four in a
power for that.
>> Yeah, it's currently just threatening to
win the game. This Aurora has to find
Snapvine or Dead Bloom or else the game
is immediately over. It finds Ers sign,
which means that Nocturn is going to
hold and be able to gank over and that
should be able to just do it for Quincy
here. Yep. Quincy readying up in the
awaken phase and will see how he wants
to get the job done.
Looks like Quincy does have that rebuke.
It is next to that Defy. So definitely
going to have a great way to answer in
the future. Ends up playing the Kane.
Does have the uh the Yasuo to be able to
just send that in.
Oh.
And there we go. That's just going to do
it. Quincy's going to be able to pick
that up. So, while Garren came out to a
roaring start in game one, could not
find the Auroras in games two or three,
and Quincy Jones on the Yasuo going to
pick up the first win of the Houston
regional qualifiers.
>> Yeah, we we really saw the full spectrum
of Garen there. The the first game it
looked unbeatable. The second game it
kind of played a mid-range plan and had
a chance, and then the third game it
just, you know, imploded. But I guess
that's the that's the risk you sign up
for when you bring Dazzling Garren.
Yeah, I mean it's it's you're going for
the the metal card is what a lot of
players are saying when they're bringing
the Garen. They bring the Aurora because
they know, hey, when I've got the great
draw, I almost can't lose, right? I've
got the Aurora. I've got the Divine
Judgment. There's the other side of it
though and not enough card draw to kind
of rip through and find it. And that's
the issue that we've seen out of order
and body as the Aurora colors and why
Misfortune has been that successful. And
you called out the stack deck earlier
on.
>> Yeah. and really just Quincy kind of
knew exactly what he had to do. Put the
pressure on, didn't give any tea any
time to doawle and find those auroras
and just, you know, really really boxed
him out at the end there.
>> Yeah. All right. Well, for our backup
match for round one or our second match,
we ended up having a very special legend
again. We've got a Volibear that we're
going to have as we're ready to jump in
to that second match.
Or maybe not. We'll talk a little bit
more then. It may be Voly Bear. I know
it's Voly Bear versus Kai'Sa. We're
getting into the second game of that
match as it is going to be Floren
Christian Logan. He is recently top aed
the Flesh and Blood World Championship
this year. And now flying in from
Vienna, Austria to play some Volibear.
He said he also wanted to go for that
metal card and he's going up against
Rishi on the other side. Yeah. No, this
will be an interesting matchup. you
know, Volibear, another one of those
like a little less mainline legends,
another deck bringing really big units
to the table. And a lot of Kai'Sa's
removal is damage based quite often. And
it'll be interesting to see if these,
you know, giant Volibear units will be
able to weather the storm.
>> Yeah. And we're starting out in game two
for this second match of the stream. And
it looks like uh Malik or Floren on the
other side has picked up game one as
Volbear against the Kai'Sa. So getting
that first win.
>> Yep. And well, interesting to see how
this matchup will play in these
postboard games here.
>> So for this second game, we do have
biomaw layer for Voly Bear. So once you
go into the biom layer, you can't go
home. Yeah, you can go to the other
battlefield, but you can't go home. And
on the other side, Dreaming Tree, which
we saw in that last game, right? You can
just targeting your own units with
spells, you'll be able to draw a card as
well the first time per turn. But to
kick kick things off, our Volibear has
got a ballista to hit the board to help
deal with some of the early threats.
Yeah, and that that's that's when you
know you've kind of made a nice a nice
choice with your deck when you play the
ballista and your opponent's like, "Can
I read that? What does that do?" And
you're like, "Nice catch catching them
off guard." All according to plan.
>> And it's a a nice answer. The thing with
ballista is a little slow, right? Cuz
your opponent is going to score when
they go in, but the ballista helps you
clean it up afterwards so they don't get
those hold points. So, it helps buy you
a little bit of space for these Aurora
decks where you need ways to deal with
the early game without those being units
that you get to play. And so the bully
bear really likes to have these
ballistas come in. So yes, you have to
let this Raven Bloom score. But since
Rishi has gone out of runes, ballista on
this next turn when uh Floren untaps is
just going to be okay. Well, I'll awaken
my ballista and I will exhaust my
ballista and kill the student.
>> Yeah, interesting decision from Rishi
there cuz you know, he's got to kind of
like weigh that. Do I want the point
now? Do I want to save my student?
Especially on a card like student which,
you know, can grow its might in response
to something like ballista. But he's
going to value the point here which, you
know, does make sense. The Volibear deck
is definitely going to be more
threatening in a longer game and he's
just going to see if he can put the
pressure on and close it out quick.
>> Yeah, very notable card for Rishi that
we're seeing in the hand, the thermo
beam. So, we know this is an Aurora deck
uh for Volibear on the other side. But
with also the ballistas if he does kind
of catch an Aurora and these two
ballistas in the thermmo beam cuz that
gets everything that's going to be
massive for Ishi in this game especially
because double ballista starts to
threaten even Kaisa survivor from trying
to run in and get those conquers.
>> Yeah, thermmo beam it's expensive but
man it is powerful. Cleans up every gear
that is in play. And you know, the
second ballista, you know, if I if I was
on the Kai'Sa side, if I didn't have
that thermal beam, I'd be probably be
pretty worried because, you know, there
comes a point where like you just don't
have units in that deck big enough to
survive or, you know, many big enough to
survive multiple ballistas.
>> Yeah. The battlefield just becomes way
too hostile. You're just like, well, I
am just going to conquer eight times
this game because I'm not holding. It's
not happening.
>> Yeah. And also a immobilize over from
Malik, so he's going to have a little
extra runes to work with going into
these later turns.
Yeah, as I was looking at Malik's hand
as well, we had that second ballista,
but I I also recognize a disintegrate
and you know, this is one of those
proving grounds cards from the the Annie
deck that a lot of people don't really
expect to be very good in constructive
play. It's two for two. It's not that
bad. It's a fine little removal spell,
but not a lot of targets that it hits.
When you also have the uh iron
ballistas, it's going to be able to give
you that extra oomph to get over the
top. Having that two damage to add to
those other two damage abilities, right?
>> Or I guess did I say disintegrate? It's
the other one.
>> Incinerate.
>> Yeah, that's that's our bad. You know,
we'll take it on. Look,
>> the first one. Give me give me one more
and I got it all.
>> Annie's got a lot of abilities. They all
involve blasting fire. You know, they
have some pretty similar names. Can't
fault you on that one. But, you know,
it's interesting from Rishi's side of
the table here cuz, you know, he does
have that thermogenic beam, which is
going to be a really powerful play at
some point. But, he's kind of got to
think to himself, when do I want to use
this? Do I want to use it now and, you
know, sacrifice some tempo to get off
those ballistas off the board, or am I
okay with just feeding a few units in
and then like really catching the
ballistas on a surprise turn where Malik
might be really banking on using them to
kill a key unit or two? Yeah,
interesting for Mercy to be open to
stacking to try and actually get a hold
here. Yes, the ballista can only deal
with one of these uh two units, but
still kind of um maybe opening yourself
up to any other battlefield hate
specific uh spells like uh Skysplitter
probably not in this case yet because we
haven't don't have that Aurora yet. Um
but there are still just other options.
Something like a uh void seeker that
could very likely be in a Volibear deck.
>> True. I think what the the real
nightmare scenario would be if Mallex
had a dead bloom predator because then
he can use the ballistas to pick off one
and then just slam the dead bloom over
the top to just chomp down on the other.
>> Kind
of like this Frank. Uh that is the
nightmare scenario and it is happening
right now. We are in the nightmare even
though the nocturns were in the last
game as we do have the dead bloom
hitting the board into the dreaming
tree. Rishi is tapped out. So this is
just food for the fire, food for the
bear.
>> Yep. And you know, on top of that, just,
you know, kick them while they're down.
Mix is going to get a rune back off the
holy bear legend.
>> Yeah, he's no longer hibernating. The
runes are all here and he's ready to
actually come out. Uh, winter is over
for Malik.
>> Yeah. So, definitely that is that is the
risk from Rishi's end on letting those
kind of iron ballistas run wild and do
their thing. Uh, and now he's got a dead
bloom to deal with.
Oh,
>> and it looks like another piece of tech
from the side of Rishi, the mega mech
has been drawn. Sometimes just getting
these bigger units can help you deal
with the Auroraex of actually finding a
way to fight through. Helps your
stupifies actually be online some of
these other cards that you may be forced
to actually keep in uh and now you
actually have a big option. But
generally that can kind of help you
close out the game and look for a big
hold. Whereas when you've only been able
to score a few points early on it it can
get a lot less value. But I think the
big saving grace is going to be uh him
sitting on that thermo beam. So once
this Aurora hits the table, whenever it
does, he's immediately got the answer
>> for sure. And yeah, that's definitely
kind of the risk you take with mega mech
because, you know, it's not a lot of
texture. It's not going to accelerate.
It's just a giant ball of stats and
that's like a dangerous access to try to
fight Voly Bear on cuz that's sort of
what they excel at. But I agree, if you
can get it down early enough, you can
sort of threaten going toe-to-toe with
them, especially when you combine it
with some of the powerful shrink options
that Kai'Sa has.
Let's see what the Volibear has in the
tank now. Feels like no Aurora. I don't
see one in hand as he's flipping
through. I see a Magma Wororm though as
that is a very powerful tool to come off
of the Aurora and really enable the rest
of your deck. And notably, it is uh big
enough that it's not going to just get
falling start on the back row. So, you
can kind of stick it around if you have
the time in the game. And I'm curious if
this is actually a game where Malik has
created enough space that you can even
just kind of raw play out a magma worm
which is a very rare opportunity I think
uh in Riftbound where that feels like a
good play. Um and it kind of feels like
it might be okay here
>> for sure. Yeah. I mean you know he is a
little behind in points and you know
he's thinking right now. I'm sure he is
doing that calculation of can I take the
time off to get this magma worm down
because if I do that in the future all
my units are coming in ready and I'm
going to be able to catch back up real
quick.
There's the thing. Are there enough
spells in hand as well to maybe prevent
some conquers? That's the other option
you have to think about is can I just
hold up a bunch of runes uh or do I need
to actually, you know, try and continue
to establish? Um it looks like they're
just uh handling a kind of points
dispute here where um he conquered with
the dead bloom and then of course held
because the dead bloom was still there.
So you should be at two points. Um it
looks like they've got that corrected
now as Yeah. just going to be a magnorm.
>> Yeah. So that that Magna worm going to
be a real big threat for Rishi cuz now
you know normally you're used to the
Volibear deck being like powerful but
slow, but now it's going to be powerful
but fast.
>> Yeah. And it it really it really makes
that champ zone uh Volibear so much more
threatening as well cuz you often see
with these Volibear decks that it almost
never gets deployed. The game by the
time it gets deployed, the game is kind
of over because uh the Aurora has
brought out enough stuff and they
they've won or they're just too far
behind and they can't actually get it
out. But with a Magma on board, suddenly
this is a very threatening unit where
the on attack trigger of dealing the
five damage can also just actually
matter quite a bit where Voli Bear is
going to actually hit the board, come in
ready and send in for an attack. Yeah,
you know, Mal is putting an immense
amount of pressure on these battlefields
here. He's got the ballistas, he's got
the big units, he's got more that are
going to be coming in ready. And, you
know, it's going to be up to Rishi to
find a way to navigate this and try to
maintain his point lead without losing
too much material.
All right, let's look for what he is
willing to commit. Three points is kind
of the unfortunate spot. If he's at
four, you can consider just kind of like
moving in, go to six, and then look for
that big play later on. But also, you
don't want to overcommit this mega map.
You don't want to lose this thing for
free at any point in the game. And what
we just talked about with the Volibear
being able to come in, you know,
essentially accelerated, right? Comes in
ready from the magmaorm, this mega just
becomes food uh food for the blender
when that comes in. And even something
like a smoke screen actually doesn't
quite get there cuz it's a nine might
unit and the five damage comes through.
So that minus four actually still allows
it to trade with the mega mech.
>> Yeah, for sure. And you know, a lot of
decks in Riftbound, like they will allow
you to kind of keep chipping in as the
game goes on. Pick up a conquer here,
pick up a conquer there. But Volibear
actually one of the decks that can just
say like, "No, I'm just going to hold
these battlefields and there's going to
be nothing you can do about it.
>> You're done." Like that's that's all you
got. So, uh, it is going to be just the
the attempt at a double conquer, but
that is just a free skysplitter that
gets to come down because of the high
might of these units. Skysplitter
reduced cost based on the might of a a
unit that you have, the highest might
unit you've got. uh and just going to
deal five to a battlefield. Gets rid of
the hopeful break point found for Rishi.
Time warp found. So if he can get up to
six with some units on board, he can
kind of get there. But uh feels like
we're at that point where the volley
bear is really starting to hold you off
>> for sure. And yeah, I think he is.
Rishi, you know, is really going to have
to sort of find a way to engineer a game
plan around time warp where maybe he can
catch Malak off guard and, you know, get
in some conquers, go up to six, surprise
play that time warp, and hold to a win.
But, you know, with these ballistas and
all these big units on the table, that
might be tough.
>> Yeah. And just going to rip one now for
another look into the deck. Another
point just needing to buy time and
potentially even just to get this mega
mech out of there. So, it gets to score,
gets to run home, and you get to find a
new draw
>> for sure. You know, as you said, kind of
at this point, all of Rishi's hopes and
dreams are riding on this mega mech. So,
using this time warp as a way to just be
like, "Hey, I'm just going to take one
more point right now and maybe I'm going
to protect this mega mech to use again
later." It's actually pretty pretty
cool.
>> Yeah. And he does end up finding uh a
very important card for this situation,
which is going to be that Thousand
Tailed Watcher. Uh it's one of the ways
that you can actually try and crack
through a big Voybear board and
especially if you have the might to
follow up with something like a mega
mech. And so the question becomes, do
you want to start looking for that? As
he is just going to finally deploy that
thermmo beam to deal with the two
ballista. And I do wonder, I mean,
really the the uh the dark comedy of
this is the the the Aurora coming off
the top on this turn from from Malik on
the other side
>> for sure. But no, it's time to get rid
of those ballistas. And you know, maybe
you'll get punished with the Aurora, but
it hasn't been here yet. And you know,
sometimes you just got to be like, hey,
they don't have it. I'm going to cross
my fingers and hope they don't draw it
and just do the best I can.
>> Yeah, now a full development from Rishi,
which makes sense. You got the Thousand
Tailed Watcher in the bank. Now you just
need to get some might on the board. Be
ready to look for that score. But being
at five instead of six again kind of
very impactful being off cadence. You
don't just have a double conquer win
yet. You do have to get on there and
then you have to look for a potential
hold afterwards for sure. And I can't
tell. I'm not sure if Rishi has enough
runes to threaten another time warp. My
guess would be that he doesn't just yet.
So he's going to have to try to get this
done the fair way.
But you know, as you said, Thousand
Watcher is the one card that says, "Hey,
you're trying to pile a bunch of stats
into a battlefield to keep me out."
Watcher doesn't care how many there are.
They're all getting minus three and that
could really cut down the numbers on the
table.
>> I do see some cards being flicked and I
do believe there was an Aurora ripped
off the top here. The question is is can
it be deployed or is there something
else that needs to be done? And there it
is. So, my bad. Hey, my fault, Richie.
Hey, I'm sorry. I shouldn't have said
anything.
>> It's it's the caster curse, you know. It
just it persists through all games.
>> Oh, no. All right. My be that's on me.
That's on me, guys. Uh I'll take the
blame on that one.
>> Yeah. And you know, now from Rishi's
side of the table, you're just sitting
here and you're like, man, did I get
finessed? Was he just holding this
Aurora waiting for the thermo beam where
no reality it just came right off the
top
and there is going to be just the push
in from
the dead bloom predator. Go ahead and
get some points going. And now uh just
going to hold the Magorm back realizing,
hey, having stuff come in ready is
actually still very valuable. I think
especially when it comes to having the
Volibar in the champ zone. I think
that's what uh Mal is looking at. So is
going to be an Inivia and just the
decision is does this go and attempt to
hold Vile Mos or do I keep this at home
try and be able to deal with whatever
gets sent in.
>> Yeah. Know it is crazy how different the
texture of the game is when your
opponents on five versus six. You know
they're on six, you got to do everything
you can to stop them. They're on five.
you kind of have to do almost nothing
and you could really store up your
resources to to knock them out in a
following turn.
>> Yeah, the big thing is next turn I have
to deal with this. Next turn I have to
make sure that everything gets uh
protected. And I think one of the big
things that Rishi actually gets the
luxury of here is because uh on the
other side Mox didn't go into the
dreaming tree. You can just send a
sentry in there and develop further and
then look for that thousand tailed
watcher big push to try and end the
game. Yeah, it's definitely kind of like
that standoff where like, okay, who's
going to do it? Who's going to put their
cards in the middle and say, "This is
the time where I'm going to box you
out." And right now, both players kind
of just committing minimal necessary to
score their points.
>> And Watcher is going to be deployed now
though, instead wanting to get the dead
bloom off the board, get up to seven,
and look for the hold. Uh but you know
the magorm I think is going to make the
hold a little bit dubious being able to
have something enter ready especially
because you've got something on board
face up that you can play that can help
deal with some of these situations
>> for sure and definitely can't you know
underestimate the trigger from that
Anivvia either uh Mal is going to have a
lot to work with on his next turn.
Let's see how Rishi wants to do this.
>> Yeah going to be just a send in to Vile
Mos. Looks like a pretty big commitment
being lined up. Lot of mightite. Neither
of these going to need to worry about
trading, but if there is maybe something
like a skysplitter or any other kind of
answer to deal some damage, there could
be a trade opened up, but it looks like
nothing there. The other thing though is
Thousand Tail Watcher does do that minus
three uh everywhere. So, if there's a
follow-up spell from Rishi, you might be
able to actually deal with one of these
backline units and that can open up the
hold to be a lot better. with two runes
available. I think there was a falling
star in hand that may be deployed at the
end of this turn.
>> Yeah, you know, if a falling star comes
down from Rishi here, we might see this
board swing pretty drastically because
while the Aurora is a powerful play,
we're at a stage in the game where it's
probably not going to get too many
opportunities to do its thing. And if
the Magma worm is taken off the table,
all of a sudden the units aren't coming
in ready anymore and they might not be
able to threaten these battlefields at
all.
>> Yeah, and it looks like that is maybe
the target. Yeah, it is going to be the
magmaorm just double tap there. So
Anivvia is the only one that's going to
be able to run in straight away and the
minus three on everything there. I still
don't know that eight might is enough to
push over. In fact, I don't think it is.
So there's going to have to be an
additional thing to happen with this
Anivia in order for Mal to be able to
push in and actually find the win.
>> Yeah, but the the one upside for Mal
here, Rishi's runes are fully exhausted.
No real alternative cost coming out of
the Kaisa deck. So he kind of just has,
you know, what we call riftbound puzzle
game at this point. Can you figure out
what's on the board and find a way to
beat it?
>> Yeah, and I think one of the big things
is even if you can actually push through
the big stack on Viomos, there still is
the sentry on Dreaming Tree that is uh
his point is worth just as much as the
one at Vom that will also be the winning
point uh if he is able to hold on. So
being able to deal with both locations
now that that Magworm is gone, I think
is going to be a really tough task.
>> Yeah, Watchful Sentry, you know, holds
down the forts. He's far and wide and
might just be enough to get that last
point.
>> Here we go. Calculating.
>> The finger taps have been deployed.
Does feel like Rishi may have been able
to turn the corner and find that spot.
The ballista being taken out by the
thermo beam very impactful still because
a ballista being able to deal with the
sentry and then just having to worry
about the other side makes a massive
difference. Yeah. Know I think really
really smart of Rishi to make that call
and like hey there might be an Aurora
coming but the game is so late stage
that I'd rather just take out these
ballistas kind of get under the tempo
and I think I can beat an Aurora if it
comes at this point.
>> So let's see how this starts.
That's a cadre.
>> So this
>> so this is looking this is saying I need
skysplitter to win the game,
>> right? This is saying I don't really
have it right now. I'm going to see if I
could find it. And one thing to keep in
mind, there is always a dead bloom off
the top from the Aurora that could kind
of swing the math here.
>> So two draws.
>> See if they change anything.
>> So let's see. Right now is what an eight
and her trigger does three on the
attack.
>> Yeah. So yeah, even she even if she
wanted to go into Vioma's layer, she's
not big enough on the on her own, even
with the trigger to get the job done, I
don't think.
>> No, she can clear everything with a
skysplitter.
>> Yep.
>> Um I think she's one off, right? Because
you deal three to everything, four to
finish uh the thousand tail, five to
finish the uh mega mech, and then
there's one damage left needed on the
hopeful.
>> Yeah. So you do need
do need something like a skysplitter on
top of this, but he's sending it in.
And so there's there's two things. He
either has the skysplitter and he can
help deal with this or he can just clear
just enough that a dead bloom does end
up actually making the big difference
here. Uh because he can clear off the
mega mech and the hopeful with this
swing uh and just leave the watcher,
which if he finds the dead bloom off on
the top, he's he's not out of the game
>> for sure. If he finds a double amount of
off the top, it might all of a sudden
become really hard for Rishi to get it
back. It's it's been really cool to see
how much this match has swung back and
forth for both players.
Doing some calculations here
and it looks like that is no
skysplitter. They're going to damage
here. So, he's going to deal with those
two. And this is going to come down to
the dead bloom. And I'm I'm looking at
the hand. I'm like trying to see the
odds like no dead bloom in hand. It
looks like he's he's got one so far. So
the question is does he find it does
>> it is
>> big dead bloom coming down and that will
just clean up the thousand watcher as
you said Frank no runes available for
Ishy
>> and you know Mak just a a tried and
trueue professional here no reaction
from his end he's just like yeah dead
bloom dead bloom you're back that's what
I wanted to happen like obviously it was
there never doubted it for a second I
set this all up this is my grandmaster
plan and you know talking about those
swings uh Rishi tried to risk the hold
he so close to getting it, but Dead
Bloom just comes in to say not today.
>> Yeah. And for another way to claw back,
it looked like there was another thermob
beam in Rishy's hand to deal with the
Aurora, but Kadricken plus a dead bloom.
This is just so much might that has been
readded to the board where Rishi did so
much work to get ahead. He was able to
find the spot that was uh nearly perfect
for the win. Able to deal with the
Magma, able to deal with everything. The
Anivvia attack doesn't win, but there is
that one out of the Dead Bloom Predator.
And to be clear, there's not a ton of
units in these Aurora decks. So, two
Dead Blooms left in the deck. Probably
one or two Kadreans, maybe another
Enivia. There's a few other options, but
the odds are not horrible that you're
going to find it,
>> right? And Rishi's going to have to
figure this out real quick because if he
doesn't, the stats are just going to be
too overwhelming. And, you know, it's
thermal beam. you know, a nice option
for some of these gear. It does usually
take most of your turn, and I just don't
know if he can sacrifice that
development right now.
>> Yeah, instead it's just going to be a
watcher. Deal with a dead bloom straight
away, but this is just going to end up
getting eaten by a cadrean on the other
side. There's a big dragon ready for a
meal, and that's a tasty fox sitting in
Ball's layer
>> for sure. And although Rishi can't, you
know, win the game off this conquer, he
will get to pick up an extra card
instead. Might give him the tools he
needs to fight back and hold on and get
this last point.
>> Yeah. The question is, is there another
time warp that you can maybe set up for,
you know, moving in a small guy and then
time warping to win the game? Uh, are
there a Caththeon reigns where you can
pivot into a strategy where you actually
just deal with every unit from the
Aurora deck and actually kind of run
them out of ways to win the game where
you can finally end? There's a there's a
few options, but sabotage is going to
start from Malik to try and deal with
potentially the time warp or the uh uh
Athenian rain options
>> for sure. And, you know, all to play for
here. This is really anyone's game. Mak
going to take his time here to figure
out what he wants to get out of Rishi's
hand.
>> Double Darius is another way you can win
on 12 runes. Double Darius smoke screen.
I wonder if Mal is going to immediately
recognize that and say, "You know what?
Get rid of my Aurora. This smoke screen
cannot stick around."
>> For sure. Yeah. He's like, "You know
what? This Aurora, it saved me from
losing the game. It's done his job. If
you want to spend five energy and some
power to take it off the table, you can
do that. I'm going to take the smoke
screen and try to fight you in the
battlefields."
>> Yeah. now being well aware of the double
Darius out that Rishi has to be able to
get those two seven ready units out of
nowhere. Uh he does have the ability to
start thinking about how he can play
around it.
>> Yeah. And it looks like it might be time
for the fury volley bear to hit the
table here. Thinking about where we're
going to put it. What a friend.
>> Oh, you're a gamer.
>> Yeah, there's that really interesting
dynamic of like I can reinforce the
Kadrian battlefield here as Malik, but
then he would be sacrificing the ability
to contest the other battlefield on the
following turn. So, you know, do you
want to play not to lose and be like, I
really want to make sure you can't take
Bom's layer right now, but then he might
actually be at risk of losing to a hole
down the line.
>> Yeah, especially that double Darius
running in, right? That's going to be
able to take out Kendrick and leave a
Darius there. So if you've got nothing
at home that you're just not going to be
able to deal with it though hopefully
for uh Malik's side is now you've got
all these draws from the cavans. Maybe
you've actually found those guys
spplitters that you've been looking for.
>> Well, that was three catalysts in a row
there off the Aurora. That's pretty
funny. And another is going to hit the
table.
>> Yeah, now you can request that same uh
debacle. Do I put this into the vias or
uh do I put it at home? Cuz he's got the
cading at home now. So at least there's
consideration to oh, we can actually
just look for the hold.
>> Yeah. Uh, and you know, Malik, he's
really thinking here cuz he's saying, "I
know your hand. I know what you're
capable of right now. Sure, you're going
to have, you know, a draw step or two if
you get an extra conquer, but I think I
can beat what you've got. I'm going to
put these in the base and make sure I
can use them next turn as I need to."
And
>> that's retreat is not going to be enough
certainly. So it is just that double
Darius and he's just going to scoop not
having a good way to answer especially
because the reinforcements that'll come
in on this next turn and that's going to
be the volley bear piloted by Floren
Christian Logan or Mal here taking that
first win here at the Houston regional
qualifier. Amazing to see some of these
niche decks find the wins especially
into the the big bad into Kai'Sa. I know
Voly Bear historically has been used as
a hey this kind of has a good match up
into Kaisa. might be a counter, but
slowly people kind of eroded that
thought. They thought, you know what, in
the end of the day, it doesn't feel that
favored. But, you know, Floren here
showing us, hey, the Voli Bear can still
get it done.
>> Yeah, for sure. And just really
impressive play from both players. You
know, Rishi kind of being like, I'm
going to make you have it. I'm going to
go for this hold. But, you know, the
dead bloom predator sometimes just comes
off the top when you need it. And that's
the that's the lottery of playing
Aurora. And sometimes it's just your
day.
>> Yeah, it's so big to be able to find
that. you know, he had a game buffer to
be able to go there, but I think he's
very happy to finish that in two instead
of having to go to a game three for
that. I don't know. I maybe the Voli
Bear gets to make a deep run, but I
think that's uh he's somebody we're
going to want to watch for that um the
medal card, the best of prizing for the
Voli Bear throughout the day
>> for sure.
>> And uh with that, I mean, we will have
plenty more matches coming up, round two
soon enough. So, don't go anywhere.
We'll be back with more Riftbound action
right after this.
Excuse
me, sir.
Any hot takes for this weekend?
>> I'll take Kai'Sa might do well.
>> Might
>> might. It might. It might might get
squeezed one in there in top eight
perhaps, but also I think that Kai'Sa is
not going to be the most represented in
top eight.
>> Love that take. Thank you so much.
Excuse me. Excuse me, both of you. Uh
any hot takes for the tournament this
weekend?
Victor's a good deck. I'm a Victor
player.
>> Love it. I think Annie will win.
>> Annie winning the whole thing. Love the
thing. Thank you so much.
>> Excuse me, Trick.
>> Yeah.
>> Big fan, by the way. Uh, do you have any
hot takes for the regional qualifier
this weekend?
>> Uh, no.
>> So, what what's your cold take?
>> Uh, my cold take is that it's going to
be a fantastic event. I'm super excited.
Fans are excited. And, uh, my hot take
actually is that I think Ari is going to
take it down.
>> I love Ari so much. Thank you so much,
Turkey. Bet. Excuse me, sir.
>> Do you have any hot takes for the the
tournament this weekend?
>> Awesome. It's awesome.
>> Going to be awesome. Yeah. What do you
think's going to win?
>> Uh Kaisa or Master Y.
>> Master Y. What kind of Master Y deck?
>> Uh mid-range.
>> Mid-range. Love it. Thank you so much.
>> Oh, the judges. Let's have the judges.
>> Come here.
>> Let's go. Excuse me, fellow judge staff.
>> I would like to know if you have any hot
takes for the regional this weekend. I'm
kind of nervous tomorrow because we have
a lot of question about conquering the
battlefields in the same turn. So, I
hope tomorrow doesn't happen a lot, but
it will happens. I know it will happens.
>> Hey, I think the the rules and learning
all that stuff for Riftbound is a hard
thing to do and that's why we have
professionals like yourself doing it
this weekend. Thanks so much.
>> Excuse me, you two. I know you're in the
middle and competing in a rigorous game
of Riftbound, but I have a question for
you. Any hot takes for the regional this
weekend?
>> I would just say just a lot of Kaisa
players if anything. I mean I I won't be
surprised if Annie takes it though
because I mean Annie is a really hot a
hot deck right now going
>> hot take from you sir
>> is we're going to see a pretty diverse
top 64. It's not going to be like 50 60%
Kaiso hopefully. So yeah.
>> Yeah. I think the sets and all the
Annies are going to come out of the
woodwork like you guys said. Thanks so
much guys.
>> Excuse me. Excuse me sir. Do you have
any hot takes for the regional qualifier
this weekend?
>> Uh Victor Best. Victor Best, you heard
it right here.
>> Do you have any hot takes for the
regional qualifier this weekend?
>> Hot takes. Um, it's gonna be packed.
>> That more than the initial number
because we had some
>> Yeah, we had a very big uh weight list.
I think it's over 2,000 players.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah. And uh it's going to be a packed
regional.
>> So then here's my hot take question I
want to ask you. Do you think the next
one could potentially be twice the size?
>> Wow. That's a the million-dollar
question.
>> Yeah,
>> you'll you'll find out over the coming
weeks.
>> Absolutely. Thanks so much, Paul.
>> Excuse me, gentlemen. I know you just
started another riveting game of 2v2
here, but I want to ask a couple of
questions. Do you have any hot takes for
the regional qualifier this weekend?
>> Kaisa is still going to be the best.
>> That's not a hot take. Come on. What do
you think? Give me one legend.
>> Teeu.
>> Teemo.
>> Hot hot hot take.
>> I think we'll see one Lux in top 32.
>> Is it you?
>> All right. All right. Thanks so much,
y'all.
>> Do you have any hot takes for the
regional qualifier this weekend?
>> Uh,
>> a hot take. Like, what do you think? You
know, out of the woodwork?
>> Uh, Lux is good.
>> Wow. Another Lux one.
>> Excuse me. Excuse me, sir. Sir, uh, sir,
they might I I would like to know, do
you have any hot takes for the regional
qualifier this weekend?
>> I literally can't believe you're doing
this right now.
That's a That's a great hot take. Thank
you so much.
>> Welcome back to the Houston Regional
Qualifier. I'm Kasanova joined by Frank
Scarren and we just had an amazing first
round of action being able to see Aasuo
take down a Garen, the might of Damasia
and then also getting that Volibear game
coming through. the dead bloom off of
the top from that Aurora from the top
rope being able to take that win over
AISA.
>> Yeah. No, that was awesome. I mean, if
that's what round one has to bring, I
just I can't wait to see what else we've
got down the pipe.
>> Well, let's uh let's jump straight into
that round two as we do have Frodan. We
got to see his Leona early on. Kind of
that little deck tech at the start of
the day. Now, we're going to get to see
it in action going up against Dizzy on
Annie Dark Child. Dizzy actually able to
top eight in uh in Georgia recently at
the 10k there with this Annie list and
going up against Dan playing that Leona
and uh you know Frodan being able to
find the win in that first round as
well.
>> Yeah know I think this is going to be
really cool you know we saw from that
deck tech Froden really kind of knows
the ins and out of his Leyona strategy
and it's just going to see it's going to
be cool to see him you know kind of put
it to work and see what he can do with
it. Yeah, and it's a great test to kick
things off, right, to see if the Leona
is going to do well enough into some of
these top tier Annie players with Dizzy
having that success as early as just a
few weeks ago for sure. And you know,
Leona has some really strong options
here. Annie's bread and butter, the Vi
Ride the Wind, you actually have some
stuns that can shut that down in the way
some other decks can't.
>> Yeah, you have tons of options actually.
You've got the rune prison to stun. You
can play hidden blade to just kill the
Vi and you can defy the ride the wind.
So being in both of the two colors that
actually can kind of deal with Video
give that big advantage for Leona. As we
do jump into this first game, we do have
Monastery of Herana for Frodan on the
Leona side. That is going to allow you
to spend a buff when you conquer there
to draw a card. So you can trade the
buffs that you're generating with the
stuns for more cards and more gas in
your hand. And on the other side, we
talked about this a little bit at the
beginning of the day. We alluded to it,
the Zon Warren's game one Annie with the
scrap heaps in the deck so that you can
get so much extra card draw and then you
board it out for the second game and it
has been so powerful. I think Annie's
game one is one of the most powerful in
the entire game of Riftbound currently
>> for sure. And you know, we see each
player start off with an iconic porro, a
pouty porro, and a stard. Yeah, it's
it's really cool to see that kind of
sideboarding dynamic where you can
literally go in and you be like, I'm
going to play Zo Warren in the first
game, so I know I can discard these
scrap heaps, get a ton of value, and
then later when I don't have access to
the warren, I can just take them out for
different cards. And I think that's some
really innovative deck building we've
been seeing.
>> Yeah. And out the gates, it is just
going to be Frod getting that conquer,
getting the stalwart porro in place uh
with its shield so it can be a three and
then just immediately, this is the
classic Leona. Hey, turn two, I play
determined. That is the game plan for
these Leona decks. There is nothing more
powerful for this Leona legend to do
than to play Leona Determinina on turn
two. And it's real nice that you get to
have her in that champ.
>> Yeah, for sure. You are definitely the
Leyona expert here. So, you know, I'm
going to I'm going to defer to you a
little bit. Um, when you're in the Leona
state like Frodan is, are you are you
aggressive? Are you mid-range? Are you
trying to go long? What are you looking
to do?
>> So, what I know about Dan is he he plays
the Leona a little bit differently
because he tried to build to be a little
better into Kai'Sa. So, he's a lot more
aggressive. He's a lot more proactive, a
lot more of these low to the ground
units to help get on board early. But
the core game plan of your determined
actually remains the same no matter
which version of Leona that you want to
play because you like to have her sit in
the back row and kind of ask your
opponent, do you want to come into a
battlefield? If you do, are you going to
be able to stop me from just going in
when I have open runes to conquer with
this Leona? Because your unit's going to
be stunned. You're not trading back. No
matter what buffs you have, if I can
buff over, I'm not going to trade. I'm
just going to take your unit down.
>> For sure. Some sometimes the threat of
the Leyona is greater than the Leona
itself.
>> Yeah, especially under these aggro decks
that often do not have an answer to you.
And it is just saying, hey, I have to
give up material for this point. And
does it get to a critical mass where
I've given up too much material and now
the Leona completely holds and I can't
stop them.
>> Okay, we're going to see an early VI
from Dizzy here.
Yeah, that's the the nice thing about Vi
on this Zand Warren's game is some of
these early Vis, especially if you get
an extra copy, you can hold on to one
for VI ride the wind, but early stages,
you'll still have some fodder to make
some really awkward break points for
your opponent to deal with. And while
stuns are really impactful against the
VI, and you get to kind of blank all of
the cards that were recycled that turn,
usually it's just going to bounce the Vi
back home and she'll still have another
opportunity if you're able to fill that
trash again.
>> For sure. It's going to be really
interesting to see how Dizzy navigates
around these stuns and counters that the
Leona deck can bring. Might not be a
matchup he's as familiar with. He might
be doing some of this on the fly, but
you know, he's a great player and I'm
excited to see what he can do.
>> Yeah. So, I will say pouty porro pretty
annoying for Leon to determine having
that deflect means you'd have to pay it
in order to get the stun. One thing in
the rules change though is you can
actually decline to pay the uh deflect
cost and not stun the Porro, which is a
potential thing that Frodan can consider
that he might want to do here.
>> Yeah, a little insight from the design
side. We didn't want deflect to be like
a trigger that could be missed. So, we
kind of baked it in as an additional
cost. And at first, we said like, hey,
you just have to pay that. You don't get
the choice. But we kind of found a nice
middle ground where it's still not a
trigger, but you can still decline and
be like, I don't want to recycle a rune.
I'm not just I'm just not going to put
my ability on the chain. So, it looks
like Dan is going to pay that deflect
cost though. So, he will get the stun.
He will get this Leona trigger to come
through.
>> Yeah. And an interesting play from Dan.
I imagine he's thinking, "Hey, if
there's a void seeker, if there's a hex
tech ray, I don't want my Leyona to die
necessarily easily, so I'm going to stun
it even to just prevent two damage."
>> Yep,
>> that's big. We'll see what Dizzy decides
to do. It looks like they have paid the
cost, but they're still in reactions on
the stun before it comes down because
when you decide the target, you have to
pay it and then it'll look to resolve.
Looks like he is going to get the stun.
Dan, show the camera the stun. Putting
it onto the Porro. We love to see it.
>> Yeah. And you know, my guess here is
that Froden probably has um maybe a
little bit extra to back this up as
well, but the buff on the Leyona does
just put her out of range of kind of any
single card that Dizzy could have. Yeah,
one of the things we saw in hand was the
on guard which is showing more of that
kind of proactive game plan that he is
going for uh by being able to utilize
the lowerc cost units a little bit more
effectively with that on guard not
having to rely on the bigger units to
come down as that is just going to be a
fight or flight and there's no immediate
answer that Dan's got in hand. He would
be looking for a defy as a way to deal
with this. So Dizzy is going to just
say, "Hey, I'll trade a card for a point
here." Um and I I get a rune out of it
because you've stunned my pora
>> for And that's that's a nice move from
Dizzy. That's kind of the one angle that
Frodan's plan didn't cover. And it's
like you're not going to kill my Leona,
but you are going to push her back to
base, prevent that point. And as you
said, he did have to already pay that
deflect cost. And you know, going down a
rune could be pretty critical in these
early turns.
>> Yeah. And that is one of those knowledge
checks, too, where I think, you know,
some amount of players are probably not
going to know that they can kind of not
pay this deflect cost. And, you know, I
know that Frodan's relatively new to the
game, but he was really excited about it
and dove in. So, I'm not surprised if he
does know or if he doesn't. It's just
one of those kind of niche interactions
that a lot of players are going to be
slowly picking up over the weekend
>> for sure. So now Fredan thinking about
what he can do to follow up here now
that he's gotten boxed out of Zoan
Warren.
>> Yeah, considering if he's just going to
keep the poro there, but he is just
going to go ahead. He had that one rune
uh energy floating from when he did pay
the deflect cost. So just going to pay
two more. Go ahead and stun the Vi. This
is just to get a buff probably over to
the Porro. The question for me though is
do you want to retreat this porro
because of the VI or because of the fact
that uh we did kind of see a glimpse of
that hand. A lot of combat tricks are
there. Um do you want to try and maybe
bait this VI in and see if you can
actually you know take out one of
Dizzy's units?
>> Yeah and for sure definitely some of the
push and pull when playing against Annie
is like Vi is probably going to get you
at some point and you just want to
mitigate how bad she gets you. So, I
could totally see Frodan being like,
"Hey, I'm just going to let this porro
go to Vi so I have the opportunity to
kill her before she gets too out of
hand."
>> We'll see how this starts. That might
just be a void seeker as we do see that
one red recycled. And there it is onto
the Poros. And now a decision has to be
made as to how much are you going to try
and defend this as four damage is coming
into the three might currently. Ong
guard works, but then you're down to a
single rune
>> for sure. And not to mention at that
point, you know, the damage is going to
stick around. So, it might even be
easier to finish that porro off, but
we're going to see a discipline here.
>> So, an attempt to kind of fight over
this as the Aporo is now going to be up
to five. Uh, it'll take the the four
damage.
>> Oh, as Dan reached for the wrong deck.
So, I think the judges are just going to
shuffle the rune deck to make sure that
there's no information gain there. Um,
easy stick to make. You got two decks.
Draw a card. accidentally reaching for
the wrong one.
>> Yeah. And definitely don't want to, you
know, underplay the pressure of being on
camera. You know, sometimes, you know,
obviously Frodo and a seasoned
professional, but sometimes you just
reach for the wrong deck, especially
when you haven't gotten so many reps in.
>> This is also notably his first uh
physical TCG. I talked to him, you know,
when I had that interview with him. I
was asking him a little bit about it
because, you know, he has that big
Hearthstone background and, you know,
he's played a ton of TFT, he's played
some card games in the past, but never
won physically. So he was like, "Yeah,
I'm still kind of learning the dexterity
of actually just kind of doing all of
the actions myself." Um, and he he said
he felt pretty good about it, but it's
still just like, you know, getting some
of that rust off. And yeah, being on
camera adds that extra element of
pressure.
>> For sure. Yeah, definitely. Like, you
know, back back in my competing days on
camera a ton, but the the pressure
really never goes away. No matter how
many times you've done it, when you
first sit down, you really feel it. But,
um, you know, Frodan, I think he's going
to fight through it. And, you know,
going to we're going to see a really
good match here. Yeah, we also see uh
Disney decides to bring back that pouty
porro now. Uh opening up Z warren to be
reconquered to get more of those on
Warren triggers is something you really
want out of this Annie deck early on.
And wow, even a second VI, you know, I
was talking about how I like when you
play one of the VI's early when you've
got multiple copies. Uh but playing both
of them out early instead of actually
holding one back. Yeah, it's interesting
because it does set up a nice board for
Dizzy where he's like, "Okay, you know,
if you if both of these vis are
threatening you, I might be able to
recycle to like pump one minimally, get
you to use your stun there, but then the
second VI is just going to come in and
finish the job." So, there there's some
good merit to having two on the table.
>> Yeah, if I'm throw down, I'm pretty
happy with how this turn played out,
though. My Porro gets to live. Uh, I get
to score up to three and I have an extra
unit at home, so I can kind of keep my
Leona back. You could even just score
with the uh shield bearer and be willing
to sacrifice it. And now you've got
Leona to say, "Hey, uh I'm actually up
in points." Dizzy, if you'd like to
commit to a battlefield, here's my Leona
determined. I would like to stun you and
take it from you.
>> Yeah, for sure. And you know, some some
legends, you know, you got to exhaust to
do their thing. One big advantage that
Radiant Dawn has is as many times as you
can stun, that's how many buffs you're
getting. And Frodan's really been taking
full advantage of that so far to really
just buff up his whole team.
Yeah, you see him shaking his head. He
keeps reaching for the wrong deck for
for the draw, just kind of getting
through that that dexterity, the you
know, early game jitters of the
tournament. Um, but he's able to end up
dropping that is a sunlit guardian, I
believe, right? Uh um this is another
card that Dan plays that uh I personally
in my Leonardo decks haven't, but this
is part of the lower to the ground
strategy that he likes. And he likes to
kind of get the poro in, get the
sunlight guardian down, look for those
kind of quick early holds uh with more
aggressive units instead of like the the
other Sona versions that we've seen some
other players playing. Like I've really
enjoyed the Sona version where you're
trying to play more around those
mid-range units and play around the
Leona getting in establishing a Sona and
then following up with the last spells.
So, this is more bunch of units, get
some buffs, and then use Kingpin as your
big kind of like lynchpin uh unit in the
deck,
>> for sure. And you know, Sunlight
Guardian uh if you can get it into a
battlefield and get that shield going,
it is a lot of stats for the energy
cost. And especially, you know, you
throw a buff on it, all of a sudden that
thing's getting pretty huge.
>> Yeah. And the tank keyword, I think,
cannot be uh understated. I think that's
one of the reasons that lecturing Yortle
was like a slept on card for a while,
but you're like, "Oh, I draw a card and
also this Tumite has tank so I can
actually protect some of my more
important units in in combat." And I
think uh Sunlight Guardian has that same
kind of effect with that tank keyword.
>> All right, Pouty Porro moving into Zon
Warren trying to contest and is going to
take a trade.
>> Makes sense as now the Kaisa is going to
come down accelerated. Dizzy going to go
for the draw plus the rumage from the
Zon Warren as this is kind of the uh the
big thing that Annie loves to do. She
loves to be able to cycle through the
deck, find the exact pieces that she
needs to put together. This is an
aggressive deck that does play this kind
of combo uh oriented play style. There's
not a ton of true combo decks in
Riftbound currently, but Annie has a lot
of small combos that you'll play
throughout the game
>> for sure. And you know, Annie really has
that advantage where she gets to play
the game on both turns always. She can
use all her runes on her turn, but then
when you go to the end of your turn, you
get to ready too and still play the game
on your opponent's turn as well. And
Dizzy clearly going to use that here to
just keep the pressure on, make sure
he's scoring some points, but also
having interaction to fight back on the
other side. All right. And I think Dizzy
just asking if he's allowed to to
shortcut the VI uh instead of having to
one by one put the cards at the bottom
of the deck. So, he's selecting it looks
like four here to push one of these vies
up to seven.
And I imagine after doing that, it's
going to be Vi's time to go in.
>> Vi into the stalwart porro. That is
going to go up to a four already on
defense into seven. And we know there's
a call the glory in hand, but also this
face breaker which you can just say, you
know what, this combat just doesn't
happen really, and I'm going to get a
buff to go to my set. And we'll see if
he remembers this trigger here from
Radiant Dawn as that stun comes through
to get that buff onto set cuz you
definitely don't want to miss that. That
is such an important buff as it's a plus
two for set. As Kingpin has the text
that when friendly units uh uh at his
location have a buff, he also gets a
plus one.
>> Absolutely. And Frodan, you know, the
way we saw his deck earlier, the way
he's built it, he's really kind of
maximizing on a lot of these stun
options. And Face Breaker, maybe not a
card every list would play, but you
know, working really great for him here.
And now this is going to kind of come
back to bite Frodan a little bit with
the face breaker because now this VI
comes in uh and the Porro is still
stunned from the face breaker. Uh so it
won't actually be able to even look for
a trade if he decides to try and buff it
up with something like the call to
glory.
>> Yeah. And this is this is kind of what
that threat of having the two vises.
It's like went in with the first one,
didn't work, it got stunned, but now
here comes the second one.
>> Yeah. And I see this VI is this VI at
seven? So, this poor would just get
buffed to seven here.
>> Uh,
>> from the call to glory.
>> It's a great question.
>> Are they just bouncing off?
Just want to make sure there's some
clarity here. Visually, it looks like to
me that there was one more recycle for
this one and then pumped up to seven.
Maybe I think maybe Dan might have
missed this as far as the uh how big
that VI actually was going to be. plays
the call to glory out and it looks like
he is just going to end up losing this
portal and loses that call to glory
which is definitely big especially with
kind of missing out on that uh radiant
dawn trigger earlier. Now he's also down
a buff on his set.
>> Yeah. Uh definitely a couple rough turn
of events for Frodan. Dizzy using his
vise extremely well, but Frodan still
has some powerful units in the base and
it's going to be interesting to see if
he can recover from that slight error
and fight back.
>> Yeah, and he definitely has the might to
do so. Right. Even without that buff,
he's going to get one from the uh the
Radiant Dawn running in. Um the VI is
not going to be able to continue to be
buffed up. I believe Dizzy has a flash,
so I think maybe one of the more likely
things to occur on this turret is we are
just going to see Frodan try and run in
and that first stun gets reacted to by a
flash as the might values are already
just in Froden's favor.
>> Yeah, and one thing that Dizzy is going
to have to keep in mind here is he did
just recycle a lot of cards out of his
trash to get these buys able to contest
Froden's units. So, he's got to make
sure he can keep that card flow going in
the trash. The Vise can remain really
strong threats.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think the other big thing
to look at is even though that sequence
of events was pretty tragic for Frodan,
losing a lot of value, uh he's still
ahead on points. He's it's four to four,
but he has the turn. He has the ability
to go try and score two more points
here. So, he's just going to push in
determined. And if he can get up to six
points, it's now he's threatening to
just kind of win the game if he's able
to hold this fistful of runes and be
able to stop this. As as expected,
flash, deny the stun, so you're going to
get away from a buff. But looking at
Frodan's hand, that's a pair of rune
prisons, there's if he can just keep all
of these runes and get set and Leona on
board. There's kind of a world that he
just holds both and wins the game.
>> Yeah. I know that's a great call out
because if he can reach that six point
threshold, that's really kind of the
sweet spot where you want to be to make
sure that you can just threatening
threaten ending the game first.
>> Yeah, looks like the judge is clarifying
that that stun will not go through. It
does say here on Leona, so if you do
flash away, not going to end up getting
stunned. So no buff comes through from
Radiant Dawn. Good counter play to Leona
to try and be able to dodge that. But I
think it was a great call out, Frank,
that this trash is just getting thin.
And so while Dizzy can try and rebuild
it a little bit by playing some cards on
this next turn, it might not be enough
for the Vise to actually have enough
juice, especially cuz we know there's a
pair of rune prisons,
>> right? And Dizzy is going to have to
commit enough cards from the trash to
even get Frodan to use his stuns in the
first place and he might just run out.
>> Yeah. So now Frodan considering what he
should dump. I saw Sunlight Guardian and
I feel like yes, I love this from throw
that away. Grab another card. Maybe you
just get another spell that works really
well with your hand. Looks like Zona's
hourglass. That's nice. I think being
able to just play that at home if you
still have the runes to play what looks
to be an ong guard and two rune prisons.
If you hold up five runes here, I think
it's beautiful. Uh you're going to
really cause this to be difficult for
Dizzy to deal with. And even here, just
going to hide the zas because not much
opportunity cost for hiding it versus
playing it. You can always just get that
reveal out.
>> Definitely. And you know, this is this
is definitely the stage of the game
where Annie would be like, "Okay, this
is exactly where I want to be. I've got
my vise. I'm closing in on points." But
again, I just really have to stress how
well the stuns can manage things cuz
even if you have the rider ride the
wind, it's still stunned. It is still
not going to be able to go in, kill the
unit, and take the battlefield.
>> And speaking of that, Ride the Wind just
grabbed off the top of the deck. Fighter
flight though, this is a good answer.
This will just prevent this double hold
guaranteed. Um but uh Frodan can respond
with this Zona's hourglass. Easy enough.
He can just flip that um before the
Leona leaves. Uh and so he'll still have
that to help out if the set ends up
getting you know taken down. And because
he's ahead with the six versus four
realistically having set and Leona back
home, you're going to have a really good
opportunity to just double conquer
again.
>> Yeah. And really good use of of his
cards by Dizzy here. He says, "Hey, I'm
going to use the flash to defend my
units and I'm going to use the fighter
flight to push yours out." Kind of just
maximizing everything he can do with the
chaos tricks.
>> That's a conquer from Kaiso Survivor. A
card drawn.
>> And just looking at the options, I mean,
this is a tough spot for Annie. You
you're recognizing that, hey, my deck's
not very good at holding. Uh so looking
at uh a set kingpin and a Leona
determined as the potential attackers,
it's very hard to consider how you can
hold against it, especially a deck that
is green and yellow. They're going to
have pumps in some way, shape, or form
or even worse, they might just have a
kill spell and they might just be able
to get rid of your unit. And as Annie,
there's not a lot of recourse. you can
try and ride the wind something in after
the fact and try and you know either
reconquer or just at least help uh
fortify one side that maybe uh Froden
will overextend into but it's going to
be kind of tough as we do see now Annie
deployed to just grab a cleave to try
and push this V over the top of Kingpin
and we know rune prison easy answer to
this
>> definitely and you know Disney's got to
have it on the radar too you know he
just watched Frodan discard a unit and
then pass the turn with six runes
available. So that is signaling, hey,
there's going to be some interaction
here and Dizzy's got to find his way to
pace around it while still scoring some
points.
>> So easy rune prison. See the Radiant
Dawn trigger to get a buff probably on
just kingpin. Just make it a seven. Make
things really difficult for Dizzy,
especially now that everything was given
to that first VI. So now the second VI
can only be a three. And from Dizzy's
side, this makes sense. Try and
reinforce. don't let Leona run in and
actually get the conquer and end the
game for free. Uh but that is only seven
on defense and that is just one pump
spell that can help put you over the
top.
>> Yeah, Dizzy going to have to try to use
his tricks a little more defensively
here which as you mentioned is really
not how Annie wants to use them. But
sometimes you have to and a fighter
flight on defense can be just as good as
a fighter flight on offense.
>> Yeah. And we see that on guard. So
there's at least one pump for the
determined and even just out the gates
being able to run in and clear away some
of the units here. But also third rune
prison found off the draw. There's
always a consideration to even just look
for the hold uh and go from seven to
eight in that way if you don't feel like
you can quite push over here as it is
just going to start with a stun from the
Leona determined. Yeah, definitely one
of the weaknesses of stuns is they don't
actually help you take the battlefield.
They just make your unit safer. So the
Leona isn't going to necessarily be big
enough to get the full conquer here
unless Frodan goes for something like an
on guard. We see
>> yeah up to seven. So seven into seven,
but Leona won't die because of the stun
onto what I assume is the Kai'Sa at this
point.
And it is going to be a ride the wind.
Probably just going home try and build
up a big enough base or to reinforce.
>> Well, I think he I think he has to
reinforce here because if he gives this
battlefield up to Frod, this will be his
conquer for the eighth point.
>> Yep. So does reinforce. Good call out.
That is just going to be another plus
three. And I think Frodan for this
though that is just six into his seven.
So even though he won't be able to
conquer, he doesn't have to actually
commit anything else,
>> right? I doubt that, you know, Dizzy is
happy with this play, but it is better
than losing. That I can promise.
>> Yeah, technically not over. So there you
go. Um as still though that double rune
prison hand looks pretty disastrous for
the side of Annie to be able to have to
contend with these. Uh you know, rune
prison being such a great card to deal
with that. You call it out at the very
start of the game and being able to stun
the VI when it comes in. And we actually
just saw it over and over and over again
because Dizzy's game plan kind of
devolved into, well, I've just got a
bunch of V's here and a little bit of
trash, so we'll just kind of try and
incrementally use it to get above your
might totals. And there's always a stun.
There was always an answer.
>> Yep. And yeah, Frodan doing a great job
of keeping the stuns rolling, stopping
Dizzy from just going crazy and doing
whatever he wants, taking some of his
units off the table. And you know that
set is still in Z warren. And if he's
there next Frodan's turn, that's game
over.
>> Dizzy, you know, he's going to see what
he can do though. Annie's got a ton of
tricks. You know, it's the kind of deck
where like it's kind of never out of the
game. Even when you think like, oh,
there's nothing Annie can do here. They
sometimes always just find a way.
>> Yeah, I think I saw a Trifarian picked
up and I think he's also got a cleave.
So, you know, Darius cleave is quite
good, right? That's 10. But you don't
want to put 10 all on one unit when
you're going up against Leona. You might
just get stunned away. And then on top
of that, there's this additional kind of
four might that can be given to uh to
the Vi if you just decide to kind of use
it straight away. And we're looking at
Dizzy right now. Does actually do it was
plus three. Um and if you cast, you
know, maybe the cleave, you can then
also send that to the bottom and give
another might over to the Vi
>> for sure.
>> The Darius come in.
>> Yep. And one of the great things about
Vi is she doesn't always need Ry the
Wind. She just has ganking. Yeah.
>> So maybe Set's not as safe as we
thought.
>> All right, Darius cast. It looks like he
pointed at the Darius for the cleave
though. So this is just going to be 10
might that will be able to be taken away
by just one stun. He is just going to
start with just the Darius in. And I
think this is just going to be an easy
response and rebuttal from uh Frodan to
just kind of go for yet another rune
prison.
>> Yeah, the stun the stuns just keep
coming out of Leona, but you know that's
kind of what she does.
All right, Dizzy still has a problem to
solve.
>> Vi positioned for the gank. Annie can
join in on the fight.
>> Yeah, he's got seven might from Kingpin.
Looks like Frod just explaining exactly
how that works. Uh can be kind of
confusing when you first read Kingpin.
You might think, oh, it shouldn't get
the plus one from itself, but it is in
fact a friendly unit of itself. though
will get that plus one uh from its own
ability making buffs just super
effective on uh Kingpin in doing double
duty as we do send in both the Annie and
the Vi and guess what rune prison number
three coming through for Frodan stun the
Vi and I think Dizzy with just one rune
left is going to be like all right well
game two
>> yeah you know Dizzy kind of just saying
all right I've lost the ability to play
around anything I just have to shove my
units in and pray you don't have it but
Froden says hey I've got It puts the
rune prison on the table and he's going
to take the first game after a shaky
start, too. Really impressive his
ability to kind of just like stay calm,
grind through, do what he does best and
secure that win.
>> Yeah, and you saw him shaking it off,
right? There's some some camera jitters.
He's shaking his head as he like reaches
for the wrong deck on the gra uh the
draw. Like clearly it's just like not
meaning to do any of this. Uh and then
now it's going to get shifted back
around where he does have a game two
coming in and actually an adjustment uh
going to Hillock for this game two. And
then also we've got green Leona. Leon is
zealot in the champion zone. So not the
normal turn two determined necessarily,
but against a very fast deck having kind
of this accelerate unit uh pseudo
accelerate where Zealot enters ready
when your opponent is within three
points of the victory score. Uh you've
kind of got a way to answer if Annie
really gets ahead on board.
>> Yeah. Know that's really interesting too
because you know we see the arena's
greatest here from Dizzy. Great
battlefield option when you know you're
going to be going first. So the odds
that he gets to that threshold for K
Leona are pretty high. That's a that's a
heads up change. You know, that's one
thing that I was like I was really
excited to see like, oh, are players
going to do the thing? Are they going to
change their chosen champion in between
games during sideboard? And I feel like
you don't see it too often, but really
excited to see Frodan use it here.
>> As we do have,
>> as you said, Arena's greatest for Dizzy,
so the extra point there. And then on
the other side, Windswept Hillock. This
is going to be that ganking uh that
comes through for Frodan. Um this is one
this is a battlefield that I've gone
back and forth in uh with Leona. There's
a lot of match ups where it feels great.
Uh you get your determined onto a
battlefield and then sometimes Leona has
a little issue with pivoting around. Uh
but the ganking there lets you kind of
run to the other side. The problem that
can arise that I've found are purple
matchups. Uh where Annie sometimes just
says sneaky deckhand in your hillock and
then conquers and you're just very far
behind. Um, but we'll see with Frodan's
more aggressive approach if this hill
ends up being even more helpful against
the purple match up than not as I think
the judge call is about arena's greatest
on Frodan's turn.
>> Yeah, you know, so looking here, we see
Frodan's points at zero. He's channeled
his runes. Uh, the arena's greatest is a
beginning phase trigger. It looks like
he might have unfortunately missed that.
Oh, maybe not. Oh, there's his point.
Okay, but
>> yeah, I definitely hear what you're
saying. I feel like Hillix's one of
those battlefields when you bring it and
you're using it, you're like, "This is
great." And when your opponent uses it
against you, you're like, "That's
cheating."
>> Like, "Wait, no, that's my battlefield.
>> My battlefield."
>> Yeah, exactly. I It's It's the one
Battlefield I've really gone back and
forth in the deck where, you know,
you've got the You've got some games
where like, "Yeah, this is this is the
best thing in the world. This is the
best battlefield." And sometimes it is a
pain as we do just have this start from
Dizzy as he will send the traveling
merchant into the hill and say, "You
know what? If I'm able to stick around
in this, I am going to conquer again on
the next turn." Going over to the
arena's greatest.
>> Yeah. Very very interesting because if
Frodan did miss that trigger, it's kind
of on Dizzy to say whether he gets it or
not. And Dizzy might have just said
like, "Hey, I don't want you to lose the
point like that. I want to play this
game the way it should." And give gave
him that point.
>> Yeah. So, there we go. And once again,
Dizzy just going to have to start the
game with a early vise. Often times,
it's not exactly what Annie wants to be
seeing the early game. Usually, uh on
this rune count, you kind of want it to
just be uh simakisa and then kind of go
from there. Um and so the vise just kind
of indicate to me that Dizzy has found
some clunky hands in the first two
games. Yeah. You know, it's not it's not
a I'm going to play Garen Rugged as my
first play level of fallback, but it is
it's not plan A.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Cuz like the Vi uh what when
I've talked to other Annie players, they
say that, you know, they're happy being
on a lower uh two drop count because Vi,
even though you kind of don't consider
her to two drop, is kind of okay to play
on your first turn of the game, even in
Annie, uh because that three might break
point is kind of enough. or sometimes
you just pump it to form might and
that's enough to kind of push in, get
the conquer, and then it has ganking, so
it can be a real threatening um uh thing
for your opponent to have to deal with.
And so I do uh you know, don't mind that
the Vi has to come down, but certainly
it is just kind of Yeah, as you said,
there's there's just like better plays.
>> Yeah. And a tough exchange of resources
here for Dizzy. He tried to void the
sunlet guardian as it moved in. Um, but
Frodan had the discipline to punish and
you know this is like really like even
watching from this scenario is where you
kind of see some of the the power of
like Kai'Sa because he had to recycle a
rune for that and he is going to feel
that especially after the recycle from
Vi.
>> Yeah, for sure. Uh cuz yeah, that's two
red gone. I mean we're looking at just
two runes for the side of Dizzy to to
kick things off in this next turn. We're
we're on turn three and this is a four
rune start. Um and uh on the other side
uh Frodan not having to really recycle
anything. Uh that's you know some of the
power of the Sunlick Guardian. really
nice when you are going second uh as a
turn one play. There's a lot of value
that you're getting and being able to
save it is just so massive as
immediately this is just going to be uh
two cards, one or two. It looks like two
going to go for the uh the vine. No,
just one to start. Wanting to keep the
uh void seeker in the trash potentially
for Annie Stubborn, I think.
>> Yeah. And you know, Frodan just doing a
great job of knowing how valuable his
stuns are and making sure to always
prioritize keeping runes and energy up
so he can use them when he needs to. And
we're just really seeing how well they
line up against this VI again and again.
>> Yeah. So, actually just offering a trade
of Vi into Guardian. But no, there is
the cleave to back this up and push
three over. And is there just going to
be that rune prison, the pesky rune
prison that has been there time and time
again? And that is going to be the case.
>> Yeah, Frodan really just just the rune
prison in invitational card right now.
So,
>> uh, so that will just bounce the VI. It
will be able to still stay alive though.
The assault plus three even with this
buff. Sunlight guardian not enough
damage to push over the top unless
there's something like I think an ong
guard here hits ais. Um but uh it
doesn't feel like something that Dan is
reaching to go do and it may just be a
bounce back. But we'll see what Dizzy's
got to add onto this as he does go for a
fighter flight. This does work. Uh you
know just cuz the VI is stunned doesn't
mean it's not a body. Uh zero might as
far as uh offensive value is enough to
just conquer this. Yeah, that's a really
great play from Dizzy cuz now that you
know he got the rune prison out of the
hand, he still managed to get his his
point. He's, you know, it's an arena's
greatest game, so he's really just
trying to snowball and really really
good play from Dizzy. Yeah, and even
considering running the traveling
merchant over to the arena's greatest to
potentially hold this battlefield as the
VI has ganking. So you're basically also
on Hillock because you have your own
ganking unit that can kind of run
between the two and now maybe keep the
merchant back over on this side and make
it really unattractive for Froden to try
and run in there.
>> Yeah, there's a real riskreward that
Dizzy has to navigate here because as it
was the Sunlit Guardian was threatening
to just kill the Vi on its own. So he's
going to move the traveling merchant
over there to reinforce. But now he
might be at risk of getting two for one
if Frodan has a way to make the Guardian
even bigger. But being Annie, he does
get to ready some runes himself. And we
might see a nice back and forth here.
>> Yeah, as we're going to just start out
with playing the Leona determined, you
know, she's arriving a little bit late
to this game, but still potentially in
time to to kind of still find that
victory as you don't have to worry about
Video the Wind and that six point break
point as much for Annie. If Dizzy gets
to six, doesn't mean the game is just
over.
>> Yep. And it looks like that gambit is
paying off for Dizzy as Frodan sends the
Guardian over to the windswept Hill. And
it looks like the hold on the arena's
greatest is going to work.
>> Yeah, that'll put Dizzy up to five. He's
been able to refill his trash quite a
bit. So, he will be able to kind of
reload this VI and send it back over to
the Hill as a potential uh try and go
for that conquer. And it'll come down to
what defensive options are available for
Frodan to try and hold on with that
Sunlick Guardian as he's considering
going for a hidden card here. And it
will be a hide. Still going to keep him
notably at four runes. So if he doesn't
have any more recycles on this turn, uh
Leona Zealot can be deployed um coming
in ready on the next turn as Dizzy has
hit that fivepoint threshold. Yeah, that
was a really interesting play from cuz I
think I saw a call to glory in his hand.
So he could have said, "Hey, I'm going
to try to crack this battlefield and get
the two for one, but you know, Annie did
have the runes up instead." He says it's
like maybe it's actually good for me for
you to go to five points because then my
my Leyona will be ready to do her thing.
>> Yeah, now that Void Seeker is going to
come out. That's four into four. So Dan
is going to have to flinch first,
whether that is the hidden card or that
call to glory being deployed. But if the
call to glory comes out and that is the
info being sent, uh that is going to let
Dizzy, you know, kind of have the go
light of like, okay, there's not a lot
of runes available still left and we
know kind of what that might value is
going to be. Uh but the hidden card gets
to remain hidden and two runes available
for Frodan, so the Vi can't just be
fully committed yet. Yeah, you know,
Call to Glory, one of the one of the few
Origins cards that kind of has that
alternative cost and Frodan choosing to
pay it. Uh he couldn't, you know, he
couldn't play it normally now, but he
only has two units, only so many buffs
to give around and a lot of stuns to
give. So, I think spending that buff is
not really going to cost him too much in
the long run.
>> Yeah, big fan of almost always using the
alternate cost for Call of Glory. I
think there are some some, you know,
edge cases where you're going to
actually pay it, but I actually think it
is the best card in Leona's deck. I
often start my deck with a predetermined
three Call of Glory when building a
Leona deck. And I think if you're not
playing it in your Leona at home, add it
to the list
>> for sure. And I think same same for set.
Really, if you're playing buffs and
you're in order, you should probably be
considering Call to Glory.
>> All right. And we're going to have a
stack deck from Dizzy, sneaky deck hand,
a cleave, and yet another VI coming
through there. Um, feels like with the
VI already on board, maybe you don't
necessarily need one unless you want to
make sure you've got the redundancy as
none of the other cards were exactly
what you're looking for. Yeah, Disney
definitely in a in a tricky spot
because, you know, he does have that
point lead. It's right where he wants to
be, but you know, the Leona is in the
champion zone kind of ready to come out
and punish him if he if he overextends.
So, he's going to have to figure out
what he needs to do here to make sure he
keeps scoring without losing too much of
a presence.
>> And it's going to start with two runes
coming down for a falling star. So, just
even more aggressive recycling. Curious
if this is just going to go for Leona or
if you're going to try and put one into
the Sunlink Guardian. And it looks like
it is just going to be the sunlight
guardian trying to make this hidden card
become revealed. It is going to be zonas
which I believe is that going to
completely take this no recall and heal
right now it is. Yeah. So
>> yeah interesting there cuz zona is one
of the few hidden cards that actually
can impact things other than the
battlefield where it's hidden because
it's a gear and when you flip it up it
gets kicked back to your base. So even
if Dizzy did go for that Leyona, the
zonas would have been able to save it.
>> Yep. So there we go. going to get the
conquer over to the hillock with the
ganking. Dizzy does get to that
allimportant six that we do see from the
Annie. But as we've mentioned a couple
of times before, there are actually ways
for Frodan with this Leona deck to
answer. Rune Prison, Hidden Blade.
There's a couple of different options
that you can use to get there. The Face
Breaker even can do enough that we saw
in the previous game. And so Dizzy is
not out of the woods yet, even though
he's been able to score so.
>> Yeah, one one nice advantage that Dizzy
has though is Froden is only on three.
So, the maximum he can go up to here is
five. And that allows Dizzy to kind of
play a slower game, maybe pace his
threats a little slower than he
otherwise might because he doesn't have
to be at risk of losing the game the
following turn.
>> All right. And uh Frodan is down to
actually completely exhaust his runes,
go for the Zealot. We talked about how
this will enter ready now that Dizzy has
pushed ahead. And it is going to be both
Leona and Zealot running in to the wind
swapped Hill, which is a very powerful
combo to have them both on Hillick where
they can move into the other
battlefield. Uh, and this is going to
try and stun out this VI, reduce the
might, which, you know, likely doesn't
matter here. It's a very small unit. Um,
but it is something that Dizzy is going
to have to contend with as he goes
forward. The question here though is
does he have like a ride the wind to get
the VI out of here and still look for
the conqueror? No, but a Gus to get the
VI back home.
>> Yeah, really great use of Gus there. You
know, a lot of times you just think I'm
using Gus to return my opponent's units
to their hand. But it does have the
versatility of sometimes, you know,
saving your own unit. Maybe it's not
like retreat. you're not going to get a
rune as well, but saving by is pretty
important and will allow Dizzy to
potentially put that ride the wind combo
together.
>> Yeah, once again denying a buff as well
as Frodent is going to send in that
sunlight guardian be able to go up to
five points. I think uh a hidden card
being deployed as well. I think I saw a
hidden blade. Maybe it's just again
we'll see. I think hidden blade makes
this play make a lot of sense from where
it's like, hey, I'm tapping out which is
really scary into viide the wind. But if
I've got hidden blade, then I can just
hide it and use the runes in that way.
Definitely hidden blade is defin wants
here because you know saving your units
is nice but it's not as nice when you've
lost the game whereas hidden blade
actually help you not lose which is what
he needs.
>> I guess it could be face breaker as
well. That is true. Yeah, right. Yeah,
you can still uh stun the VI uh in that
way and that's also a hidden card. No,
it's actually cool cuz like normally you
don't think really of calm order as like
the oh, they have all this hidden depth,
but you know, Frodan really going out of
his way to have three different things
to really keep the opponents not sure
what it is every time.
>> Yeah. And uh another really impactful
card in Dizzy's hand uh that we hadn't
been able to talk about in this match up
just yet is that Rebuke. And I think
against Leon, it's very potent in
dealing with the Zealot or the
Determined. But because Dan has been
able to build so much board presence, I
think the Rebuke is just a little soft
right now for this first turn. And the
ride the wind being, I believe, absent
from the hand is going to make the VI a
lot harder to actually kind of pull off
as it looks like Dizzy is just going to
be kind of going for a setup turn uh on
this one trying to make sure that he can
go for that double conquer on the
subsequent turn.
>> Yep, definitely just taking his time. He
knows he doesn't have to rush this turn.
He's going to build his board presence,
see if he can draw that ride the wind or
some other pivotal piece that'll help
him on his next turn. Frodan's going to
breathe a sigh of relief and, you know,
take his hold points. Yeah, it just goes
show goes to show the potency of the
Leona deck. Uh this is a deck that I
think has been gated for a lot of
players because of its Kai'Sa match up
having a lot of trouble going up against
Kai'Sa. But I love that we get to
showcase how in some of the other decks,
some of the other strong decks in the
format. I think Annie is is one of them.
Another one that I think Leona is really
good against is Yei. So some of these
other good decks, Leona really gets to
target. It's kind of this level three
deck where yes, you don't target the
best deck in the room maybe, which is
the Kai'Sa, but you do get to kind of
deal with some of these other side
fringe decks.
>> Yeah. And you know, we also set sets out
there as well. All these decks that are
just trying to put kind of big stat
turns on the table, Leona is just really
well positioned against. And it is cool
to see Frodan really put that to work in
this Annie matchup.
>> Yeah. And I think if that is a a hidden
blade or even a face breaker, I think
we're at a certain point where that hold
is going to be a little bit much for an
Annie to get over. One of the weaknesses
of the deck is it can't get over the
large numbers outside of just the VI.
Yes, it has the Darius which can kind of
do a decent job, but the VI is really
where you get over the big holds where
you're able to crack that through as it
is just going to be a move and a flash.
He is just digging.
>> Yeah, that's bit of a desperation play
here from Dizzy. Oh, but he does.
>> Oh, he discarded the flash.
>> Okay. Yeah. No, I thought you was like,
"Oh, man. We're we're flashing for
movement triggers. This is not looking
good." But no,
>> just a just a loot away. And Dizzy finds
a cleave to take out this Sunlit
Guardian and put himself up to seven as
well.
>> All right, but Frodan does still have
these four runes up. He's got I'm not
sure how many cards in hand. I don't
think it's a ton, but he's got a few
cards left in hand as well as just a
massive hold and the hidden card. So
really, I mean, the tough thing is is
because it's three different units
holding, it's not even like fighter
flight kind of gets you there. You need
a lot to try and make this happen.
Fortunately with VI at base, you don't
need Ride the Wind. So Rebuke is a great
start. There's not enough runes to go
like rebuke Annie, rebuke again or
anything like that. So, it is just going
to be whatever Dizzy's got in hand,
>> right? And you know, as we saw before in
that fight orflight play, if he can
clear the units out, a stun isn't going
to be good enough to stop the conquer.
Uh, and we're seeing a a this is this is
the moment. No more counting, no more
calculating. Just say, "Recycle it all.
I've got to try to win."
>> This is where you go, "Please, please,
please, please, please, please, please,
no stun, no stun, no stun." And you just
hope that it's not there.
>> Yeah. Cross your fingers and pray that
hidden card is another Zas. It's a
hidden blade and that probably is just
going to do it. The two draws are going
to come through so you'll see what you
can get. But that is just going to be Vi
going to the trash. Dizzy only three
runes and a Porro and a dream as there
is a total of eight might defending when
it comes to unit combat with the
shields.
>> What's actually interesting because that
that traveling merchant does still have
the assault from the cleave.
>> Can he do something here? And I think he
maybe has gust.
>> He sees it. Ride the wind.
>> And ride the wind plus gust.
>> Okay, first we got we he's going to he's
going to do a little move trigger. Get
rid of an unnecessarily traveling
merchant. Does have cards or is are they
all on the table?
>> He has he has some amount of cards in
hand. It's one or two cards in hand.
Four runes open. This assault trigger.
So it's five seven into
>> eight.
>> Eight. So he's currently behind.
>> But if there is a Gust here, I'm not
sure that there is. There's one rune
ready. If Augustus can take out that
porro, this might just be enough.
>> Nothing in hand.
>> Yeah, Dan doesn't have to flinch.
>> But he's just got the hidden blade
anyways.
>> Two hidden blades back to back.
>> Dizzy shakes his head. He's just like,
"Yeah, that's that's tough."
>> Draw two. Nothing left
>> just to cleave. He had the second
cleave, so he would have been able to
push over initially, but that is just
going to be Frodan taking it 200 over
Dizzy on Annie and Dizzy. No slouch. He
was able to top eight in Atlanta at the
10K earlier this month or earlier last
month. And uh Gan coming in through with
the Leona going to complete a 200 start
to the tournament.
>> Yeah, you know, Frodan, I think really
showing some being on the bleeding edge
of the meta there, the the rise of Annie
and but he's just got the stuns to deal
with it and you just saw how brutally
effective they were there.
>> I get to smile. I'm I get to be happy
that Leona gets to win on camera. I love
the deck so much. It's cool as much. I
love Dizzy, too. He's he's a sweet guy
and he's playing the Annie deck and I'm
rooting for him, but I see Leona and I
got to have my my little bit of bias
when my favorite deck comes to play and
it's great to watch that happen and
we'll see. You know, one loss is not the
end of the road for Dizzy. He can still
make that big run.
>> Yeah. No, definitely still a lot of
rounds left to play. Dizzy looked like,
you know, really he was really calm and
collected. I think he's going to have a
great shot at battling back.
>> Yeah. And of course for him he's like ah
shoot the rogue deck that's good against
me. So we are going to have struggles
there. But before we get into our second
match of this round, we do have a deck
tech with Prismaticism. So, let's go
ahead and talk to Pris about what he's
brought.
I'm here with Prismaticism, fresh off
the uh top eight at the 10K in Vegas.
And Pris, you've had a lot of success in
a ton of different games over a long
period of time, but I wanted to ask you
how it's been competing in person in
your first kind of physical TCG. Oh,
>> it's been a great experience. The
community has been great. The people
have been really friendly and I've even
getting getting the feeling uh kind of
back in hot early days the first time I
went to a land where you see a lot of
faces that you recognize from online or
from other games and then it's just like
I'm feeling uh flustered seeing them but
then like they're they're the ones
flustered seeing me too in a way. So
it's really cool.
>> No, that's really sweet. And I I you
know you you had this big success with
Teemo in Vegas and you're running back
the Teemo. So, I wanted to give a chance
for you to kind of talk about this Teemo
list for our audience so people can
understand what the Swiss Scout is
trying to do.
>> Okay. Yeah. So, Teemo, he's built around
hiding cards for one mana instead of
paying power costs. That's the core of
the deck where you get to hide cards
very efficiently. Uh the star of the
deck though is Dr. Mundo. Um with purple
and blue, you have a lot of cards that
you can play cheaply and that replace
themselves so you can fill up your
discard pile very quickly. So, he
reaches just enormous numbers of might
that other decks can't deal with. Um,
the other deck, the other card that is
very important is Ember Monk. Uh, some
decks can deal with Mundo, yellow decks
primarily, but the decks that deal with
Mundo can't deal with Ember Monk. And
even the other matchups, Embermunk gives
me the tempo that I need to get to the
Mundo in the late game. And then a
couple other cards that are very
important. I've got Consult the Past and
Stack Deck. These let me see a lot of
cards from my deck every game, which
makes the deck very consistent and then
also gives me a lot of choices to make
during the game, which makes the deck
very skill intensive to play. All right,
that's awesome, Pris. Thanks so much for
giving us a little bit of breakdown.
Best of luck. I know you're trying to go
for that Teemo medal card, so uh I hope
we'll see you do really well in this
event.
>> Thank you, Kasanova.
All right, Frank, we got a treat for
you. We got Teemo. I know you wanted to
see Teemo today, and we get to see it in
the hands of Prismaticism, who has been
doing a really great job in the early
stages of Riftbound, and we saw him in
top eight in Vegas on this Teemo deck
before.
>> Yeah. No, I'm super excited. This is
exactly what I wanted. also love Pris,
you know, great Legends of Raa player as
well. So, I'm just really excited to see
what he can do with this Teemo deck.
Seems like he really knows the ins and
the outs. Um, not going for a Nocturn
build, but looking to really optimize
Mundo, and I just have to agree with him
where if you can get Mundo big enough,
especially in this meta, a lot of the
decks just literally cannot beat it.
>> Yeah, I I absolutely love it. And, you
know, he he even brings up the Ember
Monk. We actually saw some builds of the
all-in Mundo actually foregoing Ember
Monk and really just kind of going all
in on that Mundo. I like that he's kind
of got this like mid-range game plan as
well in the games that he can't just
rely on the good doctor to come through.
>> Yeah. No, his logic makes perfect sense.
There's not a lot of order removal out
there to punish your Mundo, but when
there is, you have that ember monk to
kind of get in under them.
>> All right. Well, let's jump in with
match two of round two. It is
Prismaticism versus Knass or Alan Woo,
who is a MTG Pro Tour champion. And so
this is a a hell of a match to get out
early on to have Pris versus Nalpass in
Teemo versus Kai'Sa. Two Titans of the
of the TCG industry going up against
each other on two Titans of the format.
And in Vegas, we saw Pris dismantle some
Kai'Sa over and over again with his
Teemo. Uh but even from talking to Pris,
he thinks he's a bit unfavored into the
Kais if they really know the matchup,
>> right? And you know, definitely excited
to see two card game great really go at
it here. Um, you know, we see now
leading off with that Legion rear guard,
a more aggressive build of Kai'Sa. And
uh, yeah, but we'll see how Teemo can
respond.
>> Yeah, and kick things off. It is going
to be Z warren for Teemo and Reaver's
Row for Kai'Sa. So Teemo trying to
continue to fill up that graveyard, make
the Mundo as big and unstoppable as
possible. Whereas on the other side, you
know, as you're saying, the more
aggressive versions of Kai'Sa really
like this reaver rail. They'll try and
get their Kais out very quickly onto the
point, get that conquer and get the draw
and then move it back.
>> Yeah. And it looks like both players
really breaking out very quickly into
full tempo gameplay as Pris says, "Hey,
I know that Legion rear guard could come
down with Accelerate later, but I'm just
going to gust it now to stop you from
scoring a point."
>> Yeah, the early game plan from the team.
Just buy space until you can get the
Mundo. He's talking about decks that
really can't deal with Dr. Mundo. Kaisa
is the perfect example. Uh she doesn't
really have any cards in her arsenal
that actually let you remove the Mundo.
Kind of the best case scenario is you
get enough might on the board and you
can kind of come in with the thousand
tailed Watcher and get over the top.
>> Right. It really for for this match up
for Teemo, it really just is a stall
game. Can I live long enough and stop my
opponent from scoring enough points that
by the time I play Mundo, I've got a big
enough trash for him to be gigantic and
I could just run him in there and close
out the game.
>> And this is the perfect way to build the
trash. You've got the traveling merchant
throwing stuff away on move. You've got
the conquer on the zon warren. Already
three cards in the trash.
>> And there's that ember monk.
>> Yep. Ember monk hideo. This is the exact
kind of start that Teemo likes to see.
Yes. This is all kind of face up, but
it's like try me. This is 12 power.
>> Yeah. Well, definitely one of my
favorite things to do in playing Teemo
is just hide from the zone cuz it really
is, you know, Pris is just saying it's
right here. You know exactly what it is.
I don't think you could beat it.
>> Yeah. One of the big things I I do note
here, I'm I'm curious if just maybe it's
off camera, but Allen's uh Kai'Sa I'm
not seeing in the the champ zone here.
I'm wondering if it was accidentally
shuffled into the deck and if that's
something that is either they just told
them to play or or what goes from there.
>> That that is a good call out. It is
possible that it is offcreen, but I'm I
I'm sure we'll see eventually.
>> Yeah, we'll see if that comes into into
play. Um yeah, not sure. I actually
don't know the rules on what happens
there. So we'll have to see if if the
judges have to step in for that if it
even comes up or hopefully it's just
offscreen.
So we are going to have pass look to
send in a hopeful maybe just being
willing to try and set up some trades.
So it is going to start with NPass
having focus. He is going to cleave up
to seven. So I I actually like this
quite a bit. He knows that okay Pris
flips Teemo. I can still get rid of this
ember monk. And that is the really
important thing that he wants to be able
to deal with is say, I don't want this
ember monk to be able to stick on the
board. He knows it's six. Send seven in.
Go for the trade.
>> Right. Definitely one of the the good
ways to fight back against Teemo is kind
of not let them get too entrenched in a
single battlefield and say, "Hey, I know
we might trade some resources here when
we fight, but I just want to get some of
your hidden cards out of there."
>> And even a smoke screen going to be able
to be committed here. Uh so the math on
this is going to be eight currently on
the side of uh Prismat but now there's
also array so plenty able to kind of
start to push through and I did get a
note from production the Kai'Sa is off
screen so we're not going to have any
worries there just now pass does have
his Kai'Sa out there
>> very good to know yeah lot lots of
spells flying here from both player well
mostly from now pass at this point but
>> yeah but that's massive being able to
just answer this that is The downside of
Temo having it be face up 12 power is
really difficult to deal with but a
smoke screen a cleave that's very
efficient kind of plus seven that kind
of comes through there and then a ray to
just clean things up.
>> Yeah, now pass kind of had exactly what
he needed to dismantle the the problem
that Prismaticism put together and you
know now Pris is going to be on the back
foot and we're going to have to see what
he can do.
There we go. That is going to be all
those costs paid.
Pris, this is the tough thing with
Teemo, right? These are the spots that
the deck really struggles in. When
you've got no material on the board, you
don't have a ton of ways to get on the
board quickly. Uh, Thousand Tail Watch
Watcher can be deployed and help out
with this. Singularity uh doesn't really
help you catch up. It just kind of is
able to reset the board and maybe buys
you enough time, but these are really
challenging hand states. Yeah, and you
know, this is why Kai'Sa is known as one
of the best decks in the format because
not only does it have these really
powerful lateg game spells, it can just
have a really aggressive tempo curve and
put you on the back foot super fast even
when you put a lot of resources into
trying to hold.
>> Yeah, it feels like crazy that Pris was
able to put 12 might on the board and
now not only was able to remove it, but
also keep his hopeful.
>> Yeah.
Okay. But we'll see Pris start to
rebuild a little bit.
The scary thing is, you know, now pass
might just have some more removal that
can reach the base and it's unclear if
this ember monk will even be safe.
>> Yeah, if there is a falling star, that
starts to be the blowout, right? Knock
pass goes up to four points. Just kills
off the ember monk and now Pris is still
another turn behind where he can't get
any purchase onto the board cuz even if
NPass scores a lot early, Pris can
reestablish a board, get a Mundo out,
and then it becomes almost impossible
for the Kaiser to win and he can claw
back the game,
>> right? But he definitely has to do it
before it is too late because although
Mundo is can do a lot of work, you know,
if the score is like 7 to1, 7 to2, it
might just be too much for Mundo to
overcome.
There's just going to be the Kai'Sa
coming in. Actually just going to be
played to hold into the Ember Monk on
the Reverse Row. You know that you can
always just retreat it, but you also
have the option if it feels like you can
stay in, you have you can do so.
>> Yeah, that's the really awesome thing
about Reus row for Kai'Sa. you know, if
you want to come in. Kai'Sa is usually
pretty happy to just back out cuz then
she could conquer and just draw a card
on the followup.
>> And this really threatens, hey, I showed
you a smoke screen earlier. Do you want
to risk it? Do you want to come in? Do
you think I'll retreat or do you think I
will be able to smoke screen and kind of
blow you out once again as the stack
deck is just going to be the start for
Pris. I think at this point now, the
singularity starts to become a very good
card to find as you've got the Kai'Sa
and the hopeful as the two targets,
>> right? And yeah, I do I do love that
moment of tension when you go in the
reaver's row and the trigger goes on
because you don't have to retreat, but
once you pass up on that opportunity,
you can no longer do it.
Prismaticism doing a little dig, seeing
what he could find.
No way to get this Ember Monk bigger now
that there's no hidden cards to flip.
Relying on something like a Stupify,
which we've seen one thrown away earlier
in another played. So the third copy
would have to come out. He's done a good
amount of digging through the deck. So
it's possible you see all three in the
top, you know, 20 25 of your deck, but
at this point, you know, a lot lower
odds that you're able to find that. And
that looks like a singularity to me. And
it is. That is the perfect card to find
in this scenario.
>> Yep. One of one of the ways that Teemo
can really use to catch back up and
prismaticism going to kind of get a
perfect spot for it here as you said.
And this is the kind of thing that
Kai'Sa can't really fight back against.
Kais is good at putting units in play,
good at taking rid of units, but not
that great at protecting their own
units.
>> And it looks like that may be a retreat.
No, just a stupify. Oh, this is really
scary cuz now he's tempting Prisy
saying, "Look, when you come in for your
conquer, I may just have a ray uh that
can answer you immediately." And also,
instead of holding it on, he was looking
for a retreat of his own to potentially
save the Kai'Sa. And I wonder if he
found it or had it. Looks like he just
stupified again uh just to try and draw.
So still threatening that ray. Um but
instead of you know hiding it and
obuscating it, he might not even have
it. He just has to make Pris think about
it. And he could have found a retreat.
>> Yeah, definitely looked like digging for
a retreat to me cuz while Kais is not
great at protecting them in terms of
keeping them in play, retreat is a good
way to at least return them to your hand
so you can use them again.
>> Yeah, and Pris is just going to run in.
But the ray is there and there's no way
for Pris to kind of get around that. And
I think at this point in the game, I I
think Prismat is recognizing I just have
to make you have it because he's very
far behind and he needs to get on board.
Um, and realistically, you can't just
let the Kaisa keep running you over as I
believe there still is uh that um rear
guard in hand that was gusted earlier on
in the game. So, if NPass wants to push
to six points here, he's just going to
be able to. Yeah, pass definitely has
done a really great job of just keeping
Pris under the gun being like, "Hey, I
know you're trying to play a slow game
and set up for your big Mundo down the
line and I'm just not going to let you
do that if I can."
>> All right, there's just a Yortle and it
looks like five runes going down. So
maybe a Darius. No. Wow, this is an
inclusion that I've not seen in many
Kaiso decks. The consult the pass from
Nul Pass really valuing even more card
draw in the main deck.
>> Yeah. I know that is very interesting
because you know one of the what might
look like a drawback is you can't
actually pay the hidden cost with
Daughter of the Void. So you actually
have to recycle if you're looking to
hide it. But now Cash just kind of I
guess he's leaning into that tempo build
and saying I'm willing to sack runes to
just have more cards and make sure I can
just keep driving in for points again
and again.
>> Yeah, being willing to say I will
recycle a rune for draw two is very
nice. And I think this is another
consultant pass that's gone down. Uh
we've this is not the first time I've
seen this. This was something that was
done in China a little bit, but it was
relatively unpopular. There's very few
builds that I saw of this. And I think
that, you know, for Nogas to kind of
lean into this and like it means, hey,
maybe some of the other cards that are
filling up these Kaiser decks I'm not a
fan of. And I just want more consistency
on seeing the cards I do want.
>> Yeah. And this is a nice play from him
because, you know, as you said, I think
he does have that rear guard. He could
have gone to six, which usually is a
pivotal number to hit, but I think he's
kind of more determined. I don't need to
rush. I can just draw a bunch of cards
and then I will absolutely be able to
overwhelm whatever pitmaticism can offer
to finish out the game.
>> Yeah, it's also possible that I just
missed him discard it to Warren and he
doesn't actually have it in hand but I
if he did there is still as you said
like reason to hold back because you
just have control of the game and you
just need to keep holding on to that
control.
>> Yeah, you know heristics are good.
Saying I you always want to get to six
if you can is good but that doesn't mean
it's always right.
>> Correct. Um, and Pris going to start off
with a stack deck here to see if he
could find anything to help start
digging himself out.
>> Yeah, at this point I'm like maybe your
first Mundo, but even that feels a
little slow when your opponent's at
five. Uh, feel like the the early answer
to the 12 might stack has been a really
tough thing to start to overcome and is
it is just going to be a Mundo in hand.
It's huge Mundo for Pris and the
question is is it just too little too
late?
>> Yeah, now that is a gigantic Mundo. Pris
has definitely achieved his miniame of
create a gigantic trash. I don't even
want to know how big that Mundo is.
>> I'm not going to try and count it
whenever they tell us. We We'll find out
then. Uh as surely whenever it becomes
relevant, we will know.
Knock pass does have a retreat now. It
looks like an Athenian rain and it maybe
was a stupify. I think there's a fourth
card I missed. But also that consult the
pass that exists is going to just add a
couple more cards to this hand. And
while there's nothing in the deck that
exactly deals with Mundo, still being
able to start building a huge board
since Pris is so behind on points can be
plenty.
>> Yeah. You know, and as he as Pass panned
through the hand, I'm not sure that I
did see that rear guard, so it might
have actually been
>> got trashed away at some point.
>> So up to six, consult, draw two. Looks
like a Darius and was that just another
Darius? I think maybe as the two draws,
which is really great when you have this
many runes. Double Darius is another way
that you can theoretically deal with the
Mundo. Um, you know, you have to wait
for him to have a couple of turns of
beginning phases to turn through some of
this trash, but uh 14 might is a lot and
that can actually help you push through
the Mundo when you need to.
>> Yeah. And you know, as as we saw from
Pris's deck tech, he really has
constructed his deck to be like, I'm
just putting it all on the back of the
good doctor. And we're going to see if
Mundo truly can reverse a 7:1 point
differential. And it might look hard,
but it's definitely not impossible. cuz
that is an Athenian rain
being cast. Does this does this work? Is
this enough?
A Falling Star and Nathan Reigns. That's
six plus. I mean, that's 18. Is this
Mundo? I mean, I could see that only
being 12 cards in the trash. That's
Yeah.
>> Yeah. You know, could do it. Normally
you think of a Kathy and Rains ability
to kind of mow down a bunch of different
units, but it also can just deal 12 to a
single unit and Mundo was big, but it
turns out he was not big enough for Pris
to keep him around.
>> Yeah, I mean Rain plus Falling Star. It
takes a lot to get through, but is it is
enough as now it is just going to be a
little Sprite trying to run in. Deals
with the sentry that is going to be card
draw. These sprites do give some ability
uh for Pris to actually continue to push
through as that looks like that was a
scrap heap getting discarded this time
uh to the Warren's trigger. Does he
actually have a way to accelerate again
or does he have to ride the win maybe
the sprite over to the the Reaver's row
has to find some kind of answer.
>> No, I love that sprite call here from
Brismaticism. That was actually a card
that after I watched him play in Vegas,
I hadn't put that in my team deck and I
immediately went home and I was like,
man, I got to get some sprites calls in
here. All right. So, he's he just uses
them really great. They're really
versatile and the sprite doesn't stick
around, but it usually does the job you
need it to do. It can even get in there
so you can hide a card in a pinch.
>> Yeah, that's awesome. He actually plays
a Sprite's Call and then he needs
another Sprite's Call to Accelerate. So,
he actually uses the Gorilla Warfare to
grab Sprit's Call that he just played
and play it again. Um, so really nice
from Pris to at least uh hold on a
little bit longer. He also grabbed the
Teemo, so he can go ahead and hide that
on one of the sprites and then react to
the temporary trigger to have a four
might hold potentially, but that is a
Ray trying to stop the sprite here. And
that might just be enough to uh seal out
the game with the hold.
>> Yeah, it looks like Pris might have just
been doing a trash check there. Like,
let me see your trash so I know what I
have to deal with after we get into the
next game.
>> Yeah, looks like sideboarding is going
to come through, but big for Nas to be
able to hold on.
All right. Well, we'll see what happens
through the sideboarding from this game
to see if Pris is able to turn things
around. It felt like a very good start
for the Teemo deck, but the answer was
just there. I mean, cleave plus smoke
screen on the whole is so much
difference and the ray. It had to be all
three. Uh really there wasn't much else
that was going to get over the top as
that is just a difference of 10 might
basically coming through with the three
damage and then the four and the three
from the cleave and the smoke screen.
>> Definitely. Yeah, that's the one one
trap of Teemo. Sometimes your gameplay
is a little sharp. Sometimes you take a
big risk and if they do manage to get
over your hidden stack, it's usually
pretty devastating.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean, and it it was face
up, right, in this case. Often times
with Teemo, you have the advantage of
well, your cards are hidden. The
opponent can't see them. They don't know
what is there. Uh but this time around,
just the nature of that early game is
yeah, you want to get the Teemo Scout
out there. That is the most might you
can actually represent and does end up
hurting uh at in the long run for that
spot. But uh we are going to be getting
into game two very soon uh as they were
get just getting that uh second game
ready. I think for the the Kai'Sa list,
we did see the draw. I'm wondering did
you see any cards that were like notably
missing from the Kai'Sa that maybe the
consult could have come in because I
didn't immediately catch any.
>> Um nothing immediate. I mean I didn't
see a time warp at any point as I know a
card that some Kais have been flexing in
and out as the meta has developed. So I
could see a world where you know he just
decided I don't need these time warps.
I'm going to like maybe just try to
overwhelm with card advantage and not
look for that one big spiky play and
look to more grind things out.
>> Yeah, and it's it's I really like that
call out, right? Because often in some
of these main decks it was like two warp
or one warp, but the consult the pass
maybe aren't even a three of, right? It
could just be there's two consult the
pass instead of the warps or maybe it's
like one less rain and get the consult
the pass. So maybe cutting some of that
top end and then getting this draw that
you're spending power for to maybe find
the falling stars more consistently
where those are some some matchups if
you find enough falling stars you just
win. It's really hard for your opponent
to deal with it.
>> Right. I will say Teemo actually has a
unique way to play around falling star
and atheon rain that some other decks
don't because you can hide units. Those
can actually be threatened by the
falling star and you could flip them up
to kind of keep your board presence and
not get totally wiped.
>> All right. All right. Well, let's jump
in to the next game and see if Pris is
able to make some adjustments with this
Teemo to get over Kai'Sa once again as
he's shown he can in the past or if NP
pass will be able to lock things down on
the void gate as this is another hostile
environment for Temo to try and hold on
as this will give plus one to spells and
ability damage going to help out for
those falling stars being able to hit on
to the ember monks get much easier
clears there as it is banal tree for
Pris. This is just hey I can hide extra
cards here.
>> Yeah, this is that really I would say
Teemo is kind of strongest battlefield
cuz you know maybe you can crack my hold
stack of one Teemo. But if there's two
Teeos hiding in the battle tree, I don't
know if Nal Pax is going to be able to
get Prismaticism out of there.
>> Yeah, and now we do have a fight
orflight ditch to the move trigger. I
imagine there's some other hidden cards.
I I think one of the big plays that you
get to do here when you have a two drop
early on is you get to hide consult the
pass teemo. And I think it's a really
nice early one because you have to
respect maybe double Teemo or Teemo
Fighter Flight, but so you don't want to
run in, but it could just be the Teemo
with a consult the past hanging out to
give you that extra draw.
>> Definitely. And you know, one thing you
see Prismaticism do there, which I think
is really pays off a lot of the ways he
built this deck, is he just uses two
energy to hide the cards, which will
allow him to kind of maintain the runes
he needs to play Mundo down the line.
Wow. And this is Seal from Nog Pass. So
Seal, Darius gets to come out and Pris
wouldn't play around this because you
don't expect seals in this deck. Darius
usually can't come out on five runes,
but in this spot, Pris gets blown out by
the seal because it enables Darius
Trafarian to come down as a second card.
This is massive. It was exactly consult
Teemo. And normally there's no answer on
five runes that perfectly deals with it,
but exactly Fury Seal does. So
>> yeah, you know, that's that is some
really heads up deck building right
there. Obviously, like, you know,
intuitively, you might be like, "Oh, I'm
already getting all the power I need
from Daughter of the Void. I might not
need to use these seals, but there are a
lot of spaces to spend that red power
like on Darius or Kaiser Survivor." And
it does allow this really powerful,
really unexpected play that you're
talking about with the seal and also
those consult pass. You know, we were
talking about, hey, yeah, you can't use
auto the void for that, but now tap a
seal, that's a draw, too. That's insane.
That's really, really good. And we saw
some seals out of Ting Fang in the top
eight of Vegas earlier on playing
exactly the seals of rage. Maybe Malpass
either taking some inspiration there or
just having the same idea of, hey, these
seals are actually quite good to play in
Kaisen.
>> Yeah, but all all really coming together
as we see that really powerful Darius
play. Prismaticism is going to have to
find out, you know, my hold's been
broken twice in a row. This time, can I
get back in and reestablish a hold
before the point score gets out of hand
like it did last game.
>> Yeah, and this one is tough. I mean, you
know, often Pris is known for the
methodical play, playing around kind of
as many options as possible. In the
first game, I don't think you can
feasibly decide to play around smokec
screen cleave ray as like a combination
of cards on the same turn. Uh, and then
in this spot, I think playing around a
seal of rage Darius is not something
that's normally in your range when
you're playing against Kai'Sa. And so it
causes, you know, this amazing spot for
an Alpas to now have full control of the
game.
>> Yeah, really, really important to note
that the full event here in Houston is
closed deck list. So, you know, that was
just not on Pris's radar at all. And it
it really paid off now for going a
little outside the box in his Kai'Sa
build.
>> Yeah. And it it it just as you said
right goes to show because it's closed
deck list. If you've got any of these
little secrets, any little hidden nugget
of tech or one of that maybe people
won't expect, you might get even extra
value than you would normally get out of
the card.
>> So a long think on that stack deck from
Prisy. We'll have to see what he can do.
It's just going to be a Sprite mother
just having more ways to continue to
immediately impact the board. I believe
that Sprite Mother is a sideboard card
uh for Prismaticism as this is now six
might coming in as the stack deck is
going to give that plus one to the Raven
Blue.
>> Yeah. And I I I love Sprite Mother here
from Pris. I think it's a just a great
way to go against Kai'Sa and be like,
"Hey, I'm going to threaten the
battlefield. Maybe you hexray hex tech
ray it, but then I still have a body
left behind in my base to keep the
pressure on."
>> Yeah, for Brizz, that is going to enable
a hidden card to go onto the Bandal
tree, even if it's just a consult. just
trying to get more ammo for in the tank
for this Teemo deck. This game, the
blowout was massive again, but because
one of the cards was a consult the pass,
you didn't lose a horrible amount of
material and you're kind of refilling
the hand. Uh so it's not quite as
disastrous as when you kind of lost
three units immediately uh to the the
cleave in the smoke screen.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And you know, one one really
nice thing here is normally when you you
know, you lose control of a battlefield,
your hidden cards go away and that
sprite is temporary, but you actually
can respond to the temporary trigger by
flipping up your hidden card.
>> Yep. And here Kai'Sa is going to come
in. It is just a consult getting some
more value out of this sprite. Uh as
this seal already, you know, giving plus
one rune here because of the ability of
the accelerate needing to cost uh a fury
rune. oftentimes players kind of shy
away from accelerating Kai'Sa as much as
possible because they want to make sure
they have enough runes built up, but
when you have the seal really unlocks
your ability to kind of look for those
spots.
>> Yeah, and loving the rapid pace of play
from both players here. Clearly very
comfortable. Clearly both know what they
need to do. That Kai'Sa came flying in
fast, drew a card, and now it's on Prisy
to figure something out.
All right, looking here. It is going to
be currently seven runes for Pris, so no
Mundo just yet. Not the most attractive
singularity board either. Plus, that
will keep you at seven runes for another
turn, which is not ideal as it is just
going to be Sprite Mother, poke the
bear, see if there is a Ray. And there's
always been so far in this series, Knuck
Pass has always kind of had that answer,
which kind of is the Kai'Sa experience
more often than not.
>> Definitely. And you know, Singularity
definitely a great card to kind of catch
you back up when you're behind. It's
really at its best when you're ahead and
you're using it to kind of keep yourself
safe. Um, so if Pris had it here, it
could help, but I don't think this is
the ideal setup for it. So even if he
had it, he's going to go with the Sprite
Mother instead.
>> Yeah, double sprites here. Sprite mother
into sprite call. Send those two in to
deal with the Kai'Sa. Get a conquer. not
fully on uh point tempo right at three
not four as now class has been able to
make it to four which is of course quite
scary for Pris as this could be the turn
to go to six but it does open up the
opportunity where maybe Pris can start
to push in this bright mother find room
to maybe stick a Mundo but it might be a
little uh too little too late if now
pass is able to go to six here because
jamming Mundo when your opponent goes to
six is is just too late. Yeah, and it's
interesting because of the the the red
seals from now pass. I wonder if that
even further makes you think that
there's no time warp because maybe, you
know, obviously the red seal can't help
you there. So maybe you're maybe he has
just cut time warp and he's looking to
do a different strategy.
>> Yeah. And honestly, with so many
different Kaiso players I've talked to,
I think time warp has more and more
fallen out of favor. There are still a
few staunch supporters who are like, you
know, this is you need this card. It is
a mirror breaker. It's going to let you
win a lot of these games. Uh, but I've
heard a lot of different players who
have been more towards a Cathian Rain or
even just kind of cutting out a little
bit more of that top end, especially
with the resurgence of Annie.
>> Yeah, definitely one of the more
divisive cards among Kaiser players.
Some some swear by it, live by it, die
by it, some hate it, and don't even want
to play a single copy.
>> All right, now back over to Pris. Now,
pass not able to go to six. So, I think
for Pris, that's a little bit of a sire
of relief. You'll have at least some
more time to potentially make something
happen. There's even, you know, sprite
mother to bandal tree, play out Mundo,
hide some cards, and just utilize your
power. Even though you'll kind of
decimate your rune base, uh can get you
in a position to potentially turn things
around. But if he doesn't have the
Mundo, if he doesn't feel like it's
strong enough, it's hard to find some
options to start to deal with Kai'Sa
untapping with a hopeful at home.
>> Yeah, and you know, Prismaticism going
to have some tough choices here cuz I'm
sure he would love to get that sprite
mother into Bandal tree and start hiding
cards, but now does have those four
runes available just daring any piece of
removal. and Prismaticism is going to
have to weigh. Is it worth the risk to
get in there if he doesn't have it? Or
maybe you could kind of, you know, quote
unquote waste the four energy he left up
by not giving him the opportunity to
play his removal.
>> Definitely worth a big tank here as this
will probably be the pivotal pivotal
decision for this entire game. Whatever
Pris decides to do, it is just going to
be an Ember Monk at home for now.
Merchant just filling up the back row
saying, "Okay, you will go to seven and
then from there I'm going to have to try
and completely run the game back."
>> Yeah. And Prismaticism saying, "Hey, I'm
not going to go in right now. I'm not
going to let you use those runes." This
play is very scary into an Atheian rain.
I imagine Pris just kind of did the
evaluation in his head, said, "I'm far
behind enough. I have to take this risk.
If he has it, he has it. I'm going to
lose. But if he doesn't, I think this is
going to give him his best fighting
chance to get back into the game." Yeah,
I think he is accepting losing drain.
And there it is. Uh so from there, we're
just going to see Pris scoop up his
units and just probably scoop up his
cards after that as a he is going to
untap. He is going to looks like maybe
maybe play this out. Maybe he's got one
more little hailmary play that he can
try and make. But with both battlefields
in control for Nalpass uh and at seven
points, the rain cleaning up the back
row. I like the the shout from Pris. You
kind of have to just go for it. You have
to say, you know what, if you have it,
you have it. Uh, and there I think there
are quite a few spots when playing
against Kai'Sa that this can come up
where you do just have to make him have
it. And uh, this time Nekbas pretty much
had it every time.
>> Yeah, I mean because you know if you if
you play the game as though they always
have rain and you play around it, you're
going to like lose to it when they don't
have it by not playing to beat it.
>> Pris saying I'm going to do what I can
if you don't have it. Now does have it
and that's going to secure him the win.
>> Yeah, that's the pickup for Kai'Sa. And
look, this is an expected result as far
as Kai'Sa's throughout the tournament.
We expect to see a lot of Kai'Sa kind of
coming out strong and especially a lot
of strong TCG players coming in and
having success with Kai'Sa. Pris came in
knowing he could play Kai'Sa or he can
go for metal card with Teemo and still
have a good chance to, you know, maybe
make top eight because he's done it
before. Uh and he he even said that he
said the metal card was one of the big
things that he wanted. Uh that could
have just as easily been a Kaiser mirror
between two great Kaiso players and we'd
see that kind of spot. But uh for NP
pass, you come in, you say, I want to
play the best deck. I've got my, you
know, little sneaky tech. kind of got
word that the seal was actually a one of
seal of rage. So you kind of have these
really high roll spots where you find
the seal next to a Darius and it works
out really great. And that's what you
need to win a tournament this big. You
need those like times where your deck
just says, "Yeah, we've got you. I've
got your back. You got to play great all
day. Sometimes the deck's got you."
>> Yeah. No. And although like Yeah, as
you're saying, he did choose to play
Kaisa. He did take a pretty unique take
on it. It's really cool to see it in
action. I definitely think he's going to
get a lot of edges throughout the day
with his opponents not being used to
some of his card choices. And it's kind
of cool cuz even though that seal of
rage is a one of, you know, it might
like spread around, especially going,
you know, if he makes a deep day two
run, people in the hall, it might be
like, oh, he's got a seal of rage. And
almost that like puts the fear in them
of like now I have to play around Darius
into Seal of Rage. And that's just a
whole another level of texture to the
game that Kais' normally.
>> Yeah. On five runes, you're never
playing around Darius. And now when you
play out pass, maybe maybe you do. Yeah,
realistically that's probably more value
out of the seal rage than even the seal
rage is going to give him in most of the
spots if people actually start worrying
about the legend of that. But we talked
about that earlier, the Kai'Sa builds,
the variation that we get to see. And
now pass gets to show us a new flavor,
right? The the time warps. I wonder when
the first time warp we'll see cast
actually comes from the KISA's. I mean,
I guess we did see one earlier on
against the Volibear, but that was
literally to draw a card and try and buy
some space. And I wonder if that card
continues to kind of show as maybe a
weak point and some of the top Kaisers
not being on it.
>> Yeah. No, it's very interesting. Like I
I respect the Kaisa decks kind of
pivoting to more of that low to the
ground strategy. Even especially like
you saw the rear guard like they are
really maximizing their ability to just
score points early and play that tempo
game. And when you're doing that and
doing it well, you really don't need a
card like Time Warp.
>> Yeah, exactly. Especially the Arena's
Greatest variations, as you said, right?
A little bit more aggressive, lower to
the ground. And Arita's greatest when
you're on the play, you get that extra
point, you're going to start really
running over some of these slower decks.
And I think for a deck like Teemo that
the name of the game against Kai'Sa is
time. These more aggressive builds like
we saw on Napas with the additional card
draw trying to find things like the uh
the falling star which can deal with the
the threats like Emer Monk from the
Teemo are actually going to be even
harder for Pris to deal with if he runs
into a lot more of that variation.
>> For sure. And you know, I think one of
the biggest edges you get when you cut
time warp is that actually opens up kind
of more slots for a Cathon rain because
you can only play so many of those
powerful expensive cards that kind of do
tax your runes and your power. But as we
saw in some matchups, Athenian rain is
just lights out.
>> Yeah. Another another big card that we
actually got to see get a lot of value
that's been out of a lot of Kais for a
while was that smoke screen in the first
game being able to deal with the ember
monk that minus four coming in big. And
I think one of the things to look at
with that smoke screen is two of the
decks that started to pick up uh some
steam coming into this event were Set
and Annie. And both of them actually are
a little susceptible to smoke screen
finding blowouts, especially into set.
But Annie when she's trying to play
around the Darius, it also has some of
that uh game. And we're even seeing some
of these edge cases where the smoke
screen still gets to work really well
against other decks as well.
>> No, I I kind of love the smoke screen. I
think it's sort of your like keep them
honest card from Kai'Sa cuz a lot of
times they're going to be playing around
intervals of three. You know, you've got
Hex Ray, you've got Cleave. So, a lot of
people playing against Kaiser are very
tuned into, oh, they can add three to
whatever this mathematical equation is.
And then sometimes that smoke screen
comes in and just by nature of being
four instead of three, it really changes
the whole scope of the combat or can
just swing something that otherwise
other cards couldn't do.
>> Well, we do have plenty more rounds to
get to after that. That is round two in
the books, but round three coming up
soon. We are going to be jumping into
those games soon enough, but just right
after this.
>> Chen, it's six to four and I'm holding
both battlefields. So, I have to conquer
both and hold on to them to win the
game.
>> Yeah, that's impossible.
>> Your Draven doesn't stand a chance
against my Azir and his mighty sand
soldier army. That's 10 total night,
buddy.
>> We'll see about that. I attack with
Draven.
>> Puny.
>> Pay one power and give him plus two.
>> Ooh, scary. Not.
>> That's not all. I pay one and play blood
rush, then give Draven plus two. I pay
one, play blood rush, and give Draven
plus two. You
>> don't have to repeat yourself. I heard
you the first time.
>> I'm using our new repeat mechanic.
>> Oh, well, it's still not enough to
conquer. With my remaining runes, I'm
going to support Draven.
With the long sword.
[Music]
Uh-oh.
Then I'm good. With my 12 my tier 10, I
will conquer this battlefield and wipe
your sand soldiers off the board.
>> Whoa, not so fast.
I wonder what this thing does.
I'll grant this quick draw equipment
sterx gauge to the one and only emperor
of the sands, Azir. That gives him three
additional might. You do not follow the
math, but you must witness, which gives
me 13 total might, one more than yours.
Your attack is defeated.
>> No.
>> I guess there's only one move left. I
invoke rule 650.
>> Riftbound rule 650. A player may concede
at any time.
>> GG.
>> Close game. Hi everyone, Chang and Dave
from the Riftbound team here. We hope
you've been having a blast with the
origin set.
>> We've been seeing a ton of theory
crafting starting from the initial card
reveals and the team is super energized
by that of excitement that you
Riftbounders have shown for our game.
>> As we continue on our Rifton journey, we
wanted to introduce everyone to our
second set, Spirit Forged. In Spirit
Forged, weapons aren't just tools.
They're extensions of your might and
soul. The forged aspect is the steel you
wield, while the spirit represents the
Ionia spirit blossom, which has lifted
the veil between the mortal and spirit
realms and made its way home in some of
the champions and art for our new set.
Spirit forge takes origins and builds
upon it in every way with more ways to
play each domain, 12 new legends,
equipment that lets you enhance your
units in new ways, and a new gear token
type, gold, which provides a new path to
power. You won't believe some of the
cool stuff we have coming your way.
>> Not to mention 12 incredible Spirit
Blossom overnumber cards like these.
>> Dave and Changen aren't allowed to show
you these cards yet.
>> Huh. All right. Well, here's something
we can tell you about. Equipment.
>> Take a look at Trinity Force. Equipable
for the low cost of a single power. It
grants your unit plus two might and also
gives you an additional victory point
when you hold a battlefield with it
equipped. tons of damage.
>> Uh, actually, it's just plus two might
and a victory point.
>> All right. All right. Moving on. We've
also got equipment that's a little
tricky to play, like Guardian Angel, a
card that prevents its unit from dying
one time.
>> But equipment is only as good as the
unit that holds it. Well, that's not
exactly true, as it can enhance any unit
or champion you play. But it does help
to know how you use the equipment. Enter
weapon master, one of our new keywords
that allows units to equip something for
free when played. Take a look at Lucian
Merciless. He can conquer again if he
wins the fight. And with the right
equipment in his hands, he definitely
will.
>> Mastery of equipment is definitely
strong, but I prefer speed. Quick draw
is our other new keyword. With quick
draw, you can plate equipment from your
hand onto a unit as a reaction, like on
this card, long sword. Quick draw makes
equipment an important part of the
chain.
>> The chain? Is that one of our new
weapons?
>> Gotcha. The chain is the sequence where
players respond to each other with
activated abilities or reaction spells
until both are done. It is not a
physical thing. Dave,
>> who is saying that? We actually don't
know.
>> There is something I do know all about.
Our new champion, legend, Civer and
Ranada Classic. These two champions are
all about gold. They create it and you
get to spend it. Spending gold gets you
a power resource of any domain, letting
you play more powerful cards.
>> One of my favorite new champions is
Draven Vanquisher, who generates gold
when he conquers. Time to cash in on all
that adoration.
>> And one of my favorite new champions is
Draven Vanquisher, who generates gold
when he conquers. Time to cash in on all
that adoration.
>> Uh, Dave, you okay? Why? Why are you
repeating me?
>> Sorry, I was just excited for the final
mechanic reveal. Repeat. With repeat,
you can play a spell twice if you can
pay its cost a second time. Spells like
feral strength are good, but if you have
the runes, we don't have to settle for
good. We can have great. All this talk
about repeat is making me think that our
last game needs a repeat, too.
>> Wait, what do you mean?
>> Chengren, it's six to four and I'm
holding both battlefields.
>> So, I have to conquer both and hold on
to them to win the game.
>> That's right. It's impossible. Wait, why
does this feel familiar?
>> Don't worry about it.
Hello, Riftbounders. I'm Barrett Bryant
and I have the absolute pleasure of
being joined with the Dave Guskin, game
director for Riftbound. Dave, I'm so
glad you can be here with me and I've
just got a couple of questions for you.
So, my first question I want to ask you
as we are here in Houston for the first
ever English regional qualifier, um,
what have you learned from the global
release now of Origins and building upon
that as a as a game designer?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, obviously we've still
got this kind of the results of this
tournament to see, but I think it's been
really interesting to see kind of how
people develop their understanding of a
brand new game, right? Like Rift is new
to everybody and Origins is kind of both
a new game as well as a new environment.
So, it's been interesting to see kind of
like the development of the Kai'Sa
versus E meta game and now kind of
moving into the English release and
seeing um you know Seth and Annie and
Ari kind of like maybe kind of getting
up there. Um so, it's been very
interesting and I think it's it's cool
to see people take the tools explore in
spaces that maybe we didn't even think
were interesting or um you know we
didn't expect and it's kind of seeing
you know players having their hands is
always the most exciting time for
designers. So,
>> with that same idea, yeah,
>> Spirit Forged on the horizon. That's
right. So as Origins functions as this
like base set beginning of the game.
Yeah.
>> Spirit forge, how is that meant to build
upon that layer and then also with
future sets obviously.
>> Yeah. So interesting note about spirit
forged. The equipment mechanic was
something we played with at the very
beginning of development for Riftbound.
So we actually we loved how it played
but we were like this is maybe like a
little bit too much to put into Origins.
Want to kind of build that foundation as
you said, right? The core rules of the
game and attacking and defending and
like that. So we took equipment and
brought it into Spear forge. So, we
actually kind of think of origins and
and spear forge together as like a
really strong foundation for the entire
game. That said, we put a lot of
interesting kind of new twists on color
combinations um and like the way that
you might play that kind of deck in
Spear Force. So, it'll be interesting to
see how that goes, especially with like,
you know, the making things mighty and
the like choosing targets kind of stuff
is pretty interesting new space for
Riftbound.
>> I personally really even like the repeat
mechanic being introduced. So,
>> I like the repeat mechanic too.
Going into Spirit Forge still on that
topic as a lot of people are excited for
those cards as we had the full set
released this week.
>> What do you think players are going to
be doing not just in 1 v one in a
competitive setting, but in multiplayer?
>> Yeah, multiplayer is kind of, you know,
I think of it as like the the heart of
Riftbound. Um, a lot of people are
playing 1 v one right now because easy
to find opponents, people are
competitive, they want to show that
they're mastering the game, but I think
multiplayer is kind of uh a really fun
way to play. I think interestingly, I
think there's a lot of cool tools for
2v2 in Spirit Forge. So you kind of
check for cards that say friendly and
you can use those on your partner stuff
in 2v2. I also think there's just like a
lot of cool um like big spell moments I
would say in Spirit forge and that's
always fun in multiplayer, right? Um one
of the things we did relatively recently
based on player feedback um maybe
earlier this year is we used to have a
rule where only the two players involved
in a combat could play spells unless you
were invited. But now we've kind of
opened it up so it's just like fun
chaos, you know, it's I love chaos and
it should. Yeah. So I think that'll be
really fun to see in Spirit Forest. I
love side formats. I love the
multiplayer. I'm here to play
multiplayer, Dave, with all my friends.
I'm not competing, obviously.
>> But speaking of side formats,
>> thoughts on expanding on draft for
Riftbound?
>> Yeah, so um as you may know, we have
sealed deck. Uh we kind of release rules
for that with Origins. Um and that's
play with three colors. Uh a deck is 25
cards and you build out a six-ack. So
draft, traditionally booster draft is
three packs. Um and then you kind of
draft a deck like that. We're still
working on rules for draft. I don't feel
100% confident that we've nailed it.
It's likely that um as we get closer to
something that I feel good about, that
the team feels good about, we'll kind of
release those rules, maybe even in like
a beta state and have players try it
out. Um but I I feel confident that
we'll find something and I think it'll
be really fun. Um we also have found
that like as we develop future sets,
we're spending more time thinking about
like, hey, how would this work in draft?
How would limited work? And kind of
making sure that we kind of build our
commons on commons and rares for that
purpose. So
>> I loved every part of that. That was
fantastic, Dave. And I hope everyone at
home also got to experience this insight
just as I did. Dave, thank you so much
for this and I can't wait to see what
else is coming for Riftbound.
>> Welcome back to the Houston regional
qualifier. I'm Kasanova still joined by
Frank Scarren. We are going to be
jumping in with round three in just a
moment here, but so far the games have
been very exciting, a lot of fun. We got
to see a lot of really unique deck list
come through and we did get to showcase
just how scary Kais' can be.
>> Yeah, you know, a lot of really great
matches, really close, good back and
forths. Got to see a pretty nice spread
of legends which is cool. We also just
got to see, you know, my boss there,
Dave Guskin, game director for
Riftbound, kind of talk all things
Riftbound and just really excited for
the future and excited for some more
great games today.
>> All right, well our next matchup coming
through. We're going to have yet another
deck that we have not seen yet. It is a
misfortune piloted by Ali Aldrazi if you
are familiar of long-term magic the
gathering grinder going up against
Linton lover on Annie.
>> Yeah, you know Ali I know him as more as
an acquaintance but just a really long
time Magic Grinder big in that scene.
I've seen he's really been getting into
Riftbound. It's really cool to see some
of these players from other card games
kind of like you know test the waters
with Riftbound. I I would expect him to
be you know really great here as he is
in Magic and really cool to see this
Misfortune deck he's bringing. I imagine
this is going to be the other side of
the dazzling Aurora coin we saw from the
earlier Garen match.
>> Yeah, and we we actually saw him at
Vegas as well. Had a pretty deep run.
Didn't quite make the top eight, but
still, you know, the fact is he's he's
flying around grinding Riftbound
already. I love that players from all
across the TCG sphere are kind of
joining together to say, you know what,
Ripbound looks great. I'm going to jump
in there and try that out. As we do have
basically the confirmation that this is
an Aurora Misfortune with the Sigil of
the Storm being the first battlefield.
So whenever Annie tries to go conquer
there, going to be slowing down the game
with some of those runes. On the other
side, another Warren start. I think most
of the Annies have coalesed on this
Warren's scrap heap game one game plan.
>> Yeah, just like you were talking about
earlier, the the Warren just a really
powerful way for Annie to leverage the
scrap heaps early and ensure those extra
card draws and find, you know, just
really every trick and tool they need to
finesse around their opponents.
>> All right, so starting out. Uh-oh.
This is not the first time we've seen
this happen. And I wonder if it's just
players not being used to which side uh
the uh the decks are going to be on.
Maybe they play on the other side. Uh
normally just trying to use the uh the
zones as best they can, but that is
going to be traveling Merchant to start
things out and the pass. The anti-
trigger comes through. And now on the
other side, we'll be going over with Ali
Drazzi. We'll see if he's able to find
the early ramp tools and if the Aurora
ends up in hand if we ever get a glitz.
>> Yeah, so we've se we've seen a little
bit of action from Annie so far today.
Lit lover uh is going to be looking to
kind of do the same thing. Get in, score
those early points, use movement tricks
to keep the battlefield in their favor.
Um and eventually maybe use Vi and ride
the wind to close it out. Ali Aldrazi on
the other side with a different take on
Dazzling Aurora with Misfortune um to
just find it, ramp up to it, put it into
play, and then just get some unbeatable
units on the board.
>> Yeah, and we've seen this time and time
again on the Warren game. Traveling
Merchant goes in, trash a card, draw a
card. Now the Warren's Conquer comes
through. Trash a card. Draw a card. And
I just saw a scrap he picked up. So
it'll be trash card, draw two cards if
the conquer comes through. But the Gust
going to be able to deny that.
>> Yeah, Alazi is going to do everything he
can here to kind of deny those early
points and just have the time he needs
to hopefully get Aurora in.
>> Yeah, I saw the three runes get uh get
turned sideways there and I said, "Yep,
that's a sneaky deck hand." But a
fighter is going to continue to buy some
space,
>> right? You know, it's it's it's
interesting cuz like Alias, he's really
trading cards negatively here, but he is
just stopping the point scoring and you
know, he may be down a bunch of cards
when he gets to the Dazzling Aurora
turn, but the Aurora will just make up
that disparity so quickly as long as it
has the time to do so.
>> Yep. And that's everything in the
matchup is time. And you know,
Misfortune is one of the decks that
can't really deal with the viide the
wind at six. you do have a way to kind
of buy space like a a fighter flight can
stop one of the conquers which can be
enough. Um but you don't get to destroy
the vice. So if there's a huge enough
trash, you might just be dealing with it
again on the next turn.
>> Yeah. I mean, you know, really
impressive for him to be able to stop
two attempts to conquer on only three
runes. And now we see that further paid
off with a catalyst of Aons. It's kind
of going exactly how he wants. The real
question is just going to be does he
have the dazzling Aurora? Yeah, that is
of course the question. But the fact
that instead of uh you know Litton Lover
being at two potentially able to score
to uh to three on this turn, it is just
going to be the first point of the game
and even then it might not even be an
opportunity here for Linten Lover to get
the second point. So going into you know
this third turn where Catalyst has come
down uh is going to be really really
tough for Annie to actually score enough
points in this game before MF just to
start dropping bombs cuz even without
the Aurora some of these fortune decks
are able to kind of put the pressure on
just playing mind spplitters out of hand
and kind of shredding the best cards
from your your deck,
>> right? Yeah. If there is no Aurora here,
a you know, dead bloom predator, a
mindspplitter, they'll do a great job as
well. Uh but you see Linton is now going
to take this kind of shields down moment
that Ali created by playing the catalyst
to be like, hey, I'm going to score this
one. I'm going to accelerate out of
Kai'Sa and score this one as well.
Although, since it's a sigil, it is
going to come at the cost of a rune
recycle and, you know, really play into
that game plan of slowing them down as
much as Alli can.
>> Yeah. So that's a a full uh turn d ramp,
right? Uh having to pay one for the
accelerate, now one for the conquer. So
just going to be very behind on the
runes. But Annie is very good at playing
this low econ low rune game as we do
have Ali now up to that uh very very
important ninth rune. And we just have
the question, is there going to be an
Aurora? I imagine if he's got it, it'll
be deployed immediately.
>> Yeah, you know, it's interesting. Even
just the even just the moment of
hesitation, seeing him start to think is
kind of like, oh well, he doesn't have
it
>> and now he's going to have to find the
next best play.
>> Yeah. And it might just be a dead bloom,
but we'll see. Maybe he was just
considering if there's any other
options. Is that's eight.
>> Nope. No,
>> not nine. So, it's it's a dead bloom.
>> You know, as we said, dead bloom, no
slouch either. And you know, if uh
Linton's going to want to use like a
fight or flight or something here, the
dead bloom does have have deflect, which
will cost another rune again and really
just slow the development. Yeah, it's
going to buy a lot of space. The ride
the wind being kind of uh grabbed there
as a consideration to just try and run
away. Uh the first one is free is what I
always say with the ride the wind
because Annie Stubborn can always grab
it back. Uh so you're kind of allowed to
use it however you'd like. Um, and it
looks like that may just be the case as
we see two runes uh tapped and that is
just going to be the power paid. Ride
the wind to save the Kai'Sa for now. Um,
so that's the first one in the bin so
that any stubborn can grab it later.
>> Yeah, and you really just got to love
the flexibility on Ride the Wind. You
know, not only is it this really
threatening tool to score points later
in the game, but as you see Lindlover
just totally okay with using it right
there to protect Kai'Sa and, you know,
keep her around to threaten more points
and more cards down the line. Yeah, the
question now becomes is is there a way
to kind of get through this dead bloom
cleave is usually the best answer and
Darius cleave is by far the best answer,
but this is five runes and you know we
talked about how usually on five runes
you don't have to play around Darius
because only a seal is kind of that zero
cost to push through and so uh yeah, not
going to be looking at Darius Cleave to
push over this dead bloom in this spot.
>> Yeah, the these are definitely the
pivotal turns where Lit Lover's got to
fight back against these uh big plays
starting to come down. Make sure Alli
doesn't get to run away with it too
much. And the Ann deck definitely has
the tools to do it.
>> Yeah, Vain. This is another way that
this can be answered, right? That's now
Vain gets the the plus three might with
the assault three that comes in and it
gets to come in ready when your opponent
controls a battlefield. So, with the
dead bloom there, this is now nine might
at home that can run into this uh dead
bloom and should be able to get over the
top.
>> Yeah. And it's interesting because, you
know, you're looking at Alrazi's side
and you're like, "Oh, he's got one rune
up. I don't know if I play around much
here." But actually, Misfortune has one
really powerful tool on the pocket in
bullet time, which for only one rune,
you could do a lot of damage. It comes
at a lot of development, but Ali does
potentially have the runes to do it.
Yeah, there is always the spot where you
say, you know what, I don't have the
Aurora anyway, so I'll spend five of my
runes and and uh just go ahead and put
them to the bottom of my deck, recycle
five runes, and just completely blow out
this play and then gank over my uh dead
bloom and say, you know what, this is
going to be enough to hold out. but uh
does not go for it if he even has the
bullet time in hand. Instead just gets
rid of the Kai'Sa and now Lintlover has
to consider if they wanted to pull back
the uh Vain to hand. Looks like decides
against it and instead will potentially
look for a hold.
>> Yeah, it's always an interesting
decision with Vain because Linton lover
could pay the energy, put it back in
their hand, and then you know they have
it to keep threatening those kind of big
assault and ready moves, but it does
cost a rune every time you're player.
Also, it's the sigil of the storm. So if
you keep conquering that repeatedly,
you're just going to lose more and more
runes. And Lintlover choosing to just
keep in and play, maybe seeing if they
can get some points from holding.
>> Yeah, cuz I mean this is big, right?
Annie is on three runes. There's just
been all of her runes have been gatekeep
the entire time uh from the sigil from
just needing to spend it on these
powerheavy cards. Uh but the control is
there and Ali is in trouble, right? He's
not up to nine runes anymore. might be
able to just go for another dead bloom,
but this time it's soul gorge into grab
dead bloom. So, this is a massive uh
power expenditure. Probably never
getting to Aurora this game. It's going
to come down to can the units from your
deck do enough as this soul gorgger is
going to grab that dead bloom. And
that's yeah, recycle four, maybe recycle
five if you go for the vein. Yeah, you
know, Soulgard is really interesting
from the Aurora decks because I see
them, you know, sometimes play it as
like a one of to make sure they kind of
never run out of resources to hit, but
even in just a spot like this, playing
it straight up, you know, it does cost a
lot of power as you mentioned, but this
is a really strong swing for Alli.
Yeah, lot of might gets to come to the
board. Does not want to recycle that
additional rune, so not going to go to
the Sigil of the Storm. Uh needing to
potentially uh stay on this break point
of going from four runes to six to maybe
uh eight on the following turn. still
keeping dead blooms in mind going
forward as this is going to be dropping
a confront and trying to find an
additional card as yeah as I said I
think Aurora is very much off the menu
for this game and he's got to try and
win with the other pieces. Yep. But I
know I think he's been doing a great job
at that so far. You know the first Dead
Bloom Predator is often hard to beat.
The second one especially when you know
taken back from the trash by a card like
Solar Gorgger can be even harder to beat
>> and a hidden card to back it up.
>> Okay, this is a lot of being expended.
as the hidden card is going to go down
there. I I mean I imagine fighter or
flight there's really not anything else
that gets played uh in this deck most of
the time. And I'm curious if we've got
any like main deck rebukes coming out of
the Annie as well. That's one where it's
like maybe there's one copy in the maid
and some of the side and usually that'd
be a huge blowout. But I if I remember
correctly, rebuke is at battlefield
only. And so a fighter flight could
actually be massive here where you make
your opponent recycle three runes to
target the dead bloom with a rebuke and
then you just kind of send it home.
>> Yeah. No, I agree with you there. I'm I
believe rebuke is battlefield only. And
having that fight or flight hidden,
there's really not much Annie could do
to punish you and make you lose it on
the spot. And it does just give you that
extra layer of protection against, you
know, big assault units, things like Vi
Ride the Wind and anything of that
nature.
>> Yeah. And it looks like VI Ride the Wind
is currently in hand uh for Linton
Lover. So trying to just get to that
sixpoint break point where you can
really look to just send it and go for
game. And uh for now you're very ahead
when it comes to uh points in this game.
So you can just look to build up a huge
board, get to that six points next turn,
and then try and win on the following
turn. You've got that time. Yeah, we've
seen this a lot for Manny, like just
kind of using that early point advantage
to kind of leverage almost like a setup
turn in the middle of the game where
you're saying, "Hey, I'm going to take
off scoring points for a second and just
make sure I can get what I need on the
board to win down the line."
Yep. On the other side of Ali going up
to uh five runes now because of the hide
actually going to be kind of off that uh
even cadence. Five runes does allow you
to play maybe a misfortune at home. Uh,
but really there's not a ton that this
deck does on five runes. And I'm
wondering if there's maybe ramp cards in
hand to potentially be played out. But
that's three and an invert timelines
going to just kind of reset these hands
dumping an Aurora and a sabotage. And
it's going to be a lot of cards gone for
Linton Lover, including the Vide. But
also, that's a scrap heap. So, it is
going to be five cards drawn up for
Linton.
>> Yeah, it is interesting. Like scrap
heap, it's not just if you make yourself
discard the card. If your opponent makes
you discard it, too, you do get that
rebate. So, but you know, a pretty good
deal for Ali as he was running pretty
low on resources there.
>> Yeah. So, he's going to find uh a new
grip of h uh a grip of cards and he does
deal with a V ride the win, right? So,
there is maybe some time that can be
bought. Now, you don't know what the new
hand is for Annie and odds are those are
pretty good cards too if they made it
into the deck, but it will potentially
buy you a lot of space if you can
continue to count those vies. Uh maybe
eventually you can run Lint Lumber out
of them. Yeah, giving giving Annie a
fresh hand of cards. Definitely pretty
spooky as a lot of their cards are
pretty redundant and really good at
dealing with big units with cards like
Fighter Flight. And let's see if Linton
Lover found any of them.
Yeah, a couple of flashes which are a
lot less good in this spot. Right, the
flashes uh maybe for the early game
could have been nicer, but uh as of now,
I think in this matchup a little bit
dead at this stage of the game where
most of your material you don't really
mind if it gets taken out. You're just
trying to use uh the last few big
conquers. So, I will say, yeah, a couple
of kind of dead cards, but the fighter
flight will certainly help out a little
bit more as she is going to just try and
target the dead bloom. Going to have to
pay the deflect cost there.
>> Yeah, and it's interesting cuz Ali could
have ganked the dead bloom over to the
sigil, but I imagine just like wanting
not wanting to recycle a rune and you
know, he's not really trying to rush the
points down at this point. I think his
best way to finding a win here is to
kind of make sure he can just build up a
really strong board presence and then
use that to eventually look to lock
Linton Lover out.
>> Yeah, I like this. Five into five here
from the Vain into the Soul Gorgger very
willing to just take the trade.
Fighterflight is going to send Vain
home. Uh but when we saw that hand
fanned out from Lintlover, there's a
couple of cleaves that are going to work
great with the traveling merchant to
still make this trade happen.
>> Yeah, that's a really great play by
Lintlover cuz it's kind of saying, I'm
going to make you use this. If you
don't, yeah, we trade and then you just
lose the fight or flight for free.
>> So, double move triggers, try and draw
some e even more potential plays to go
around here. And then the cleave
available to just continue to push this
over the top.
So, a lot of cycling coming through, a
lot of stuff being put in the trash
trying to find the next copy of Vi
because again, you have Annie Stubborn.
So, the ride of the wind always gets
through. It's just a matter of being
able to find a new copy of VI to replace
the old one.
>> Yeah. And now Litten Lover has kind of
set up the exact situation that their
deck excels in, which is, hey, I've made
it to six and now really at any moment
I'm just threatening that sweet end the
game combo.
>> Yeah. And I mean, this is one of the
reasons that a lot of players started to
stray away from Misfortune was the rise
of Annie. This matchup is actually very
hard to play against because of how fast
Annie can be. And we're seeing that
here. You know, I think Ali's doing a
great job of trying to slow this deck
down and try and stop it from being that
terror, but as you see, so many
resources having to be expended just to
slow the deck down and now even having
to dump so many runes even once he found
the Aurora, there just wasn't even time
to play it. Yeah, and you know, I think
that that soul while that soul gorgger
play was really powerful, he did feel
the pain of having to recycle four runes
on the later turns and you know, Linton
lover really just capitalizing on that
momentum and scoring points and just
getting to the to the spot that the anti
deck wants to be
is now being at six. And even without Vi
ride the wind, it's actually just kind
of possible from this board state that
you don't even need the VI. like it can
just be Darius Ride the Wind in a cleave
or something of that nature.
>> Yeah, definitely the the cards that Fury
has access to are just so good at just
getting over the top of like one big
unit out of out of some of the bigger
body units or like a mind spplitter and
Lin lover really in the driver's seat
here, but we'll see if Ali can do
anything to turn it around.
>> Yeah, and as you said, you know, one
unit, right, fighter flight, there's one
in the bin. So, you just that's that's
as good as in hand when you got any
stubborn and I think there actually is
also a fighter flight in hand. So, a lot
of ways to kind of deal with this as
that is going to be the dead bloom
moving in. And now there's the
consideration of uh do you want to
actually push this dead bloom back? It
would in my opinion be a mistake to push
it back now because the runes are up to
play misfortune accelerated. You can
send her in, rye the dead bloom, and
then send it in again.
>> Yeah, it's interesting. I feel like
sometimes
you'll almost forget that the Misfortune
chosen champion is like a pretty big
part of the equation cuz it's just sort
of hanging out there in the zone and
there's like a lot of other things going
on. But that ability to ready anything
can really come up in big spots and you
know we might be about to see one of
them here.
>> Yeah. So I mean you can either ready you
know potentially ready a rune here to
have two runes up to try and help defend
with maybe your own fighter flight or
you get to ready this dead bloom be able
to send it in as a potential way to help
hold. And that is going to be the choice
is the dead bloom.
It's the stack deck while there's a a a
showdown window here to use it.
>> Yeah.
>> To make the most out of your energy.
>> Yeah. Imagine this stack deck isn't
looking to solve the problem now as much
as looking to make sure you have what
you need the next turn.
>> And she finds a VI off it. So, I think
that is a big find. That's exactly what
the deck's been looking for to kind of
almost guarantee the to seal the deal
where you get to develop the VI. You
will have to still kind of find the ride
the wind via the Annie. So, you might
have an additional setup turn to make
this happen. uh as the runes I don't
think math out. Um but that's still the
big thing that you're looking for as Ali
is just going to fortify the Z warrants.
>> Yeah, I will say looking at Linton
lovers trash uh hard to tell exactly but
I know there hasn't been any recycles
yet so that is going to be a pretty
gigantic buy.
>> A million I think. Yeah, I think I think
I think it's about a million.
>> Yeah, maybe maybe even two.
>> Yeah, potentially. Yeah,
>> as you see here,
Linton now, you know, four points on the
side of Ali. Is this just another setup
turn? As there's a Darius in hand as
well, I believe. So, you could just kind
of play a Darius, be like, "Here's a
here's a chunk of might. I got Darius.
I've got Vain." And then wait to play
the uh the Vi uh until uh you can
actually do the full Vi ride the wind
combo. In the event uh that you do run
into something like a challenge, I think
trying to play around that can be kind
of uh quite valuable. Um the other side
of it is you don't play around the
challenge and you just uh play out the
VI and then you're now playing around a
fighter flank because you've got the
initial ready at the start of turn and
then when you move it in and then ride
the wind you can rery her with the ride
to win.
>> Definitely. Yeah. No. Uh, Ry the Wind's
ability to fight back against fight
orflight is really awesome and just, you
know, comes up a ton honestly and I one
thing that I want to call out here
that's pretty interesting and what I
really like about this Dazzling Aurora
deck that Ali has is you would think
when you read the Misfortune Legend like
oh give something ganking that kind of
sounds like an aggressive tool and it's
like oh maybe that's not going to be
that good in this build because the deck
doesn't play early units but it's
actually pretty pivotal in these later
turns cuz you could be like I have this
hold stack protecting this one
battlefield. That's how I'm going to
stop you from double conquering. And
then to stop you from holding yourself,
I could just gank one over and break up
whatever you're doing over here. So, it
really can create these strong reversal
board states where the Dazzling Aurora
deck can dig itself out of a pretty big
hole. And
>> and I think that's been the pivotal part
that pushed the Misfortune Dazzling deck
from being like pretty good with the
units that it access to with the
mindsplitter being able to rip cards
from hand. And you know, you got the
dead blooms of course being in the body
color and also you know things like
fight or flight to stall, bullet time to
stall and kind of pushed it to being
actually a very good deck like a
tournament deck where now you also have
this counterplay to the counter hole.
>> Yeah, definitely one of the decks that
took a few iterations but I think it's
found a really a really sweet spot in
the meta.
>> And there we going up going to have to
deal with the vein but of course as you
said right you've got the easy access
just go for the gank. you're able to get
that dealt with as Lover didn't go for a
full develop just the pouty porro and
holding on to a lot more runes this time
around. That is going to be six runes
going up to eight which would be enough
to play Annie Stubborn buy and ride the
whip.
>> Yep. Looks like Linton lover is just
going to try to deploy that full combo
from hand to close out the game and I'm
sure it's on Ali's radar but sometimes
it's just one of those combos that even
when you know it's there sometimes you
can't do anything about it. Yeah, I mean
that's the big thing, right? This deck,
I think the only answer that it has
available is going to be Ride the or
sorry, not Ride the Wind, uh, Fighter
Flight, uh, or potentially Rebuke, but
main deck rebuke in this deck is not
something I see a ton of.
>> Yeah, it's definitely like, you know,
bullet time. That's not even going to
come close to clearing the VI threshold.
Maybe if you have enough might in a
battlefield, but it's definitely it's
definitely hard.
>> Yeah, it'll be really tough. So, we are
going to get the gank. There's this
natural ganking also on uh just this
misfortune as we did see an energy
created ready the rune on this. Now do
it again and then recycle the rune to
the conqueror. So being able to get a
couple extra energy for this turn.
>> Yeah, you know that's another just
really nice nuance of Misfortune.
There's not many things that in the game
right now that let you ready kind of
anything you want. She could ready your
unit. She could ready your runes. She
could ready your legend. Whatever you
need, she's got you.
>> And now that's going to be another 24
six. So, eight total
energy being exhausted here for Ali.
Could just be another dead bloom to help
hold it. Is a mind spplitter this time
>> and you can take the V away.
>> Yeah, V ride the wind off the table once
again.
>> No, the mindsplitter is actually kind of
exactly what Ali needs here because, you
know, he sused it out. He does know
about it and this is something that he
can do about it. I imagine he's got to
slam this V here and it's kind of going
to put Lint lover on a top deck, I
think.
>> Yeah, this is the proactive approach,
right? So, you've got the reactivity of
being able to have fighter flight as an
answer or rebuke if you happen to have
it in the main board. But re uh
proactively, you can just mind spplitter
out the combo pieces and get rid of
them. And while you can't get rid of
Ride the Wind because of Annie Stubborn,
you can get rid of the vise. And we
talked about earlier if you can remove
all of the vise, maybe you can get
through it. And we saw one get taken out
by the invert timelines. Now one gets
taken out by the mind spplitter pro.
There's just one more that can even be
in the deck. So if you can deal with
that last one in some way, you might
just have enough might to hold through
anything else.
>> Yeah, and that was, you know, that kind
of double-edged sword that you were
talking about where do I keep the buy
safe in my hand or do I put it in play
and risk it dying to a removal spell.
Another thing that, you know, other than
the fight orflight, ride the win
situation, it does open it up to mind
spplitter getting to just yink it on
out.
>> Yeah, you have to decide, do I play
around challenge or do I play around
mindsplitter? And in this case, well,
unfortunately, Mindsplitter was the one
that Ali had and was able to take it
away from Lintlover. Now, while this
game looked well within hand for
Lintlover, I actually think it's going
to be a struggle to push over this 15.
Uh, we know there's a cleave and a
Darius, but there's not enough runes to
do all the things that Lintlover needs
to do.
>> Yeah, and again, that misfortune legend
just sitting there threateningly being
like, "Hey, maybe you can kick my body
misfortune out of the sigil, but then
there might be a dead bloom predator
who's going to gank his way on over.
Yeah, and the rest of the hand is a
Kai'Sa and a Vain. I mean, I I think at
this point we're actually looking like
Ali has completely flipped it with this
mindslitter. One card completely turning
the tides of this entire game as the
Darius gets to conquer. A card gets to
be drawn by Linton Lover, but it has to
be something incredibly impactful to
make a difference here because Ali's
just going to be able to gank over with
a seven or an eight to try and score the
last point and win this game as two of
the cards in hand we know are completely
worthless. Yeah, I think the big thing
Littton lover would be looking here
maybe be a fighter flight to try to, you
know, push off an attacker, but we'll
see what they can do.
>> Yeah, I was looking at the hand. It
looked like a unit was ripped again. Is
that just like double vein and a Kai'Sa?
I think it's not enough. And Ali might
have actually turned the corner on this
game that felt pretty doomed for a while
off the back of a mindspplitter. Just
showing the power of that kind of
thought sees effective looking into the
hand stealing something.
>> Yep. And he's going to start off with a
stack deck to just be like, "Hey, I'm
going to make sure I give myself the
best chance that I can." I think I saw
the a ride the wind in there, which I
imagine will help even further secure.
>> Saw another soul gorge. We talked about
it maybe a one of in a lot of these, but
Ali opting to go for two of them in the
list at least.
>> Yeah. And you know, it really paid him
off this game. That was a It cost him a
lot of power, but it was a pivotal turn
to make sure he didn't fall too far
behind.
And you know, I got to say, if he wins
this game here, I honestly think the MVP
for him was Sigil of the Storm.
Literally just had to cuz you know, some
decks can be like, "Oh, I'll just
conquer the other battlefield." But the
Annie deck is kind of priced into
saying, "I'm just going to conquer both
as often as I can cuz that's how I win."
And when you're forced to just conquer
Sigil again and again and again, it's
just so many runes. And we could see,
you know, there was that turn where they
were one short of doing the combo. And
that's thanks to Sigil of the Storm.
>> Yeah. Yeah, and even in this uh most
recent turn having the extra veins, you
might have been able to get enough might
on the board uh to try and push through
a second Darius, right? But how many
runes have been lost to the sigil
denying that ability or even the ability
to play out uh any stubborn to grab
another cleave or just any other answer,
fighter flight, whatever that you need,
and it's just not there. So instead, it
is going to be that game one going over
to Ali Aldrazi on the Misfortune. And
really, I was starting to even count him
out as we were getting towards the end
there with the Van Hand, but it just
came down to that mindsplitter making it
all happen.
>> Yeah. No, that was a that was a really
great game. And you know, some people
think like, oh, if the Misfortune deck
doesn't find the dazzling Aurora, they
can't really play the game. The deck
doesn't have much bite. But we saw there
in a game with no Aurora at all, he was
able to kind of just play his bigger
units, get that soul gorge for the big
tempo tempo play, and get it done.
>> Yeah. Well, let's jump right on into
game two. See what other adjustments can
be made for the Annie player or even for
Aliadres against this matchup that can
be so difficult. Able to get it done in
game one. But will he be able to get it
done for the rest of the series? This
time he does have his oblisk of power to
answer the arena's greatest. So Annie
gets to be on the play for Arena's
greatest, which is a struggle for any
slow deck, but obisk might be able to
make that still get flipped if it is the
immediate catalyst. and an Aurora in
hand, you can kind of start to bring
things back.
>> Yeah, it it is interesting because it's
kind of like the bounce back where it's
like Arena's greatest is a big going
first, but then Obelisk is a big going
second battlefield and you know it's
going to give both players power. I do
think Lintlover might have missed the
rune from Obelisk.
>> Yeah,
>> but uh a catalyst from Ali is going to
really vault him ahead on development.
>> Yeah, it does look like it was missed,
but it did look like a sneaky deck hand
was picked up. So, this is going to be a
lot of early points going to Litton
Lover. Already going to be up to three
as Ali Aldrazi is completely tapped out.
Nothing he's going to be able to do to
react to this as the traveling merchant
gets to move on to the oblisk as well.
>> Yep. And, you know, the sigil of storm
no longer a factor this game. So, Linton
lovers is going to be able to conquer as
much as they want to.
>> Yeah, we'll see if that rune ends up
eventually mattering. Usually with
Annie, you can kind of get away with it
and it's okay. But, we did see, you
know, how much damage Sigil of the Storm
did last time. So even that one rune
might end up making a difference in this
game. You really want to make sure that
you uh just slowly when you start the
games make sure you hit all those
triggers.
>> All right. And this game we'll get to
see if Ali actually can get that
Dazzling Aurora down. This isn't going
to be the turn for it. Uh what would his
best play this turn be?
>> I mean eight runes you can just kind of
dead bloom at this point. It's it's very
it is tough for Annie to deal with the
dead bloom. It's it's not a a fun card
for Annie to actually have to deal with.
uh it would slow down your Aurora yet
another turn. So sometimes it's not
exactly what you want to see. It's why
we've even seen some MF Aurora decks
going towards more of the mountain
drakes and the Ursign like staying away
from the high power costed stuff. So you
can still play them out and hit your
Aurora on curve.
>> Yeah, it is an interesting fork cuz it's
like do I want if if if Ali's looking at
both a dead bloom and an Aurora being
like do I want to play this now? Do I
feel like I'm far enough behind that I
need to get this on the table and
contest some of these points? And that
is what we're going to see here added
onto the obelisk of power to come try to
smush the poor traveling merchant.
>> And uh usually smush indeed would
happen, but that is just going to be a
fighter flight to buy the time for the
merchant this time around. So going to
be able to easily go up to five points
just lightning fast from Annie. And I
believe in the hand I also did see a
rebuke. So there is you know even more
time that can be bought. Either could
have sent this dead bloom back to hand
or decides this time to just fight
orflight instead. And I wonder if that
rebuke is just being held to try and
grab that last point because it is such
a potent ability.
>> Yeah, Lint and Lover are really going to
looking like they're going to lean into
the arena's greatest here. Try to rack
those points up fast. And it's actually
interesting that probably the most
resilient threat against Rebuke is Dead
Bloom Predator because you know if Ali
starts with all his runes and he's just,
you know, going to attack a battlefield,
if it gets rebuked, it could just come
right back down onto the same
battlefield.
>> Right. So up to five just a Kai'Sa at
home going to pass the turn. We'll see
if Ali decides to spend any runes before
sending the dead bloom in because that's
where things could really come into play
with the rebuke, but spending a rune for
sabotage will be able to easily deal
with it as he can just get rid of that
rebuke. And that's such a nice answer to
have. Yeah, and honestly not the best
hand here from Liten Lover. They are
gonna have to hopefully get some extra
draws off the Kaiser they already have
in play or maybe this traveling merchant
will stick around to help dig for some
new options. But with the sabotage
taking the rebuke, it does feel like Ali
might be able to put himself in the
driver's seat pretty soon.
>> Yeah, I think that uh Liver was pretty
reliant on this rebuke for finding a a
winning line and this is going to be a
big struggle to deal with the dead
bloom. Now, there is of course the fight
orflight in the bin that you can go and
grab with the Annie Stubborn to kind of
conquer up to seven with your Kaisen,
maybe draw an extra card and try and
look, but that doesn't get you that
eighth point. And the eighth point
becomes so difficult due to, as you've
mentioned, the ganking from Bounty
Hunter allowing this dead bloom to just
run a muk back and forth.
>> Yeah, I I think Linton lover is going to
have a pretty good chance to close this
one out, but it's going to have to be
done pretty quickly before the
Misfortune deck can run away with it.
So there we're going to just have
potentially Misfortune Captain come from
the champion zone.
>> Yeah, if Misfortune Captain comes in,
especially accelerated to knock out the
sneaky deck hand, it's kind of going to
be saying no more free points. But
instead, we're going to see a mindsitter
to really really fully pick apart Litten
Lover's hand.
>> Yeah, just keep shredding the hand and
put way too much might to be dealt with.
And this completely locks out the Annie
stubborn fighterflight conquer line as
well as a hidden card coming down. So
this stack becomes difficult to deal
with unless lover can find something
like the Vi uh to try and push over the
top. And one thing I I really love about
this play is if Ali had let's say
attacked and killed the sneaky deck
hand, the Kai'Sa could have potentially
conquered back and drawn a card. But now
this way it pretty much leaves close to
no opportunities for this Kaiser to
conquer since sneaky deckhand already
controls the battlefield. And that's
just one less card that you know Litten
Lover is going to be able to draw.
>> Yeah. And now the sneaky deckhand draw
from Linton Lover on the top of the deck
this time. Sneaky deck hand plus flash
that doesn't do anything in this
matchup. There's there's really not uh
much that can be done here. And sneaky
deckhand is way past its time. It's
something that you want to be able to
rumage away. And we're not on zon warren
anymore. So this is kind of stuck. It's
just a dead card as well as the flash
realistically. Yeah, sneaky deck hand.
Really one of those cards that just has
an insane range. Sometimes it's the best
card you've ever seen and sometimes it
is a three mana two might do absolutely
nothing. I would rather it be anything
else and this is one of those times.
>> Yeah. And for this turn to have to just
be pass do nothing and it's not even
holding up resources to do anything big.
You're just giving time to an Aurora
deck to continue to reamp the runes and
and set itself up to just have way too
much might on the board to be dealt
with. And I think this is the the part
of the game where Ali Alreza can start
to really run away with things giving
ganking to the dead bloom going to run
over. Flash can be used if you want to
maintain this two might. And
realistically, I mean, I don't know if
the flash gets better.
>> Yeah, I mean I will say the big thing
that Lyn lover has going for them is six
points. You know, that is the magic
number. So, it's going to take Alli a
couple turns here to get to the to the
magic eight. And if Lyn lever could just
find a way to pull off the double
conquer, they're threatening the win
every single turn from here on out.
>> Yeah, I need something like a
there's a lot of runes here. I wonder if
there's enough for something like a
fighter flight to go into the dead
bloom. You move in, you conquer, you get
a ride the wind off the draw. You're
able to play the Annie stubborn fight
orflight the other unit, ride the wind
over, try and score these last few
points. But I think it's is not quite
enough runes to get all of those things
done in a single turn.
>> Yeah, especially with the hidden card at
Obliska Power almost certainly being a
fight or flight. It's it is going to be
a pretty big mountain to overcome, but I
think this is an accelerated Kai'Sa. So,
it looks like a call to action.
>> Yeah, send these in into the seven. The
flash is there, so if this is a fight or
flight, you can just flash everything
back. um which will allow there not to
be a a trade and still keep the the
might on board which I guess is just
kind of again like it doesn't get much
better. So this is where you just kind
of have to deploy it. You've gotten
through that fighter flight and the
question just becomes can you now find
enough to actually push through and find
the win again there is that fighter
flight in the bin so Annie Stubbard can
find that for the next turn and at least
you can push one of these back. So there
is kind of some opportunity to maybe
find a win. Yeah, I mean I will say just
getting that hidden fight or flight off
the board is pretty huge. I would
definitely great play to trade a trash
from that from Littton Lover a flash for
that. Um and yeah,
>> jumping in eight runes once again
available for Ali.
It is kind of crazy to see how these
games have just not been about dazzling
Aurora at all. And it doesn't really,
you know, the lack of it has not
actually looked that painful.
>> Well, and that goes to show some some
good deck building, right? You need to
be able to have a game when you don't
find it. And it is the difference
between an MF Aurora deck and say a
Garen Aurora deck. This is not to fire
shots at T and his Garen deck earlier
on, but it is just the nature of having
the the purple orange combo instead of
the yellow orange combo uh for the
Aurorus is there's a there feels to be a
lot more room to make a deck that is a
bit more functional when you are missing
the Aurora.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And you know, you see some
of these misfortune builds really lean
into I'm going to play scrap heaps, I'm
going to play treasure troves, I'm going
to play pack of wonders, and they are
really setting up their whole game plan
to be dig to Aurora, nothing else
matters. And I don't know if Ali has
those cards in his deck, but we haven't
seen them yet. He seems just way more
comfortable with just playing ramp into
big units, and that's good enough. And
if you have Aurora, even better,
>> cuz we are finally going to see any
stubborn hit the board. I feel like the
fighter flight is the only thing that is
really helpful in the bin. In fact,
actually the only two options are flash
and fight orflight because Sabotage
recycles the the card. So Rebuke does
end up at the bottom of the deck. Can't
be grabbed by any Stubborn, which is a
very big note for Sabotage in this
matchup as is now going to just be I
believe just that fighter flight
deployed. Deal with the dead bloom to
send it home. Yeah, this this might be
where Linton lover can try to go on a
miracle run. You know, get that out of
here with fighter flight. Conquer with
Kai'Sa. Maybe draw another fight or
flight or something else. Oh, but here's
that sneaky deck hand.
>> Okay, so sneaky. This is saying Ali have
nothing. If he's got nothing for all
these runes, then you get to send both
the Kaises in uh to deal with the mind
spplitter and push through there. Um but
it is going to be enough at least for
now. Uh does end up having a fight or
flight to deal with the sneaky deck hand
and now sending in the double kaises a
rebuke. So he does actually have it
probably in the board uh and bringing in
as a way to deal with Vi, but that is
going to stuff the double Kai'Sa and
opens up a hold for Ali and a dead bloom
at home to run into an open arena's
greatest. And that's just going to do
it. 200 for Misfortune over Annie, which
is not the result that I would normally
expect for this matchup.
>> Yeah, you know, Ali kind of just played
it really well. Had what he needed when
he needed it. And it's it really is
amazing to just see the Aurora deck's
ability to just cover those point
spreads cuz both games he was just in
like a five or six point hole and was
just able to battle back battle back and
eventually just kind of get to that
board state where he could just have a
big unit in each battlefield or threaten
the ganking while having the interaction
from his hand that he needs
>> starts to make make me think there's
maybe a bit more to the matchup than
just like a big Annie favor. You know, I
think coming into this event, I probably
would have put it at like a 60/40 for
Annie. But, uh, you know, we look at
this this match up and while it still
looked tough, it didn't feel like Alli
was completely out of control or out of
contention at any moment. And it may
just be that the MF build does need to
be flexible enough to really lean out of
the Aurora in this specific matchup.
Really lean to get a dead bloom down and
kind of defend it as dead bloom is so
difficult for the analyst to actually
kind of handle. Yeah, I mean we saw in
both the games really just the the rune
tax that's put on by Sigil of Storm, put
on by deflect. Really can kind of just
back Annie into a corner because the
Annie deck loves to just get all it
runes into play, use the Annie from the
champion zone, just kind of have a ton
of energy to work with. And that just
wasn't something Linton Lover was able
to do this match.
>> And I think really notably that we can
kind of look at from this match is
Alli's ability to kind of dodge the
vise. And one of them was of course, you
know, blind invert timelines kind of
gets rid of it. And then from there,
it's pretty targeted on, hey, I lose the
VI. So, when I'm thinking about what
options I have for my turn, the
mindsplitter has to be the best choice.
Even though it does completely run you
out of resources, so you won't really
have much to defend from there. The
might of that plus denying the one card
that always beats you is enough to
actually make it happen. Yeah, the the
invert timelines was was really cool
there because I feel like, you know,
thinking about it, I'm sure this is not
kind of the the intended role for the
card in the deck, but it does allow you
to be like, you know, that your Annie
opponent is likely just trying to hoard
the combo into their hand and you can
just catch them off guard with an invert
timelines, get like a ride, the wind, a
VI, and you know, they do get to draw
four new cards, maybe the fifth like we
saw with Scrap Heap, but they do still
have to draw the extra copies and
they're not always going to.
>> All right. Well, our next round or our
next match for round three is another
exciting one. We've got set for the
first time on the broadcast. It is going
to be piloted by Togg, a content creator
for Riftbound. Makes a lot of set
content and he has been having a pretty
good run so far. You know, 20 start
going up against a Kaiisa, which we've
seen some players talking about thinking
that set might even have a little favor,
which is why it was picking up in
popularity coming into this event. And
we'll see if TOG can prove us right in
that match up.
>> Yeah. No, it's really interesting
matchup. I think Set has a lot of tools
to deal with the things that a lot of
the Kai'Sa decks are doing. You know,
you got sabotage, you maybe got some
unyielding spirits in the board, and
then you even I see a lot of the sets
used to start with the uh body set in
the chosen champ zone. I see a lot of
them moving to the order set because if
you get a buff on that, he goes up to
seven and he's out of falling star
range.
>> Yeah, I think that's been the big thing
with Kingpin and especially with the
arena bars coming in in more enforce in
the main deck. We've seen uh
historically we saw either zero bar or
maybe one of bar as maybe a high roll
option, but now a lot of set players
opting for three bar in the main to try
and enable exactly what you're talking
about that kingpin having the buff being
at seven dodging that falling star range
or even just kingpin with showstopper
being such a potent combination. And
while the brawler set is a little bit
better in some of the matchups like Yei
uh where you need that extra might to
push over the top and you need to ensure
that you have a buff body earlier on, I
think that the Kingpin has found a lot
of room to be quite strong as we are
going to be jumping into this matchup as
we've got Togg on set the boss versus
emo Tempest on Kaisa Daughter of the
Void. Yeah, and you know, it's going to
be an interesting balance for Togg
because uh body and calm are kind of the
domains that get to dish the buffs out
and then order is the domain that
usually spends them. So, as Set, you're
sort of missing access to some of those
things that give you the buffs, but
that's where a card like arena bar comes
in that can just give you the buffs
again and again could be really critical
for set to be able to spend the buffs
and do the things that they need to do
to make sure you know the juice is
always flowing.
>> Yeah. Well, we're going to get to see
which type of uh set this is as it
actually is going to be a brawler champ
Zone for Togg. For me, I've preferred
this. I actually really like brawler
champ Zone, but 3x Kingpin in the deck.
Uh where I like to always have access to
this buffed unit when I maybe miss the
buff enablers, whereas I still want to
see the kingpins throughout the game.
And so, I'm wondering if Tog will be on
a similar build to that or if he's even
leaning heavier into the brawler. But
we're going to see in this first game on
Dreaming Tree. So to valuing the card
draw from some buffs or from the uh the
spells that are he's going to target his
units with the call of the glories uh
coming through as one of the main ones
that we're going to be looking at. And
on the other side, Voidgate just trying
to create a hostile environment on the
other battlefield getting that plus one
damage from the Kaisa spells.
>> Yep. And a a slightly slow start from
Tog. No uh two energy play, but here
comes a Fiora victorious to get on the
board and start to contest and fight
back against this Raven Bloom student.
Yeah, and it looks like the quick
response from Tempest is just to falling
star this. But considering if he wants
to move in with the Raven Bloom first is
going to send that to Tree. Going to
just take that conquer. You know, we saw
him fanning the cards for the Falling
Star. I think it makes sense. Uh Tog had
a slow start and you can just keep him
off the board even further. It it's
going to be a really strong play to
make. So the Falling Star is just going
to come down.
>> Yeah, set set is at his scariest when he
can get some units. You know, set's
really sticky. Once you get the buffs
on, you can use the boss legend to keep
your units in play through the removal.
So, Emote Tempest doing a really heads
up job of saying, I'm just going to
spend this falling star now before Fior
can get buffed and before she can get
that resiliency.
>> Yeah, now going to be going up to six
runes. There's potential to to come in
with the uh the brawler making an
appearance and then actually having a
buffed unit already starting to roll.
So, you don't have to worry too much uh
about, you know, not being able to be
sticky whatsoever at that point. But,
we'll see if there's any other good
options in the hand. Still a lot of
cards remaining for Tog. He had to miss
the first turn. So really just that
Fiora coming down. Plenty of options
should still be around.
>> Yeah. And definitely, you know, it's
it's a scary thing to have a slow start
against Kai'Sa. It's a it's a deck that
can really punish you for doing that.
But we'll see what Todd can do to kind
of regain some of that tempo. And you
know, Separ is a great way to do that.
And as you said, that guaranteed buff
just gives you that built-in resiliency.
>> Yeah. And that is going to be the
option. So now really you're watching
out for like there's not much that can
completely get rid of your brawler from
home. Uh you need uh like double stupify
plus a falling star or something to kind
of push through. Um but this is just
going to be spend the buff then
showstopper in just trying to get on
board immediately. You'll get to refresh
the buff from the showstopper. This is
going to be nine might coming in uh and
just completely obliterating the suit.
Nothing at one rune is going to be able
to help uh unless there's a retreat in
hand or uh we've seen this play a lot on
dreaming tree. Stupify your own unit.
Draw two.
>> Yeah, you know, stupify pretty great
card even just as as printed minus a
might draw a card. But when you get to
draw a second card off it, it starts to
feel pretty degenerate. And I like this
play a lot from Tog. You know, he's
saying, "Hey, I had a slow start. So now
I'm going to spend recycle some of my
runes, lose some power to make sure I
can get back on this board and not get
run over."
>> Yep. As he does end up hiding a card.
>> Oo, I like that technology. Tuck the
buff.
>> I've seen a couple players do this.
Yeah,
>> that's good. That is That is good.
does make it really clear. And when the
board gets a little bit cluttered with a
lot of different stuff, there's a lot of
things going on in Riftbound. I like it.
It makes it real clean.
>> Yeah.
And here is Kaisa Survivor coming out of
the champ zone.
>> Yeah. Just going to go into gate. Not
even worrying about, hey, you've hidden
your card here. I'll respect it. I'm
ahead on point, so just going to go
ahead and go for that conquer. Get the
draw. And what what what range of hidden
cards are we looking at from the set
deck?
>> All right, so let's let's let's break it
out. Let's think about it. We got hidden
blade is the obvious one when we're in
order. Um I've seen a lot of divine
judgments in sets to try and deal with
the Kai'Sa and so they like pockub as
just like an additional way that you can
kind of get another unit onto the board.
Um it's also three might that kind of
shows up out of nowhere where your
opponent doesn't expect it. I think the
other one that we can see sometimes is
face breaker. Uh, it's not as common in
set, but you like to have this ability
to just say, I'm gonna hold this
location for this turn. I I would just
want to have this kind of always bail
out. I will hold against your watcher.
I'll stop that from blowing me out. I'll
hold against, you know, any of the big
threats that come through, the Darius
Cleave, etc. Um, so there's a lot of
different options. And uh, Face Breaker,
I believe you're going to draw from
Dreaming Tree when you pick your own
unit when you cast that Face Breaker.
So, uh, there may be even more room for
that card to exist when we are playing a
Dreaming Tree game one.
>> Yeah, that makes a lot of sense. Cass,
you know, Facebreaker, one of Set's
iconic League of Legends moves. So, it
would make sense that fits right into
his deck. And Tog is thinking about what
he can do here. He is potentially going
to be down on points soon, so he wants
to make sure he keeps up as well as he
can.
>> All right, buff spent on to the set
brawler. Going to move him home now. I
imagine we've got a way to ready the
set.
>> Yep. And there's that pocket cub you
were talking about to keep a presence at
Tog for Tog at the Dreaming Tree. And
I'm thinking first mate. Yep,
>> there we go.
Send that in. Only on one rune on the
other side for Tempest. Uh nothing is
going to make up four value on a single
rune. Um but there is going to still be
a Ray that comes through. This is eight
against four though, so minus three life
is not going to
>> the void gate. Okay.
>> Oh, good call out. Good catch. Yeah,
that is actually going to be four for
one resource. That wouldn't happen
anywhere except for the void gate.
>> Yeah. Now, this is where you can really
see void gate shine coming out of
Kai'Sa. Just the ability to tick your
damage numbers up by one. You know,
Riftbound is a game where just getting
to those damage thresholds is so
critical. It might be the difference
between like two or three points in the
long run. And we see the Hexte ray uh
able to do its job except
>> Yeah, I like this from Togg. You know,
you realize, hey, I got juiced by the
void gate. I'm gonna at least try and
take something for this. I'm going to
use this challenge. My set's going to go
down anyway, so I'll at least go and uh
deal with your Raven Bloom student.
>> Yeah. And because Challenge could
definitely be a little scary to use in
this matchup cuz, you know, I'm sure Emo
Tempus has, you know, we've already seen
Stupify. There might be some smoke
screens running around and those are
reactions. So, if you go for a challenge
when the Kaisa player has some runes
available, you might just get blown out.
So, choosing to use it there when the
shields were down, I think, is a great
call by Tog. Yeah, I think Togg may have
uh he he may have even kind of missed
voidgate, not thought about it. Just
kind of going through the motions of a
play that you would really be
comfortable and confident doing so
frequently with brawler into a Kaiso
when there's only a rune available for
uh for the side of the daughter of the
void knowing that hey, nothing can minus
four here. But void gate does kind of
change that math. And I think usually
brawler is so important to keep alive
kind of forever in this matchup. Uh so
this is going to be really tough to
overcome now that the brawler is gone.
Yeah, because he did he did take that
buff off to pump it up, which then, you
know, no longer allows it to be saved by
the boss and unfortunately led to losing
the brawler.
All right, so now
Tempest just going to have a development
turn. Darius does get ready though off
of this. So the pocket cup is going to
just be fodder at this point and it will
just be a single first mate available
for TOG on the back row going into this
next turn which is not a lot of material
to work with.
>> Yeah and definitely one of the strengths
of the Kaisa deck is just its ability to
put pressure from hand on the
battlefields. So many accelerate units,
so many tricks, so much removal and
Darius Trifarian a real big part of
that.
see what the next steps can be for Togg.
If this is a list that has the Kingpin's
main deck, something like a Kingpin uh
plus Showstopper is a lot of value that
can still come out with this amount of
runes. And well, there's a Kingpin. I
wonder if the Showstopper is there to
back it up to deal with this Darius. I
would not be surprised as it does feel
like such a good setup here.
And that is immediately what it is. Uh
that is going to be a kingpin
showstopper coming through for Tog to
deal with the Darius onto the Dreaming
Tree and you called that at the start of
this matchup. Kingpin with that buff
going to be able to dodge out on Falling
Star. That seven might is so impactful.
>> Yeah, Tog doing exactly what he needed
to do to not fall too far behind in this
game to have a chance that is going to
wipe up Darius. And now what I really
like about this play is now Tak has a
pretty strong foothold and he does have
a great option for the boss legend cuz
even if Emo Tempest can find a way to
threaten this set, he could just, you
know, spend the buff, spend a power, put
him back into base for next turn.
All right, so we'll see. One of the big
notable things, too, is there are the
cleaves, but cleave hopeful doesn't get
over the seven. Cleave Darius does, and
that's something that Tog has to be
aware of. But of course having the buff
on kingpin even if that is the case you
know worst case yes you lose out on your
set the cleave Darius comes through you
still can save it with boss.
>> Yeah it does feel like when you are when
you're playing against set and I'm sure
Emo Tempest is feeling this right now it
kind of is like a long-term losing
battle because like when you are trading
your cards for their buffs eventually
they're just going to build up such a
large army cuz their units aren't
actually dying. So Emo Tempest has to
walk a really tight line to make sure
they're navigating that effectively and
they have so far. We'll see if they can
keep it up.
>> Yeah, as is going to lose out the uh
first mate just to the hopeful straight
away. And I think he's recognizing, hey,
that may end up indicating that you've
got something else to come deal with my
set on the other side. Couple of
showstoppers already played, so Emo
Tempest doesn't have to worry about any
more of well one more of them for the
rest of the game.
>> Yeah, and definitely really powerful
signature spell for set. really good way
for, you know, both get those buffs on
for the boss and kind of leverage
getting into battlefields, especially if
you've slipped behind a bit.
>> Tempest considering the options, but I
I've got to imagine that this is going
to be a Darius Cleave setup, but no,
maybe not. Going to start with Sentry at
least. Ah, I see why the ordering in
this way actually just enough runes to
play it. And now the Darius as the
second card gets to come in ready. And
when he runs into the dreaming tree, you
can now cast the cleave and get the
draw. So really good sequencing from
Emotest.
>> Yeah, Emo Tempest just really maximizing
all his cards. Uh turning Tog's Dreaming
Tree against him a bit here and you know
the cleave is going to be an extra draw
and it will get the buff offset and kick
him back to the base. Very
low econ for Togg. Just going to be
awakening with only three runes. Going
to be able to get those uh last two up
to five, which is not a ton. It's
usually enough for this deck to kind of
manage as I think I saw a pit rookie in
hand. Uh which, you know, can just buff
up this kingpin and be able to take
either of these battlefields. Um, but we
did see Tempest just rip one of those uh
uh Thousand Tailed Watchers off the top
of the deck, which is another way that
they're going to just act from hand, get
the Conquer, and being at five, not
being able to win immediately on this
next turn, but still putting the
pressure on Tog getting up to that seven
point threshold.
>> Yeah, definitely wouldn't wouldn't count
Togg out just yet, but he's certainly
playing from behind. This is kind of
roughly exactly where Kaiso wants to be.
uh keeping set pretty pretty cleanly on
the back foot and allowing those card
those really powerful expensive cards
like Thousand Tailed Watcher to come
into play and do their thing. And it'll
be interesting to see if Emo goes for it
this turn.
>> Yeah, and that is going to be up to six
points. So even if Emo Tempest is not
able to take the Dreaming Tree this turn
on the subsequent turn, Emo Tempest is
threatening the win.
Yeah, always an interesting decision in
these spots on because you know getting
that seventh point sometimes it's just
really not something you need to do and
it is going to be better to just amass
your forces to go for the the 78 in a
one-two punch in a single turn
especially something like set because if
you know the thousand tailed watcher is
used here that set is buffed once again
and will get to survive and go back to
the base but we do see it come down
here. Yeah, and especially I mean it's a
really good call out you make, right?
Being at six with a watcher in hand,
there's really a lot of reason to
potentially just not play this because
next turn if you have your forces back
at home, you've got enough might at your
base. You play the watcher, it's almost
impossible. It's really hard for
actually like manage that from that
spot. But one big note that we have to
make here is there are five runes on the
side of Tog, which means he's going to
seven. And we've seen Divine Judgment
set make this kind of big splash. And if
that gets played, you can't play this
watcher anymore that's sitting in your
hand.
>> Yeah. And I imagine a big deciding
factor here for Emo Tempest is I'm
seeing a little bit of his hand here. It
looks like he's just on double hex ray
and cleave. So if he didn't play the
Thousand Tailed Watcher, there would
have been no development, which you know
that never feels great. So going to use
the Thousand Tailed Watcher and hope
that that's enough to get a hold and win
this game.
>> Yeah. And because the boss has to save
Kingpin in that way, Divine Judgment
couldn't even be deployed anyway. But
you wouldn't even want to with that
thousand tailed watcher being kind of
that thing that's been deployed at this
point. And Emo Tempest gets to keep
another rune available to send this ray
at the pit rookie when it tries to come
in.
>> And dog's just going to scoop it up.
And that is game one here in the Kai'Sa
set matchup.
Really kind of just got to see Kai'Sa
put on a clinic do everything it wanted
to do. uh set put up a good fight back
but was unable to really kind of get
over that hump especially after a miss
missing the first unit play.
>> Yeah, that's been the the big thing with
this match up. Now of course missing
turn one for set that's always going to
make a huge difference in the game. Uh,
but also it's like there are these
opportunities for Kaisa to have answers
to the units. Whether it is answer them
twice by being able to win with unit
combat, make the boss be activated and
then win with like a falling star on the
backline or even just continually beat
down these units. So that set is
required to be on such low economy that
you can kind of still get there. And
this time we did see kind of a misstep
from Tog into the void gate which cost
him brawler. And that might have been
the difference maker. And we'll see if
in game two and three with, you know, no
void gate, but also just maybe talk
being a little bit more locked in on his
brawler, maybe he's going to able to
completely turn things around and find
those two games.
>> Yeah, void gate definitely interesting.
You know, a lot of times sometimes it
feels like flavor text and not actual
text, but when it comes up, it's usually
very impactful and we did see it there
that game. Yeah, I mean the big thing
with the void gate and I think a lot of
these Kaisers have brought it back in
when it fell out of favor uh quite a bit
uh is actually funny enough the Annie
matchup is the one that really lent to
it because she's loving to accelerate
Kai'Sa into conquer uh and guess what
Ray going up to four is pretty good
against Kai'Sa survivor. So you get some
room in the mirror, you get some room in
the Annie matchup and it kind of
actually found some room where it hits
into set in some nice ways.
>> Yeah. And I really love kind of like the
iterations that the Kai'Sa battlefields
have gone through. There was a point
where they were kind of leaning into
some of the whole battlefields. Then
they were like Arena's greatest for the
more temple ones. Now the summer back to
Voidgate. So Kaiso really just has a lot
of different options on like how you
want to pilot the deck exactly for each
player. And we see Voidgate come up
really big for Emotest that game.
>> All right. Well, let's go ahead and jump
over to that second game. Let's see what
uh Togg can do to turn things around in
this second one or if Emo Tempest even
has some ways to help deal with Set. But
game two for Set. Uh you will at least
have the option to maybe bring in those
unyielding spirits that maybe weren't in
the main board which can help quite a
bit for this matchup. And uh when it
comes to the battlefields, we are going
to get the uh Grove of the God Willow
for Set. And now Kaisa's dreaming tree.
And I wonder if it was a read from Emo
Tempest like, "Hey, I know a lot of
these set builds are liking Dreaming
Tree game one. Maybe I can get value of
holding back my Dreaming Tree and having
two Dreaming Tree games to play."
>> Yeah, two really powerful battlefields
on the board for this game. Lots of
extra cards that could potentially be
drawn here. We might be in for a
slugfest between these two players. And
uh a much better start for Tog this
time. He's able to get on the board and,
you know, get some stuff buffed up
early, which I think is going to help
him out a ton. Yeah, a lot of tech
pieces for Togg in hand already. We
talked about the Unyielding Spirit and
we mentioned the Divine Judgment and
both of which are actually in Tog's hand
to start this game. And so because he
has the Divine Judgment in hand, wo,
that is a crazy card for a Kaiisa deck
to be playing as well and re
Inquisitive. But I I want to mention the
Divine Judgment changes to game plan a
little bit because he will want to
develop a good Divine Judgment board and
not spend too many runes on power early
so he can actually cast it.
>> Yeah. Yeah, and you know, I actually
love this Ahri Inquisitive from Emo
Tempest cuz I think from the Kaisa side,
you just know that your set opponent is
going to bring in cards like Unyielding.
And if you have like a Cathian Rain,
like theoretically, it's your best card,
but when it gets countered for one
energy, one power, if that exchange
happens, you're probably losing. So, I
could see a world where emote said, "I'm
not going to risk it. I'm not going to
try to get this Athenian rain through.
I'm going to pivot to this Ari
Inquisitive plan because unyielding
Spirit does nothing to stop Ari
Inquisitive." and you know, it might
just catch someone off guard and maybe
you just sideboarded in some cards that
aren't actually going to end up being
useful.
>> Yeah, very cool sideboard option into
the unit based uh decks where often
maybe you'll be able to get on board and
you can just drop an Inquisitor and say,
"I'm going to hold this." And especially
if we end up seeing Emo Tempest maybe
with the third battlefield even being a
hold battlefield, uh this could make
even more sense. But right now, we saw
the dreaming tree be used against Tog in
the last game. Now, the Grove of the God
Willow is attempting to be used against
Tog with this Ari Inquisitive.
>> Yeah. uh emompus doing his best, you
know, Ahri impression and just being
like, "Hey, I'm going to hold the grove
of the Godwillow." Todd coming in
saying, "No, you aren't." And at least
getting a trade out for the Ari
Inquisitive.
>> Yeah. Now considering if he wants to pay
the buff to save uh the Sithria. So,
he's just going to hold on that. Says,
"Hey, let me think on this trigger." Uh
and it looks like just going to uh get
one energy ready to go and send one to
the bottom.
>> Yeah. And you know, as it stands, the
Watchful Sentry still at the groove of
the Godwillow. we might see the extra
draw start rolling in. And it's
definitely the kind of thing that once
you hold it once, you hold it twice,
things could really snowball out of
control.
>> Yeah, and it looks like uh Emo Tempest
is going to get it for this turn. Uh the
buff's going to come out. Uh Citria, you
know, spending the buff to save her, and
then she just gets a new one from the
set brawler getting played, but oh,
maybe not. Brawler comes from the champ
zone. It is going to be a showstopper.
So, yeah, Tog really does not want to
allow that to be a hold for Emo Tempest.
Need to deny the cards.
>> Yeah, now I like that decision a lot
from Tog. He's saying, "Hey, I know this
is going to cost me a lot of resources
through my runes, but you you just can't
let the Kai'Sa deck just get to draw a
ton of cards for free or they will bury
you.
>> And this is very costly, right? You
know, I mentioned that often times when
you see the Divine Judgment, the plan
pivots to not spending a lot of runes
early. But Tog recognizing that to
create a board state that actually
serves Divine Judgment being a good
play, I actually have to invest a lot of
runes on this turn. And that is one for
the Showstopper, one for the boss, and
one for the brawler. So this is three
full runes being utilized by Tog on this
turn.
>> Definitely. But it has at least set him
up with a pretty stable board that I
think Emo Tempest is going to have a
hard time dealing with easily. And as
you can see, instead of trying to fight
what's already there, he's just going to
go over to the Dreaming Tree himself,
get a draw from that Kai'Sa conquer
trigger, and see what he can do against
the units on a later turn.
>> Yeah, I'm going to get a draw from that
Godwillow. It's also put at a cadence
where he is going up to five runes now,
seven on the next turn. So, that Divine
Judgment might still be able to find
that uh that next out as we do actually
have even more tech out of Emo Tempest
hand. And I'm seeing a Draven. So, you
know, not something that we've never
seen in Kais'. Like the Ari inquisitive
was really out of left field for me.
That's not one I've really seen in the
Kaisalis. But Draven is one that's not
often played in Kai'Sa, but it is one of
those big guys that you can throw into
the deck.
>> Yeah, it seems like Emoteus is just
trying to say like, "Hey, especially in
these postboard games, I'm going to try
to fight you in stats. I'm going to try
to fight you in might." And you know,
Kais is able to do it. Maybe not as well
as set when it's firing on all
cylinders. And we see a retreat here.
Yeah, continue to ramp up, draw more
cards, but this is just playing into
that divine judgment that Tog has ready
to go for the next turn. And this is
exactly what she wants to see. This
time, the void gate there not uh not
able to stop the brawler as we saw the
same exact situation. Kaisa survivor on
the battlefield. One rune available for
Emo Tempest. This time, as is normal in
the matchup, you can bring the brawler
back and then get it forward with the
first mate to get that conquer.
>> Yeah, and it's pretty cool. I think I I
think I happen to see two call to
glories in Tog's hands. So, he's kind of
got a lot of tools to make sure he keeps
his units in play, wins these critical
combats, and I will say, you know, Emo
Tempest might be, hey, I'm going to play
around the first Call to Glory, but
playing around two is usually really,
really hard.
>> Yeah, and this turn, you know, Emo
Tempest plays out a lot of little
things, which is going to be rough when
To reveals the divine judgment. I think
it's going to come out in this uh turn.
I think there's a lot of cards in
Emote's hand, a lot of runes that came
from the retreat ramp up. It feels like
the conditions are met for the Divine
Judgment to be a very strong play.
>> Yeah. Now, it seems like Todd really did
everything he could to navigate to
basically the perfect Divine Judgment
board and I would be really surprised if
he didn't use it here.
>> Yeah. The question now remains for Tog
is he has a lot of cards in his own
hand. So, do you have maybe a spot where
you actually don't want to divine
judgment because you feel like your hand
is actually strong enough to win? But I
think generally you're looking at the
KISS runes, the Kais group grip of cards
and you feel like you can make this
trade, especially maybe keeping the
calls with Cyria back where you could
play them for free.
>> Definitely. But it'll be it'll be
interesting to see what Tog chooses to
do here. I think that Divine Judgment
might end up just being way too tempting
even though it's going to hurt him. I
think it's going to hurt Emo Tempest and
Kai'Sa a lot more. And there there it
is.
>> Yeah, I think he was kind of thinking
for a little while cuz he had no hidden
cards in hand. One of the big things you
love with the divine judgment is you
kind of get to see uh you know a pocket
cub and you get to put that down and
you're ready to have that ready to go or
or a hidden blade and you've got more
room to play around with where you're
basically making this not a symmetrical
effect at all. Um, but even in this
spot, it's not quite a symmetrical
effect because you have these extra
runes to save your set brawler and keep
this massive unit around where on the
other side, I mean, Emo Tempest is
keeping like a lecturing Yortle and a
Porro and then ditching a bunch of runes
to try and play whatever cards he had in
hand. That Draven starts to look very
sad in this kind of situation.
>> Yeah. And you know, this is kind of the
cost that Kai'Sa has for playing some of
these lower might cantripy units is that
in a spot like this, the might on the
table is just going to be so much more
important than, you know, drawing some
extra cards. And, you know, I think
it's, as you said, I could even see a
world where Tog is like, I'm not even
going to play cards from my hand
anymore. I'm just going to spend all my
resources to just keep these two units I
have in play, keep buffing them and
making sure they live to get these last
couple points.
>> Yeah. And we see the hand of Emo
Tempest. There's like the Sakathian,
Rain, Draven, Darius. These are just too
big. Like once this divine judgment
comes down, your econ is way too low on
these runes. This rune count when you go
down to two. You'll go up to four on,
you know, your first turn back, but
that's still not enough to play any of
these cards. You have to send him to the
bottom. And it's a recycle, so you don't
even get the draw from the watchful
sentry. So you have to figure out what
you can do with two cards and two runes
to try and come back on board against a
brawler, which is very tough. And again,
I got to go back to the call the
glories. Those definitely are going to
be keeps forg because he has the Sith
three in play. And as you said, he won't
play cards from hand. He'll just save
his units, but he can play cards from
hand because he's got Call the Glory,
which is free because of uh our our best
girl, Cyria of Cloudfield, making it so
with all of her basically infinite buffs
that she gets to keep having.
>> Yeah, know that's that's a great point,
Cass. And I think that's really why
Cyria has such a strong home in this
deck because, you know, as I was saying
earlier, Set can sometimes lack access
to buffs, but Cyria is just saying like,
I'm just going to keep giving you buffs
to spend again and again and again. And
I do think that's going to be really
impactful here for Tog to be able to
close out this game.
>> All right. And plus, he's got the point
lead. So even here with Emoteus having
access to score two points up to four. I
think Togg doesn't really mind. And uh I
will say Emote Tempest having access to
this uh retreat to be able to go onto
the lecturing Yortle for draw a card
ramp a rune going into the next turn
might open up a spot where you have
enough runes to deal with the brawler in
the Sithria and find kind of claw your
way back. But it is really an uphill
battle for Kai'Sa as soon as that divine
judgment hits the table.
>> Yeah. Know Divine Judgment definitely
really really awesome piece of
technology and you know Todd just
clearly had a plan built around it and
executed on it and is maybe going to be
able to leverage it into closing out
this second game and evening up the
match.
Yeah, but Emo Tempest does keep the grip
of cards and all of the runes available.
Trying to bluff what he could have
something like a smoke screen plus a
removal spell can be really scary for
Tog to walk directly into. So, he has to
consider if he can spend this buff or
not on set brawler. But, I think on
average, yeah, you're going to spend it
because you always have that backup of
the the Sith 3A being able to just
utilize that call to glory, spend the
buff for free, and even get this set
even bigger if you really need to. Yeah,
and I do I do think I'm seeing a smoke
screen over there in Emote Tempest 10,
but I agree that I'm not sure if it's
going to be enough. I you know, respect
the decision to hold it up. You know,
you're kind of in a spot where the
divine judgment put you really far
behind and you're going to have to be
like maybe I just have to hope they
don't have it and I could catch them off
guard with the smoke screen and we'll
see how it plays out.
>> All right, so going to send eight into
the porro at the godwill.
Try and go up to the sixth point here.
I like this decision to go to the grove
because it's both saying, "Hey, I'm
going to kick you out of the hold
battlefield so you don't get extra
cards." And as we see, I think emo emois
has a retreat here. And if he has to use
it, if he if had gone to the dreaming
tree instead, that would have come along
with an extra draw.
>> Yeah, I think he's trying to make Yeah,
the retreat really unattractive because
if you send Cyria into the lecturing
Yortle, you can offer the trade and Emo
Tempest has to decide, do I retreat to
draw the card, get the rune, or do I
just kind of let let that go? Um, and we
immediately see Tempest just values
getting kind of the rune and is willing
to sacrifice the fact that, hey, if you
want to try and trade the Cyrio, that's
going to be just fine. Uh, I'll just go
ahead and hold on to some runes, maybe
even the smokec screen to completely
deny this as Cyria is going to run in
and we'll see if offers the trade or if
he decides to lead with something like
the Call of Glory and he's just going to
pay. I like this a lot.
>> Yeah, pick up an extra draw from the
Dreaming Tree himself. Uh, I think this
is just setting up really nicely. The
smoke screen might actually line up
pretty well here. And it'll be
interesting to see if Todd did hold on
to that second call to glory and is
willing to use it to fight for this
battle.
>> And that's why I'd really I love the pay
if he does have the second cuz by paying
for the first, you might bait in the
smoke screen and then you just do the
second one. And that's so so good to be
able to push over the top. And uh yeah,
just perfect holding on to double call
the glory off of the divine judgment
because you've got that citri in play
that you know you'll be able to
leverage.
>> Yep. And now Tog's got himself up to
seven. Great spot to be in seven unit in
each battlefield. I think it's going to
be pretty hard for Emo Tempest to
overcome this. And I'm thinking Tog
might get this win on a hold. Yeah, I I
like from Tempest though, making sure
you cast a retreat on that turn. Uh it
gives you the out of drawing into a
cathen. You'd still lose to an
unyielding spirit from that point, but a
cath rain would actually be able to kind
of clean up that board and make it so
you don't immediately lose from that
spot because you go up to seven runes.
>> Yeah. And I will say, I got to say,
great showing from both players there.
They clearly both had plans. They
clearly both executed on their plans and
Togs was a little better this game. Came
out ahead. But I I just loved the R
Inquisitive from Emo Tempest. I think
breaking the mold and kind of just like
you you know these decks like Set and
Annie are on the rise and I I I see
exactly where he's coming from with
trying to kind of use that card to push
things back into Kais's favor. Yeah,
it's one of those funny things where
it's like it felt like the tech didn't
do that much this game, but it did put
an awkward spot for Tog where he had to
kind of just offer this trade that
wasn't the most exciting trade for him.
Uh, and it forces a lot of resources to
be used to break uh not a very big hold
overall when it comes to just might
numbers uh because you are just such a
unit based deck and inquisitive does
counter that. We saw send in trade a
unit and then play brawler showstopper
just to prevent emote from holding on
Godilla. So definitely huge. Yeah, and I
think that was a really strong decision
by T as well. You know, you might be you
might if you're in a spot, you might be
thinking, hey, I don't want to use this
many resources just to kill a watchful
sentry at this point, but you know, he
just knew I want to score those points.
I want to make sure Emo Tempest isn't
getting the draws from Grove of the
Godwillow. And that exchange ultimately,
I think, ended up a big factor in him
able to turn that one into a win.
>> All right, we got a little quick look at
the sideboard from Emo Tempest. I saw a
couple unchecked power. I don't think
those are coming in, but just kind of
cool to see the different flavors of
tech that people are bringing in for
some of the bigger matchups. Uh,
unchecked power has been one we've seen
come in and out for the Aurora matchups.
Um, but there is just the consideration
that if your opponent brings in
something like unyielding spirit that
you lose a lot of value on that
unchecked.
>> Yeah. And I'm looking at Emo Tempest
here and he's like staring at this
Atheian rain. And it's so it's so tough
cuz it if they don't have the Unyielding
Spirit, the card's great. And I think
it's just so tempting to be like I'm
just going to put it in. Hope I draw it.
There's almost like a gambit between
both players because theoretically on
Tog's side, if you thought they were
going to board out a Chaunion Raid, you
might not bring in Unyielding Spirit at
all. So, it really is this cat and mouse
of like who's going to blink, who's
going to have the card or not. And I
think I saw Emo Tempest put one back in.
It's
>> in. Yeah.
>> So, we'll see. He might be able to catch
Tog off guard with it in the third game.
>> Yeah. So, we'll see uh what Tog did with
the sideboard if he made any adjustments
for this final game. But, uh you know,
Divine Judgment did pop off in that
game. is massive. It just completely
sealed the deal. Um, and we did see that
the yieldings were in previously. I saw
him kind of thumbming around with a
primal fury is also a consideration. I
think that can find some good purchase
for just being able to kind of
counteract a watcher when that tries to
come in cuz usually that's tapping out
all the resources and then if you're
able to just kind of give this plus
seven, you can completely turn the flip
the script on that.
>> Yeah, definitely with the the min one
floor on the shrink from the thousand
tailed watcher, that math just kind of
lines up perfectly. You go down to a
one, it comes in as a seven. Primal
Strength puts you back up to an eight.
Easy win for the combat.
>> Yeah, and actually, interestingly
enough, with that primal strength uh
potenti, it looked like it was coming
in. Uh this is Taran's Peak, which
actually opens up more ranges that Togg
will actually be able to cast this
primal strength without having to hold
on to four runes, maybe just holding two
and getting that conquer. He actually
opens up that spell, which is quite cool
to see. Um Kais have kind of strayed
away from Tarun's peak because sometimes
it comes back to bite you. Uh however,
it is very strong on the play to be able
to move your your uh two drop in and
then have runes available to cast
something like array as followup. So it
is going to be Targon's Peak for the
side of emo Tempest and Monastery of
Herana for Togg on set. And I have gone
on record multiple times saying I think
this is the strongest battlefield for
set. Um, I think when you have a Cyria
on board, it feels very unfair uh what
you were able to do with Monastery and
it is kind of one-sided cuz most other
decks do not have the buffs to make it
happen.
>> Yeah. I mean, I think one of the real
strengths of set as a deck is you just
have three battlefields between Dreaming
Tree, Grove, and Monastery that all say
draw a card on them. So, you kind of get
to cheat and not have to worry about
putting card advantage in your actual
deck because you're just going to get it
from your battlefield and from your
legend rebying your units.
>> Yeah. Yeah, and that's always like kind
of historically the the weakness of set
is actually card draw. So by these uh
set decks kind of coalesing and
realizing, hey, that's really the weak
point of my list is that I I can't find
enough cards when I run out of steam.
I'm just out. Uh and actually finding
ways to not have that happen by having
three battlefields that let you draw
cards is just so massive. And we'll see
uh if Todd can immediately start kind of
making that work with Monastery of
Herana as it can be just so incredibly
valuable time and time again as he will
get that buff. Uh usually this first one
though, if you don't have a way to
rebuff against uh the the Kai'Sa, we may
just see Tog holding back and not
actually spending the buff this first
time when he sends the Cyria in.
>> Yeah, both both players off to pretty
strong starts here, curving out, getting
some units into play. Uh Tog is going to
make that decision to hold back the
Sithria for a later turn, especially
because Emoteest had some extra runes
available from the Targon's Peak. Uh,
but this will give Emo Tempest a pretty
good first crack in with Kai'Sa here to
just score some points, pull ahead to a
pretty nice 3 0 early lead.
>> I'm going to run in, get that conquer.
Uh, should be at just a single rune and
recycle one of those uh, and be able to
just play.
>> Oh, no. It was the last turn that he put
the K. Okay. Yeah. Yeah, we're good. So,
>> yeah, Kai'Sa said I don't have a buff. I
don't care. I'm going to draw a card
anyway from this area if we're on it.
>> No condition on that one. just the
conquer.
>> And you know, it's interesting cuz I
imagine after the last game, Divine
Judgment is at the forefront of Evo
Tempest's mind. It seemed like it caught
him off guard the last game. So, I
imagine this game he's going to look to
position his board to not get as blown
out if uh Tog happens to have it again.
>> Yeah. Well, looking at the hand though,
I don't know if he's going to even have
a choice as this just looks like a a two
drop spam kind of turn. uh going to keep
a couple of runes up for the retreat
potentially to save the Kaisen instead
of fully playing out every single unit
that he could. Um and this makes a lot
of sense, right? You want to keep that
Kaiser around.
>> Yeah, the the retreat's a nice way to
get out under from a giant set brawler
coming to punch you in the face and make
sure you know the unit will go back to
hand. You'll lose some tempo, but Kai'Sa
is pretty good to just play again and
again with the accelerate.
>> Yeah, this is where, you know, now you
actually have to play around that smoke
screen. Uh two runes up. You know, when
there's one rune up, there's no way to
deal the four unless we've got the void
gate. But two runes up, that's the smoke
screen. So, if Tog decides to spend this
buff, buff the brawler up to eight and
send it into Kai'Sa, he has to be wary
of that. I saw pit rookie in hand, and
usually you'd want to maybe set up for a
big conquer with the double spend of the
buffs with the brawler to do so. Or
you'd want to wait until you've
conquered and spent the buff from Citria
to draw a card to then play a unit. So,
we'll see what kind of order of
operations Togg can set up here.
>> Yeah. Yeah, and one of the things that I
really love from this set deck that I'm
sure is on Tak's radar is if you conquer
the monastery with a buffed set brawler,
you can spend the buff to draw and then
he will immediately get rebuffed by his
conquer trigger to buff himself. And
that's just such a powerful combination
to sort of have your cake and eat it
too.
>> Nice. Okay, so we see a little shortcut
here. Pit rookie give the buff to set.
Going to buff the set all the way up to
12. That gets around any smoke screen
shenanigans and it will just be a
retreat onto the Kaisa to send it home.
This is where you get to conquer, get
the buff there, spend the buff from the
Sithria to draw a card. Um, if he wants,
and then I think if he's going to send
another unit out onto the board, it just
makes sense to spend it cuz you will
just get another buff onto Cyria
anyways.
>> Yep. Talk thinking about how he wants to
do this. Looking at his hand, got a
little glimpse of a pocket cub peeking
out.
>> Yeah, no divine judgment notably. I'm
not seeing unyielding either. So the
tech for the Kai'Sa match up
specifically not being found just yet.
>> Oh, and it looked like that handwave
might have been no, I'm not going to
spend a buff.
>> So maybe wanting to hold up runes for
some spells, some action on Emo Tempest
turn.
>> Yeah. And you know, you got to respect
just being like, hey, I'm just playing
to the board. You know, I don't want to
lose the game with like seven cards in
my hand. I'd rather my units just stay
buffed so I can keep using the boss
legend. And I think that's just a really
good thing for Todd to key into. Yeah,
I'm wondering I'm I'm seeing trying to
catch like uh all the cards in the hand
to figure out what Togg is really
wanting to hold on to because this is
going to be six runes available, right?
If he plays any unit reasonably, he
should have just kind of used the
Cytherria um in order to draw a card,
but he is going to go for the challenge
and then four runes up, I think there's
a primal strength in hand. So, exactly
what we were talking about earlier with
how maybe this Targon speak can actually
kind of run into some issues where Toga
is going to have more range to play
around the primal fury.
>> Yeah, that makes a lot of sense, Cass.
And we do see a second retreat come from
Emo Tempest here. So he's going to he
just got a ton of runes in play. It'll
be interesting to see if he has any kind
of haymakers to leverage all this energy
available.
>> All right, looks like a pocket cub is
going to be deployed as the hidden and
now exactly four runes available for
this uh Targon Peak.
>> Yeah, great moves from Tog turning
around kind of that early point lead
that Emo Tempest was able to establish
closing the gap a little bit there. And
it'll be interesting to see what Emo
Tempest has here to make sure he keeps
the pressure on. And I think I see the
Athenian rain.
>> Yeah, Kathy Rain is going to be a big
difference maker as he's just counting
out exactly what he needs to do. The
nice thing is, you know, Boss is going
to have to exhaust to save something.
So, you are going to be able to clean up
the Sitha, you are going to be able to
clean up the pit rookie, and you're
gonna, you know, take the buff away from
Brawler when you are able to do this.
Pocket Cup is going to be able to
respond to those reflexive triggers uh
when it takes down the Cyria to recind
of establish control of the Targon's
peak and not make it so easy for
everything to come through for Tempest.
But he ramped so many runes with these
retreats that maybe this Raven Bloom is
going to be able to pump above the
pocket cup anyway.
>> Yeah. And you know, this is just just
one of those spots where if Tog had the
unyielding, this might have gone way
different for Emo Tempest, but he
didn't. And the Aadian rain is going to
be able to clean up a lot of what Tog
had in play.
>> Yeah. And big for Tempest heads up
recognizing, hey, if I assign enough to
the uh brawler, even if you use the
boss, uh you're not actually able to
save it, right? Because the buff puts it
at five. But if you put three stacks on
there, that's six damage. When boss
saves it, it loses the buff. So you
actually only need five of the six from
a thin rain to deal with the set
brawler.
>> Yeah, you can kill it twice. And now a
void seeker coming down on Cyrio will
prompt a pocket cub to flip up. But I
think this Raven Bloom student has
gotten enough pumps that it might be
able to contest the Cub.
>> Yeah, and the cool thing here though,
exhausting that rune before paying that
power to save the Sithria, that primal
strength can actually come through uh
and deal with it with the pocket cup or
just a hidden blade. If there was no
prim, maybe there was never a primal.
Maybe I'm seeing primals. Ghost of
primal strength in the hand. Uh but a
hidden blade is just going to deal with
that Raven Bloom student.
>> Yeah, hidden blade. I I get why T's
doing it. Definitely a tough one though
because at this stage of the game, the
two extra cards that Emote just got to
pick up are probably going to be pretty
relevant. Uh but you know, he feels like
he needs to keep his foothold, make sure
he scores some points, and just try to
tempo Kai'Sa out. And we'll see if he's
able to do that.
Oh no, he just drew Unyielding Spirit.
Oh, one turn too late. Had all those
runes available to deal with the
potential. And that's the card draw from
the Cyria which you know you can't think
about but you dig one deeper and you're
actually able to find that unyielding to
save the day as it is just going to be
Kingpin coming down give the buff over
to Cyria and just looking to rebuild
into a bunch of runes for Emo Tempest
coming up.
>> Yeah, Todd does at least have the board
advantage right now. Uh Emo Tempest did
just pick up a bunch of cards, so he's
probably going to be able to start
fighting back soon. But as long as Todd
can at least keep chipping in and
scoring those points, he's very much in
this game.
>> I am seeing though that the the Kingpin
comes down and in the hand there's the
Falling Star. No buff on the Kingpin to
save it just yet. And being at five, you
know, that falling star can just deal
with it before it comes becomes a
problem.
>> Yeah, very very tough turn cuz without
the extra two runes from Targon's Peak,
Tog is going to be unable to hold up the
unyielding spirit this turn. So
definitely the way things have have kind
of shook out this match, the unyielding
spirit has not been there when it needed
to be. And even now that it's there,
it's too taxing to hold up.
>> Yeah. So so many cards for the Kai'Sa.
Now it gets to be a full redevelopment.
We see a hopeful or even Bloom a lot of
the kind of small units that Kai'Sa is
known for playing, but realistically
with all the backup of we see like
smokec screen and we see a lot of other
spells available in the deck. uh it
becomes like they're just strong enough
because you have the spells to push
through as it will be an accelerated
Kaisa survivor instead. Maybe just going
into the peak uh to reset a couple of
rooms, but no, just going to clean up
the Citria, leave with nothing but a
pocket cup.
>> Yeah, I imagine Emo Tempest is thinking
like, hey, I mean, look at his hand.
He's got like eight, nine cards. He's
got to be thinking, as long as I just
don't lose the board and get tempoed
out, I'm going to win the long game like
no matter what from this position. And I
think is doing a great job of kind of
playing to that game plan, but there is
still the divine judgment we saw
earlier. It feels like that's kind of
the thing that Todd would need to level
the playing field again. Yeah, it makes
sense. But being at five runes now, it
would mean you can't spend power cost on
any of these other cards and still find
that divine judgment for this next turn,
which is going to be a really tough ask
cuz as we're going to see now that
primal strength will come through just
to send the pocket cub in and that
doesn't feel like your favorite use of
this card to just try and put 10 over
four uh just to deal with emote Kai'Sa.
>> It does at least let him get safely
around smokeokescreen which is nice.
Second hidden card could be another
blade. Could be another pocka cub.
Blade on the monastery. Not a lot of
cards left in hand. Just going to be
able to deploy the blade uh to
potentially draw or just unyielding.
Buy some space for the pocket cup to
just stick around. I mean really really
trying to hold on for as many points as
possible. Get uh squeeze all the juice
out of every single card that he's got.
I
>> mean T is doing what he's got to do. The
one thing that Nemo Tempest doesn't have
is units in play. So, you know, I see
he's Oh, but there's one coming in
ready.
>> Yeah, but this is answered by that
hidden blade. And when your opponent has
nine cards, uh you don't really care
about giving them two more. However, Emo
Tempest is going to say, "Well, I'll
just go to the other battlefield. We'll
play around this uh potential hidden
blade that is very likely there."
>> Yeah, good heads up play from Emo
Tempest. He's being like, you know, I'll
let you keep the hidden card. I don't
need to contest this right now. I just
don't want to, you know, run the Darius
in, lose it. And at this point, the two
extra cards, as you said, really just
wouldn't matter.
>> Yeah, but that still keeps this point
lead for TOG at six. Currently,
only four runes available. I think
there's been this Kinku monk in hand for
a while. Showstopper not going to be
able to combine with that to get
anything done.
>> Yeah, Kingu Monk it can buff itself, so
it's definitely can, you know, be a
little tricky for Tog to set up the
right board state, especially against a
deck like Kaiso that's so good at
killing your units.
But Kai'Sa notably being on five means
that you are not losing immediately. So
trying to set up a board state where you
can look to double conquer on the next
turn is actually feasible. It is a very
real possibility for talk especially
considering the hidden blade at the
monastery. I think there's opportunity
to have the kingo monk buff up the pocka
cub. Um maybe on the next turn if uh
when Tempest sends stuff in, you can
even just hidden blade your own pocket
cub, save it, draw two, have this
backline of a few units and then some
extra cards with a showstopper to try
and look for this double conquer.
>> Yeah, Tag, you just see the gears
turning. He's like, "How do I do it? How
do I set up this double conquer next
turn?" And looks like you were right.
And he thinks the best way to do it is
to get this monk down, buff the cub, and
then ship the turn back over to Emo
Tempest.
and we'll see what the uh big
expenditure coming from Tempest is, but
there's just a lot of these like little
two drops that can't quite get over the
top. And it looks like Tempest even
considering just holding on Tarun's Peak
or at least setting up to uh potentially
hold on the next turn as this will be a
ready Darius from the second card. Can
double Darius in over the top of the
pocket cub uh to deny the ability for
there to be just a single hidden blade
saving the day. Yeah, emote just with a
just with an embarrassment of riches
able to throw his weight around. Send in
this first Darius to see what it is. Oh
wow. Okay, so Tog actually going to kill
the Darius instead of trying to draw his
own cards even though he knows that this
Darius can come in and deal with the
Pocket Cub. Going to rely just on the
showstopper and the single pocket cub
with that Kingu monk in the backline.
Really hoping for a big top deck.
>> Yeah, I mean it's it's not impossible. I
got to say T has done a great job of
just like playing to his outs and just
setting up a board state where it is
conceivable for him to pull off the
double conquer. And I got to say it
would be pretty hilarious if Kaiso with
just 11 cards in hand just dies to the
set with two runes and two cards in
hand.
>> Yeah, I think the hard thing is that
it's four runes so some of your bigger
units that would combo with the
showstopper cannot come through on this
turn. The draw looks like maybe another
monk which is yet again, you know, on
four runes. This is just not going to be
doable.
>> Emo Tempest just laying out his massive
wad of cards in his base.
>> Yeah, cuz we know that there's a smoke
screen for Emo Tempest and that will be
able to answer just Kinku giving the
buffs. I think Togg recognizing that,
hey, I mean, all I can do is actually
just play this Kinku monk and try and
push in and say, well, five into five.
We'll try and trade there and then the
rest. But uh you can try and send
everything into one side and even
attempt to hold, but into that big of a
group of cards, it's going to be really
difficult to make that happen.
>> Yeah, I have to imagine Tog knows it's
not looking great for him here, but he's
going to, you know, do the best he can.
Find the best board state to at least
give himself a fighting chance.
>> And we'll see if that is both of them
going into Monastery and then
potentially using a buff to draw an
additional card. If you can find a face
breaker that can also maybe find the win
off of hiding that smoke screen going to
come down.
>> We might actually be about to see the
rare off turn Darius
>> Trifair and that is enough for Emo
Tempest to take the game. Tog going to
scoop it up and that is yet another
Kai'Sa finding the win just barely eking
out over the set this time of Tog. Emo
Tempest going to start this tournament
3-0.
>> Yeah and you know you see right there
that set deck clearly came to this
tournament with Kais in mind. had a game
plan to try to beat it. Was able to do
that one game with the divine judgment,
but then just the raw power of Kai'Sa
even when the target's on your back,
Kai'Sa plows through and finds the win
in the
>> and just one card short of finding the
tech piece, finding that unyielding
spirit to be able to stop the the uh the
Cathine Rain from just tearing through
the entire board. And just that one more
card, he had the runes available would
have made all the difference.
>> Yeah. Yeah, and you know that moment
where he where Emo Tempest really was
like staring at his sideboard, looked at
the Athenian rain, made the hard
decision, I think I need this to win in
this matchup. I'm going to try to get
around on yielding spirit and he did it
and he won. Great payoff.
>> All right. Well, that is three rounds in
the books. We're going to swap over to
some of our other lovely casters going
forward for the next few rounds, but
before that, we'll have a short break
and then we're back with more of the
Houston regional qualifiers. Don't go
anywhere. Another
interesting thing that you can do here
at the regional qualifier in Houston is
our wonderful prize wall section. I'm
joined right now with Terra Bell. And
tell me a little bit about some of the
stuff that you really enjoy that you can
redeem here at the prize wall.
>> Sure. Yeah. Uh we have our wonderful um
figurines. These are not too exclusive
to us. You can get them on Riot, but I
think y'all should get definitely hook
those up for 15 tickets. It's not a bad
price for that. Um, also we have our
wonderful plushies. My favorite of
course is Vagger. I love him so much. Or
Vagger, however you want to pronounce
it. And we have our little figurines,
our little Porro. He's super cute, too.
I love him. Um, and we have our uh
playmats which are over there on the
other other wall over there, and you can
get those as well. Um,
>> so I have also heard that you can redeem
your prize wall tickets for these
alternate metallic cards. So, like the
coveted best of prize, but they're a
little bit different. What can you show
me about those?
>> Sure. I'll show you my favorite
champion, which is set. Um, he is
amazing. Uh,
>> the texture on these are really great.
Um, the whenever I don't know if you can
tell on the camera or not, but the
texture on it is amazing. Like just
>> I don't know, they did very well on
these.
>> There's also one more thing personally.
You know, I I watch a lot of League of
Legends and um I'm a big fan of Teemo. I
heard you guys have some Teemo hats.
>> You think there's a world where I can
maybe snag one and take it to the
broadcast desk?
>> I'm pretty sure you could if you tried.
>> Awesome. Well, thank you so much, Tara.
That's one of the many things you can
check out here in Houston at the
regional qualifier. You don't want to
miss out the next one.
[Music]
Hallelujah.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Welcome back everybody. I'm Barrett
Bryant joined by the wonderful Aaron
Barrett Barrett. My apologies. And uh I
sadly I didn't get to take one of those
Teemo hats like they promised me
yesterday. So uh maybe in the future
after the event is over I'll get myself
a Teemo hat. But uh what do you think
about Teemo? Because we have yet really
to see a Teemo really explode into the
tournament except for Prismat, right?
Yeah, we got to watch Prismat earlier,
but Prismat did end up falling to Nok
Pass in some games that maybe weren't
the closest, but I do think Teemo is one
of those decks that has a really high
chance of doing well this weekend, and a
lot of really great players are playing
it, including Prismat, but you can't win
them all. So, I'm really excited to see
more Teemo coming throughout the
weekend. Um, I have high hopes.
>> I do have high hopes as well. But Teemo
is a legend that we've seen and we
hopefully will see in the future. But
how about a legend that we haven't seen
just quite yet? You know, I'm thinking,
of course, the Jinxes of the world.
Don't you think you're It's about time
for us to get a Jinx match up here on
the desk.
>> It is always time for a Jinx matchup.
Jinx is probably my favorite legend
insert one. I'm really thrilled to see
someone playing Jinx, and it's someone
that I know and I'm a friend with, so
I'm really excited to watch.
>> Yeah, absolutely. So, of course, we have
that one coming out, but we don't want
to spoil too much yet. You know, we want
them to get to know us just a little
bit, of course. Um, Erin, you work with
the game, of course. So, uh, it's it's
very exciting to have here and have your
insight for me on the desk, you know,
going through all these rounds, seeing
all this riffound play, and you've even
had the privilege to do some card
slinging here at the event as an
employee. Uh, tell me about the
experiences you've seen from finding and
playing against all of these players
here.
>> Yeah, I mean, the emotion in the room is
incredible. People are so excited.
Everyone just wants to get more
Riftbound under their belts. Games and
games and games being played all over.
And it's so so awesome to see as someone
who works on it. And it really is super
gratifying and I'm really happy to get
to be here and watch and talk about more
games.
>> And what were you piloting in that cards
lane?
>> Oh, all sorts of things. I will say my
favorite was a Jinx deck. A little
sprinkling of some spirit forge cards
maybe in there.
>> Really great time.
>> Love that. Absolutely. I mean, I I love
card slinging. I just think it's one of
those fun opportunities where you get to
have these people interactions cuz at
the end of the day, we're all human
beings and we just love Riftbound. We
love card games and we're so excited to
be here in Houston, Texas for the
regional qualifier. But uh we've got
another round. We are moving into round
four here in Houston, Texas. And we've
got a very nice surprise here on some of
our players that we're going to be
representing. It's Jim Davis, a very
prolific Magic the Gathering player and
also, you know, content creator as well.
>> Yeah, I mean Jim has made a good name
for himself on the Magic scene. Uh is
starting to get into ripbound content
creation. Really awesome stuff. As I
said, I am a friend of Jim, so I really
want to see him do well. And I mean, I
love Jinx. So,
>> absolutely. Of course, on the other
side, we do have Jay Dog 992 sporting
the oho prolific Kai'Sa, daughter of the
void as well. So, Jinx versus Kai'Sa.
And Jinx plays a lot of her spells of
her own. Of course, you know, different
legend, different abilities going
forward, but we're going to be jumping
into this game one. And I'm very excited
to see what's going on.
>> Yeah, it looks like we have the dreaming
tree coming in from Kai'Sa. pretty stock
normal uh opening game one battlefield.
Pretty safe for both players. However,
against uh Jinx, maybe some cleaves in
there to draw some cards of her own. And
Zon Warren, a similar thing for Jinx to
have.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Raven balloon turn
one, pretty easy representation. And
then also the Zhorns as we pass back to
Jim. You know, as long as as long as you
can get a unit like a traveling merchant
onto the board, we can easily start
getting double advantage of the same
abilities. But instead, it looks like
we're going to be immediately be playing
our Jinx Demolitionist with a double
discard of Flame Chompers. We have no
runes anymore. Aaron,
>> well, I've said this a lot of times. If
anyone's heard me play Riftbound, I will
say, uh, runes are for suckers. And this
is a play I love to make. You know, turn
one, especially against a deck like
Kai'Sa, you have three bodies. Even if
you do get Falling Starred, you're
pretty likely to take a battlefield, and
you just have so much pressure early on.
Uh the Jinx stack in particular usually
really set up well to play off just a
small number of runes.
>> I this is exactly the kind of
explosivity and like we even watched Jim
there kind of posture for a minute. He
thought about it and then we immediately
saw everything hit the board right off
the get-go. I mean especially using the
champion champion unit right now because
we only had to play the two cards from
our hands which we were discarding
anyway and the other card was free. It
came from our champion zone.
>> Yeah, you can see in Jim's hand he
actually has a scrap peep. had a really
important decision on that Jinx turn
one. Do I want to keep one of those
runes and just discard a scrap keep? And
he said, "No, I want all the bodies in
play. I want to make sure I'm pressuring
you and I want to be able to get ahead
because against a deck like Kai'Sa, they
do have a much better closing power than
Jinx.
>> Yeah. Uh, and speaking of that, even
combating the board power as we had
passed back to uh, Jaydog on that last
turn, we then proceeded to progress the
board state. We moved our own Raven
Bloom student up to the Z warren got our
movement or conquer ability and then we
on the next turn following played
another Raven Bloom and that Nox's
hopeful of course with that discount on
the Legion ability. But as we pass back
to Jim's turn, we're moving things up.
Flame Chomper is having enough might to
combat against that Raven Bloom right
off the get- go.
>> Yeah, I really want to call out what Jay
Dog did here. He moved in with that
Raven Bloom student. Didn't leave up any
energy for a spell. Played two things.
Knew it was going to die of the flame
chompers. That's a pretty big flag in
the ground saying, "I think this game is
about racing. I want these points. I
need to beat you. You put three things
into play turn one. What can I do about
it?"
>> Yeah, absolutely. And so now we have the
decision here as we pass things back one
to one in the score race. But the
decision now is as we have two ready
units on the side of gym, are we going
to actually progress into that dreaming
tree? As we move a flame choppers up
going up to two points, I think that's
the safe one to move. Of course, you
want to kind of keep this Jinx
demolition when you really need to get
over a little bit more power or might.
>> Yeah, definitely. And there's a question
of okay, if I move the Jinx, maybe uh
Jay Dog can't kill it without trading
with it and we get a one for one where
it looks like he's very likely be able
to eat both of the flame chompers this
turn. We have a third flame chompers
with the Chemac enforcer. That is crazy.
This is about as fast as your Jinx deck
can be.
>> No. And and like you said, runes are for
suckers, right, Aaron? So, we're back
down to one. And as we pass back to
Jinx, who then goes up to six of their
runes, we have a lot of decisions to
make here. I think, like you said,
things like Falling Stars could be a
huge play here. But unsure if in the
hand and all you have at your disposal
in this current moment is a Nox's
hopeful and uh a Braven Bloom student.
So, it's not necessarily enough that you
feel comfortable going in except for the
hopeful, but we have six rooms to play
with. What do you think you could
anticipate coming down right here?
>> Yeah, I mean the six rune turn is a big
turn for the Kaiso deck. Usually means
you have the access to a Darius plus a
one mana spell. Really lets you take a
board. Uh maybe with the dreaming tree
in particular, you can draw two cards
off a stupify. That's really strong. Uh
here we have that hex tech ray uh
opening up. Again, it seems like Jay Dog
is about getting these points, clearing
these things. Really wants that student
to get in.
>> Absolutely. I mean, you have to be even
a little careful that if we want to do a
Kai'Sa accelerate play, conquer for the
draw on the Z with the conquer ability,
you know, you have to be a little
worried because that demolitionist is
still on the other side of the table and
so you are you kind of just throwing the
Kaiso away if you tap out to do so, but
that seems to not be the play. The
strength of the deck is keeping your
runes up to play spells. We get
discounts on them. Of course, we've
already used it on the hex tech ray, but
we want to maybe keep this Noxis hopeful
alive and then get a bonus draw if we
target it using something from like the
dreaming tree.
>> Definitely leaving up five runes is an
interesting number. Gives you access to
void seeker and a smoke screen. Looks
like I see a retreat in Jay Dog's hand.
And I think I see that Darius chose not
to play that despite playing a one mana
spell in the same turn. Really could
have just gotten everything in the
board, but Jim does just have so much
power uh available. Jinx is a six while
attacking. Chem's a four while
attacking. The Chompers is a three. Uh,
you know, Darius not the best on defense
if you're not able to leave up those
spells.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I think it's going to
be another one of those flame chompers.
As you said, we found the third one. We
might as well use it to our disposal.
See where the turn goes. Go into the Z
warren. See if there's any contest.
There isn't. Go to three. And now we
have the on conquer effect again.
>> Yeah. I wonder if Jim's thinking about
discarding the fourth flame chompers
right here.
>> What the fourth?
>> Yeah. You know, I think it'd be pretty
powerful if he could.
Do do you get to play with four flame
chompers whereas like I don't get to but
you know do you get the added benefit?
>> Yeah the dev white list is really
>> absolutely but yeah deep in the tank
here for gym because like you said we
have these strong attackers at our
disposal in our base but once they get
to the battlefields the assault is not
live while defending. So we kind we can
be afraid of something like a thousand
jail watcher play. You brought up the
Darius that's in hand. It's going to be
very susceptible to a Darius that can
ready itself in the same turn and gain
that extra two might when we only get
our extra might on on assault.
>> Yeah. So here I it is one of those
things where Jinx is really vulnerable,
but it looks like we're going just for a
trade with that void seeker here. Jinx
gone. That's a pretty great place for
Jim. He didn't get to take that
battlefield, but you know there's a lot
of ways that could have gone so much for
us if there was a smoke screen that ends
up with the Jinx dying and the hopeful
still saying. So I think he's probably
reasonably happy about this. Yeah, I
think even the recycle that, you know,
Jinx did have to actually pay for
instead of, you know, being able to use
your legend because we've already done
it from the Hex Tech Ray from the turn
prior. But like you said, moving in this
Chem Techch enforcer to just get the
point on the board going to four. And so
now it's basically just up to Jay Dog if
he wants to try and compete and keep up
in the point match, but we need a unit
that comes in ready to do so. But Jim
gonna keep his board a little bit more
healthy. Here comes a traveling merchant
for later.
>> Yeah. So this is a situation where Jay
Dog was really patient with this Darius
in his hand and now once he plays the
Darius this turn as he has a second
spell to ready it. Jim doesn't really
have that base presence to pressure the
Darius anymore. So if you play a Darius
play a spell, go in and get rid of this
flame chompers or this chem enforcer.
Maybe you get to ready with the Darius
again next turn and really make a big
play to catch back up.
>> Those are my favorite kind of turns
because that that plus two might on
defense is a huge swing. Especially if
the reason you got there was by playing
stupifies, you know, because the same
reason why you like playing a Raven
Bloom and then stupifying your opponents
because you're going to gain the extra.
But here comes the first Falling Stars
of this match. Really important card in
this matchup. Jinx, I do think is
reasonably good against Kaisen in the
games where they don't draw a bunch of
Falling Stars. You do get to put a ton
of units on the board and Jinx and
Kai'Sa can fall behind a little bit, but
this situation, kill your thing in your
base, kill the thing at the Z warren.
Oh, now my Raven Bloom's plus one. Now
it's going to be able to take that chem
enforcer. Uh Jim had a huge lead in a
huge board and it's about to be all
gone.
>> Yeah. And and here's where I would think
just like you said, there's a world
where we could have gone into that Chem
Enforcer, but maybe just completely
value like, you know, assessing that Jim
might have a one mana shenanigan of his
own. You know, there could be something
that he could play. But I I think it's
just we're playing it safe. It's just
about keeping up in points. But then see
there it is. We even read it. the hex
tech race still being able to be played
because a showdown does still occur. You
lose the unit.
>> Yeah. And I think what Jay Dog was
thinking here is I have this Darius now.
I can play this Darius and gems timed
out. Nothing that can happen. I'm going
to go in and get this Chem Enforcer. Now
I don't think it ever crossed Jay Dog's
mind that this Chem Enforcer was ever
going to hold.
>> Yeah, absolutely. As we pass back, going
to three here because that other point
was denied and we are going to be
passing back to Jim. Going to have four
runes to play with. Two cards in hand as
we draw for our third. Not a lot of room
to really battle this Darius right now
off the get-go. So, it might just have
to be another setup turn.
>> Yeah, it is the first turn we've seen
Jim have four runes in play. So, you
know, maybe this is really new territory
for him and he'll get to do some stuff.
A falling star of his own to take out
that Darius that works from No. Uh, and
that's really what he needs here.
>> Yeah. And followed up by another two
cost traveling merchant means we're down
to one card in hand. And we are at the
sweet spot we want to really be at.
Close to four Jinx going into it. And
you have still kept the units off of
Jog's board as we still pass back. Of
course, the rune disparity is massive.
>> It is massive, but when you build a deck
like Jinx and you're playing Falling
Star and Red Jinx and these Flame
Chompers, you're kind of expecting to be
at this place. Jim, four runes, bet can
play almost any card in his deck at this
point.
>> The champion unit Kai'Sa survivor coming
in with the accelerate cost to go to
that dreaming tree battlefield to even
up the score game finally in this game
with the bonus on conquer effect. will
get that draw. And with that leaving two
up once again, the scary two runes,
something like a smoke screen you
brought up earlier that we could
potentially see as we pack pass back to
Jim. And with that extra draw, we have
three cards to play with instead.
>> Yeah, three cards, four runes means you
probably get to play two of them. I
think Jim's really looking for something
like a cleave here. Being able to go
into that dreaming tree, trigger your
merchant, cleave your merchant, draw a
card really gets you back into the flow
of things. You really want to get ahead
this turn. If you don't have something
like a cleave, maybe you're hoping for
an accelerating, something like a legion
rear guard to go uh in and double fight
the Kai'Sa or try and score the Zon
Warren and just keep things flowing.
Aaron, I have to point out very briefly
that uh this is the first time I've seen
a purple or a Chaos Rune hit Jim's side
of the board actually and two of them at
once even. Uh but the first ones I've
seen all game stacked deck coming in
just to play and get a look at what
we're looking for. And there is a cleave
in those three cards like you were
mentioning.
>> Yeah, this is a really interesting stack
deck. you see a VI, a cleave, and a tide
turner. Uh, I don't think that's a card
you tend to see in these Jinx lists, but
it is a card that makes some sense if
you're trying to protect your V's. Uh, a
lot of options here for Jim of do I want
to make that cleave play this turn or do
I see myself maybe trying to win with
like a VI ride the win play and I need
this VI now. Uh, big moment for his
planning of how the next like three
turns of this game go.
>> And I think it's the best part when you
play a card like stack deck. I think
it's not just about those three cards,
but you now have information of cards
that you will not see basically the rest
of the game. So, what you choose to
recycle from that effect does mean a lot
in these games for Riftbound. And so,
hopefully we're going to determine as we
are swinging into the sky. I can only
imagine we did end up grabbing that
cleave.
>> Yeah. So, we definitely have the cleave
here. And Jim is probably taking the
read from earlier with that void seeker
turn against the Jinx that Jayd Dog
doesn't have a smoke screen or if he
does, he drew in the last couple turns.
>> Absolutely. Yeah. So the on move effect
we get from the traveling merchant. And
of course we do pay the one and we are
going to cleave this and draw off of the
dreaming true just like you said. And so
now with assault three, but here comes a
rebuttal for the retreat that we knew
was sitting in hand for Jay Dog. And
again also targets his own unit drawing
off of the Dreaming Tree. So an exchange
of draw, but the point still going to go
for Jim.
>> Yeah, I bet Jim's pretty happy. He saw
the one energy get exhausted and was
like, "Oh, am I going to get stupified
here? Are we going to trade?" And it
turns out, oh no, I do get to score my
point. This is really great. I need to
get to that six point threshold so I can
threaten that by ride the wind.
>> Absolutely. Follow things up with a Nox
is hopeful
>> and we want that to stick there. And
here comes a hidden card on the side of
Jinx. You know, we we saw a a fighter
flight get discarded already. And we've
already talked about Tide Turner. So I
really have no clue which one this could
be.
>> Yeah. I mean, I think if you are Jay
Dog, you're just going to assume it's
fighter flight, right? A lot of these
decks, that's the only hidden card they
play. Especially if you're used to
playing against something like Annie.
That deck tends to only play Fight or
Flight as their hidden card. Well, it's
going to get killed. So, we're going to
see. And it's a purple team. Now,
>> that is not a card you tend to see in
these decks, so you can't really
predict. Jayd Dog uh doesn't have an
accelerator. Another answer here. It
looks like Jim's going to get to hold
and score a point.
>> That was crazy. I all of a sudden having
an extra hidden unit onto the I mean, I
think hidden units are so powerful
because of the context you just
explained, right? It's not just about it
being a trick that you get to play, but
your opponent thinks it might just be a
spell, but actually it will retain that
hold value. But the second Darius for
Jay Dog this game coming into play. And
because we've already baited out our
first card for the turn, the the ability
that says it readies, it's going to come
in and easily get rid of that Teemo.
>> Yeah, it looks like Jay Dog did leave up
three for a Void Seeker. So Jim can try
and move into the Zorns, but if Jay Dog
has that Void Seeker, it's a pretty big
blowout for Jim. There's a world here
where maybe he just deploys to his
battlefield and waits a little bit. He
did get some cards here. Has five runes
again. The most we've seen from him this
game. And uh you know this is an
opportunity to Okay, you're only at
five. Maybe I have a little bit of
ability to wait.
>> Yeah, I think we're in that same
situation too on the other side for Jim
where you know an offensive swing with
the hopeful give it a cleave if we had
another copy. You know getting that
dreaming tree repeated proc but we're
already getting these bonus draws from
Jinx herself. We're trying to find and
dig for these pieces to close out these
games, but we have to get to six points
to do that double conquer play that
you're talking about, you know, for
trying to do a ride the win by trick
that not just Annie can do, but as we're
showcasing here, Jinx is allowed to play
that same combo.
>> Here is Jim's second falling star,
probably trying to get that Darius, but
another retreat. I think this is a
sequence that another one that's pretty
good for Jim, though, with Jay Dog
getting up to this many runes, things
like time warper on the table, thousand
tail watcher, they become really big
plays to try and get ahead. Yeah,
absolutely. That's even a situation for
Jay Dog. If if he gets to six runes, we
can easily find out very quickly. A
thing like a time warp can easily be a
game ender sometimes for either doing a
double conquer on the following turn
afterwards or for the double hold.
>> Jim thinking pretty hard here with these
two cards. I would be wondering if he
has like a Chem Enforcer and a card he
really wants to keep. It's like, do I
discard that? Or maybe just a separate
separate choice between these two two
drops. puts Merchant in. One that maybe
next turn lets him acrew that little
more card advantage, a little more
value. He just barely needs to get over
the edge.
>> Yeah, it's our last one, too. I think a
third one for the game. Passing back to
Jayog again. No units to be seen, but
now with these heavy amounts of runes,
we could see big plays. But the first
lecturing Yortle coming down for a draw.
Of course, that tank ability on it being
also a little pesky when it comes to
combat damage. towards the end of the
game when you want to assign damage the
correct way to get rid of strong cards
but that tank word or tank trait says
nope you actually have to kill me first.
Yeah, electing your really impressive a
unit that's really great to play early
gives you something on the board lets
you threaten those battlefields but also
turns into a powerful late game draw.
Cheap replaces itself maybe messes up
their math. It kind of does a little bit
of everything
>> like the Kaiso deck. The Kaiso deck does
a little bit of everything.
>> That is true. I mean the deck is really
robust. removal, accelerate units, card
draw. Uh you see it really in this game.
Jim was really explosive, but the
robustness of this Kaiso deck, it keeps
playing these Dariuses, keeps flowing
card draw, keeps getting removal, and
that's really hard for Jim to keep up
with.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Especially when we
keep retreating these units back to our
hand. Like, I mean, the information is
there. Jim knows what could potentially
be played, which is good for when you
are trying to play around it. But when
you know it's a Darius that is going to
come in ready because we've already
played a card. We move in now. We're at
six points for Jay Dog. We are all of a
sudden in winning range.
>> Yeah, this is a really tough spot for
Jin compared to Kai'Sa. Jinx's not as
good at stopping the opponent from
scoring those two points in one turn.
Outside of something like Fighter
Flight, you can't really block against a
giant monster coming in.
>> Here comes that Traveling Merchant move
though. And a scrap heat getting
discarded. So, extra draws here for Jim.
And like you said, five runes here on
the board. Some of the most we've seen
him have the entire game. But that move
trigger getting is going to still be
answered once we finally move to the
showdown. That void seeker coming
through and going to get rid of that
traveling merchant.
>> Yeah, Jim with no board here. Five
points. Can't really threaten a ton. I
could see if he has Vi ride the wind.
This is a turn you maybe have to make
that type of play. Play your VI, make it
big enough to beat the Darius. Ride the
wind it into the Dreaming Tree and then
instead of going to another battlefield
like you normally would with that combo,
instead just back the VI up to the base
to have it ready for next turn and hope
you can have something happen. Oh, there
are two vies. Uh, that's pretty
powerful, but I'm not sure Jim's going
to get another turn.
>> No, I don't think so. Unless we have a a
very important trick, specifically like
a hex tech ray for the lecturing Yortle.
But any unit that comes in ready like
the Kai'Sa that we know is still in hand
will be enough to close it out. And I
think Jim sees that and says, "Let's go
to game two." Game one going to Jay Dog.
So, pretty explosive from both players
here, Aaron. I mean, we know how quickly
Jim was playing the beginning of the
game, using those resources, losing all
of your runes at the beginning of the
game. I love plays like that.
>> Yeah, it's really sweet. I mean, I did
say runes are for losers, and
unfortunately for Jim, that was true.
Uh, but it is kind of the things you're
trying to do is the jinx deck. You're
not winning the long game against
Kai'Sa. They have more card draw. They
have bigger monsters. They have better
removal. The one thing you have is that
essence of speed and applying all these
units and really being able to threaten
both battlefields on turn two. And there
wasn't a moment in that game that Jim
didn't attempt to regain that tempo,
regain that speed. But when you see the
right removal pieces of the Kaisa deck,
when you have the retreats to
continuously save your units that also
still come in ready to contest those
battlefields, the point discrepancy
catches up very quickly and that's how
game one goes over to Jayog. So I'm
excited to see how the game two
adaptation comes from Jim because I mean
being able to go first, but we've now
lost the game with Zon Warren in play.
So, I think Battlefields are really
going to have to mix things up here or
maybe just speed up the game a little
bit. Maybe something like an arena's
greatest. Right.
>> Right. I think one of the things that
really likes that really makes me like
Jinx is the fact that your three
battlefields you get to pick are all
good for you and they're usually much
better than your opponent. Arena's
greatest and zon obvious options.
Something like Reaver's Row, really,
really powerful third battlefield. And
not every deck in the format gets to
say, "Oh, all three of my battlefields
are better for me every time."
>> Absolutely. But we're going to find out
very quickly as we are jumping into game
two in round four at the regional
qualifier. So yeah, going first here for
Jim and we did end up selecting that
arena's greatest for game two and
Targon's Peak on the other side. So
Kaisen now being have access on the
going second game being able to play
more spells on our opponent's turn
because we're going to have hopefully
two more runes ready.
>> Yeah, here we see that tide turner. One
of the great things about that card,
maybe it's a hidden card, maybe it's a
trick to save a VI, but also you can
just play it as a two cost two might
body.
>> And I think we've all learned very
quickly in Riftbound that playing
something on turn two we've or turn one
a two drop like we've seen from both of
these players is so important because
you want to immediately start figuring
out what the point mapping of the game
is going to look like. So like you said,
tight turner, it's still just a two
drop. We want to play that and it's
going to easily be able to move into one
of these battlefields. Um maybe the
Targon's Peak if we plan on tapping
completely out to play some units.
>> Yeah, definitely. And so we have a
really good start here from Jay Dog. I
think one of the best starts from Kai'Sa
is when you're on the draw, you get to
play that two drop and hold up that
Hexte Ray. It makes it where Jim goes
in. Do we have the removal?
>> It looks like we do. That's really big
here.
>> Hex Tech Ray just like you said. And so
that tight turner unless we have some
sort of trick as Jim doesn't immediate.
Okay, there it goes. It's gone. But now
with four runes to play with and now
Kai'Sa completely tapped out. What are
you going to do now to set up your
board? But this is now acting as if
because of that removal. Like you said,
it's like Jim went second, at least when
it comes to board presence.
>> Yeah, I mean, this is one of those
situations that is really tough for Jim.
He has that Jinx in the champion zone.
Can choose to play it and take one of
these battlefields, maybe get that
Targon's peak and ready two of his
runes. Maybe he has something like a
fight or flight, but doing that really
sets you so far behind. Here's a brazen
buccaneer. That's an interesting one.
>> Yeah. Yeah. cost six, but uh we're going
to discard a card to reduce its cost.
And depending on what this discard a
card is, we could see even like another
flame chomper come into play. Um but
it's got five might, which for four,
which feels really good then.
>> Yeah, when you're playing Jinx against a
deck like Kai'Sa, as I said last game,
those falling stars are really
important. oftentimes they're removing
two of your units. Being able to play a
unit with more than three might and have
it take a whole falling star to remove
it and not get killed by a single void
seeker can potentially be a really big
break point on the numbers and how these
fights can go.
>> Yeah, but it is in our base of course.
So, we're just going to have to then
again concede the tempo here as we are
going to be the first point or second
point because of the arena's greatest.
We're going to go to our second point
for here for Jay Dog. And we have five
runes to play with. It could be as
simple as an accelerate Kai'Sa if you
want to do it early. But it looks like
instead we are going to our pay4 and
play a sprite mother which is
essentially still going to score us a
point because this sprite token that we
play does come in ready.
>> Yeah. So Jay Dog here going to get two
points going to get that target peak
ready two runes. Leave up a void seeker.
I it looks like if Jim goes in if
doesn't have access to something like a
cleave is just going to get potentially
removed out by some of that red removal.
Can can we talk about a little bit about
the sprite? It feels so bad attacking
into a temporary unit.
>> It is a tough place to be if your unit's
going to trade with it. And so you
really get this feeling in the situation
of am I just supposed to not score here
this turn? Am I not supposed to make
that trade? Uh how bad is it if I just
pass the turn? I mean, they're not going
to score from a hold. But if you didn't
kill the sprite, that means that
battlefield's open and that Sprite
mother just gets to move in for free.
And on the other side of it, attacking
the other unit knowing the sprite will
be disappearing feels really good. But
like you said, it just means that
there's like an uncontested battlefield
for the player that put the temporary
unit there to come and take it again on
the next turn. Just like you said, and
because you said it won't be a hold
effect. You'll be able to get the
unconquer from the Targon Peak again.
>> Yeah, Targon's Peak in particular, great
thing to take with this sprite. Jim, uh,
big turn here. Has six runes. Uh really
what are you trying the things you're
trying to think of here are
>> can I take both battlefields
>> I'm behind on points by two that's a big
difference at this type of game where
you're really trading these back and
forth and
>> if I can't take this by two is there a
way for me to try and play this long
game I do have brazen buccaneers it
looks like maybe my units are bigger
possibly has something like Darius in
his deck there is the falling star
that's probably going to kill both of
the real units here
>> that's probably the best play I can
imagine happening right now because not
only will this brazen buccaneer able to
help us get back to that point
discrepancy that we are at. But we have
four runes now to play with still to
play more units. We played a card double
knock is hopeful I think could be very
strong here for having two more four
might units on the board.
>> Yeah, double Knox is hopeful again. More
of those units that don't die to falling
star. Jay Dog hasn't had a chance to
play a really powerful falling star in
self this game. Maybe has one in his
hand. Wants to wait. I think this is an
opportunity for Jim to get that little
bit ahead. Uh, interesting note, Jay
Dog, also out of blue runes now. Yeah,
potentially things like smokec screen,
there's no guarantee they're working.
Uh, and we see a Teemo played to the
base.
>> Uh, again, like you said, it's one of
those cards that yes, it functions as a
hidden card, but it's also just a two
drop and we just want to play cards.
>> Really interesting thing here is Jim
could have hidden that at the arena's
greatest. Could have really protected
that battlefield. But this gives the
impression to me, and maybe Jay Dog
thinks this as well, Jim must not have
more units. This is the only way Jim is
able to contest that Targon's peak and
contest trying to score that point next
turn.
>> Yeah, we don't give ganking really
anything except for the buy with the
ride the wind play. It has ganking. So,
how do we move to that other battlefield
without having something in our base to
move over there first? But it looks like
it was just another reset turn for Jay
Dog as we just played a lecturing Yortle
and that Nox is hopeful getting a little
extra value holding one rune up as we
pass back to Jim and this Teemo stayed
alive so we're going to be able to swing
into that Targon's Peak. So Jim is going
to have two runes to play with at the
end of his turn no matter what. But we
have six to play with now once again in
that same spot. This is still the most
runes I've seen Jim have this whole
match basically because we usually throw
this away. I'm waiting for the flame
chompers to keep coming back so that we
keep continuing to have more cards on
our board. But instead, here comes that
first five for this game.
>> Yeah, there's a couple things going on
here that are really important. One, Jim
got to four points and is ahead on the
race compared to Jay Dog. If they both
score two points every turn, Jim will
get to eight before Jay Dog does. They
was behind by those two points. Was able
to find his way back because of Jay
Dog's weak turn there. And also now
having to deploy that Vi, which is kind
of not what you want to do against
Kaiso. Now it is vulnerable to that
Cathy and Rain or that falling star
makes it way harder to get that ride the
wind combo later when you're forced to
play it now. Yeah, I think I think any
sort of very very high play a Kaathan
ring type of idea or you know even a
Darius here to contest against this
Brazen Buccaneer, it's just a scary
position to be in because I feel like
both of these units out of battlefields
are going to be gone this turn like you
said and we're going to go to five
points for Jay Dog side and then you're
just staring at the VI. But if it's
something instead like a spell that can
target the VI, then it feels like Jim's
entire board is gone once again. void
seekering the 1-1. One of the life's
lowliest uh sad things you have to do.
It is the type of situation where it
gives the impression Jay Dog maybe can't
fight through the brazen Buccaneer
without using both units or really is
trying to draw into something powerful
to play this turn. Possibly a hand of
just all spells and no units.
>> Yeah, that that makes sense to me that
I've never really thought about it in
the sense of wow, you're right. This
could deal four, but instead right now
it is only going to deal one to this
Teemo. But like you said, it still gets
it off the board, but it also just sets
up as the first card to be played for
this Darius as it's now going to come in
ready and have the plus two might. So
the seven being able to contest against
this brazen with the tank on the
lecturing yortle, it makes me feel like
this Darius is going to be super safe.
The fighter flight though,
>> this is the big problem with the play
Jay Dog just made. moving in with the
Darius and the lecturing ur means that
fighter or flight gets to eat your
lecturing ur for free. You were playing
around. You saw hex tech from gym game
one. If you had it before, it would have
traded with the Darius where the
lecturing would have protected it. But
this is a bad scenario.
>> That was that was and all of a sudden
things are coming up gym a little bit
more because we're going to get that
hold not being able to be contested at
all just by the Nox is hopeful. And we
now have this VI ready to go. Jim going
to five here. If we can just get to six,
we will be in range for that double
conquer play that we know oh so well for
this VI.
>> Yeah, I mean Jay Dog has no runes up.
This VI can take that battlefield. There
is no recourse. Jim really in the
driver's seat here. It's mostly about
how can I make sure I am set up at my
base ready to take both of these
battlefields again on the next turn.
>> You think we finally drew all of the
flame chompers or scrap heaps? You think
that demolitionist will come into play
now? I mean again it's another one of
those those for my units I can avoid a
falling stars range at least for the you
know needing both reflexive triggers but
it also would give you so many units on
the board as long as you can use one of
these units to take over and grab this
Targon's peak you'd go to six and then
you're just staring at Jaydog going hey
you basically have to remove my whole
board or I'm really threatening the game
here.
>> Yeah I mean on this turn Jim has to
assume that Jay Dog doesn't have that
falling star. If he did, he probably
would have played the Darius plus the
falling star and killed the VI out of
the base. And here comes that falling
star, the card of the match for killing
that Darius. Jim really blowing up the
board. Jay Dog's going to need some big
Accelerate units from hand. Maybe a
Watcher. Uh maybe in a Cathian rain that
would show up really powerfully right
here. Uh but even with all those things,
Jim does have that Jinx in the champions
ready to steal a battlefield at least
once.
>> Yeah, and it looks like it's so it's
much more important for Jim here to get
to six. And there it is. That buy going
to be going in. not great on defense as
we're aware. Um, doesn't gain all that
extra might because you're going to have
to recycle those cards from your trash,
but instead it does still offer the
three might to be here that that Nox
Hobo is probably going to take over. But
still five runes to play with, but if
we're going to be playing cards like
fight or flight defensively, we might
want to keep some of that up again. But
the Targon speed conquer says we're
going to get him back anyway.
>> This would be a turn where if Jim is
playing more copies of Tide Turner, it'd
be really great to swap it out with that
buy.
that might dog
safe and ready to come back in and
conquer over whatever Jay Dog does.
>> It's some sort of two
two drop play as we are doing the one.
No, there's a hidden I mean it's the
same idea, right?
>> Well, so that must not be a tide turner.
If I'm Jay Dog, I'm like that can't be
tieer. Maybe Jim is trying to finagle
swapping the tide turner with the
buccaneer and having a really big
defensive wall. But if he had that tie
turner, I think he would just play it
and swap out the VI instead. We've seen
Teemo and we've seen Fighter Flight.
Both of those particularly good here for
different reasons. Fight or flight able
to protect the VI from a removal spell
like a void seeker or a hex tech. Teemo
allowing a unit to survive through that
Noxus hopeful coming in.
>> Yeah, turning the fight orflight into
reaction speed matters a lot at least
when it comes to fighting against
certain cards. Um, so I like the idea of
it if it is the fight or flight giving
it that extra bump.
>> I mean, doesn't help us here for say if
it's going to be targeted on this
falling star, but or but we have to put
both triggers here for the brazen
buccaneer if that's what we want to get
rid of, but we're just going to split it
up.
>> A one in one split here is really
interesting. If Jay Dog does have access
to Oh, there is that Teemo keeping that
formite on the battlefield. The hopeful
doesn't get to take it for free. Uh but
if Jay Dog does have either a couple
stupifies for the Buccaneer or a smoke
screen can finish it off from the
falling star. Really looking to do that
type of thing here. Pretty low on runes
and things to be able to play this turn.
I see a lecturing ur in hand, but that's
not what you really want to be spending
your runes on.
>> Yeah, if that is eating part of the real
estate space in our hand. It's not
necessarily the one we want to be
playing. And this Darius is nice at
least when it comes to getting on the
board and contesting this Teemo that got
flipped up. But a the fight orflight
from hand also just gets the job done
and puts it back which means this could
potentially be the game here. This Nox
is hopeful sure yes it can move up. But
if you're only going to have the two
runes left unless of course we take this
takes the trade instead is now
challenging. But with the Jinx
demolitionist I can only imagine.
>> Yeah. Passing the turn here. Jinx in the
zone. Jim not even drawing his card just
being like I have this. You are not here
anymore. The game is over. I'm at eight
points. Uh that game was really really
great. Jim was behind early on, behind
by those two points, was able to catch
up, get ahead by two points or the
important number four to three and then
Jay Dog was never able to capitalize or
come back ahead and that was really
really awesome. I'm so glad we're going
to a game three for this because I think
man the when the first fight or flight
got played by Jim I was like well that's
not the card I guess I was expecting in
that exact moment and I don't think Jay
Dog was either because all of a sudden
the point the it swung the other
direction based off of the early game
and just like you said Jim able to close
it out. Yeah, I mean I made a comment
during that game that the Jinx deck is
not particularly good at stopping those
big monsters outside of fighter flight
and Jim found multiple fighter flights
to keep that uh Darius out and keep the
things out and keep him on that board
pressure. That's about as much as he
could hope for that game. He didn't have
the flame chompers. He didn't have the
explosive start, but he was still able
use his tools, conquer those
battlefields, and you know, get ahead
and win through the power of those tempo
plays of fight or flight.
>> That's exactly right. because I didn't
see we didn't see Jim go super wide that
game. We didn't play a ton of units. We
played exactly the amount of units we
needed to win and play this game. But we
have a third game that we want to be
getting into. Of course, now we are
going to be jumping a little bit into
this game a little bit further down the
line. Uh we have the technology here
that immediately there was a bit of a
judge call and so we can skip past that
point. So we're going to play a little
bit of catchup of course, but this is
Jay Dog on the play here being able to
go first. immediately starts off with a
watchful sentry and the battlefields
here is Arena's greatest has shown up
once again here Aaron which if I'm Jim I
kind of want to see that well you do but
the Kaised has that potential to play a
really aggressive game that is why Jay
Dog has his own arena and when he is on
the play chooses to put it out there uh
reavers row also a pretty good
aggressive and defensive battlefield I
can see Jayd dog getting some good
leverage from that as well though with
unit like watchful sentry maybe not the
one you care too much about protecting.
>> No, absolutely not. You kind of want
that one to go away, but it's there to
score points. Uh because once it dies,
we were going to replace itself and draw
a card from its death now. But as we
pass back, uh Jim here has a Reaver's
row. So, this is going to be really
good, too. That at least when it comes
to the combat potential from Jay Dog of
like the Dariuses or the Accelerated
Jinxes, we can save our units or at
least one of them, right? We can choose
to bring it back and maybe just keep a
little bit more stuff on the board. But
instead, we led with a stacked deck for
our turn one, followed up by a Pouty
Poro.
>> Pouty Poro. Nice. Great two drop doesn't
help doesn't make it as bad when you get
falling starred really early. Uh also
big enough to threaten that watchful
sentry. Maybe kick it out or try and
take that arena's greatest.
>> Yeah, it makes sense. That's probably
why we went to the reaver's row because
maybe you want to keep it alive. But as
you stated earlier, you're kind of okay
with it just going away as well, but
maybe just not necessarily wanting to
give up the unit that early. But we've
seen this before. We've actually seen it
already this match. But another great
turn two play here for the Kaiser deck
in general is that Raven Bloom student
followed up by the Noxis Hope with that
cost reduction.
>> Yeah, the choice of moving the watchful
sentry into the Reavers row is really
interesting. There's something you could
consider as Jay Dog there, which is if I
think Jim is going to go to wherever I
put this sentry, where do I want his
pouty porro to be? Would I rather it be
at the Reaver's Row? Would I rather it
be at that arena's greatest? And I think
if you're Jay Dog, you're much happier
if it's at the arena's greatest and you
can kill it back when you attack in.
Yeah, that that's kind of where I'm at.
And we're going to see right here if
that was the decision or Yeah, we're
going to utilize its effect just valuing
having the extra unit saying I don't
need to draw the card right now. I will
eventually draw the card when it does
die. But yeah, of course giving that
point over to Jim 22 each I believe,
right? Because of the arena's greatest
moving in.
>> Yeah, Jay Dog really believing that this
watchful sentry is going to be worth
more than being able to trade back for
that pout saying I need this body. I
want bodies to be able to threaten these
battlefields and I want to save this
rather than make the other move of go to
the arena's greatest on that second
turn.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Now, as we pass back
to Jim with our or we have our five
runes to play with after we've moved up
with that, we're just going to play
traveling merchant plus vi. Very early
buy here and I kind of think that's
sometimes a scary decision to make
because it's very vulnerable.
>> It is very vulnerable. As I said,
falling star in the base right here
would be really bad for Jim. pick off
that traveling merchant, pick off that
VI, but sometimes that's the only two
drop you have and you really do want to
play two bodies on that second turn. I
can believe Jim also maybe has the
second VI in hand. The second one tend
not tends to not be as good. You can't
make it as large and you're not too
worried if the first one dies if you
have the second.
>> Yeah, Watchful Cream now moving over
getting that full value. Like I said, we
kept it alive. Moving it over to the
arena's greatest. And here comes that
sprite mother that we saw in game two
going to give us this sprite token which
can easily contest against this patty
porro.
>> It is very funny seeing sprites go to
the reavers row cuz it's like oh do I
want to save it? I guess it doesn't
really matter.
>> That is an interesting play to do there.
But I you know probably Yeah. What would
you do? Would you keep it alive?
>> You know sometimes it's about letting
them know you don't really need it. Just
you know let it go.
>> I think there's actually a world where
it's kind of can be a trap as we are now
passing. Jaydog is passing his turn with
two runes up. That's smokeokesc screen
territory where you could maybe bait
your opponent into attacking into the
sprite. You're like, "Oh, I could
reavers row this, but it will go away
anyway." But then the then the sprite
could potentially actually win a
showdown with something like uh smokec
screen being played.
>> Yeah, I mean Jim is in a spot here where
attacking into this reaver's row is
pretty tough. And the arena's greatest
looks really appealing. There's a one
night watchful sentry. You can send in
almost anything. Even if there is a
smoke screen, you're still getting that
trade. Uh, I would totally believe that
this situation will end with Jim trying
to go to both using this uh, merchant to
discard a card so that you can eat some
extra cards with that vine and make it
large enough to get through the sprite
plus like a stupify if possible.
>> I love discarding the Chem Enforcer to
make sure that we don't discard more
cards, which means Jim really likes what
he has. Uh, we don't want to, even if it
means building more units onto the
board, we don't want to have to give up
that extra card to do so.
because we like the stuff we have. I
mean, we're thinking about it. We have
six runes to play with. Again, I don't
think I've seen Jim have more than six
runes the entire match.
>> Yeah, Jim here has a lot of options.
Maybe can play this Jinx discard cards
that way to really make sure this VI
gets through the sprite. I can see an
avenue where you make it bigger. There
were smoke screens not even good enough
here.
>> Yeah, we we thought about seeing the
falling stars from Jay Dog, but instead
it's coming here from Jim targeting both
of those units. that's going to actually
kill the sprite mother and the Raven
Bloom. Now only having to deal with a
Nox is hopeful on the next turn because
the Sprite will disappear. It's only
temporary.
>> Yeah, Jim really does want to score both
these battlefields though. He's at the
odd number at three. Four again, that
magic number 4 68. That's what you're
trying to do here. And I imagine Jim is
going to spend a lot of resources here
to really make sure he gets that point.
This looks like recycling to that VI to
try and do just that. Yeah, I was going
to wonder, you know, the double recycle
play gets it up to four and even if
there's something that like a stupify
that comes in, you trade and then you
still have the powdery porro or do you
think you overload it? It looks like we
didn't do too many cards.
>> Just one here putting up to a four. We
have a smoke screen putting up to three,
but if Jim has something like a cleave
here, it could still work out in his
favor.
>> Yeah, I mean, good to know. I read the
smoke screen play. We were baiting the
sprite trade, but it looks like we're
going to have to let it go. And now this
Patty Porro is currently not in position
to beat this sprite. And so the double
conquer that you said is so important on
this turn potentially might not happen.
>> Yeah, Jim might be beating himself up a
bit there. Not eating more stuff with
that VI. Potentially has that second VI
though. That's a reason you would really
want to conserve those things in his
trash. But losing out on that point
makes that second V much worse. There is
that second VI but at three points
instead of at that even number that is
so crucial.
>> Yeah, I mean yeah, you're right. I
there's I I think I've played Vi enough
times in the game and not recycled
enough because you thought you could get
around or you were playing around a
specific thing and it wasn't actually
the one that you could have gotten there
instead.
Not getting that conquered due to that.
I wonder if that could end up deciding
this match when we think about it all
the way down at the end. And I'm excited
to look back at it at this point because
I think that was a crucial moment.
>> Definitely. I mean that was a huge turn
for Gem. A lot of options, a lot of
cards that could be played, lots of
numbers you could move around. the ones
he went with put him in this state. Now
his question is not what did I do wrong?
Was there anything wrong there? It's
okay, how do I win this game now? I
still have this buy. I have a Jinx in my
champion zone. Maybe I have a ride the
win. Maybe I have ways to steal. Jay
Dog's board's not that impressive right
now.
>> No, we did a great job with that falling
stars, right? Remove the two things that
it could get rid of. And now just with
the Nox is hopeful. Of course, this will
easily take over and take that arena or
the arena's greatest battlefield,
killing off the traveling merchant. But,
you know, we're posturing that we maybe
want to do a Darius turn as well for Jay
Dog for a double conquer. You know, we
set two aside, keep the five ready to
go. Of course, we still have that Kaiso
survivor that we can bring in whenever
we want.
>> Yeah, it's possible the five is for that
Kaiso survivor. Accelerate, get that in
the Reavers row. Kaiso great in the
Reaver's row draws you a card. If they
try and kick you out, then you get to
conquer with the Kai'Sa again the next
turn. And there is one of those falling
stars, but there are two patty porros at
least. So, three runes or two runes with
the Kai'Sa gone from Kai'Sa. But that VI
probably Jim's lifeline getting put into
the trash here. Now probably needs a
really new plan.
>> Unacelerated Kaisa though. Uh Jaydog
being okay with only still staying at
three points. Thinks that this Knox is
hopeful might just be good enough to
retain and get that hold. Uh or sorry,
we actually we're at four. We bump up to
four. So, as we pass back to Jim here,
but with the Kai'Sa not being
accelerated means that it technically is
vulnerable from something like another
falling star on the side of Jim, but it
might be a little difficult to mess with
it now because it's still in the base.
>> This is a situation where for Jim, even
something like a falling star on that
Kai'Sa isn't that appealing. You really
need to be getting these points. The
Kai'Sa deck will be getting ahead if you
give it enough time. and just getting
rid of something like the Kai'Sa
compared to playing your own stuff
really pressuring this board not as
appealing as it is in games where you're
already ahead and you get to clear out
their base.
>> Yeah, I mean I I think of like every
time I look at a card and I think about
well hold on does this target a card at
a battlefield? Does this target a card
anywhere? It it really does, you know,
show you that discrepancy of its power
level and I wonder like I mean if if
Yeah, once again here's another falling
star that means we actually can get rid
of this Kai'Sa. And I can only imagine
that's where it's gonna go. There it
goes.
>> Yeah. I mean, if you are gym here, you
kill this Kai'Sa and you're hoping,
okay, maybe Jay Dog doesn't have any
more accelerate units. Maybe we're just
going to trade these onepoint
battlefields and that gives me an
opportunity to make a big play later.
Tieer here, not as impressive as
tieering something bigger. You're just
moving your two might units around, but
happy to see it pop back up again.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I mean, like you said,
I mean, just the value and I think a lot
of people have been kind of sleeping on
this card because it not just functions
as this hidden trick that you can do for
the chaos domain. It still just
functions as a two drop as we've seen it
and then it's also a defensive trick.
Obviously, we're only protecting a
powdery porro could have been protecting
something much larger, but I I do love
the versatility of that card and it's so
good.
>> Yeah, Jay Dog here with seven runes. Not
enough to accelerate something like a
thousand tailed Watcher to really get
back on even number value. Uh, is Jay
Dog looking like he's going to pass? No.
No way. Here. Has plenty of stuff to do.
>> Yeah, Void Seeker here. Um, I think What
do you think? Do you think it's better
that it was the Tide Turner there
instead of the Pouty Porro now because
of the deflect that would have been on
the Pouty Borro?
>> Yeah, I mean, Jim is probably like, "Oh,
well, I guess I should have left that
there. It would have cost you a rune."
Um, would that rune matter this game?
Hard to tell. It seems like uh Jay Dog
has plenty of things going on and I
imagine if there were any time warps in
the deck that would need 10 runes, those
probably got boarded out at this stage.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I mean, the games are
going so quickly, right? At least when
it comes to the board state and spending
our runes for power costs, of course. Uh
but I mean, the fact that the Nox is
hopeful, Jay chose to retreat it back,
keeping it safe potentially for, you
know, the double conquer later, but
we're only at five points. So this is
now an opportunity that if Jim now
taking this Reaver's Row could play some
sort of accelerated unit and I think
that's exactly where this accelerated
Jinx demolitionist is coming in as we're
going to get a double discard. One of
which being a scrap pee, but we also did
discard a key card, I think, for a good
play, the ride the win.
>> Right. Well, that ride the wind lost a
lot of its value. We've had two of our
vise already get removed this game, and
this game actually has gone pretty long.
A lot of one-scoring turns. Uh Jim being
down two vise and a ride the wind and
finally playing as champion. The ways he
has to finish out this game are
dwindling pretty quickly and he's going
to really need to make sure he finds the
last few. Yeah, I think it might
actually come down to do we have the
other VI and another ride the wind.
>> Jim moves in with the Jinx here, which
is really interesting. Jay Dog passed
with four runes up.
>> Yeah,
>> as Jim I may be thinking that's a void
seeker. My Jinx is going to be removed
there, but Jay Dog just let it go
through. Jay Dog having looks like four
cards in hand going through Jim's head.
What could those be? Maybe it is things
like stupify, smokec screen. Maybe it's
another falling star. Maybe it's that
thousand tailed Watcher. couldn't play
that turn, but it's definitely some of
the more slow and clunky cards compared
to the really sliff removal. Oh,
>> the double hide here, I think, is so
fun. And I don't know what those cards
are. It's going to be a surprise for all
of us, but the fact that you're at six
with a unit at each battlefield, it
means that something like double fight
orflight could be gamewinning, but it
could also just be like some Teeos or
something.
>> Yeah. I mean Jim didn't get the over
runes are for losers game one but this
game they are all gone play our Jinx get
in lose two runes hide two cards no hand
what do you have I think your hand's
pretty clunky let's see it
>> going with a hex tech ray right here
though and going to be targeting that
pouty porro of course for the cause but
because one of them was a ride the wind
it can secure our porro by moving it off
of that battlefield because hex tech ray
only can deal damage to units on
battlefields
>> yeah this goes back to that fight or
flight when it's hidden becomes a
reaction. You can respond to those
things like Hexte Ray and that's really
really important in a matchup here like
Kaisen.
>> Yeah, absolutely. As we're getting
another two with a double recycle, a
falling star coming through here. It
would either have to be double triggers
on to the Jinx. Yeah, there it is.
That's the only way that we're going to
remove that right here. But if moves it
back, it doesn't matter. Doesn't do
anything.
>> That is tough. So Jim was really hoping
Jay Dog's hand there were just
accelerate units. I hope you have
thousand tail watcher. I hope you have
Darius. Please don't have a bunch of
removal. And it turns out Jay Dog's hand
was falling stars removal. Hexte gym now
out of cards, low on runes, just a pouty
porro. Jay Dog at six. This looks like
it's probably about to be wrapped up
here.
>> Yeah, I mean there there is still some
hope. Of course, you know, we're Jinx.
You know, we get to see some more cards.
We're going to get another Chaos Rune
and a Fury rune, but like a cleave does
get your Pyro in winning range for that
battlefield. I just don't know of a unit
that we can play right now for two that
would come in ready. And that's the big
problem of just like how can we get to
that battlefield right now. Maybe it's
the same situation though for Jay Dog.
If we can just contest this Knox is
hopeful, they won't have enough units to
win either.
>> Right. So we get to go in with this
pouty poro though, right? So now we're
going up to seven. Jay Dog only has
electrile. That's only two might
currently only offering a trade. Jay Dog
maybe can't win on the following turn,
but if he had the read on uh Jim having
all those uh fighter flights and is
saving those accelerate units, one of
those right now would be backbreaking.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I This is actually the
obviously the most tense moment of the
match as we are at time. We have gone to
turns, but with the score is so high, I
can only imagine the game will still be
ending either not if not here for some
crazy play from Jim. It would man I
guess it could be it could be fight
orflight plus cleave is all I can think
of. That's exactly three.
>> That would be really really good. Really
impressive pair of draws. But that's the
thing about Jinx is if you ever need two
card combos, you can peel those off the
top. There it goes. Counting down our
turns. Uh Jim with two cards in hand.
Thinking really hard about which ones to
play here, which makes me think he only
gets to play one of them.
>> Only one of them. Is it the winning one?
Is it potentially the losing one? as we
are paying two for something. Ride the
wind cost two. Okay, looks like he's
just going to establish some more cards
on the board. The hold for the extra
might here kind of matters.
>> Oh, he couldn't play that falling star.
He had those two chaos runes. You know,
that is a pretty backbreaking thing.
Even if he could though, could just kill
the Noxus Hope or just the Yortle. There
is an advantage though and that is it.
Wow, how close the end of that game got
for Jim. All the way down the double
fight orflight read trying to be the
play that wins him the game. But at the
end of the day, it looks like the spells
reign supreme. So Jay Dog taking it
down, moving on. He was already two and
one, so now moving on at 3 and one. He's
very much in the race for trying to make
it into that day two for top 64. So, but
at the end of the day, I'm so glad we
got to look at that Jinx decks because I
think that was a true highlight of what
that deck can do.
>> Yeah, I thought we saw a lot of cool
things in those games. We saw Jinx game
one vomit all its hand on the board. Get
two flame chompers. Get this Jinx. Blow
up all my runes. Game two a slow
grindier game with these fighter
flights. Keeping that tempo, getting
letting you get ahead. And in game
three, Jim really exemplified one of the
principles of aggressive decks, which is
played your outs, moving those units in,
hiding those cards, hoping that Jay
Dog's hand was not spells, just units.
And then at the end there, very similar
thing, thinking about where to play that
chemac enforcer. Chose to play at the
battlefield. Jay Dog has somehow no
accelerate units and no removal spells.
Maybe he can't stop you and you hold.
But at the end of the day, Kai'Sa has a
ton of answers to a ton of things.
>> Yeah, and that's exactly what we saw it
end up being. But I think at the end of
the day, I did learn a lesson, Aaron.
And that's runes are for losers because
I think that game was played incredibly
well by Jim. And you know, I think we're
excited to get ready to our next feature
match for round four. So, but it is one
of those things to where it's like I
want to see Jim. I actually had the
pleasure of talking to Jim at some point
this weekend and he is very much here
going for that race for the metal card.
So, I do wish him luck because only two
losses so far is still not a bad thing
to be mad about.
>> Yeah, there's probably not a ton of
jinxes in the room. Not one of those
decks people consider one of the
strongest coming into the weekend, but
that gives you a strong opportunity to
fight for that best of prize, which is
really, really cool. I of course love
Jim and I guess him the best. And Jay
Dog doing great. Excited to see more of
him this weekend. Kais is a strong deck.
I think there's a world where we get to
see him play again.
>> Absolutely. But I think it's time to
move on to not only some more legends
like Jinx that we finally got to see
this weekend. Two legends we have yet to
see on the stream going into round four.
We've got actually a good friend of mine
uh Madrout Ryan is his name. He's
playing Victor and I I believe he has
that one loss going into this round
versus Greedy Mad Hatter on Finally
Aaron a Master Y. I feel like we've been
talking about this legend for quite a
few months now and now we finally get to
see one here in the regional qualifier.
Yeah, Master Y has kind of had this
position as one of the two big decks.
Kai'Sa, Master Y, those have been the
talks of a lot of the events. There's
been some upsets recently. Annie set
doing really good finishes. Uh, but here
we are. Master E coming in against what
I think a lot of people would consider a
good deck, but maybe a bit of an
underdog in Victor.
>> Yeah, absolutely. As it looks like for
game one, we are going to be going in
for
a let me look. Trifarian war cramp,
which is great because we play a lot of
units. We want to give some extra might
for that. But going first here for the
Victor deck is a big is big because we
actually didn't end up using our Victor
legend ability. Playing a Raven Bloom
student is really good for this deck for
the idea of like not having to go
straight to start generating recruits.
Well, Victor is one of those decks that
I do think plays better going second
than a lot of the other decks because
you do always get to play both a two
drop and make that recruit and threaten
both battlefields even when you're going
second. Uh, not a lot of decks can do
that and it looks like uh, you know,
greedy Mad Hatter here, not getting to
capitalize, pit rookie, not really using
all three runes in the same way. Uh, lot
of room here for Victor to kind of get
that started and get a game ahead. Yeah,
especially with uh the battlefield of
choice here for Mad Hatter is going to
be the Vile Lair, which is going to stop
all sort of moving shenanigans, at least
when it comes to going from biomas layer
to base. Ganking of of course is still
on the table and other movement
shenanigans that could go to the other
battlefield. But going to go ahead and
get that first point here for the Victor
and we're going to play oursel a soaring
scout as well. Gonna hopefully get some
more runes later once this dies. I don't
know if this was something that uh
Madrat was going to do, but didn't hit
an order rune that turn. No option to
play that yellow victor from the zone.
Could have played that and had it where
if the pit rookie traded with the raven
bloom, you get a recruit, but instead
you're leaving up this one. Stupify
retreat. All options here in case uh
Madhatter goes in.
>> Absolutely. Passing back though, you
know, this pit rookie and the biggest
thing obviously with master in general
is we need to get onto these
battlefields. We need our legend ability
to be live, which means we have to be
defending alone. So that doesn't work
offensively. good idea to maybe go to
the trifarian war cap.
>> Yeah, you're going in here, you're
taking that hold. Once uh the Wu
Bladesman takes that first spot, it
becomes pretty hard for other decks to
attack in. It's not like Madr has a lot
of might in play. If he's going to go in
and take this fight, really needs some
extra tricks going on.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And Kiana now hitting
the board. And as we know, you know, the
uh mind domain as well as the order
domain are very, very good at playing
things that target your opponent's
units. So, you know, the deflect on that
Kiana is going to go, I think, for some
pretty good mileage here instead of
necessarily for some combat wins, but
passing things back. That means that
hold point is going to come through here
for Madr going to two as we finally now
have some order runes. So, maybe that
Victor can come into place because that
that Raven Bloom did end up surviving.
>> Shenanigans.
>> Yeah, I find Mr. here. There are a
couple things that could kill this Kiana
without deflect. Cole the week doesn't
require a choice. If you can get that
pit rookie off the board and play your
cold of the week, maybe you never have
to pay for this deflect.
>> Yeah, another uh this is my favorite
combination also for these two domains
is that you get access to the watchful
sentry plus the soaring scout. These
incredibly strong death nail abilities
that give you extra advantage for both
of them. Of course, we have finally also
seen the seal of unity. I believe this
one is unity as it gives you that, you
know, yellow pip when it comes for
paying power costs at the cost of course
recycling one of those runes. now as the
Victor champion unit, Victor leader uh
comes in.
>> Yeah, all out of runes, which means that
Madra can't fight through this pit
rookie this turn. Pretty happy I'm sure
as Mad Hatter Kiana looks like it's
going to be able to take this vile Mos
Lair, give you that rune or that card
depending on how your hand set up. And
uh not the most power still on Madr's
board to kind of fight back against
stuff.
>> Yeah, and I I think that's going to be
the hardest part, right, is that you
know, we didn't contest the pit rookie.
Now the pit rookie at least when
defending alone because of you know the
the blade the blade master himself it's
going to be at five and so we're having
to move multiple units obviously with
the bonus help from the war camp to get
us there but instead we're going to
attack into that raven bloom into the
biom layer and uh because we've lost
that raven bloom we could use our
trigger. Yeah mad hatter here going in
for a rune off the Kiana. That's really
interesting. Nine is usually not the
number you are going for here.
oftentimes it's eight. You want dead
blue predator, you want white flame
protector, but nine means I have both a
big play and a trick I want to hold up.
>> Yeah. And I mean, yeah, it's it's so
many runes to think about, but at the
same time, you don't really have to you
don't have to use a lot of resources as
the Y deck, right? You get to, you know,
you know, how many disciplines are you
holding? How many on guards are you
holding as we play this stallwart porro
to reinforce the Trifarian war camp? And
in a rare situation where you typically
want to be defending alone, unless we
move that pit rookie back, which seems
to be the play, because of Trifarian War
Camp, you kind of make up the difference
if it's not defending uh alone. Yeah,
this is a battlefield in the game where
it's not always obvious whether you want
to have multiple things there. Uh
deciding to move back that pit rookie
says, "Okay, now I have a porro that's
going to be a six. You're going to need
to move in with at least three of these
tokens to make a trade. And I still have
all these runes up. Maybe I have tricks.
maybe I want to play something else. A
lot of options in Mad Hatter's camp and
a lot of pressure on Madr to make a move
on their next turn.
>> And they got a lot of units to play with
to make that move, right? Um but the
fact that, you know, one of them being
that Victor leader, we don't want to
necessarily attack with that one. That's
one of your, you know, one of your units
you love to keep in your base because
you want to continuously generate the
value from that unit without putting it
in danger. But sometimes at the end of
the game, you do need it to score some
extra points. as we are going to use a
couple more of our runes on the side of
Madhatter. We're going to play that
Clockwork Keeper and just, you know,
solidify some more board presence here.
>> Yeah, these extra two might units in the
base again because of the Wuju Bladem
not the most impressive things. You
really didn't want to play those to the
battlefields, but it does mean if you do
somehow lose the hold of both of these,
you can probably take back one of them.
A big thing though, Mad Hatter did leave
open those two runes. That leaves an
opportunity for defy ong guard
discipline. Lots of tricks here that
Madrout has a pretty hard turn to having
to think about all the computations.
>> Yeah, seven runes to play with. Um,
there's of course a lot of things at our
disposal. I mean, of course, we are we
do have the mind domain, so I can think
of like thousand tail watcher can be
played when it comes to just giving that
effect of giving minus might, but
instead a lecturing Yortle here draws us
some more cards. Even more units have
now hit the board. Um, this is actually
some of the most units I've seen all day
today, at least when it comes to a
stream. But that's exactly what Victor
is really good at doing. If you like
having units, he gives you a lot of
them.
>> In the last match we watched of Jinx
versus Le uh Jinx versus Kai'Sa, I'd
mentioned that lecturing was a really
strong play early and a really strong
play late to protect your cards while
can tripping. But here, it's just really
not what you're excited to be doing with
your runes. You really want to be taking
these battlefields. You want to be
making big plays here and instead you
are playing a two might unit to your
base that's not protecting anything. Uh
good sign that we are digging for some
tools.
>> Yeah. And a lot of these units now being
picked up and moved to the trifanian war
camp, which is of course going to give
them all one might. But like you said,
that stall war puro with the combination
of the Wuju blade master is going to go
all the way up to six might. But all of
these units on the side of Madr are
going to get plus one. So we're going to
have to make some decisions on what we
want to do with our damage distribution
at least for the Madhatter.
>> Yeah. So the numbers here are 6v8. So if
Madhatter does have that discipline or
that on guard can offer a full trade
here, not let Madrout score, but if you
go in with one of these pump spells and
Madrout does have something as simple as
a stupify, you get blown out pretty
hard. You still only kill three of the
things, one gets to conquer and you lost
your trick that is potentially really
important to help you like protect that
Kiana around.
>> And just as our players pointed out from
Matt Hatter, he's like, "Can does this
victor work when these two units in this
battlefield die?" and he goes, "Yeah, I
mean, if you trade with two of these
real units, not the non non-token units,
I'm going to get two recruits back. So,
it's a pretty good trade. At least it
feels that way for a drought. But here
is that on guard, like you said, which
is going to put it up to eight, which
makes this an even trade, but we're
still going to get two of our recruits
back." And you still have some units to
play with later. Um, but so do both
players, I suppose.
>> Yeah, Madrow taking a big think here.
Maybe has something like one of those
stupifiers or smoke screens. Is it worth
going here? What if Mad Hatter has that
Defy or has another ong guard? Really
big options on how to make this. Decides
to say, "Yeah, that's okay. I'm happy
with this. I get some bodies. I draw a
card. I get a rune." Yeah. And every
single one of these going to create a
trigger for us as we are going to
channel a rune exhausted, draw a card,
and then get two recruits back as both
the Watchful Sentry and the Soaring
Scout are are go to the trash. So, the
board stay kind of remaining the same
except for only trading. And we still
didn't score that point. So, we are
going to be behind in that capacity
because it feels like at this current
rate based off of what we played, this
Kiana is not going anywhere.
>> Well, we do have the option to move this
Victor into the Triferian war camp. And
now it's a unit you don't really want to
put into danger. But
>> if you have some trick of your own, then
these two might units on Matt Hather's
side, maybe not implying the biggest
threat to you. If you do have a stupify,
if you do have a smoke screen, you chose
not to play. But it looks like we're
just going to be making some recruits
and probably hanging out here for the
chain.
>> Yeah, keeping that one energy or one
rune up of course means that the stupify
can still come into play. But with none
of your units in danger, there's not
really anything for you to be doing with
it. So it looks like yeah, like you
said, just board generation and that
means this is kind of like a free turn
for Mad Hatter and we have a lot of
runes to really solidify either the
decision of more units in general going
wide or we can play some of our bigger
units. I mean, I think you can even just
get away with playing something like a
dead boom for later. I mean, we're
picking up a lot of them.
>> Yeah. I mean, this is a space where you
can play a big eight might unit, have
something in play, really get that
pressure on. I want to point out there
that Mad Hatter's battlefield this game
is File's layer
>> and his Kiana is trapped there. It's not
a unit you want to have sit there. When
it survives a turn, you really want to
back it out and back in so you can
conquer again, but it's mostly hindering
him. And when you see Madr Victor, your
units don't really matter a ton. You can
leave them at the layer. They're all the
same one might garbage.
>> Yeah, except for, you know, the fact
that a lot of these recruits, of course,
are from one might and that Kiana is
going to be at a whopping six might
because of the blade mast's legend
ability. So, you have a you have to
commit a lot of resources to get rid of
it. Um, I'm I'm wondering at the point,
you know, at when do we start seeing
these highlevel kind of like removal
cards that the order domain has access
to that a lot of Victor players do
enjoy? You said cold the week earlier,
right now we're in a position though
that yes, we have recruits that we can
get rid of, but there are still three
units on the other side of the board and
some of them are only two my guys.
>> Yeah, this could be a situation where
we're looking at some of the bigger
things. We could have access to, you
know, hidden blade or uh potentially
even something like a singularity trying
to remove multiple of these units
playing, you know, Master E himself, a
six might unit. If you're able to pop
that and the Kiana in the same turn, you
can make some really big moves and
swings on this board. I actually love it
when a lot of the Master Yi decks play
the Master Yihoned uh unit into the base
and they don't immediately go with it.
They set it up for something like a
white flame protector coming in a little
bit later that could buff it up and make
it this absolutely devastating unit to
deal with. And of course, it will sit by
at the battlefield by itself when you do
a big play like that. Cuz some of the
times I feel like I see this Mastery E
come in cuz it comes in ready and they
feel like they must immediately go
somewhere. But MadHatter is having great
control at keeping these battlefields.
this entire game.
>> Yeah, I had the choice to go in with
that master E instead of that clockwork
keeper. And it's just one of those
situations where it's like, no, I want
to keep my big thing in my base. I'll
let this small thing trade with a couple
of your recruits. That's all okay. This
is what matters to me.
>> Absolutely. As we're passing back now to
Madrout, generating even more of those
runes. We've the most order runes I've
seen all game for them. Uh but yeah,
there's going to be a hard room to
tackle because you can immediately stare
across the board and we have to deal
with a four might unit that gets
basically buffed up to six by itself.
We're staring at a six might unit in the
base. But oh, how about a singularity?
Talk about removal cards. This one does
six damage to two things, including
things at bases. So, this mastery could
easily get pointed out paying a deflect
cost with our seal.
>> Yeah, this is exactly what I was
alluding to there. problem with playing
that mastery is it does risk this if we
don't have an ong guard or potentially a
pre-board unyielding spirit from
Madhatter here. This could be a huge
swing on the battlefield. Really gives
Mout a ton of opportunity to go in take
both these battlefields get up to four
points and be able to pressure some own
threats throughout the rest of this
game. And you're left you've left Mad
Hatter with just a pit rookie which is
not going to be able to contest against
you know multiple units or even just
like even like the lecturing ur by its
lonesome out of battlefield. It only
trades with it offensively,
right? Well, MadHatter does have access
to some more pretty big accelerate or
you know can be played to battlefields.
Deadl prior a massive one potentially
playing cards like tasty fa folk. Both
of those do allow you to rec come in
really quickly and create a pretty big
brick wall uh for Madrout. But if Madr
has more of the order removal and things
that kill things despite their size,
those maybe just aren't even good
enough.
>> There is that on guard that you said. We
took a long time thinking about if we
wanted to spend it there. And it looks
like we're going to be using it on the
Kiana to keep her alive. That wait, no,
that sorry, it has to be the E because
the other one will only go to six. But
in response, a further stupify is going
to be enough to still have it die
because it's not at the base by itself.
It only gets the plus one might from the
ong guard.
>> So there's two situations here that
occurred. One, Madrout just drew that
stupify or two, it was incredibly
patient on that turn where they had the
eight might versus eight might battle
and chose not to play it. So deciding
possibly that that stupify, I need it
for a later turn and this was that later
turn that mattered.
>> Absolutely. And I think it could go a
long way. Like you said, removing that
master y hone when you can because you
did you played it safely in your base
and I played a card that is allowing me
to get rid of it. And now we've entered
the situation just like you said
earlier. We're able to take over both of
these battlefields. Finally catch up in
the point game at least a little bit.
And now you've left Madhatter with a
single unit. And even next turn if Matt
Hatterder does play something like you
know a dead boom predator or that tasty
faux folk that you were alluding to you
have less units in total on the board
which means cards like Cole the week
that we've talked about earlier become
even more powerful.
>> Yeah getting to trade off some dinguses
here make a couple more recruits really
do keep a pretty large board even if the
dreaded boom predator ends up going to
the trian war camp here. Uh these
recruits are really good at taking down
one giant thing at this battlefield. To
me, this really seems like a game where
these two battlefields and what they
have done to the the texture of what's
going on has had a massive massive
impact. Both of them in Madrat's favor.
And this is just game one, right? We
have yet to see what else the
battlefields that both of these players
are cooking up because and hopefully, at
least what I'm praying for is a game
three where we get to see all of the
tools that both of these decks have
accessible and you know, we see the full
story on why each of these players pick
which battlefields they do on each game
in certain matchups.
Yeah,
hidden cards always exciting. If you're
Mad Hatter, you have to assume that's
something like a culling blade. That's
just the most common removal spell
coming in here. And if you follow with
what I said where you think dread room
predator is much better at vile mall's
layer, then that's where I'd want to put
the hidden blade.
>> Yeah, you're right. I mean, it makes
sense. I mean, at least when it comes to
the units on the side for Mad, you know,
regardless of it is you're only really
protecting something like a recruit, but
like you said, when you can get a high
value removal off of that when it's
going to cost basically all or the
majority of the runes for MadHatter's
turn as we're picking up and counting
quite a few of them, I can only imagine
that's probably what's coming down.
If Madhatter wants to go in with just
this pit rookie into the recruit and the
hidden card and believes it's a hidden
blade, that does put Madr into a bit of
an awkward spot, maybe just intending to
calling blade the own recruit to draw
two cards. It's pretty hard for me to
imagine the thing you're really feeling
is kill that pit rookie and give more
cards to Madhatter and they have so many
runes in play. Yeah, and I think that's
exactly why we see the dead bloom being
played at the Trifarian War camp because
like you said, that's going to create
that decision that Mad has to make
instead of it being like a go-to
decision because as we know, this hidden
uh this hidden blade is that you can
only use it and target units that are at
that battlefield. We can't just pick
that dead bloom because it's on the
other side. But it's going to gain that
plus one might from its own trifarian.
And this is a lot of might to deal with
for Madrid. And you know, these two
recruits are not going to be able to
compete. I see a thought there. It
looked like he had a a retreat in hand.
Considering just recycling it on one of
these run on one of these recruits to
get an extra rune in play. Already has
eight going up to nine and then 11. That
seems like a lot. That's maybe not what
necessarily what you want to be doing.
So decides not to go with it.
>> Yeah. And I think now we're at the point
where because that ate up most of the
runes that Madhatter is going to use.
Although we got to six points um going
to just keep this pit rookie at home. We
actually are very afraid of whatever
this hidden card could be regardless of
it being, you know, things like that
hidden blade because you don't
necessarily want to give away those
cards yet. But that means we're going to
get the hold point here for Madr. And
that means all we have to really do is
figure out how to deal with this dead
bloom predator.
>> Yeah, we have quite a few bodies in
play. If we're interested in sending in
the Victor, we can ship with both the
recruits, the Daring Porro and the
Victor all into the same place.
Actually, was he a consult the pass? It
looks like uh MadHatter maybe could have
taken that battlefield for free. Uh but
you know, hidden cards are hidden cards
and it's a spooky place.
>> They make you scared and I think that's
exactly what happened here because you
know now at least when the full uh
hindsight comes through. Absolutely. We
could have swung in there.
>> Yeah. So now we have this option. We're
at five again can send in all of these
bodies. Just got two more cards. A ton
of things to think about here. Uh it
while you see that MadHatter has six
points, it does feel to me like Madrid
is in the driver's seat of this game.
>> Yeah. And especially now, like you said,
so many runes of at your disposal this
turn. You know, how many of them do we
have to commit to dealing with this
dread or this dead bloom? And then on
top of that, what can the follow-up turn
be? But instead, it looks like this a
second singularity coming through. And
if we end up choosing this dead bloom,
we do have to pay that deflect cost.
>> Well, you know, we have so many of these
runes. We're not worried about this
deflect cost. We're getting an
opportunity to clear the board from uh
Mad Hatter here. And then that really
makes it pretty close to impossible in a
lot of the Ebuilds to conquer both these
battlefields and actually threaten a win
here. And all Madr needs is that little
bit of time because just up so many
cards and so many resources.
>> Yeah, the deal six here is going to go a
long way because it means we have to
commit less of these resources to
trading with this dead bloom. But we
still need enough of resources because I
think we want I think Madral wants to
get to six. He has to not just trade
with the dead bloom. need to win the the
the showdown,
>> right? One of the things to be really
careful of here making this move is you
want to send it enough to kill the dead
bloom predator,
>> but you want to make sure you don't get
blown out by an ong guard. If you ong
guard and you don't remove the dead
bloom predator in the same combat, it's
going to heal off that singularity and
then taking it out is going to be so so
much harder. And that's probably why
we're sending in two guys here.
>> Yeah, six total might coming here on the
side for Madr when you add everything
up. And because this dead bloom has
already taken six, it is at two. Three
because of the Trifarian, four, five due
to the Master Yi effect. So I, you know,
Onguard is still technically enough to
win,
but it won't or I mean, we can win
regardless. What am I saying? We're
going to win regardless.
>> Yeah, if you have on guard here, you are
down to only four left. So on guard
would make it or no, you're at five
left. It would make it where you would
survive unless Madrout has a trick, but
all you have is getting a rune and a
card. That's not the power play you're
looking for.
>> No, not necessarily. But it looks like
we uh that means Madr did successfully
pull off and dealing with this uh dead
bloom. And we still have a little
recruit that we can move up and we're
going to refund one of these recruits,
of course, cuz this Victor Leer has
leader has been here almost all game. So
moving this recruit up is going to get
Mad up to six points here and a full
empty board on the side of Madhatter as
I can only presume what we're probably
going to pass back to. Yeah, this is one
of those situations we're looking for
another dead bloom predator. A tasty
faith folk master. Not a deck that
really has ways to get both battlefields
or take over a board if you get too far
behind. uh a situation where I think
your best chance is peeling a second
dead bloom predator, having a second one
in hand, putting it on that battlefield
and saying, "Mad, I hope you don't have
any more removal and I hope I get to
hold once. Pretty please let me."
>> Yeah, but I mean, you know, uh you know,
she's going to actually put this recruit
from our Victor, Herald of the Arcane
abilities onto the battlefield. Um
because we do have control of it. We
only going to keep three of our runes
up. Another hidden card. But see now,
see, now the story's been a little
spoiled for me, Aaron, because now I'm
not expecting something like a hidden
blade. I am now expecting consult the
past.
>> Yeah. So, the situation is okay, maybe
it is a consult the pass. Maybe it's a
hidden blade. I imagine when you're in
Mad Hatter's seat right here, you're not
sure you can really play around it being
the the hidden blade. You're probably
just forced into taking these
battlefields and putting your units in
there and really just hoping maybe it's
just the consult. Maybe you're not
drawing anything that impressive. Yeah,
at least based off of this spread, I
believe it is 10 runes to play with here
for Mad Hatter. Like you said, either of
those plays of Tasty Faithful or the
Dead Bloom. Those both sound great for
me, at least when it comes to contesting
these battlefields because if you do not
contest both, a drought wins on the
double hold.
A big problem with this master ECE and
some of these big units is they are so
expensive. So, while we do have 10
runes, we can really only play one of
those. And while we're able to leave up
maybe one trick, discipline and defy,
it's pretty hard to have two. So if
Madrout does have any recourse, it's a
tough position. But you're really trying
to think of, you know, okay, maybe that
is hidden blade, maybe it's not. Maybe I
can only take one of these battlefields.
If I don't think it's a hidden blade and
I have one big accelerate unit, which
place am I trying to go to?
>> Ooh, okay. I mean, we're having to use a
discipline here just for the sake of
drawing cards even. I mean, you have to
target something, right? So
>> that is a sign that we do not have any
of those bake units. We are digging for
something. These battlefields need to be
taken. If not, Mr is going to win on the
hold and we need to do it. There is a
tasty fave folk though, the less large
one compared to a dead bloom predator.
But uh when you're looking for a
lifeline, you'll take any of them you
can get.
>> Yeah, this means those any of those
tricks that we talked about. We just
used our trick offensively to hopefully
draw this card. But that means of course
we want to swing into the other the viom
and oh not the hidden blade. That could
have been the game ender immediately,
but consult the pass. Drawing two cards
right here means we could potentially
draw a card that could lead to a conquer
play from a drought.
>> I'm sure Mad Hatter is breathing a huge
sigh of relief. Finn Blade, the game is
over. Consult the pass. The game is
still going on. Retreat not a
game-winning thing. It sounds like this
Tasty Fo gets to conquer. Mad with only
five might in play in the base. One
recruit, one Victor needs something else
here to not lose the game. Yeah, I mean
really valuing wanting that channel here
and like the game is so close to ending
right as we have now seven points for
Mad Hatter as with the hold point coming
up from Madral right here. We are going
to go to seven as well. How do we deal
with this tasty faith folks? six might I
mean another singularity does get the
job done
but soda's grand strategim as we are
going to use all of these runes that
we've generated throughout the game and
it's a hefty power cost of course but we
are going to buff up a lot of these
units and that looks like it's going to
spell the game one go to Victor yeah I
mean grand strategm you can think of all
the fancy little tricks that add up to
six maybe I need a stupifier two of them
maybe I have a sprite mother to be able
to get me just big enough to overtake it
and get in with the recruit but grand
strategy just says, "My numbers are so
big, none of that matters."
>> That's exactly what the card is meant to
do for the deck, right? It's meant to be
that close out. You we Drows Plate did a
such a good job of generating so many
units across the game, using them very
strategically with that Trifarian War
Camp. And don't get me wrong, Mad Hatter
playing incredibly well and the
strengths of the Yi deck. And we saw how
hard it was and how much you have to
commit as the Victor deck to get through
them. But at the end of the day, the
removal won. We got everything off of
the board and that led to the win for
the Victor deck.
>> Yeah, I mean you have a lot of these
little recruits. You have the ability to
pressure both these battlefields all the
time. Sometimes the master E deck only
really good at fighting one of them or
protecting one of them. Did get those
early holds, but over time the value
grind is just so large and the E deck
doesn't really have access to that same
level of card advantage. We saw that
Kiana, one of those sources, get trapped
to that vile moss layer. Not able to get
backed up. Did get killed by recruits
even though it did survive a whole turn.
And that's got to feel pretty rough for
Madhatter. It's like, can I can't
believe my own battlefield was a problem
for me here.
>> But luckily, it's only game one, of
course, and that means that Vioma's Lair
that was Mad Hatter's own battlefield
won't be coming back again, at least
unless uh Madr pulls out one of their
own. And maybe we just won't send our
Kiana there. But we're going to be going
into game two here. Oh, I spoke too soon
as a Vilesm Lair has hit the board on
the side from Mad and we're going to
have the Grove of the God Willow. A
mustplay of course for these Master E
decks.
>> Yeah, I'm not surprised to see Vom's
Lair here in the Victor deck. As I was
saying in game one, your units kind of
don't matter to you. Get them in there.
Who cares if they can't move? They're
just little one might recruits. I kind
of want them to die anyway.
>> Yeah, absolutely. But of course going
first here for the side of Madhatter and
an easy turn two play followed
immediately up with a turn two play. And
of course with Victor and that extra
bonus room we get for going second. We
also get a recruit as a little bonus.
>> Yeah, it's so nice when you're playing
Victor because you just don't need as
many three drops as some of the other
decks cuz when you're on the draw, you
always have something to do with your
two. And now you know maybe you're going
second but you're already threatening
both battlefields.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Of course, we're
moving this pit rookie into the Grove of
the God Willow. This this is going to be
the most contested battlefield this
entire game because it gives so much
value drawing more cards and then the
mask of foresight going to be coming
down as well. Uh it's so good.
>> Yeah, I mean now we have a five might
pit rookie. That means the daring porro
plus the recruit can't even trade with
it if you really want to stop drawing a
card from that grove of the godwillow.
So mad drought looking to probably have
some type of trick here. A lot of
options available but if not I could see
this grove of the godwillow quickly
running away with the game. Yeah, and
that's the best thing you can ask for
too, right? I mean, two two drops like
we said, how important this is for these
decks that are trying to accumulate
advantage. Hopefully, we see Madral do a
similar play. Maybe we just see the
Victor come out from the champion
champion zone. But if you do that, I
mean, it's great that you have a
constant recruit generator, but you have
now kind of passed up this opportunity
to contest this grove. Instead though,
Sprite Mother coming in. And we saw
this, of course, in the last match when
we saw a lot of those mind decks, but
Sprite Mother being able to generate
this Sprite token, different kind of
token for the deck, of course, that is
hopefully going to help contest in the
might when trying to battle this pit
rookie perhaps.
>> Yeah, I mean, you see Mad Hatter is
exhausted, has no runes available. This
is a pretty free attack. Uh, a really
nice thing about Sprite Mother in these
Victor decks is the yellow Victor
doesn't say non-token unit. It says
nonrecruit unit. So, despite the sprite
being a token, if it dies, you still get
a recruit a lot of the time. Really fun
synergy between those two.
>> Love it. Absolutely. But of course, we
want to get rid of that daring porro
when trading the units. And of course,
this sprite token will never get a hold
on Grove of the God Willow for that
draw. But it is good to get Madhatter
off of that battlefield and just send
the recruit that we made on the first
turn into the Violas Lair like you said.
>> Yeah, deciding that this recruit is
worth a point to Madrout. It's pretty
likely that this lonely por is going to
end up going out on that battlefield,
not really wanting to fight the sprite.
even could get with a discipline or a
trick through, but really not a thing
you want to do when the sprite's going
to go away on its own anyway.
>> Yeah, that that makes 100% sense to me.
I just think you're going to we'll fight
over the the God Willow later because
you can't really assume that a lot of
the units, as we've seen Madr in game
one, the way that we're holding on to
these battlefields are not with a bunch
of units, right? It is one single
recruit. Your job is to score points
offensively. It is not meant to score
defensively on holds unless you just
don't have enough gas to remove my stuff
and take over. But the sprite token
answers that question for us.
Four here for the Kiana and that biom.
We've seen the situation before Aaron we
were just talking about. I hope and I I
don't expect that Kiana to go to that
bom lair maybe this game.
>> You know Madr gets to have a bit of a
say in that here depending on how he
wants to move his units in. I mean that
porro pretty tough to get through. has
six might when you attack into it on
this board. I imagine Mad's gonna move
some stuff from the god Willow, maybe
play some extra things there and try and
make it pretty hard for uh Madhatter to
find their way in there. Uh especially
because spending that orange rune to
play the Kiana makes it pretty hard to
play more of those really giant units
that can pressure that battlefield.
>> Yeah, of course. Uh it only costs four,
you know, to play the Kiana, you know,
off the get- go. So, we do still have a
couple of runes up for any sort of
tricks if this Porro does find a way to
get contested, but just moving in with
this recruit, getting that extra point
up. I mean, we showed very early on in
these turns, points mattering a lot for
Mad going second because we need to find
some way to still be in the game, even
though eventually we know that these
hard big removal spells can come through
for this deck like we saw in game one.
And Madhatter has to be ready for those.
>> Yeah, this is a postport thing. We saw
multiple singularities out of Madr. I
can believe Madhatter's bringing in
cards like Unyielding Spirit. Those were
such a big piece of the first game. Uh
so those maybe are less functional or
less powerful here, but I can also
believe Madrs out those singularities
and has some more of that order removal
instead.
>> Yeah, answering a six a six rune two
power spell with a one one rune one
power spell is a great exchange of
resources if you're the one with the one
cost spell of course. But just going to
play a couple more units, including that
champion unit coming down from Madr as
we pass things back. And we did
reinforce with a soaring scout because
we want this to eventually die. And
maybe we get a hold trigger, but it's
not really a lot of power when it comes
down to it or might.
>> No, this is going to be a battlefield
where you're expecting both these things
to be removed. But you do have that
Victor in play. So that soaring scout's
going to give you another recruit.
You're not actually losing out on any
might in play by having that scout get
killed here. But you really want that
rune. That's going to put you to six up
to eight. Maybe something like a
thousand tailed watcher coming
accelerated. That is the magic number
for that.
>> That is that is exactly the magic
number. And we're even seeing some
disruption here. A charm coming into
play. And this is a perfect way to take
advantage and get that Victor off of the
table. And we saw it generate so much
value in game one. And now that it's
gone. Yeah, I mean charm one of these
cards that's really strong in a lot of
the column decks, but especially in
Master E where when you're able to
really maximize the power of your legend
and have a six might unit off just a
single two drop charm pretty much
becomes really close to a a vengeance of
your own, kill a single unit.
>> Yeah, I mean it's great removal in this
kind of type of deck because like you
said, I mean the shield pora is so large
and you know when you look at cards like
Victor Leader, they're meant to be
utility based so they typically have a
little bit less might on them um for
their cost. But now leaving up, we still
have so many runes to play with. That
charm play obviously only costs one and
one recycle. We go in get these
conquers, get all these effects, get
that conquer from counter effect from
the Kiana drawing us a card. And we're
sitting pretty not only in points, but
cards in hand. And we still haven't done
anything with our runes for the turn.
>> Yeah, last game we saw Madhatter win at
six runes with a Kiana conquer. Choose
to take that rune and go up to seven
going to nine. This game at six says I
actually don't need that many. I'm just
going to go to eight. Enough to play
some of those big things. maybe doesn't
have as many tricks you need to hold up
after.
>> Following things up right here. The
first play going to be this first mate
after we've attacked. So now Kiana has
the ability to come back to base because
we can keep her a little bit safe and
then that sets up for the conquer
ability again next turn.
>> It looks like we left the Kiana there. I
imagine thinking you know Madr does not
have a lot of might in play. Just this
sprite mother that's only three K is a
six. needs some tricks to really get
through and Mad Hatter gets to hold up
protection of their own. So leaning into
getting that hold ability of the Grove
of the Godwillow could be really big
here. But if Madrout does have something
like that Thousand Tailed Watcher which
is now available to them because of that
soaring scout death, this could
backfire. Yeah, I mean very much oh it's
exactly how you read it. Here comes that
thousand tailed Watcher and we're paying
that accelerate cost in that prime
moment giving all of this minus might.
Man, this is one of I'm surprised we
didn't even see it game one. Obviously,
just not finding it. But this is going
to be a very good way to get a lot of
these units off of the board while still
maintaining units of your own. And
that's why it's so different than cards
like Singularity being used for removal
when an effect like this comes into
play.
>> Yeah, I will say this is a matchup where
Thousand Watch is really strong, but
it's not quite as strong against the Wu
Blade Master as it is against other
decks. that uh stalwart porro reduced to
one might but once it goes into combat
with his sprite mother will get one from
it shield one from the mask and two from
the Wuji blade master so it would still
be a five uh meaning that it's not a
free battlefield to take like normally
thousand tail watcher works in these
situations
>> yeah absolutely but just enough to deal
with this Kiana and now we are
contemplating of course some extra
tricks so the Kiana now goes down to one
just like you said but with Master Yi
it's going to go back up to three you
need enough tricks to give at least four
might worth of stats to even trade with
this watcher and it's very hard to do
unless you have double on guard.
>> Well, did have access to the mask in
play. So, it actually was a four. So, if
you do have ong guard discipline, that
is a pretty massive blowout, but you
need both of them. Looks like Madhatter
didn't have both. Uh, sigh of relief for
Mr. cuz that could have gone badly
instead getting to hide a card and be
back in the driver's seat.
>> Hidden blade or consult the pass?
>> We've only seen consults this game. I
would believe that Madrout is playing
hidden blade. I think it's one of the
really great parts of the Victor deck
when you already want to play things
like yellow seal is you get to play a
lot of hidden cards. You can play either
of those to a battlefield just for
exhausting that seal. And in this deck,
Hidden Blade and Consult the Past are
pretty similar. Both of them really can
be kill your own thing, draw two, or
just draw two from Consult. We get to
eight runes here for Mad Hatter, which
is that good number when it comes to
playing things like White Flame
Protector or Dead Bloom Predator. Um,
and both of those cards are good enough
to help contest against this thousand
tailed watcher. And you don't really
have to worry about your porro. And of
course, it is stuck there in the bile
layer.
Yeah, Madrout pretty happy with his vile
moss layer this game. Though I don't
think the porro is likely to be running
away. Uh, Thousand Tail Watcher. If you
think that's a hidden blade and you have
a dead bloom predator, it's a tough spot
to feel like I guess I'm going to play
it there. Get hidden bladed. I did draw
two cards, but I also had to recycle two
of my own runes. Now it's hard to do
more stuff. I'm exhausting out for that.
Don't get to have any tricks up. But if
you don't make a play like that, what's
getting rid of this thousand tail
watcher?
>> I think it's a play I'd be willing to
risk because we're already up by two
points in this game. And if you don't
contest the Thousand Tailed Watcher in
any way, you're slowly starting to give
some of those points back. And as soon
as Madral finds some way to deal with
this porro,
the the point discrepancy starts to go
the other direction. Right. So I I
wonder if it is worth playing something
like a dead boon if we have access to
it. But we could also just see maybe
another setup turn using the point
advantage that we have gotten so far to
just set up.
>> Yeah, another option available to
Madhatter is just playing a mastery or a
white flame protector here. getting to
buff that first mate means if that is a
hidden blade, you're not sacrificing a
unit as important to you as something
like that dead bloom predator and
instead really putting the ball in
Madr's court. If it is the consult the
past, great, I got to take this
battlefield and I'm only offering a
trade with this first mate and that uh
sprite mother.
>> It is the hidden blade and we are going
to go ahead and deal with it. Valuing
the hold and of course even though you
are giving over two cards because the
controller of that card or that owned it
will draw the two because this will
maintain the hold. We get our draw from
the god Willow.
>> This is I'm sure really painful for Matt
Hatter. I just saw him draw double defy
off of the hidden blade. Could have, if
he had those in his hand, would have had
the option to maybe play Master Y and go
in and offer a trade with Defy up. But
now it's just like, well, I'm down these
runes. I have this Defy maybe available
next turn to fight through another
hidden blade if Madr has more access to
removal.
>> I I just see that when I was over here
like you're right. This thing is consult
the pass and you know but because you
postured consult the pass so well in
game one it means the hidden blade was
still there. Speaking of more removal,
Riptide Rex, we saw this very early on
in some Kaiso list but loving it here as
a unit and also functioning of dealing
six damage to an enemy at a battlefield.
>> Yeah, in particular really good against
Wu Blade Master, right? The units are
only buffed in combat. So dealing six
damage before combat means you can take
out a lot of stuff including the mastery
champion and things like tasty fay folk.
>> What a great play. And this is exactly
what I was talking about the swing now
of points and also the board state. Yes,
of course flame protector was a good
play in the sense that we still have an
eight might unit on our side of the
board for when we need to use it. But
there's now a riptide rex. The watcher
stayed alive that bonus turn like we
said and now the shield porro is gone
and it's only one unit remaining
remaining now for MadHatter and we're at
five. We're not even in winning range.
>> Really interesting choice here from a
drought. Chose to leave that thousand
tailed watcher there despite not having
energy up. No ability to bluff. Could
have chosen to back that out, but seems
like wants to force Madhatter to be
like, "Okay, you have two battlefields.
I'm only letting you conquer one. I
really want to hold this other one."
Absolutely. But here comes the honed ye,
which of course comes in ready. So it is
going to be able to contest another one
going up to seven which once again is
not going to help us win the game right
at this exact moment. But now it is on
the onus once again from a drought as we
are passing back keeping one energy up
like from those defies that we did end
up drawing. But it the spell has to be
within the cost range that it is allowed
to be dealt with for that to happen.
>> Yeah, these past couple turns have been
really huge swings. We saw massive play
from a drought to take back over those
battlefields, really push for those
points. the Madhatter being able to do
the white flame into the thousand tail
watcher that got left at the grove of
the god Willow in addition to playing
the Master E that was in the champ zone.
I wonder if Madrout expected this to be
the outcome.
>> Yeah, I don't know. But I mean, as I see
a singularity right here, this does cost
enough to where it obviously can't get
to five, but this is going to cost
almost all of our runes in this exact
turn. only being able to keep one up,
trying to deal six to both of these,
which will get rid of the Master Yi, but
the White Flame still has to be dealt
with with only six damage on it. We have
to find a way to deal two to it. But if
it's combat, we're have to actually do
four, five because of the mask and with
the Wuju Blades. Yeah, Riptide Rex
pretty large here. A unit that
definitely gets to get that settled. Has
to work. MadHatter at seven. If a hold
happens here, we're losing the game.
Choosing to go in the recruit to the
Valairs first. wants to lock in that
seventh point, but I imagine this
Riptide Rex just is forced to go in
here.
>> Yeah, absolutely. He's gonna have to
make some sort of trade. And because it
was damage dealt, like you said, we have
to find a way the deal with five. I
mean, an ong guard blade is still enough
to get over, right?
>> Wait, we went into the vile mall there.
>> Showdown means it heals the damage.
>> It's healed out. This This doesn't work
anymore.
>> It does. Yeah. So, instead, we're going
to But the hold win the G. What can we
do for one?
>> You're right. Hey, I didn't even think
about this, but the showdown resets all
damage of all units.
>> Is Madrout unsure of how many points
MadHatter has? Is it Is it not seven?
>> Is it not? Maybe. Maybe I'm wrong. Maybe
a hidden card here.
>> These plays only make sense if Madr
believes this is not winning the game
here.
>> Yeah,
for the whole Yeah, I think that can
only be the discrepancy, which is enough
to win the game and take us to a game
three. I'm I mean I I mean I'm I'm
actually on the edge of my seat because
I don't know what the answer is and I'm
excited to find out. But passing things
back I think we see Mr. maybe realizing
like oh well well maybe maybe it is the
game over.
I can't wait to find out what the result
of this is.
>> This is a tough fight. It looks like it
was correct. Mr. just not realizing that
Madhatter had a win there. Had some
plays could have made. Could have moved
the Rex in. could have made the trade.
That's going to sting.
>> You really got to shake that off going
into game three. You won game one. You
were in a pretty good position game two.
>> Don't let it get to you. Capitalize on
this game three.
>> And that's what you know what and that's
why you know the note the notepads
there, right? You know, that's why we're
keeping track of all this information.
But you're right. I mean, stuff like
that, it it still could have been very
close on both ends because yes, you deny
the ability for the hold point, which is
the way you can win. Then you're tell
them you have to get a double conquer.
You have to get this hold. But and
instead we see the full commit for their
hold point win and it was just one turn
too late basically,
>> right? I mean you get in your head about
all these things going on in this game.
You have so many plays in your hand, so
many runes available. You have all these
options and things going on and
sometimes just the little things slip
through. There's game is so deep, so
many choices, especially when you have
so many little recruits and units to
move around and uh you know sometimes
that bites you.
>> Absolutely it does. But we that means we
have a game three that we get to jump
into. And now with, you know, I I'm
interested to know how much time are
going to be left on the clock because
both of these decks need some time to
get to the point where they want to do
to win the game. And so, you know, I'm
okay for draws, especially in a large
tournament like this one. But with four
minutes roughly in the game as we see
the obelisk of power coming through for
Master Yi's deck and then the Dreaming
Tree coming down for the Victor deck.
>> Yeah, I mean, we have a start here. Two
units while on the play because that
obelisk of power. This is what you need
to try and win a game really quickly in
this amount of time.
>> Absolutely it is. And so we're seeing
all of the units and both of the players
here coming in for uh playing as many
units as you can right away. And that's
one of the perks of the Obiska power
coming in for Master Yi is that we had
exactly four runes going second. Kiana
down on turn one feels very good.
>> It is very good. But Madr going to get
to score both these points, set up these
battlefields, maybe have some hidden
cards, maybe a hidden blade to fight
against this Kiana. Um, it definitely
seems like the type of situation where
both players normal game plans aren't
going to work here. It is not about
playing the long game, playing big units
or playing good removal spells. It's
about how many points can I score before
this time runs out.
>> Yeah, absolutely. We're going to go to
some extra turns if that ends up being
the case. And also, not even just that,
I think when you play battlefields like
Obelisk of Power, they just they shift
the way the game is played oh so
quickly. You know, we saw it with
Arena's greatest for a lot of these
aggressive decks. It just speeds the
game pace up and urgency from all of
these players. with the stupify
targeting your own unit play here for
the draw, not just from the dreaming
tree, from the draw from the stupify.
Incredible play we see a lot of the time
in the Kaisa list, but we're able to do
it here also in Victor.
>> Yeah, two cards here. It's an
interesting thing of okay, I did get
some cards, but that slowed me down from
playing some units. Could have
potentially used that Victor Legend,
make that extra recruit here if you had
all these tools available, but instead
just getting two one might things in
play. Definitely not enough to really
pressure that Kiana after it takes one
of these battlefields.
>> But little units do still score points
and that is the kind of pace that we're
going at at this moment. But the Kiana
going to come in here for the dreaming
tree. Although the death nail ability
and the scoring swing scout will give us
an extra rune. The conquer effect either
going to give us a draw or channel a
rune exhausted and yeah like you said
going to channel the rune here like we
did in game one. But the question now is
like you said with these one might units
we don't have a lot really going on for
trying to contest with this Kiana right
off the bat.
We do have the magical six number of
runes because of this. Kiana spent one
to play it. Got one back. That means
next turn we maybe get to play a white
flame protector or a dead bloom
predator. Really pressure these
battlefields. And again, Madrout's
board. Not that impressive. Maybe
something like a thousand tailed Watcher
with eight runes here could be a pretty
big swing. But Mad Hatter holding up a
lot of energy to make some plays.
>> Also getting the hold point here. Not
contesting his recruit. That seems very
good whenever you play Victor, right?
You're like, "Wow, my recruit made it
all the way back to my turn." Um, you
know, of course we'd like that to be
some sort of hold benefit, but not
really mattering here so far. But yeah,
eight runes a lot. You could see that
accelerated watcher play to help us get
through on that Kiana, especially now
that it has a buff as well.
What else can we do with eight might
Aaron that is not just necessarily
dealing with the Kiana, but like making
sure that whatever play MadHatter does
on their next turn that you still feel
like you're in the driver's seat of this
game. could add something like a grand
strategm. Really use both those units to
get in there, but that's the type of
thing you really want to save for a
bigger board. Choosing to play this
lecturing girdle. Pretty interesting. A
small ball play again. I brought this up
game one. Maybe not the thing you're
really excited to be doing, but it does
put more bodies into play if you do have
a future grand strategy or a future way
to turn all these units into some extra
value. Yeah, because I can imagine if we
pass bat and let's say Matt Hatterder
gets a double conquer play of course or
the hold of course holding for the
dreaming tree and then conquering over
on top of the recruit going up to three
points with something like a grand
strategen play with all of these units
now we have created onto our our board.
We can go up to five pretty safely and
it's really just up to the ownus of what
Madhatter chooses to do with their turn.
Going to go ahead and move some of these
units up though to reinforce that
obelisk though. And you know these are
now units that when they die they would
generate recruits because we have now
played victor leader. Yeah, this is a
decision. You know, Madrout that turn
didn't do anything to really take that
battlefield, but is ahead by some
points. I was saying, "Okay, Mad Hatter,
you get two points. We're tied. That's
fine." But also moves these things in.
Says, "Hey, if you kill these, I would
like some value." Does open up to a
charm here, which is what's going to
happen. Victor now going to get eaten by
that Kiana and makes it where that
battlefield where you just move those
units way less good for you if it gets
killed.
>> Absolutely. But one less rune to play
with as well as we now go to seven,
which means it in
So, as we do the recycle, here comes the
honed ye going to come in. Comes in
readied, of course, and is going to be
able to swing into this battlefield.
One, two, six. Yeah, just Yeah, easily
enough power here to get through as we
are then going to be able to knock all
of these units off of the board. And it
looks like, yep, there's our channel.
And there's our draw from our death
triggers. Of course,
>> Mad chose to take a turn off there to
really build up a board. And it all just
disappeared in the span of a single
turn. Every single unit he played that
previous turn is now in the trash.
>> Absolutely it is. And now there's two
gigantic units on the side here for Mad
Hatter. And as we can kind of see the
time of course now coming in through the
cool. So judges are now going to be
going back through our footage as it
seems one of our judges on the spot
check did see something description. I
missed it. So I'm excited to figure out
what it might end up being. So there was
a judge call there. So we're going to
get some sort of end result here from
that judge ruling and we'll get that
fixed here shortly.
>> But yeah. So, is this idea of like, you
know, not being able to channel both
runes, it seems to be some sort of
discrepancy, and I don't know where it
was specifically, but we will get some
answers, of course, and going to be
coming back into the game here shortly.
But Aaron, when it comes all the way
back down to it, it it is the idea of
like we have lost all of that value we
tried to create from Madral like you
said, how do we get onto the
battlefields now? Singularity was the
only option I could think of because
it's the only way I feel like we're
going to deal with both of these large
units. Yeah, this is the downside to
Madhatter's turn is getting out of all
of your runes. No energy up. That means
you are unable to have an on guard or
any type of protection to protect that
Y. And now despite having a pretty good
board previously, you are letting uh Mad
take both of these battlefields and
score two more points up to five and
still have some runes left over to make
another play.
>> Absolutely. And again, we have our
little guys and those are perfect enough
for scoring points. and scoring points.
It does matter when it comes to this
moment of the game where we are at
turns. Having more more points at the
end of the five turns in overtime means
you can be in an advantageous position
to win. And not only that, with only one
unit on Madhatter's side, how are you
going to catch up?
>> This is a situation where once again
brought this up every single game. We
have these big accelerate units, we have
these dead predators, we have these
tasty fay folks. That's kind of the only
tools the E deck really has. The deck
does one game plan really, really well.
Yeah, one unit at a battlefield at a
time. But as we are using again all of
our a hidden card coming down here on
the Dreaming Tree. We did play a Raven
Bloom student and I think we're even
thinking about again. We saw this with
Jim Davis in the last match. Um but
yeah, going to be that recycle. I
thought we were going to see a double
hidden play to be honest.
>> You know, it takes a certain type of
person to really just hide everything
everywhere, but you know, doing this
here, if it's a consult the past little
threat on this pit rookie, maybe it's a
hidden blade. maybe I don't move in. Um
I think it's the type of place where
you're probably still going to want to
just gut check it if your pit rookie
gets hidden bladed. How bad for you is
that? Especially if it gives you the
opportunity to draw one of those big
units.
>> Yeah, I mean it's getting down to the
wire. I mean this this is where we're
going to start contesting this hidden
card. We haven't played anything for the
turn here for MadHatter. Testing the
waters, swinging with the unit first.
You're already winning in the might
battle. Consult a pass or hidden blade.
What is it? Well,
>> if there's a thought here, it must be a
hidden blade. We're choosing who to
target here. Yeah, and you talked about
this in the last game where there's just
when it's just the recruit, it is more
advantageous to give me all of the value
in drawing the cards, not just
destroying a two might unit.
>> Yeah, in particular, this is the
dreaming tree. So, this hidden blade was
worth three cards. Really big swing on
card advantage there. And still ahead on
points, but there is that dead bloom
predator to put it back to five and
five. Uh, really interesting spot here.
>> Madra, lot of new tools in hand though.
Could have a lot of things.
>> Yeah, but not as many runes to play
with. We did remember we hit a card
that's a power. We'd played a
singularity that's two more power. So we
lost three runes last turn. And even
though this deck is good at channeling
them and we started with an Obeliska
power this turn, we still are only
ending up at eight. And the only reason
why I say only eight is because we are
playing such large cards to deal with
these large units like dead bloom. As we
pass back to Mad again, we are in a
situation where we really need to
contest both of these units because we
are in time. We have to stop the point
generation.
This is a situation where Wu Blademaster
is a really big deal. Something like a
thousand tailed Watcher, which I think I
saw in Madr's hand, would be normally
really good against Dead Predator, but
it's a 10 because the Blade Master. It
doesn't even get to get eaten by that
Thousand Tail, so plays a Riptide Rex
instead.
>> Yeah, Riptide Rex easily removing that
pit rookie as we move in with a recruit
going up to six points, which does put
us in the lead, but this is only turn
three. And then the cold a weak play
that we've been talking about this
entire match. It doesn't target. don't
have to pay the deflect cost and you
just get rid of a recruit as we show
off. Yeah, no targeting there. All units
removed while also being ahead on points
and we get the double double conquer
here going to seven. I don't know what
MadHatter can do now to at least win and
catch up in the point games next turn.
>> Now, this is a really tough spot again.
One big accelerate unit. Saying it,
saying it, saying it. And in this
situation, if there's not accelerating
unit at all, Madrout's threatening the
win on the hold. This is a really tough
spot. Needs uh possibly could have
something like challenge in their deck.
Big thing, but uh that is the handshake.
Mad drought coming through. I mean,
Victor, lot of small units, a lot of
cheap things, really really strong
having all of that order removal against
a deck full of big units.
>> Yeah, coming into that round going X and
one. And so the fact that Victor being
one of these these decks that I feel
like so many people were talking about
at the beginning of Origins and now
seeing at least you know this one for
the first time this weekend have this
good success and so many more players
not playing the the legend anymore. Good
to still see have a good showing here.
And then also on the other side of the
conversation, Master Yi, everyone was
playing this legend and now maybe not so
much because I think a lot of people
have shifted to the Annie deck a lot.
Well, I think another thing is I mean
Master Yi is one of those decks. It it
really showed during those games. It
kind of has a really linear game plan.
Play some cheap units, try and hold
these battlefields early and then have
these big accelerate units you can play
to these battlefields to try and close a
game. But if people are playing decks
that are prepared for that, like this
Victor deck seems like it clearly was
with all of this removal and ways to
answer big guys, you don't have a ton of
recourse. You can just kind of get
bullied around the whole game. And we
saw that again and again during those
games. Yeah, absolutely. Um, and the
same idea, Mad player that I know, Ryan
Lavine, is actually a very prolific
Yu-Gi-Oh player, taking that information
and content creator for not just that,
but Universes as well. Now, here full
force for Uribbound, we see so many
players coming from so many different
games this weekend. And speaking of
other players from other games, as we
watched Jim Davis play in that match
earlier, as I alluded to, I did have a
chance to talk with Jim Davis earlier
today, and I would love for you guys to
see the wisdom in the words that he
said.
Hey, Riftbounders. I have the privilege
to be joined with Jim Davis. For
everybody who doesn't know, Jim, can you
tell us a little bit about yourself?
>> Uh, yeah. I've been playing uh Pro Magic
for a really long time. Been doing
content full-time for 10 years. Got into
Riftbound. The game's awesome. Started a
new channel called Arcane Academy for
it. Super hyped to be playing uh two
awesome card games competitively. And be
here at the first events. It's awesome.
>> Yeah, I can definitely say you're one of
my favorite players to watch for Magic,
at least in content wise. So, I'm
excited to even watch your Riftbound
content. And my question to you is
obviously we're here in the thick of it
in the regional qualifier. You're
participating competing. What did you
pick to try and take down this whole
tournament?
>> So, I'm not trying it with a tournament.
>> All right. So, I'm playing Jinx and I'm
trying to go for the metal uh the best
of prize, which I think is one of the
coolest prize structures I've ever seen
for any TCG ever in the history of TCGs.
Uh so cool. such a fun like side quest
to have where I don't think all women
Jinx I think Jinx is actually like I
think it's really really hard to play
and really really hard to build. Uh so I
think it's also really popular
character. So the metal metal token is
going to be awesome like really really
desired. Uh and then hopefully I'll be
the best Jinx player in the room which
is the goal. So we'll see what happens.
>> Well as one of the best probably Magic
players in the room I can only imagine
you will probably end up being one of
the best riftbound players in the world.
Uh any final thoughts on, you know, tips
and tricks, things you've learned from
playing competitive card games across
multiple years that you can tell anybody
at home or that you're using here
specifically as a strategy for just
surviving a tournament?
>> It's a long it's a long day. You know, I
think it's be kind of looking at as a
big picture. My biggest thing in a
tournament is try and not think about
the actual event itself. You know, like
a lot of players will go, I'm 300, I'm
40. I'm doing so good. Oh man, if I one
more win, I'll make day two. Your goal
in a tournament is just to play. You
know, it's not really think about
anything else. This game is so hard that
you need every bit of every neuron
firing on the game. So your best bet is
just to kind of like play each round as
an individual thing. Sit down and play
your best and then at some point in the
day if they're going to tell you to stop
playing either you'll be in top eight or
you'll be 0 and five or whatever, you
know? So to kind of just keep playing,
don't think about the event. It's all
about the games.
>> Eventually the tournament must end. Your
time when it ends just depends on how
you're doing. But Jim, thank you so
much. I can't wait to see how you're
doing and I hope to see you holding a
metallic Jinx by the end of this event.
Thanks so much.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Hey, Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat
up here.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat.
Welcome back everybody. I'm once again
Barrett Bryant joined by Aaron Barv
Baric. Sorry about that. Twice in a row.
Uh but we have round five that we have
to dig into. We are officially at the
midway point to our regional qualifier
here in Houston and we've seen so much
incredible gameplay, so many legends
represented, really seeking out those
metallic prize cards cuz that's all I
hear people talking about at this event.
So I I kind of want to ask you Aaron
speaking to this metallic prize because
I can't imagine this is anything going
anywhere anytime soon. So the future of
what this prize could hold, the fact
that we have like spirit forge legends
now we can think about and thinking like
the metallic versions of those. Is there
a world where like this becomes one of
the most soughta prizes for this game?
>> Yeah, I mean people love their
champions. It's part of what makes
League of Legends awesome. It's part of
what makes Riftbound awesome. And yeah,
we want to give people ways to feel like
they can play their character and win
with their character and get something
awesome. I have gotten so much awesome
resounding feedback about these and it
seems like so many people in the room
came to play just to win their one and
that's super awesome. So, no, I don't
see these going away anytime soon and I
imagine we're going to try and think of
ways to do more of this really cool
thing.
>> Absolutely. And I I think in general
just like the prizes here in the event
as a whole being a part of this
community, this brand new game. I think
everyone is just so excited to be here
and share their experiences with each
other on from other areas of the world
of wherever they come from from League
of Legends, TFT, other card games. It's
it's just that we all love Riftbound.
And I I don't know about you, but I love
multiplayer for this game as well. The
fact that I've seen so many people
playing in 2v2 all weekend
the game completely shifts on its head
when you incorporate two more players at
the table obviously.
>> Right. That's something I love to hear.
I mean Riftbound is designed from the
ground up to be something really
multiplayer focused but also uh you know
it is an incredible 1v one game and I'm
glad we have the opportunity for people
to engage with it in so many ways.
Competitive, casual, whatever they like.
And you know story of this weekend is
competitive but we want it to be for
everyone. That's what Riftbound's about.
Speaking of competitiveness, we have a
real heavy hitter, I think, coming up in
this next round as we go into round five
because we have, dare I say, a player
that has already won quite a bit of an
achievement in this game already. And of
course, he's sporting the set, the boss.
We have Argon. And if you have
recognized his face here, uh oh wait, oh
yeah, sorry. Argot here sporting set who
we had saw success not only you know the
past two weeks for these 10ks and such
like that in Atlanta and Vegas and such
as that versus Quint here sporting
another Master Yi. Yeah, I mean we got
to watch Master Yi last round that was
against a Victor deck that was
definitely well prepared to handle some
big units. Set can be built in some ways
that are less good about that. You know
maybe still has access to things like
hidden blade but not going to see those
singularities, not going to see those
call the weeks in the same way. set's
all about doing it with raw numbers in
play.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And like also being
able to bring your units back into play,
right? It it's I love the idea not only
of course with this one being playing
set kingpin, one of these cards that you
know Colin talked about extensively
after the event, but leading the game
off with a Cyria leads that buff
generation sort of uh mechanic. Being
able to have access to these buffs that
we can spend for alternate abilities is
something I really love about this deck.
Yeah, we have an interesting setup of
battlefields here with the dreaming tree
coming in from Argon Forset in a matchup
where you know Wu Bladem the calm decks
tend to play even more pump spells that
can hit their units at these
battlefields. I could see this being a
similar situation where that one maybe
not an obvious win for Argon in this
match.
>> Yeah, absolutely. As we move up for the
conqueror, as we pass back for Argon,
we're going to go ahead and conquer.
take that one point on to the dreaming
tree, which you know tells me that maybe
we have one of our tricks of our own
that can target. But one of the key
points of playing the kingpin version is
that when you go first, we have that
four costed champion unit that we can
immediately put onto a battlefield with
Citrio receiving a buff. Kingpin gets
even stronger when they're at the same
spot.
>> Yeah, this is a sixmite unit on turn two
on the play. Something the Wu Blade
Master can't really fight through. You
could play a couple pump spells, a
discipline and an ong guard, but that's
still only offering a trade and that's
not getting rid of that Sithria.
>> Absolutely. Tank keyword coming in very
well for this game. And then as we pass
back for Master Yi, we're going to go
ahead and take over the Targon's Peak.
And so even more runes to play with
across the turn so that we can target
some of our stuff as we only played a
two drop. Passing it back with full
access to five runes on dealer turn, but
giving that whole point away. Yeah,
passing with this many runes in the E
deck, not always a surprise. That deck
really leans on cheap two drop units and
some of those big heavyhitting units a
lot of the time in the five and six is
where things get a little muddied, but
it's not a deck that's actually that
good at using its energy on the
opponent's turn if we're not getting
into numbers fights, if we're not
getting to discipline or getting to on
guard. There is defy, but the spell
set's going to play aren't things you're
probably looking to defy here.
One of the things that Colin here have
really highlighted in his deck when we
we go back to what he really values when
playing a legend like set the boss is
the amount of four cost units in his
deck. Of course, this one I'm eating my
words. This one costs five with set
brawler hitting the uh the base, which
is an incredibly good one to not only
use a lot of these buffs that it's going
to generate to go in and get more might,
but it also has that conquer ability to
get it back as well. But he always
values you having these high impact
middle of the game cards to play and
then keeping them alive over and over
again.
>> Yeah, I mean set is a deck that is about
that mid game. Those four and five cost
units are where so much of the might
comes from. In addition, when you're
going second and you have those five
runes on turn two, being able to play
something like a set kingpin or a Fiora
and then showstopper it into a
battlefield while you know your opponent
has probably exhausted all their runes
on their turn two lets you catch back up
from being on the draw. Uh, orange set
in particular really great in this
matchup. Big unit, awesome at breaking
through Wu Blade Mastery.
>> Absolutely. And like you said, you you
showcase cards like Showstopper being
able to be an extra form of movement to
get them going and contesting those
units. Seeing the Tasty Faithful come
down as just a very good unit to play
and not paying the accelerate cost means
we're actually going to completely net
in this value of channeling two runes
and drawing a card after it does end up
dying. Um, feels very good to just be
able to contest the you played a unit
that's going to have a lot of value for
you. I'm going to play one of my own and
neither of these are just going to go in
right away.
>> Yeah, when you're Argon here, you have
to be really happy. You got you made the
Master Y deck do something it doesn't
want to do. It backed a unit out of a
battlefield and left it open. The the
Master Y, the Wuju Blade Mastery Legend
is so good at holding. So, when you've
already got them on the back foot and
they're saying, "Well, I'm not going to
do that. I'm not going to engage with my
normal early game plan." That means you
must be in a pretty good position.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Really valuing keeping
your Lun units alive and instead I'm
wondering if we'll see another for drop
here come into play here for Argon but
in a good spot both sides I would say
having both champion units out. Very
exciting to see what we might end up
doing. But instead the mainboarded
sabotage is coming in here for Argon.
Very good choice here. Look at all those
pump spells. I mean this is one of those
sabotage you look at their hand you're
like those are all of the same card. uh
probably going to end up taking the
discipline because that one can can
trip. Uh but this is really good
information to know as Archon. That's a
lot of tricks to be wary of. Plus four
is a number. You think the master E deck
will have it sometimes, but you're not
always sure. Um follow this as a big
question, which is what do I do with the
set brawler? It's much better at
attacking than it is defending. And
that's a such a powerful threat to leave
at your base that I could believe we're
not going to move it in and instead want
to keep that there just to threaten
Quint as much of the game as possible.
>> I I completely agree with you. I I think
you want to potentially hold this set
and keep it back for later use. And I'm
excited to see what Argon is going to
decide to do, but instead we have the
Kingo Mage coming down, which allows you
to buff up to two of your other friendly
units. So, we're going to be able to get
a buff onto the Kingpin.
And it looks like we are going to make
the decision to send it in. And it means
it probably will end up dying. But of
course, set the legend says even if we
do end up losing it, we can have it
back. Yeah, you're talking about Argon
really valuing those four cost plays and
some of the mid-range things. It makes
it a lot easier to just keep sacrificing
those runes to your set uh legend
because now even if we have to spend one
to protect our set brawler at the
Targon's peak, well, next turn we'll be
at five again. We can probably play most
of the cards in our deck and still be
able to play a four drop and a
showstopper or be able to play a two and
a first mate. You know, a lot of options
with very few runes, which is really
what the boss legend is asking you to
do.
>> Yeah.
And not so much in the context while
Quint thinks about his turn, but Aaron,
when your opponent now knows basically
every card in your hand, what is your
game plan going forward? Do you just
have to always make sure that your plays
have a follow-up answer to it or do you
just constantly feel like you're on the
back foot now that your opponent knows
everything?
>> Well, you get into these really
interesting scenarios where your
opponent kind of gets to bully you a
little bit, which is okay, you know, I
have two on guards and you make a move
in a battlefield that makes it look like
these two ong guards are really going to
blow you out. Does that mean you
definitely have a trick or you know I
know you know I have these and we're
trying to play some kind of fancy mind
game. Yeah, no mind games here. Of
course, that is exactly what ended up
happening as we just you know instead uh
find your center to get a little bit of
extra value and you know of course
redraws us as we ended up finding a
second find your center as Argon knew
there was one but not two per se um as
we're going to channel more runes of
course and then of course that tasty
faith fulk did go in and contest with
that brawler but we kept it alive with
our legend.
>> Looks like we're already have all of our
runes in play total ability to play as
much as we want. Uh, this is a situation
where you see someone with all the runes
versus Kingpin blowing up all of their
runes. Again,
>> it it's it's actually great you bring
that up because having seen Colin do a
couple of interviews after, you know,
doing well with his deck, he loves
playing the game at this like I don't
have all of my runes at once, but I'm
playing this fine line of always using
them efficiently for things like these
four costed units that he loves inside
of his deck. I think of like the Kanas
that exist, the Fioras that exist. He
loves still being able to and use those,
play those, and then have the one cost
tricks that we talked about, the
showstoppers or, you know, being able to
play uh, you know, uh, call to call to
glory, the buffing them for free, you
know, showing these extra tricks. And
so, he likes playing at this low
mid-range value. And like you said, this
is a showcase for the set deck as a
whole.
>> This is a really important turn for the
fact that Argon knows there are two on
guards in Quint's hand. Quint knows
Argon knows they're two on guards, so
gets to make this type of play where
played the first mate, sent the fa folk
back to the battlefield or back to the
base. But Argon can't just send the set
brawler in. Knows there are multiple
pump spells. And even if Argon does have
a call to glory, that's not enough on
its own. That would only be a seven in a
trade. But here's a buff on the set. Now
we could go to make it Nate and we're
probably not afraid of these on guards
anymore.
>> Absolutely not. And yeah, I I I called
the wrong four drop, but of course it
was another one of those Kingo monks
buffing the first one that we played and
like you said, spinning this for the
plus4 might. Can only imagine it's going
to contest. And we've had control of
this dreaming tree the entire game.
>> Yeah, I mean this is what that early set
play let you do, right? Go in with that
Cyria, play that kingpin. It's a six
tank and you have the two might Syria.
You are on the play and the Master E
deck is not great at stealing those
battlefields early. they kind of want to
move into those open battlefields and
set up their own defenses. But when you
are the first in the line, it can be
really tough for them to fight back,
especially against numbers this large.
>> Yeah, like you said, tough decisions
here because the known information is on
both sides. There's no bluffs here to be
called. It's just about when you
exchange those resources.
>> Well, even if we have two ong guards
here with both of these energy, that's
still only a seven. We're not getting
through this set. I'm curious what type
of trick Quint could have here that is
large enough. Nothing's coming to my
mind. Maybe there is some way to protect
the first mate or take it back to base.
I can't think of.
>> Oh, it's a five.
>> Nine, right?
>> Two on guards equals a nine. But you do
know Argon's making this attack, right?
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> So, it's like what could you have? You
only have one up, but Call to Glory is
free.
>> Mhm.
>> So many buffs on this other side of the
battlefield.
>> I think that's why it's so hard for
Quinn. I I don't I don't regret being in
this situation. And I think we're on
we're in round five of this tournament
and decisions like this are incredibly
difficult when you want to continue your
run. But letting it go, saving those on
guards for a future day.
>> This gets into those mind game things.
If if Argon didn't have the call to
glory is a certain type of warrior
spirit that allows you to make this
bluff attack. Uh certain people have it.
Argon looks like the type that could.
>> Absolutely. Targon speak as we get that
conquer effect is going to give us two
extra runes for Argon passing back to
Quint. And we have a lot of points to
catch up on because we have to contest
both of these battlefields because
double hold is the game for Argon.
>> Yeah, we really have set up a pretty
strong just back and forth situation as
Argon, right? I have this battlefield
that there's almost no way you're
contesting it. My numbers are so large.
Your deck's not playing just spot
removal to take care of these things.
And my other battlefield is this set
brawler that okay, you conquer it and
you send my set back to my base. But if
I have a way to buff it, we're going to
be able to brawl again, get in with
another eight or nine or 10. And you
know, if you have these call to glories
and all these tricks, it puts a really
tight squeeze on your opponent on what
am I even able to do during my turn.
>> The first move for the turn, moving the
tasty faolk to contest against this set.
Six might sending it in. Just going to
let it go. We see the same play once
again. We're going to end up saving it
with the legend ability, recycling a
rune, keeping it right back, but giving
that point away just to maybe see a
repeat of what we saw last turn. That
could be the game for the Argon
regardless. So, it's still up to Quint,
but he's got everything to play with
still.
>> Even if Argon doesn't have a way to buff
this brawler and get it in again, having
to put that tasty Fay Folk into the
Targon's Peak makes it a tough
situation. though there is a white flame
protector which I assume Quint is going
to use to just break through a little
bit of this massive board. But the fa
folk in the other board means you won't
be able to use that to help fight
through this problem. And this hold not
this turn but next turn is going to be
threatening a win.
>> Yeah, I I actually have to do a lot of
math here, right? So it's not just the
white flame coming in for this porro
putting it up to 10. But we have to
remember this set kingpin does have
tank. So, it has to eat up basically all
of this. And with the scaling might of
the set kingpin and its own buff of its
own, there are three total buffed units
at this battlefield. So, I think it's
only going to deal with this kingpin.
>> Well, if you're able to deal, the
kingpin is going to be a nine. You do
have these two on guards, which again,
everyone at the table knows about. Maybe
you're able to use these, clear out a
little bit of stuff, but you can see
that call to glory in Argon's hand. So,
any numbers you're trying to set up,
Quinn has to think of two things. Okay.
What about the scenarios where Cardiger
exists and what about the ones where it
doesn't?
>> Yeah. And with no use of the on guard,
it's just going to be for that one for
one trade taking down the tank at the
battlefield.
>> Argon realizing, okay, you pass to me. I
could play this call to glory, but then
you will get to play these on guards,
and I think this call to glory is worth
more than your on guards and making this
deal. Let's just let this trade happen.
Yeah, very hard for Quinn here and I
understand because you know we did get
deal with the tank but we can't deal
with any of these current units in our
current state unless we move the other
poro up and maybe then use the ong
guards but we're in the same situation
so going to be a tough one here for both
of these players to figure out what the
path is for Quinn's victory.
This is a bit of the squeeze that
happens when a player is at six points.
you really feel like you need to move
your things into one battlefield to be
able to protect from them conquering it
and winning that way. But if you do that
and you like put this porro into the
Targon's Peak or you play another unit
there to try and uh bulk up, then you're
unable to play have those units in your
base to threaten the battlefield they're
currently holding. Uh and it's a squeeze
that sometimes can feel like you don't
really have a right answer and it's a
really fine line to thread throughout
the game.
Speaking of fine line, I think Argon is
trying to figure out his for that. He
already got the hold point of course
from the dreaming tree that he's had and
now it is about dealing with this tasty
fate folk. And again, he hasn't
forgotten anything that's happened early
on this game. Sabotage still showing off
those on guards from oh so long ago that
are still in hand, but we have a few
pieces that can help us break through
it.
>> Yeah, this is a situation where you have
to decide, am I trying to win the game
this turn? I see a pit rookie. That's
one buff on the set. That makes it
innate. I see that call to glory. That's
three more. That's 11. And I see a
showstopper. That's another buff, but
not one you get an opportunity to spend
on the set brawler. So, it is just a
plus one. Is it worth it to make this
play and move all in and trying to beat
this tasty fay folk? What's the worst
case scenario versus just piling all
your units into this dreaming tree and
saying, "All right, I don't think you
got it, Quint. That's a lot of numbers.
>> You called it. There it is. Going to
move that set brawler over." And a play
like that just means that we have to
look at other things. Arenita bar coming
down and using it now because the set
brawler had to uh exhaust itself to move
of course and now it has an extra buff
to deal with for for making this
battlefield even scarier and then also a
pit rookie coming in to buff up that oh
lonesome Kinko monk that was left there
earlier. That's exactly the game plan.
Now it is presenting the puzzle once
again to Quint.
>> It looks to me like this is a total
value of 19 might. Quint only has 10 in
play. We know about two on guards.
That's potentially plus four, though a
little awkward if you have to send in
the porro. Another white flame protector
plus these gets you into close ballpark
range. However, Argon has that call to
glory that we know about. That is
another secret plus two, you know, worth
three but minus one from the buff.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And I think, and this
is my favorite part about when I play
set, is I love presenting the might math
challenge to your opponent and thinking
like, hey, well, do you have the right
cards in your hand currently to get
there? And Master Yi is one of those
decks that is very good at doing that.
Um, we'll have to find out if the right
pieces are in Quint's hand, but we're
doing it right now.
>> Yeah. I mean, the one of the really cool
things about playing the boss and set is
that you get to play free quotes cards
that other people don't really have. If
you have call to glory and you have
wallet, both as options and your
opponent always has to respect that call
to glory. Here is moving in that
protector, doing these onguards, sending
in that one unit at a time to avoid that
problem of uh making these ong guards
not as good.
>> I've already forgotten about the the
bonus draw from picking our white flame
on the Dreaming Tree battlefield because
uh again hasn't been contesting this
battlefield all game. So, uh, finally
seeing that go through here.
>> Just cleaning up some stuff, trying to
make the board a little bit smaller. You
You got to think, what can I get each
time? I don't need to make big attacks
all at once and get blown out if you
have something. We can do this peace
meal. The numbers work out where we can
just take little trades.
>> Yeah. And like even this low porro here
is enough to trade with the pit rookie
that doesn't have a buff onto it. So
again, at least the Poro still uh
amounts to getting rid of one more unit,
the call of glory. We're going to spend
the buff on the Cyria and give plus
three might to the set. And of course,
the targeting occurs for the dreaming
tree draw here on Argon himself. But now
this is the world where you can choose
to distribute your might somewhere else.
That's an interesting choice to call to
glory there. It really wants to spend
the buff off the Sithria. Argon just
passed priority back then the star por
would have traded with the cyria and
argon would have been down that buff.
Here's the dead bloom predator which on
guard that looks like nine might only to
10 from the predator. That is enough to
take this battlefield back. Wow. The
puzzle did get there, presenting a
situation for Argon to still be in this
game here because now the hold point is
much harder for Argon to pull off.
Wow, it looks like it's going through.
Everything is going to get cleared off
of that battlefield. Quint taking the
point. We're going to save, of course,
the set brawler using our legend
ability. And now we're in a scary
situation where some of the largest
units in this Master Y deck are by
themselves on each of these
battlefields. You really have to respect
the the
type of calm Quint had to hold these on
guards and both players knew about them
this whole game and really got maximum
value. Use the first one to be able to
trade in 10 for 10, use the second to be
able to protect the biggest unit that he
had and take the battlefield all at
once. If at any other point those were
used differently, I don't see this
playing out nearly the same way.
>> Wow, this is so hard because I don't
know. I I the only question I have to
ask you, Aaron, is like all of a sudden
I now feel like I'm in a situation where
I ask, "What does Argon do?"
>> Right? The whole game has been the other
way. What can Quint do to break this
hold? Finally broke the hold. Argon has
this set brawler. We know there's a
showstopper in hand. That's one of the
cards that can do something, but it's
only a five unless you have another way
to buff it beforehand. Uh and it's
looking like to me there's some more
challenges there, but these units are
just way too large. Yeah, set brawler
without a buff versus having one, very
different story.
>> I can imagine the play here going
through Argon's mind is okay, if I move
my set brawler into this dream tree and
I play a challenge and I draw a card, uh
maybe I can hit a call to glory, but
what does that what does that look like?
>> Wow. And just like that, the game
completely took a 180. And game one's
going to go to Quint after that
incredible puzzle he had to solve to
break through all that might.
>> That is one of those games where you're
Archon and you're going to look back at
it and be like, "Where did I go wrong? I
had everything under control the whole
time. I was bullying you in one
battlefield. I had the other one held
the whole time. I was at seven points
and you had to take both and I knew your
hand most of the game. I feel like I
could have done something differently."
And sometimes you can't, but those are
the types of things you're going to
think about going into these next games.
Speaking of those next games, Ardon went
first that game,
>> right? That was the game with the turn
one Cyria set in the Dreaming Tree. Did
not get taken for like four turns. Got
four hold points.
But sometimes even with that, the Master
Y talked about they do one thing, but
they do it really, really well. Lots of
big units, lots of tricks, and the boss
wasn't able to keep up.
>> No, he wasn't. I wish he was, but that's
what games two and hopefully game three
are for. But man, I I really have to
applaud Quint there. I I I genuinely
think he played that turn, taking over
and whittling around all of those units,
getting them out one by one, starting
with the kingpin, taking off the smaller
units little by little for the perfect
play. I I genuinely don't think I could
have pulled that off myself, at least in
that specific mindset. And remember that
entire time, your opponent knew two of
the cards in your hand the entire as you
got to that journey.
>> Yeah, it's one of those games you got to
sequence faces as things went on. cool
as a cucumber, but I know internally if
that was me, I'd be like, I can't
believe I did that. How did that happen
for me? But you're just so relieved
you're able to pull it out. Uh I'm
really excited to see the next two games
if we get that level of back and forth
somewhere.
>> If you're Argon,
like you said, that felt like almost the
near perfect execution getting to where
we got to in the point until it all of a
sudden wasn't. What do we change? What
do we do different? You know, one of the
things that I did say going in is
compared to the last match we saw where
we had Mastery E versus Victor, Victor
had hidden blades. Victor had removal.
And that was a game where Set did its
one thing. It was just numbers. It
didn't have hidden blade. It potentially
has access to that stuff post where it
gets to bring in some of that order
removal. And that'll be a big help in
dealing with these giant monsters like
Dead Bloom Predator.
>> Yeah, I I 100% agree. That's one of the
perks of the order or the order uh
domain in general. So, we got a game two
and I don't know about you, I'm can't
wait to see what the results are going
to be. I'm still rooting for my man, the
boss set himself. Game two coming in. I
excited to see these battlefields as
well. Grove of the Godwillow coming in
for Argon and Obelisk of Power. Extra
runes for all of us on Master East side.
Can we talk about Mulligan just a little
bit? I would love to talk about the
intricacy on how such of an important
decision it isn't just in this game but
in in card games in general and this one
is so unique I feel like the the like
decision making we that it got to half
of your hand and they go to the bottom
you might never see them again
>> right we're playing a game where there
isn't really shuffling recycling your
cards pretty much means they go away so
when you see one of those important
cards is you know just as an example
quint in this game you see something
like a dead bloom predator it's one of
your best cards
You can't play it for a while.
>> Absolutely. Obser going to be very
powerful here for Master Yi because we
are able to play a turn one Kiana
recycling the only body rune we had at
the time of course and only the Cyria
coming in for Argon. But that is what
you want to see because of what we might
end up saying. Here comes the kingpin
tapping those out. Having one rune to
play with and giving a buff to Cria
because we played a unit.
>> Choosing to play the set at the base
this time. Last game we were really
aggressive. Move the Sithri in, played
the set to protect, but now the Kiana
maybe causing us to rethink or we just
have a showstopper to move the set in
ourselves.
>> Good value for wanting to specifically
get the buff onto the set to make this
hold from the grove of the godwillow
ability hopefully come full circle. But
because this is the same play that we
kind of saw in the first game, aside
from maybe keeping the Cyria, we're
going to go ahead and support it.
There's a world where this battlefield
gets held almost the entire game like we
saw in the other in the first one.
>> Yeah, this time though, Grove of the God
Willow, much better battlefield to hold.
Argon wasn't really able to capitalize
the dreaming tree in that game. And
Grove of the Godwillow though, you don't
have to do a ton of work to capitalize
once you're in there. And I brought up
game one how good these four drops are
because when you're on going second, you
get that extra rune. You can play a four
and you can showstopper. It's the same
thing when you're on the play, but it's
an obelisk of power game. We get to see
that right here. Really doing this
powerful thing. And we have a set with
eight might already on turn two.
>> Absolutely forcing this Kiana to go to
the other battlefield. Wanting to take
advantage of this on conquer ability.
Quint will decide if he wants to draw
one or channel an extra rune. And it
looks like here comes that channel. That
being honestly the decision I've seen a
lot of players making today and it makes
a lot of sense when it just comes to
paying these power costs at later on in
the game but sooner rather than later,
>> right? Well, we go back the power cards.
You know, you have Deadl Predator, White
Flame Protector, and Tasty Fay Folk.
Eight's your magic number. You play a
Kiana when you're at four puts you to
three. You go up to five. Conquer puts
you back up to six. You're ready to play
one of those big cards. Even if you
don't have them, opponent Argon has to
respect you get dead bloom predator.
What does that look like? Do I have a
plan for that? And the threat of that is
worth so much, sometimes even more than
a card.
Back to Argon as he contemplates what to
do with his turn, but does get that hold
for the grove.
I see a first mate in hand. A lot of
opportunity here with Quint being
totally exhausted out. No runes
available. can move that set kingping
back to base. Hit it with the first mate
and then move it into the Kiana if you
want to try and just take that out of
the game right now. That would be a
trade though. It' be a seven for seven.
So without another trick, maybe that's
not worth doing.
>> I love Fiora. I think this card is so
good and I'm so excited to see this
Fiora even in the Fiora legend hopefully
next set for people you know really
experimenting with the card because when
it gets a buff like it does in this deck
very easily it just gains all of the
sort of abilities.
>> Yeah, I mean Fiora really sweet. It's
especially sweet with showstopper. Once
it's ready in your base you can use the
showstopper that makes it mighty. You go
in and take a battlefield and then she
has ganking. You get to go and take that
other battlefield. Another one of those
really powerful plays you get to do
during these early turns with these four
might units or four cost units. Big
situations from just pretty cheap cards.
>> And that seems to be the play just to
reinforce that battlefield. We're seeing
very similar stuff from Quint with a
success that we saw in game one. Right.
We moved that first porro back after we
had gotten it. And of course Keiana, we
would take advantage of that on conquer
ability. Well, we can only do that when
we bring it back to go to another
battlefield. Clockwork keeper also
getting played. And we are going to take
advantage of the recycling a calm rune
to draw a bonus card
and just playing it very slow here. It's
very much the exchange of resources and
we saw at the end of it Quint come on
top. This game looks a lot like the last
game. Argon took this battlefield early,
played a set kingpin is trying to do
some big holding and Quint you know is
just fighting for the other one. We're
going to let you keep this one for a
while and um I know my bigger cards in
the end will maybe give me that
advantage. I'm curious to see if Argon
does have a tool like those hidden
blades or something to really break that
serve that wasn't able to do last time
that let the dead bloom predator crush
the battlefield and win the game.
>> And if there's any tool that's going to
help us find those cards, it is holding
on to this Grove of the God Willow
constantly over and over and over again.
And basically the only accumulation of
points that we've got in this game at
all.
>> Yeah. And one of the things about the
set deck is the cards in the deck
themselves aren't very good at drawing
cards, but set has access to multiple
battlefields that are great at it. You
have grove of the godwill and monastery
of harana. Grove being hold draw a card
and monastery being when you conquer you
can spend a buff to draw a card. So the
set deck while not having a lot of the
card draw in the deck itself really gets
to capitalize in the deck building
portion with these battlefields.
>> Fiora finally getting that buff from the
Kiko mage or monk that was played after
this porro. So the Porro is also going
to receive a buff of its own. And very
quickly, this battlefield has
accumulated a very large number of might
and a hidden card to top it off. Can
only imagine it's things like that
hidden blade you've already talked
about.
>> Yeah. So there is a little bit of a mind
game here. It could be hidden blade or
it could be pockup. Pretty common card
for these decks to play. But Quint has
to respect that it's hidden blade cuz if
you make a big play with one of your
large units and you get blown out,
that's really tough. If Quint does have
access to something like a defy in hand,
it's a way easier game to play from
here.
>> Passing back to Quint, going to keep one
rune up for Argon. Not a lot of one cost
tricks though. I I can only think of
things like unyielding spirit, but
doesn't do a whole lot in this matchup
particularly, so I don't think we're
going to see those. But Kiana going to
go in for the conquer effect. Once
again, the benefit on pulling it back
the turn prior means that we're going to
get some extra value here. And now it's
time to draw some cards because we've
got a lot of runes to play with already.
Yeah, Quints that this battlefield is a
problem. We are tied on points, which
means Argon is going to win the race if
nothing happens. So, you really got to
build up that big suite of pump spells
and tricks on your side to fight the big
suite of pump spells and tricks on
Argon's side. This game is going to boil
down to one big showdown fight again.
>> So, as we build to that final turn, do
you think I guess the question is the
mind game, will the Defies come through
quick enough? Will we find them? I can
maybe see one that will help us deal
with stuff like the hidden blades that
that are hidden.
>> Yeah, we're putting a lot of pressure on
Argon with this Kiana. I talked about
earlier in the game. There was an
opportunity to kill the Kiana with the
set and showstopper or the first mate
and trading off. Decided not to.
>> Here it looks like we were forcing that
type of trade. Uh
deciding that looks like Quint might be
trying to make a move on this
battlefield sooner than I expected.
potentially has a really strong set of
pump spells and tricks in his hand right
now and Argon's pretty low on resources
to fight back with the current rune
situation.
>> Yeah, I mean the fact that it's going to
lose so much might because it is no
longer at the same place as other buffed
units. This kingpin dropped dramatically
and on top of that if we want to use
cards like Call to Glory, which are
basically one of the only ones we can
afford, we'd have to spend more of our
buffs. So this is a perfect card for
Quint to play here that gets so much off
of Argon's board.
>> Discipline very good here getting to,
you know, make that buff get spent on
set. I got to imagine there's a move in
here where we're going to be sending in
this mastery and some of these things
into this battlefield. Uh the Grove of
the God willow, we spent a lot of
resources there to take the set out, but
only for a single turn. We must be
making a really big play. Yeah, I I I
think that was my main question to ask
was like we're setting up a zonas even
so that if we swing in with these units
that we have, we get to basically pick
and choose which of our units we're also
going to buy at buy back from the
zonia's hourglass going to get rid of
itself and put our Y back into our base
uh recall it specifically. And that's
what set does. We're doing our own
little set impression.
>> You know, these decks are pretty
similar. They're both decks about
numbers and saving your things with
tricks. Uh, Master E
comes in ready, pretty powerful. Set
Kingpin comes in at 4C. That's pretty
much the difference on the really base
level.
>> Yeah. And also holding on to this hidden
card for quite a bit because if there
was any opportunity, maybe you do it
there if it if that's what this card is.
Again, you might be right. It could just
end up being a pock, which doesn't
necessarily shift what's going on in
this exact moment of attacking with one
unit at a time on the side of Quint. If
it's a pocket cub, what do you do? Yeah,
I mean as Argon here, if it is a hidden
blade, I think you're in the mindset of
there's got to be something better than
this master. This is just a six might
unit. You have dead bloom predators,
those are eights. You have white flame
protectors, those are eights. And you're
not even kicking me out of this grove.
I'm still holding. I'm still getting
cards. I can keep playing this bluffing
game one way or another. So, I'm not
sure Quint got a lot of information from
those combats. Even if he was really
hoping if it's a hidden blade, it got
played.
just decides to move our set kingpin
back to the grove. Go back where it was.
Arena bar also going to come down now
that it is exhausted. Hey, I this game
is exactly like the last one. You
weren't joking, Aaron. And I think the
biggest note I have is that we not only
are playing the same game back and forth
and making these similar decisionm, but
the point values are lower than they
were when this started happening in game
one.
>> Yeah. Well, it in the previous game,
Argon was fighting for the second
battlefield, and in this one, Quint's
kind of just getting to have a run with
it with the Kiana, repeatedly drawing
cards, it's making that grove of the
Godwillow continuous hold way less
painful, cuz Quint, while drawing half
as many cards from the uh Kiana conquer
effect, it's still pretty reasonable
amount of cards.
>> Yeah. I mean, and like you said, all the
other cards in the set deck don't really
necessarily help you draw cards, whereas
Quint do. Yeah, we're seeing find your
centers, we're seeing disciplines, we're
seeing all these things getting to play
tricks and win combats, but keep that
hand full. And in addition to that,
there's kind of like a not exactly card
advantage, though. You do get it from
Clockwork Keeper and the like. There's
almost a certain type of theoretical
card advantage because the big cards in
Quint's deck are worth more than the big
cards in Argon's deck. A Dead Bloom
Predator is bigger than the biggest unit
Argon gets. So, even if there's less
cards, they're just worth more.
I 100% agree. We really haven't seen
Argon go above
eight runes in the entire game. And
again, we talked about how that's where
he likes to kind of sit when he plays
this set deck. But I feel like at some
point maybe there's a decision where we
have to make of like, well, what happens
if we just got to a bunch of runes, took
a couple of turns of not recycling them,
and did a big explosive turn of our own
to combat what Quint did to us in game
one.
Yeah, I mean there is a a situation this
game where Quint
spent a lot of resources the previous
turn to try and not let Argon build this
huge situation and and get to pick the
flow. Uh but it sort of looks like that
didn't work out super well. We trade a
lot of things to get this uh set kingpin
into the base so we could fight some
more stuff there, but we didn't take it
and now all the stuff's back.
>> Yeah. And again, we're saying the
similar lines that we saw previously,
but we're going to buff up this pit
rookie. Really valuing keeping our Y
alive because we really are just trying
to get this kingpin off of the board at
least momentarily as we are going to get
it back by using our set ability.
This is a situation where if it's a
hidden blade, you're maybe tempted.
Currently, this Master Yi is going to
get to take out both the daring porro
and the pit rookie.
But there is the white flame protector
just in play. So you know if it's hidden
blade I can definitely get this eight.
Quint though is holding up that one rune
really posturing that uh defy at the
very least maybe an onguard.
>> Absolutely. And once again bringing
Archiana back. I think that was an
excellent turn here from Quint. Still
maintaining a great board state for a
future turn and removing so many of
those units off of Argon. And just like
that it's looking very similar to game
one and getting to that end result.
>> Yeah. You know, despite all of that
effort, Argon still has this grove of
the god Willow
>> extra draw and once again, but instead
here comes the Defy right now and
saying, "No, you did this to me game
one, and we're going to change the story
ever so differently by just completely
nullifying
>> Defy. Defy saying, you know, I will pick
for you. This is what you're taking. You
don't get to know about all my tricks
this time."
>> That is the best way to look at it.
Absolutely. Whereas, you know, when I
think of similar abilities from like
mind spplitters, you know, obviously not
in this match, but that one, you can't
define that one.
Passing thinking. Yeah, I it's so hard
because I I really do enjoy set as a
legend and as a deck, but I feel for
Argon cuz I think this is very hard.
>> This game is really hard and a lot of
decisions. This turn in particular is
really big. Argon had a choice. Do I go
back to fighting for this same
battlefield and hold it or do I move my
set over and score the extra point? Has
the first mate to ready it out. Looks
like he's going to end up doing all of
it. Gets a point. Has enough movement to
still pile on the hold. Kind of getting
the best of all of the worlds, but is
spending a lot of cards to achieve this.
Uh makes it where you know Quinn has a
lot of things, a lot of might in play.
And uh Argon's low on energy again.
probably can only have one trick though
does have enough energy up if there's a
hidden blade in hand to be able to play
it.
>> You're right. We saw so much happen, a
lot of movement that just ended
resulting in, hey, we've buffed up more
units of this battlefield and we got a
bonus point because we did a little bit
more, which is more than what we've seen
all game because like you said in game
one, Argon did real contesting of trying
to get onto that second battlefield and
now we just did instead some cheeky
movement to get that access to the
point. Yeah, one of the big things we're
missing from the first game on Argon's
side is that lack of set brawler.
There's a unit that was able to bully
that second battlefield pretty easily
with the access to the buffs he had
attacking for eight repeatedly gets hit
back sent to base and back and forth and
back and forth. And we don't have a unit
that can pressure that battlefield by
itself in the same way except this set
kingpin that we're being forced to leave
in our hold pile.
This looks very similar to what happened
on the what I would say the game-winning
turn for Quint. It started with
something like the white flame that was
played on a turn prior, but now there's
an answer to it. Yeah, this is a play
that you only make as Quint if you have
that Defy, and I'm sure Argon knew that,
trying to go in with his 15. It was
Hidden Blade, but Quint found two Defies
throughout the game to counter the two
spells. And this is pretty brutal. I
feel like this is about as bad as Archon
could have it go for him. A lot of this
battlefield being killed though. First
mate still hanging out. Not big enough
to contest this Kiana alone. Maybe a
call to glory.
>> Yeah, that that seems to be probably one
of the only biggest things we could have
right now. But that is not the case. As
we saw with that white flame, it did get
primal strength. That's why it had even
more might on it. And Kiana once again
taking that conquer ability from it
going up and scoring up. And now it is
six points across for both players. But
now Argon, like you said, has lost
basically their entire board. The lone
kingpin remains.
>> Yeah, Argon used the showstopper last
turn. Another one really great here if
possible. Let's you get into one
battlefield, get that buff on your set
and really get some fighting going. But
if you don't have a way to put a buff on
this set, you can't really get into a
fight with this Kiana and that's going
to be really tough.
and the resources are slowly very
quickly adding up and being spent, you
know, across the board because I think I
think Quinn has to use a lot of these
cards, but we are refilling them.
Whereas like Argon has been constantly
having to refill and play more units to
the stage and play spells like this as
we're seeing instead of doing it on the
kingpin we already had. Why not just
play a second kingpin and then shows
stopper that one?
>> We have made a choice. So, we're going
to showstopper into this clockwork
keeper, which means we're going to win
this and go to seven. And I imagine what
Argon's going to do if this succeeds is
move the other set into that battlefield
and say, "I'm at seven. I'm not holding
the Grove anymore, but now I'm holding
the obelisk. You did it last turn. Can
you do it again?"
Very much using more of the tricks
though. Discipline coming through for
Quint. Going to draw a new card
and with an on guard is going to get
this clockwork keeper up to a ton of
might to contest against this kingpin.
It's at eight. And one of the tough
things with Call to Glory with set
kingpin is normally you remove one and
it gives plus two, but not in this case.
And that is the handshake. Wow. The 200
Quint victory here. Moving on at 5-0
into this this incredible regional
qualifier. Again, I a lot of people
moving off of Master Y as we talked
about a little bit beforehand. Quint
said, "No, I'm going to show up and I'm
going to show you why." Defeating Colin
who's known for playing this set deck.
Well, sometimes in matchups, the bigger
number wins and the master E deck has a
lot of numbers going for it. You know,
game one, I'm confident going to be
thinking about that one again. I had
everything going right. How did I lose
this game? I had the set brawler to
fight one battlefield. I had the hold.
Game two had the Grove of the God Willow
for so many turns, drawing so many
cards, but not able to contest the
second battlefield and really just
letting Quint get some extra points and
extra cards off that Kiana in a way you
really don't want to let happen.
>> I think that was masterfully played by
Quint. It very much showed that I think
he had the experience on, hey, my deck
can do your thing but better. even with
your legend ability to bring and recall
your units back, I'll just keep fighting
through them. I'll keep on drawing cards
while I do it. And that's why we saw the
success. And Master Yi is very much of
like the a legend to look out for. And I
think everybody knew that. And the
people that pilot it and make those good
decisions like Quint did are going to be
the ones that you need to look out for
in the tournament.
>> Definitely. People will sometimes say,
"Oh, my master E matchup's really easy.
It's a deck that's fairly easy to play.
You just play big units. you just do
this stuff, but there is a lot of play
to how do I use all of these tricks. You
have defy, you have on guard, you have
discipline, you have hourglass. It's a
lot of tools that you really need to
maximize because your opponents are also
doing powerful things and that is really
what separates a really great Master E
player from someone who is not doing as
well.
>> Absolutely. But we're only five rounds
in still. We have a lot more Riftbound
to be played today, so don't go
anywhere. We're going to cut to a break,
but we'll be back.
[Music]